ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
[inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
REYES REVISE RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WOOD [inaudible]
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN.
THE REVEREND BOB OSHITA
REVERSION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
BEING A GIRL SCOUT LEADER ARE
GOOD FRIENDS SOMETIMES TEASED MY
WIFE PATTY.
CALLING HER GROUP TROOP BEVERLY
HILLS.
PATTI ENJOY SHOPPING AND WOULD
NEVER SUGGEST CAMPING AS AN
ACTIVITY.
BUT HUNTER CADETSHIP GIRLS CHOSE
CAMPING AS THEIR NEXT ACTIVITY.
PATTY WAS ALL IN.
THE GIRL SELECTED THE WEEKEND
HAD THE SECURITY CAMPGROUND IN
CAMPING EQUIPMENT.
SHE EVEN PRACTICED PITCHING A
TENT IN OUR BACKYARD.
AS THE DREADED CAMPING WEEKEND
APPROACHED ABOUT HALF THE GROWTH
BEGAN TO HEAD TO ON THEIR
COMMITMENT.
THE BASKETBALL TEAM WAS PLAYING
IN A TOURNAMENT IN SAN JOSE.
ALSO THERE TAIKO DRUM GROUP WAS
PERFORMING SATURDAY NIGHT IN
SACRAMENTO [inaudible]
UNDAUNTED.
ATTY ENTHUSIASTICALLY WENT
FORWARD WITH THE PLAN TO CAMPING
WEEKEND.
THE GIRLS WITH ALTERNATIVE
ACTIVITIES WERE TORN.
WHAT SHOULD THEY DO?
WELL INTENTIONED PARENTS CAME TO
THE RESCUE.
THE GROWTH CAMPUS FRIDAY NIGHT
INTO SATURDAY.
THE PARENTS PICK THEM UP
SATURDAY AND DROVE THEM TO THE
TAIKO DRUM PERFORMANCE.
THEN SUNDAY MORNING HE DROVE
THEM TO SAN JOSE TO PLAN THE
FINAL TOURNAMENT GAME
[inaudible]
PROBLEM SOLVED.
PATTY RETURN FROM THAT WEEKEND
OF CAMPING AND SAID TO ME.
I WONDER WHAT THIS NEXT
GENERATION WILL BE LIKE.
THEY'RE BEING TAUGHT BY THEIR
PARENTS THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO COMMIT TO
ANYTHING COMPLETELY.
WE CAN HEAD JOHN OUR COMMITMENTS.
DO A LITTLE OF WHATEVER WE WANT.
AND THAT IS ACCEPTABLE.
WE BOTH CONTINUE TO WONDER IF
THIS NEXT GENERATION OF LOVE AND
ENABLE CHILDREN WILL KNOW THE
MEANING OF REAL COMMITMENT.
COMMITMENT TO A RELATIONSHIP.
COMMITMENT TO A RESPONSIBILITY
[inaudible]
CAREER.
OR COMMITMENT TO A CAUSE WORTHY
OF A LIFETIME OF DEDICATION.
AS WE BRING THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SESSIONS TO A
CLOSE.
LET US REFLECT ON THE NATURE OF
COMMITMENT.
AND REDEDICATE OURSELVES TO
HONOR OUR COMMITMENTS THAT ARE
WORTHY OF OUR LIFETIMES
DEDICATION.
NOW MORE NEED THEM.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEINORTH.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER STEIN THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IT'S WE SALUTE
THE SYMBOL OF OUR NATION'S
GREATNESS.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY AUGUST
FIFTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
SEMI MADISON NAM HONORABLE JIM
PATTERSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER TWENTY
THIRD DISTRICT PRESIDING TO
QUICKLY DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK READING CLICK KATHLEEN I'M
LUIS READING.
THE BONTA PLACED ON THE MORNING
ROLL CALL ACROSS SHUDDER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
ABSENCES FOR TODAY'S SESSION
[inaudible]
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW SOME GABRIEL
THAT GAS AND THE FLOOR TODAY'S
GUEST.
WILL BE SEATED AT HIS DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ENACT A FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE S.
B. TEN TWENTY THREE HERNANDEZ
AND ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
NINE FORTY THREE LOW.
CLERK WILL KNOW.
AND MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE. SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I REFRAIN THE FOLLOWING ITEM
TO COMMITTEE.
I DON'T OVER.
TWENTY NINE AB TWENTY FIVE OH
WIND KANSEN CHU TO ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY.
AND TOXIC MATERIALS
.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MAY BEGIN TAKING UP
[inaudible]
THE ITEMS.
ON THE FILE
GET ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH SENATE
THIRD READING
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE SENATE.
PROBING SECOND READING REDUCE
SECOND READING AND THEN WILL
TAKE UP SENATOR READING.
THIS IS BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE SECOND READING THE
CORPORATE SENATE BILL.
TWO FORTY FOUR ALL BILLS HAVE
BEEN DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
TAKING UP ITEMS ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE BEGINNING
WITH.
FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SIX THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SIX S. B. [inaudible]
TWELVE SIXTY GREGORY.
SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACT LIKE A
FIRE PREVENTION.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU MAY OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SP TWELVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR JACKSON WILL PROMOTE
LONG TERM FOREST HEALTH THEN
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
BY ENABLING FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES TO ENGAGE IN
COLLABORATIVE FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT.
CREATING NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LAND MANAGERS
TO MITIGATE WILDFIRE RISKS.
AND EXPANDING THE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL YOU THAT AYE AYES FORTY
SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SEVEN AB.
PARMI SP A TWENTY ONE CLERK READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS AND I
THINK EMERGENCY SERVICES.
MS LA MONDE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
ONE IS A BILL THAT GIVES
COUNTIES THE OPTION OF
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLLING
RESIDENTS INTO COUNTY OPERATED
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION PROGRAMS.
S. B. A TWENTY ONE HELPS ENSURE
THAT MORE THAN.
MORE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
RECEIVED CRITICAL EMERGENCY
ALERTS BY AUTHORIZING COUNTY
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OFFICIALS
TO AUTOMATICALLY ENROLL
RESIDENTS IN COUNTY OPERATED
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM.
RECENT AMENDMENTS AUTHORIZED
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES AGENCIES
TO CONTACT RESIDENTS WITH ACT
WITH ACCESS OR FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION OR OTHER
ASSISTANCE DURING AN EMERGENCY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU MS AMONG SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON.
DESIRABLE MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
TYPE OF ICE FORTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT
S. B..
ONE THIRTY FOUR CORKERY SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HERNANDEZ AND OTHERS AND I THINK
THE REGIONAL CENTERS
[inaudible]
MISTER SALAS.
THE US IS BIGGER MEMBERS SP ONE
THIRTY FOUR BRINGS TRANSPARENCY
THAT DEALS WITH CONTRACT BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IN A REGIONAL CENTER.
OPERATOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE.
I THINK MISS ALICE SEEM NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORATE FOR THE ROLE.
IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HAVE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED
ABOUT AYE AYES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE KNOWS.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
SEVENTY NINE S. B.. SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR CORKERY SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION THERE [inaudible]
FOR SURE FLORA.
BUT YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
PERCENT SB SEVEN SEVEN FOR A
TIME WOULD BUILD.
THE PROTECT FIREFIGHTERS HERE ON
THE FRONT LINES FOR WEEKS AT A
TIME.
AND WORK A JOB.
OF REMARKABLE STRESS
CALIFORNIA'S NOW EXPERIENCE THE
LARGEST MOST INTENSE LONGEST
LASTING BUYERS IN STATE HISTORY.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO GIVE.
HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE TASK OF
FILLER DO AN EXTRAORDINARY
PHYSICAL TASKS A RISK AS WE
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR PASSED THROUGH
POLICY COMMITTEE.
APPROPRIATIONS UNANIMOUSLY WITH
NO OPPOSITION.
THE LEGISLATION WILL EARMARK
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM TO STUDY THE PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL IMPACTS ON
FIREFIGHTERS WHO WORKED.
AT MAXIMUM HEART RATE FOR
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME THESE
FIREFIGHTERS OFTEN DEHYDRATED
SLEEP DEPRIVED AND COSTLY
EXERTING THEMSELVES OUR
FIREFIGHTERS ARE WILLING TO DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED TO DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO PROTECT THEM I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THE THANK YOU MISS
FLORA.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
CORPORAL OF THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WE IS ARAB VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLARK WELL
[inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE [inaudible]
TELL EVER.
EYES.
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
[inaudible]
FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY IS SP.
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
BY SENATOR GLAZIER AND ACTUALLY
TO COMMERCIAL FINANCING.
MISS THE MARK YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE LENDERS AND OTHER
FINANCE COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
CLEAR AND CONSISTENT DISCLOSURES
TO SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHEN
THEY OFFER THEM FINANCING AND
WHEN THEY CLOSE THE DEAL.
THIS INFORMATION WOULD HELP
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS UNDERSTAND
THE COSTS AND CONSEQUENCES OF
THE FINANCING OPTIONS AVAILABLE
TO THEM IN A RAPIDLY CHANGING
COMMERCIAL LENDING MARKET.
THIS BILL WOULD TAX THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
WITH CREATING REGULATIONS THAT
MAKE THESE DISCLOSURES
CONSISTENT AND USEFUL FOR
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES.
THE DISCLOSURE REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL WAS DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY
FOR COMMERCIAL LOANS IT WAS
BASED ON RESEARCH BY THE U. S.
FEDERAL RESERVE AND MODELED
AFTER THE RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE CONFERENCE THE STATE BANKING
SUPERVISORS.
THE BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF
RESPONSIBLE LENDERS SMALL
BUSINESS GROUPS AND ADVOCATES
FOR ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THINK MISTLETOE SEEING NO.
THIS WAS STEINORTH.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
MY PRIVATE SECTOR CAREER HAS
BEEN ABOUT TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
HELPING LOCAL BUSINESSES GROW.
I DON'T A MARKETING FIRM FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS I'VE OWNED A
SMALL CHAIN OF PIZZA PLACES FOR
OVER SIXTEEN YEARS AND I'M HERE
STANDING TO TELL YOU IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
THE SINGLE GREATEST REASON TO
LOCAL BUSINESSES FAIL IS UNDER
CAPITALIZATION.
AND THIS LEGISLATION IS HERE TO
PROVIDE CAPITAL TO THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN A WAY THAT UNIQUE.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE WAY
THAT UNIQUE AND I WELCOME
EVERYONE ELSE TO PLEASE HELP
LOCAL BUSINESSES THRIVE VOTE YES
ON S. B..
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU
MISS STEINORTH MINS BAKER YOUR
RECOMMEND YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I JOIN OUR COLLEAGUES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
AND A PARTICULAR WITH THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER.
AND THEIR CLIENTS SAY I HAD AS A
SMALL BUSINESS ATTORNEY DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THOSE SMALL.
TYPICALLY FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES WERE DESPERATE FOR
FINANCING.
AND TELL A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MEASURES WERE PUT
BEFORE THEM THEY DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THEIR OWN RESEARCH
AND FIND OUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE BUT THE INFORMATION NEEDS
TO BE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
AND I FOUND AGAIN AND AGAIN
CLIENTS THAT --
COULD HAVE REALLY BENEFITED JUST
FROM INVITED TO THEM TO HELP
THEIR BUSINESSES SURVIVE AND
RECOVER FROM THE GREAT RECESSION
AND TO BE ABLE TO RESTRUCTURE
THEIR FINANCING WHEN THEY
STARTED DOING BETTER OFF THIS
BILL WILL BE VERY VERY GOOD FOR
THOSE SMALL FAMILY BUSINESSES.
URGES STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL.
SCRIPTURE DEBATE MISSILE MONEY
MAKE CLOTHES WE WISH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
CARPOOL OF THE ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHAT IS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TYLER I SHOULD BE.
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
I MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY THREE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE IS S. B..
SIX OH SEVEN HIS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
CORKERY SENATE BILL SIX OF SEVEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE THAT'S
THE PLAN.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
SIX OR SEVEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
ELIMINATES THE USE OF WILLFUL
DEFIANCE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SUSPENSION FOR STUDENTS IN
GRADES K. THROUGH.
FIVE AND CARRIES A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET FOR STUDENTS IN GRADES
SIX THROUGH.
EIGHT FURTHERMORE THE BILL
PERMANENTLY PROHIBITS WILLFUL
DEFIANCE FROM BEING USED AS A
BASIS FOR EXPELLING ANY STUDENT
GRADES K. THROUGH.
TWELVE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED OR EXPELLED FROM
SCHOOL ARE MORE LIKELY TO DROP
OUT INNER THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
INCREASE THEIR RISK OF BECOMING
THE VICTIMS OF A VIOLENT CRIME
AND JEOPARDIZE OUR FUTURE.
RECOGNIZING THIS IMPACT ON A
CHILD'S FUTURE SOME OF THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING LA UNIFIED OAKLAND
UNIFIED IN SACRAMENTO.
HAVE MOVED TO VOLUNTARY
ELIMINATION OF WILLFUL
DIFFERENCES FORMER SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE.
IT'S PAST TIME FOR THOSE OF US
WHO MAYBE GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
TROUBLE AND WE WERE IN SCHOOL
REALIZE THAT WILLFUL DEFIANCE
WAS THE CATCHALL.
IF MAYBE YOU JUST.
DO THINGS THAT OUR OUR LITTLE
BIT OUT OF THE NORM IT'S TIME TO
TO TAKE THIS WAY AS A WAY TO
SUSPEND CHILDREN FROM SCHOOL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THING IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CLOCK CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
ROSARIO VOTE ON MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS VOTE
[inaudible]
DECIDED NO
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TELL YOU THE AYE
AYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS.
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
WORK FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FOUR S. B. TEN TWELVE
AGREE.
SENATE BILL TEN TWELVE BY
SENATOR DELGADO AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES.
MS LAMANYA MAILBAG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
TEN TWELVE GIVE CITIES THE
ABILITY TO CREATE A HOMELESS
MULTI DISCIPLINARY PERSONNEL
TEAM ALSO KNOWN AS ANDY TEACH.
WHEN I COUNTY IS NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT WITHIN THE CITY
LAST YEAR'S A. B. TEN TO TEN
KEEP COUNTIES THE ABILITY TO
CREATE HOMELESS MD TEAS?
HOWEVER NOT EVERY COUNTY HAS THE
CAPACITY TO CREATE AND MANAGE AN
MD TEETH FOR EVERY CITY WITHIN
IT. FOR EXAMPLE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAS EIGHTY CITIES WITHIN
A WHICH LEADS TO DIFFICULTY IN
CREATING AND MANAGING AND THE
TEA FOR EVERY CITY THAT HAS A
NEED.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO SIMPLIFY TO
SIMPLY FILL IN THE GAPS NOT
DUPLICATE SERVICES THEY COUNTY
THAT THE COUNTY IS ALREADY
PROVIDING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU MISS EMMA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CORPORAL OVER THE ROLL-ON.
THIS ARE TO VOTE ON THE VERGE
VOTE DESERT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS THAT IS THERE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIME ABOUT AYE SIXTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO JUMP IN THE FILE.
TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SEVEN S. B. [inaudible]
FIVE THIRTY NINE QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR DE LEóN AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA EDUCATION FINANCE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MS QUIRK SILVA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO PRINT
TO PRESENT S. B. FIVE THIRTY
NINE THIS BILL SEEKS TO IMPROVE
THE COLLEGE AXIS TAX CREDIT.
FUND A PROGRAM DESIGNED TO HELP
STUDENTS AFFORD A COLLEGE
EDUCATION THE COLLEGE ACCESS TAX
CREDIT WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND THE PROGRAM WAS
CREATED WITH THE GOAL OF HELPING
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS.
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION
TAXPAYERS CHARITABLE DONATIONS
ARE DIRECTED TO THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
S. B. FIVE THIRTY NINE EXPANDS
THE CREDIT TO HELP TO ASSIST
MORE CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO MODIFY THE COLLEGE
AXED ACCESS TAX CREDIT BY
INCREASING THE CREDIT PERCENTAGE
AWARDED TO THE TAX.
PAYER FROM 5275% OF THE AMOUNT
CONTRIBUTED BY THE TAXPAYER AND
INCREASING THE TOTAL AGGREGATED
CREDIT AMOUNT THAT MAY BE
ALLOCATED FROM FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO ONE BILLION.
WITH THIS WE CAN GROW THE FUN
AND HELP MORE STUDENTS REACH
COLLEGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WORKS OVER.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROAD.
AND VOTE.
IT IS OUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL TIED VOTE I FEEL
BEFORE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY EIGHT S. B..
ONE FIFTY TWO CORKERY SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB ONE FIFTY TWO WOULD
ALLOW THE VOTERS WITHIN CINEMA
COUNTY DECIDE WHETHER THEY WANT
TO INCREASE SALES TAXES TO
ADDRESS LOCAL NEEDS.
LAST YEAR'S SONOMA COUNTY
EXPERIENCE MOST DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEADLY WILDFIRE IN MODERN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
DURING THE DEPTHS OF A HOUSING
CRISIS FIFTY THREE HUNDRED HOMES
WERE LOST COUNTY WIDE.
A SIX THOUSAND THREE THROUGHOUT
THE NORTH BAY REGION AND IN
SANTA ROSA AN ASTOUNDING 5% OF
THE TOTAL HOUSING STOCK WAS
DESTROYED.
FRAGILE WATERSHEDS WERE
DECIMATED INFRASTRUCTURE MUST BE
REBUILT AND THE REAL FABRIC OF
THE COMMUNITY MUST BE REZONED.
THE BILL WOULD INCREASE THE
CURRENT SALES TAX CAP.
BUT IT'S THE VOTERS OF CINEMA
COUNTY WHO WILL BE THE ULTIMATE
DECIDER IS WHETHER THEY WANT TO
INCREASE TAXES.
SP ONE FIFTY TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE CANYON CINEMA OR ANY CITY
WITHIN THE COUNTY TO IMPOSE A
SALES TAX INCREASE BY NO MORE
THAN ONE SENT.
THE LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY HAS A
SUNSET EMBEDDED IT WOULD BE
REPEALED IF NOT USED BY JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THE
LEGISLATURE'S GRANTED SIMILAR
EXEMPTIONS TO LOCALITIES IN S.
B. ONE FIFTY TWO IS CONSISTENT
WITH THOSE PRIOR EXEMPTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AIBO.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CORD BLOOD NARAL.
ON WE DESIGNED THE OVERALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
IN THE
WORDS OF DOCTOR WEBER WE GOT
NOTHING BUT TIME [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TALBOT EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHTY NINE S. B. [inaudible]
SEVEN NINETY RECOVERY.
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TOO INVASIVE SPECIES.
MISTER LEVINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB SEVEN NINETY WOULD
ENSURE THAT ENTITIES WHO PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN CO MANAGING.
WATER RESERVOIRS CAN QUALIFY FOR
QUAD XGA IN ZEBRA MUSSEL
PREVENTION PROGRAM FUNDING QUAD
WINS YOUR MUSCLES ARE ONE OF THE
MOST INVASIVE SPECIES ON THE
PLANET.
AND CENTER MCGUIRE WANTS YOUR
HELP TO FIGHT BACK THIS INVASION
AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.%
THANK YOU MISS LIVING SAYING NO
[inaudible]
CAPTION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CORD BLOOD IN THE ROLE.
I'M.
THE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS ADDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL YOU BUT I
SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
FILE ITEM [inaudible] NINETY S.
B..
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE CORPORAL RATE
SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING.
MR MILLER THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER SIR S. B.
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE IS THE FOLLOW
UP TO AS B. THIRTY FIVE FROM THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HOUSING PACKAGE.
OF THE BILL THAT US STREAMLINED
HOUSING APPROVALS AND CITIES
THAT AREN'T BUILDING UP HOMES IT
REPRESENTS A CONSENSUS AGREEMENT
BETWEEN SENATOR WINTERS OFFICE
LEADERSHIP IN THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY ACD THE ADMINISTRATION
AND MANY ADVOCATES AND MAKES A
SERIES OF CLARIFICATIONS THAT
ARE ALIGNED WITH THE INTENT OF
S. B.. THIRTY FIVE AND NECESSARY
TO MAKE SURE IT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED CORRECTLY.
IT'S RECEIVE NO NO VOTES IN
ASSEMBLY POLICY COMMITTEES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
FAMOUS BLOW.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE --
SEVERAL OF A MORAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
HE DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESERVE VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
CHILDHOOD ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
NINETY ONE S. B. WHAT THE SIXTY
EIGHT QUACKERY.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO RECYCLING
[inaudible]
MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SP ONE SIXTY EIGHT HAS
ONE SIMPLE BUT CRITICAL
OBJECTIVE TO SUPPORT AND
INCREASE RECYCLING MARKETS RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NATIONAL SOARED THE A A CHINESE.
PROGRAM HAS RESULTED IN THE
RECYCLING CRISIS AND A.
STOCKPILING OF RECYCLABLE
MATERIALS IT'S AB BUILDING UP
ALL THROUGH OUR STATE.
AND TO COMBAT THIS WE NEED. TO
CREATE MARKETS FOR THESE
MATERIAL SO ESPY'S.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT DOES EXACTLY
THAT BY CREATING A CLOSED LOOP
SYSTEM FOR PAT PLASTIC THAT DOES
NOT EXIST TODAY.
WITH THE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
DATE WE ARE GIVING THE BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY A SIGNAL THAT IN --
OVER FIFTEEN MONTHS BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURERS MUST INCORPORATE.
AT LEAST 20% RECYCLED MATERIAL
IN THEIR PLASTIC BOTTLES THAT
ARE FOR SALE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLEAR PASSED
SOME OF MISINFORMATION THAT'S
BEEN CIRCULATING ABOUT THE BILL.
OF THIS BILL APPLIES ONLY TO SEE
R. V. CONTAINERS EXCEPT FOR
ALUMINUM AND GLASS [inaudible]
UP.
TO EACH INDIVIDUAL CONTAINERS
NOT REQUIRED TO MEET THE CONTENT
STANDARD IT'S THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT COMPLIANCE.
BE BASED ON THE AVERAGE OF A
COMPANY'S CONTAINERS.
THE 20% ANNUAL MINIMUM CONTENT
FOR PLASTIC CONTAINERS IS 1100%
FEASIBLE ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
BEVERAGES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
HAVE ALREADY REPORTED AS HAVING
SOME LEVEL OF RECYCLED CONTENT.
AND THERE'S ENOUGH PET PLASTIC
IN CALIFORNIA TO MEET THIS 20%
STANDARD.
CALIFORNIA IS PROJECTED TO HAVE
MORE THAN TWICE AS MUCH CLEAN
CLEAR FOOD GRADE OUR PET THEN.
RECYCLABLE PET THEN WOULD BE
NEEDED TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
THE ELIMINATION OF OVERSEAS
MARKETS HAS CREATED AN IMBALANCE
BETWEEN THE AMOUNT OF RECYCLABLE
PET.
THAT IS AVAILABLE AND IT'S
DEMAND.
AND THAT WAS WHY S. B. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT IS SO CRITICAL.
OUR CHOICE IS CLEAR WE CAN HAVE
PLASTICS IN OUR LANDFILL.
OF WHERE THEY WILL NEVER GO AWAY
OR WE CAN DEVELOP A VIBRANT
RECYCLING MARKET.
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
CREATE GOOD MANUFACTURING JOBS.
S. B. ONE SIXTY EIGHT HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THING THIS BLOOM DOCTOR QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED CHAU AYE I
WAS AT FIRST VERY SKEPTICAL OF
THIS BILL AND I DID A LOT OF
RESEARCH.
THERE IS PLENTY OF P. E. T..
FOOD QUALITY THAT CAN BE USE
THIS IS A VERY PRACTICAL BILL.
AS WELL AS A NECESSARY.
ONE IF WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO RECYCLE PLASTIC WE REALLY
HAVE TO DO THIS [inaudible]
MR VERSACE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE EIGHTY SIX WE
HEARD THIS BILL TWICE IN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
AND OUR THE AUTHOR HAS IT TAKEN
NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THIS
A GOOD BILL AYE WE HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM.
OF FOLKS AND NOT ONLY IN THE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY BUT ALSO IN
THE THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY --
WHERE THEY TESTIFIED THAT
WITHOUT?
HAVING THIS MINIMAL CONTENT
THERE THERE ARE MANY --
COMPANIES LIKE.
COCA COLA AND OTHERS THAT ARE.
SEATING THE 20% --
RECYCLED CONTENT BUT THAT WE
NEED TO ESTABLISH A BASELINE SO
THAT THE WE WE CAN NOW --
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS THAT IS THE
NATIONAL SORT POLICY WHERE CHINA
HAS REFUSED TO TAKE ANY --
MORE RECYCLED PLASTIC FROM OUR
COUNTRY AND SO THIS IS A VERY
NECESSARY BILL IN ORDER --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHENEVER WE
PUT PLASTICS AND RECYCLING BINS
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
RECYCLED.
THANK YOU MISS MURATSUCHI SAYING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE ITEM THIS ROOMY MAY CLOSE
WE WISH THANK YOU AGAIN AND I'M
ITS FIRST MISTER SPEAKER AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS STUFF FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL.
AS I SAID I'VE MANY TIMES IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS I THINK UGH
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M WOULD BE SHOCKED IF THEY
KNEW HOW LITTLE OF THE PRODUCTS
THAT THEY ARE A BELIEVER BEING
RECYCLED ARE ACTUALLY BEING
RECYCLED AND THAT CONCERN IS
ONLY DOUBLED SINCE THAT CHINA.
STARTED REJECTING --
ARE ARE UP PRODUCTS FOR
PROCESSING THERE THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS WE NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN SENDING THIS STUFF TO CHINA
ANYWAY.
WE SHOULD TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR OUR OWN RISK ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM WITH
FACKLER GLOBAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAGO
.
MISTER BLOOM OF THE CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO JUMP TO
FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE THIS IS
NINETY FIVE ON THE SENATE THERE
READING FILE [inaudible]
S. B.. FOUR SIX FIVE THE
CROCKERY.
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO THE PROPERTY
ASSESSED CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAM
[inaudible]
XAVIER HURRY.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL. FOR
SIXTY FIVE THE WILDFIRE SAFETY
FINANCE ACT WHICH AUTHORIZES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREAS. TO EXPAND THEIR
PROPERTY ASSESS CLEAN ENERGY OR
PACE PROGRAMS TO ALLOW PROPERTY
OWNERS TO FINANCE THE
INSTALLATION OF SPECIFIC WILD
FIRE SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS FOR
THEIR HOMES AND BUSINESSES.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED THE
LARGEST THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN HISTORY.
HOW FOR HALFWAY THROUGH THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FIRE SEASON
IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS YEAR WILL
SURPASS MANY OF THE LAST THEIR?
LAST YEAR'S STAGGERING DAMAGE
STATISTICS.
AND THOUGHT AND THOUGHT THOSE ON
UNMATCHABLE MERE MONTHS AGO.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE ONE
IMPORTANT TOOL TO HOMEOWNERS.
WHO MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO FINANCE
FIRE PREVENTION HOME
IMPROVEMENTS OTHER WAYS?
I WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
SENATOR TO ASSURE THAT S. B. FOR
SIXTY FIVE INCORPORATES ALL
EXISTING GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT.
AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THROUGH
A MEMBERS TAKEN AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
JUST SOME OF THE NARROWING
AMENDMENTS LIMIT THE PROGRAM TO
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
PROVIDE A TEN YEAR SUNSET DATE.
STATE BUT ONLY EXISTING AGAIN
EXISTING BUILDINGS CAN USE THE
PROGRAM AND REQUIRE PROPERTY
OWNERS TO NOT NOTIFY THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANY OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS SO THEY SOUTHERN
SURE.
IN FACT SENATOR JACKSON'S
JACKSON IS SO COMMITTED TO
ASSURING CONSUMERS ARE PROTECTED.
SHE HAS MADE THIS BILL
CONTINGENT UPON THE ROBUST
UNDERWRITING AND ABILITY TO PAY
PROVISIONS IN MY BILL AB TWENTY
SIXTY THREE BECOMING LAW.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
TO AGGRESSIVELY TACKLE ALL
ASPECTS OF REDUCING OUR WILDFIRE
RISKS.
INCLUDING HARDENING OUR EXISTING
HOUSING STOCK LOCATED IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD AREAS.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
OR DEBATE.
CAR CLUB THE ROLE I AM.
IT IS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE
.
MS AG AIR CURRY MOVES A CALL
WE ARE GOING.
TO TAKE UP THE PRIOR ADAM THAT'S
FILE ITEM [inaudible] NINETY
FOUR THIS IS S. B. TWO TWELVE BY
MR TANG.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO TWELVE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE SOLID WASTE.
MISTER TING YOU MAY OPEN.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
VERY PROUD TO STAND TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL I TWO ONE TWO SENATE
BILL TWO WHICH WAS REALLY A
CULMINATION OF OVER. THREE YEARS
OF THE LIBERATION WORKING VERY
MUCH -- WITH
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS MANY OF
THE PHARMACEUTICAL AYE AGENCIES
REGARDING TAPE THE TAKE BACK OF
DRUGS AS WELL AS WITH SHARPS --
IT REALLY IS AN AMAZING
SITUATION WERE ABLE TO OUR COME
TOGETHER WORK WITH --
THE SENATOR FROM SANTA BARBARA
MY COLLEAGUE FROM MERCED AS WELL
AS ALL THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS
IN THIS PROCESS AND I BELIEVE WE
FINALLY HAVE.
A ARE VERY GOOD FINISHED PRODUCT
HOME GENERATED DRUG THE SHARPS
WHICH IS ALL THE PRESCRIPTIONS
WE DON'T FINISH AND DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH.
THEIR ACCOUNT WHAT'S IN
ACCUMULATE FOR YEARS --
FOR REGULAR NEEDLE USERS LIKE I
PASTOR I IN RESPONSE A NUMBER OF
THE CALIPHATE PASSED LOCAL
ORDINANCES EVER PARTY
MANUFACTURES TO RUN PROGRAMS TO
TAKE HOME.
GENERATED WASTE EVEN WITH A
RELATIVELY SMALL NUMBERS NINE
COUNTIES I WAS SIX MORE WORKING
ON IT INCLUDING WITH ANGELUS
WITH WHAT SUPPORT THE PATCHWORK
IS FORMING.
SO IN ORDER TO AVOID HAVING ANY
MORE OF THE PATCHWORK QUILT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CRAFT.
STATE WHY POLICY THAT WE ARE
FAIRLY --
BROAD AGREEMENT VERY PROUD TO BE
ABLE TO OUR REACH THIS AGREEMENT
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY MISSED A SEEING NO
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
OR DEBATE.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION.
MR GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL THAT.
WE'VE WORKED ON THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS AYE IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE. FOR FOR MUCH LONGER
THAN THAT AND THROUGH.
SEVERAL YEARS OF MEETINGS AND
DIALOGUE WHICH IN MY OFFICE.
A SIMILAR KINGS OFFICER
JACKSON'S OFFICE WERE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH A COMPROMISE --
PACKAGE THAT I THINK'S GOING TO
ADVANCE.
THE ISSUE TAKE BACKS A GREAT
DEAL TO SAY CALIFORNIA WOULD PUT
US -- IN THE
LEAD ON THE ISSUE AND I WANT TO
THANK OF BOTH SUMMER RETAINING
ITS ARE JACKSON --
FOR FRANKLY CALLOUS HOURS APART
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS IMAGE TO
PARTIES THAT GAUGED A WITH THIS
INSTITUTION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOAT --
HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GREAT DOCTOR
QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SO MY COUNTY ALAMEDA COUNTY WAS
THE FIRST ONE TO COME UP WITH
THE DRUG TAKE BACK MAIL AND I
DIDN'T THINK IT WAS NECESSARY.
THE REASON WE NEED THIS BILL NOW
IS THEIR RD FIVE COUNTIES WITH
DRUG TAKE PACKS AND THEY'RE ALL
DIFFERENT.
AND THERE'S ANOTHER NINE
COUNTIES INCLUDING LA COUNTY
WHICH IS A QUARTER OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION THAT WANT TO
COME UP WITH A ROUND TRIP TAKE
BACK BILLS.
THIS IS JUST NECESSARY AND THE
INDUSTRY WANTS IT SO THEY CAN
HAVE ONE UNIFORM.
BILL IRWIN UNIFORM LAW THAT THEY
CAN LIVE WITH.
AS OPPOSED TO EACH COUNTY BEING
DIFFERENT SOME OF THEM THEY CAN
LIVE WITH SOME OF THEM THEY
CAN'T. ONE VERY IMPORTANT AYE
ASPECT OF THIS IS THE SHARPEST
TACK TAKE BACK.
SHARP'S TAKE BACK WHICH
NEGOTIATED WITH THE INDUSTRY.
IT'S AN ENTIRELY A MAIL BACK
SYSTEM THEY'RE HAPPY WITH IT.
OB IT [inaudible]
IT ALSO.
CREATES FEWER PROBLEMS BECAUSE
FRANKLY NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE
SHARPS ON THEIR PROPERTY.
SO THE MAIL TAKE BACK PROGRAM
FOR SHARPS IS GREAT INDUSTRIES
OKAY [inaudible]
ARE AND WELL AS YOU FEW PEOPLE
SAYING OPPOSE AND AMENDED ON THE
DRUG SIDE.
THEY TELL US WE SHOULD VOTE
[inaudible]
FOR SO [inaudible]
NOT EVERYBODY'S.
POLICE WE HAPPY BUT EVERYBODY
DOES WANT TO SEE THIS PASS THANK
YOU.
THINK THAT QUIRK.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL.
SKETCHING ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LOCAL ROLE ON THE ZARA
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL THE VOTE.
I FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
NINETY SIX S. B..
NINE THIRTY NINE CORKERY SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND ACTUALLY THE
PAYMENT OF CLAIMS AGAINST THE
STATE MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE DECLARING THAT URGENCY
THERE ARE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU SB NINE THIRTY
NINE IS ONE OF THE BILL'S
CARRIED BY THE CHAIRS OF THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE EACH YEAR
TO PROVIDE PREPARATION AUTHORITY
FOR LEGAL SETTLEMENTS APPROVED
BY THE DOJ.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE SETTLEMENTS WERE ENTERED
INTO LAWFULLY BY STATE UPON
ADVICE COUNCIL IN OUR BINDING
STATE OBLIGATIONS ANY FUNDS
APPROPRIATED EXCESSIVE AMOUNTS
REQUIRED FOR THE CLAIMS REVERT
BACK TO THE STATE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SAYING NO DISCRETION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL ANTI ABOUT EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE.
WHERE IT FILE ITEM?
NINETY SEVEN S. B.. FIVE
NINETEEN SEPARATE SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETEEN BY SENATOR PELL
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE HIGHWAYS [inaudible]
MISTER GIBSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL EXCUSE ME
SENATE BILL.
FIVE NINETEEN THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE CALTRANS TO ENTER INTO
A LEASE WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND SAN JOSE AT THE RATE
OF ONE DOLLAR PER MONTH FOR UP.
TO TEN PARTIALS IN EACH CITY SO
THAT THEY CAN BE USED FOR
EMERGENCY HOMELESS SHELTER AND
FEEDING PROGRAMS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW CALTRANS HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO ENTER INTO A
SIMILAR LEASE WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
WANT TO UNDERSCORE SAN FRANCISCO
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY I'M CITY OF
SAN DIEGO SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AND
OAKLAND --
DUE TO THE PASSES OF ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE
BONTA IS WAITING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AND SAN JOSE. TO WORK WITH
CALTRANS TO HELP ADDRESS AT THE
STATE HOMELESS CRISIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE ON
SENATE BILL.
FIVE NINETEEN THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON MR MATHIS YOUR RECOMMENDS
THAT YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
HERE WE ARE YET AGAIN EARLIER
THIS YEAR I AUTHORED A BILL THAT
WOULD OPEN THIS UP FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE.
BUT YET AGAIN HERE WE ARE
PICKING FAVORITES WE GO THE BAY
AREA WE GO WITH OAKLAND AND NOW
LA.
WHEN IS THE REST OF THE STATE
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS FOR
EVERYBODY?
MEMBERS LET'S BE FAIR HERE I ASK
FOR NO VOTE [inaudible]
AMOS MATHIS SEEING NO.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OVER THE ROW.
AND MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL AND TELL YOU I FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
NINETY EIGHT S. B. [inaudible]
SEVEN FIFTEEN CORKERY SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
DELGADO AND ACTUALLY TO PICK YOU
AIR POLLUTION [inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
SOME FIFTEEN SUPPORTS THE
CREATION OF GOOD JOBS BY
ENSURING CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICES WHO OPERATE HEAVY
EQUIPMENT AND CRANES HAVE THE
CONTINUED OPPORTUNITY. TO LEARN
THEIR TRADE AND FURTHER THEIR
CAREERS APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
USE OLDER HEAVY EQUIPMENT TO
PREPARE PLOY IS FOR A CAREER IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
THE EQUIPMENT USED IN THE
TRAINING IS YOU SIGNIFICANTLY
LASSEN EQUIPMENT THAT IS USED ON
A JOB SITE.
BUT APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
OPERATE HEAVY EQUIPMENT AND
CRANES HAVE HAD TO SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN ORDER TO
RETROFIT OR REPLACE EQUIPMENT TO
COMPLY WITH EXISTING AIR QUALITY
REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO RELIEVE THESE
NONPROFIT PROGRAMS FROM
EXORBITANT EXPENSES BY PROVIDING
A LOW USE EXEMPTION FOR THEIR
TRAINING EQUIPMENT.
IN THE SCOPE OF THE OVERALL
STATEWIDE EMISSIONS INVENTORY
THE APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING FEET
FLEET AS A NEGLIGIBLE
CONTRIBUTOR BUT IT IS CRITICAL
CRITICAL FOR CREATING QUALITY
JOBS THAT YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
[inaudible]
SEEING NO.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LOVE THEY'RE ALL ON THE
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
WORK WELL CLOSER ALL.
DIVERT EYES [inaudible]
FORTY TWO KNOWS.
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NINETY NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE MEMBERS S. B.
[inaudible]
FIVE OH TO CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL FIVE THOUGH TO BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS S. B. FIVE
OH TO REQUIRES ALL OPERATORS OF
THE COMMUTER RAIL SYSTEM.
BY JULY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWENTY TO ENSURE THAT EACH TRAIN
IS EQUIPPED WITH AN AUTOMATIC.
EXTERNAL DEFIBRILLATOR ES DE.
IN ADDITION THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY
AUTHORIZATION FOR METROLINK TO
PURSUE A CONSTRUCTION.
MANAGEMENT GENERAL CONTRACTOR.
APPROACH TO FACILITATE THE
DELIVERY OF THIS.
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OPTIMIZE
RAIL EXPANSION SCORE PROGRAM BY.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT SCORE
PROGRAM CONSISTS OF VARIOUS
TRACKS SIGNAL AND GRADE
SEPARATION PROJECTS AIMED AT
ACHIEVING YES THEY ARE ARE A
GOAL OF PROVIDING FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY MINUTES.
BI DIRECTIONAL SERVICE ON KEY
CORRIDORS.
THE COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL OUR
AIM TO PROTECT COMMUTER RAIL
PASSENGERS WILL BEING ABLE TO
DELIVER PROJECTS IN A TIMELY
MANNER TO INCREASE RIDERSHIP ON
THE COMMUTER RAIL SYSTEM. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THEY WAS FRAZIER SEEING NO
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
OR DEBATE.
CORD CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
PHONE NUMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI THAT EYES FIFTY
NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM.
NINETY THREE THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE SB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE BY SENATOR CANNELLA AND
OTHERS IN ATLANTA CANNABIS
DECLARING THEIR URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT S. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN NON IMPRINT BEHALF OF
SENATOR CANNELLA.
FOLLOWING THE PROPER PATH THE
PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN INUNDATED
WITH LICENSE FOR APPLICATIONS IN
SEVERAL COUNTIES INCLUDING
HUMBLE.
AND SANTA BARBARA HAVE HUGE
BACKLOGS BACKLOGS UNFORTUNATE
BOTH PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR IN
THE RECENT RATE RELEASE
REGULATIONS PREVENT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FROM EXTENDING
TEMPORARY LICENSES THAT EXPIRED
AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE THAT WILL SERVE TO
BRIDGE THE GAP WELL COUNTIES
WERE THROUGH THE BACKLOG OF
LICENSE APPLICATIONS.
WITHOUT THIS BILL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE TRYING TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE AND PLAY BY THE RULES
WILL BE UNFAIRLY BOXED OUT OF
THE LEGAL MARKET.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BY CAMP
CAMERAL EFFORT AND HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY'D ACT WOULD.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE SO
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE EYES FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SPEAK TO FIVE KNOWS YOU'RE ON
THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES
.
EVERS WE ARE GOING TO RETURN TO
THE TOP OF THE SENATE THERE
READING FILE THIS IS TOP OF THE
FILE.
TOP OF SENATE THIRD READING
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY TWO SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX THE CORPORATE RATE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
BY SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO FIREARMS
[inaudible]
SURE GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS WHEN THE LAS
VEGAS SHOOTER KILLED FIFTY EIGHT
AND INJURED OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY PEOPLE.
IN THE DEADLIEST MASS SHOOTING
IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY HE
FIRED MORE THAN ELEVEN HUNDRED
ROUNDS IN MERE MINUTES.
HE DID THIS USING A DEVICE KNOWN
AS A MULTI BURST TRIGGER
ACTIVATOR WHICH EFFECTIVELY
TRANSFORMED HIS SEMI AUTOMATIC
RIFLE INTO A MACHINE GUN.
UNFORTUNATELY MULTI BURST
TRIGGER ACTIVATORS ARE LEGAL IN
MANY STATES OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY SIX LIST
COMMON NAMES FOR THESE FIREARMS
ATTACHMENTS WHICH INCLUDE BOMB
STOCK DOUBT CRANK AND TRIGGER
ACTUATOR.
BY LISTING THEPOPULAR NAMES OF
THESE DEVICES SP THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX MAKES IT MORE LIKELY THE
FIREARMS ENTHUSIASTS WILL BE
MADE AWARE THAT SUCH DEVICES ARE
ILLEGAL IN OUR STATE.
THE BILL ALSO DESCRIBES VARIOUS
DESIGNS FOR MULTI BURST TRIGGER
ACTIVATORS AND MAKES CLEAR THAT
IF SUCH DEVICES BUILT INTO OR
USED IN CONJUNCTION WITH A
FIREARM.
IT IS WITHIN THE STATUTE AND
ILLEGAL.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY SIX WILL
DECREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF THESE
DEVICES BEING BROUGHT INTO
CALIFORNIA AND THUS REDUCE THE
CHANCES OF A TRAGEDY LIKE THE
ONE THAT OCCURRED IN LAS VEGAS.
THIS BILL HELPS STRENGTHEN OUR
LAWS IN THE CHURCH THE BOTH GUN
MERCHANTS AND OWNERS ARE
UNMISTAKABLY PUT ON NOTICE THAT
THESE DEVICES ARE LEGAL TO
POSSESS OR SELL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS GABRIEL MUCH
MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
A FIREARM IS SIMPLY A TOOL.
IN A FOR ACTUALLY GOING TO STOP
MASS MURDERERS AND DO THESE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO MORE ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH SIDE.
WE NEED TO STOP BLAMING FIREARMS
WE NEED TO STOP SAYING BUT
STOCKS AND EVERYTHING ELSE OR
THE ROOT OF ALL EVIL.
AND WE NEED TO REALIZE THAT
THESE ARE SIMPLY TOOLS.
THAT IT'S THE HUMAN BEHIND THE
TOOL.
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE THE SAME WAY
AS IS NOT THE CAR'S FAULT FOR
DRUNK DRIVER.
ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS DOCTOR CHOI
[inaudible]
YOU'RE RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I RISE SITE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS A BIT A LOT
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY SIX SAW
THIS BILL IS NOT A YA SOLUTION
IN SEARCH FOR A PROPER.
IT WORKED REPRESENTS ARE.
JUST A AND NO THOUGH IS STONE
MONTH NOT IN THIS OUR BODY IS SO
ONGOING AFFLUENT. TO DISMANTLE
THE A SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS
ALL OF OUR LAW ABIDING
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS.
SOME INCOME ARE IN SACRAMENTO
LOOSELY BY.
IN THE QUEST TO LAW RESTRICTING
THE RIGHTS ARE OVERALL ABIDING
GUN OWNERS.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME.
MAKING EVERY EFFORT TO OUR
DEMANDS ON A SOFT ON CRIME RAFTO
OWN MANAGERS [inaudible]
OF MEASURES.
THIS BILL LISTA UNNECESSARY.
AND A DOZEN NOTHING [inaudible]
SO ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF A GUN
VIOLENCE.
BY YEAH PREMIUM ON STOCKS
[inaudible]
TRUST ME.
THEY WILL ALWAYS I HAVE WELL
WHATEVER GUN THEY WANT. TO DO
WITH THEIR WORK.
I ASK MY COLLEAGUES DOCTORS JOIN
ME.
IN OPPOSING SPF.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX MISTER BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX I AGREE.
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM BY
THEY'LL YOU THAT WE NEED TO DO A
LOT MORE.
ON MENTAL HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
STOP PEOPLE WHO HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS FROM GETTING
GUNS.
THAT DOES NOT SEEM TO BE THE
CASE -- IN
THE VEGAS SHOOTING.
WHICH ITS HOME A LITTLE BIT FOR
ME BECAUSE WHEN THE VEGAS
SHOOTER.
I'M LEASE HOLY HELL.
ON THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
AT A CONCERT THAT DAY.
ARE THAT NIGHT THE NIGHT IT WAS
JASON ALL DEAN --
WAS WAS ON STAGE.
THE NIGHT BEFORE.
I WAS AT ADJACENT CONCERT WITH
MY GIRLFRIEND --
SING AND DANCING AND AND HAVING
A GOOD TIME --
TWENTY FOUR HOURS BEFORE IT'S
RUNNING OF A THEATER IN MOUNTAIN
VIEW.
AND I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE --
THE THE IMPACT IF SOMEBODY WHERE
IT WOULD'VE STARTED FIRING.
OVER A THOUSAND ROUNDS --
INTO A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
LITTLE IT LITERALLY TAKE.
THEY'RE AT A CONCERT SURROUNDED
BY FENCES.
A CAGED IN.
AND SOMEBODY WHO IS ABLE TO USE
A BOMB STOCK. TO BE ABLE TO
SHOOT.
FAR MORE BULLETS PER MINUTE THAN
ANYBODY EVER NEEDS TO OUTSIDE OF
WAR -- TO
DETAIN FLICK THE AND IT IMMENSE
DAMAGE --
THAT THAT PERSON INFLICTED SO.
THIS IDEA THAT --
YOU KNOW WE DON'T ELIMINATE CARS --
YOU KNOW THAT BACK THERE THAT
BECAUSE CAR ACCIDENTS WE DON'T.
BOARD PUT SPEED LIMITS ON THE
ROAD.
AND THIS IS AN ELIMINATING A GUN.
IT'S OF RESTRICTING THE ABILITY
OF SOMEBODY TO BE ABLE TO
TOTALLY UNNECESSARILY FIRE.
THOUSANDS OF ROUNDS IN IN AND I
AM.
INCREDIBLY SHORT TIME SPAN SO
YOU KNOW IF YOU NEED THE SECOND
AMENDMENT TO HUNT.
THAT'S COOL BUT IF YOU NEED
ISSUED A HUNDRED ROUNDS IN A
MINUTE TO HUNT [inaudible]
YOU'RE USELESS --
SOMETHING'S WRONG WITH YOU.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS ALLOWS YOU
TO DO.
AND SO I FULLY ENCOURAGE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT SB BECAUSE
YOU'RE MATHIS STATE YOUR POINT
OF ORDER --
TO DO WITH THE RIGHT OF HAUNTING
IT HAD TO DO WITH THE RIDE OF
CITIZENS BEING ABLE TO WRITE
THEMSELVES FROM THE GOVERNMENT
THAT'S THAT.
THIS IS A PULITZER MATHIS THE
POINT OF ORDERS NOW ALL TAKEN
POINT ORDERS NOT OPPORTUNITY. TO
EXTEND DEBATE IT'S TO ISSUE A
POINT OF ORDER THAT I'M ABLE TO
RULE ON I MEAN TO SAY THAT POINT
OF ORDER IS NOT WELL TAKEN
MISTER.
BERMAN IS.
RIGHT JUST ON THE MATTERS I HAVE
ABOUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
DOWSING CLARIFIES.
THAT A POINT OF ORDER IS REALLY
STRICTLY ON THE RULES.
THAT THIS BODY IS ABIDING BY.
SO THAT'S OUT OF ORDER --
MISTER BERMAN HAS CLOSED DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
ON THIS MATTER.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MR GABRIEL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I JUST SAY I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
IRVINE DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS --
IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM I THINK
THAT MASS SHOOTINGS ARE PROBLEM
OUR SOCIETY.
I SUSPECT THAT IF MY COLLEAGUE
WENT KNAUS MOST PARENTS IN HIS
COMMUNITY IF THEY THOUGHT THAT
MASS SHOOTINGS OR PROBLEM.
THEY WOULD AGREE THAT THEY ARE
PROBLEM AND I THINK WHAT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR A LOT OF US IS
THAT EVERY TIME THERE'S
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WHICH IS A
REASONABLE MODEST COMMONSENSE
MEASURE.
ON THE ISSUE OF GUNS THERE SO
MUCH PUSH BACK AND I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY.
THIS IS NOT A MEASURE TO TAKE
FOLKS GUNS AWAY.
MULTI BURST TRIGGER ACTIVATORS
ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS SIMPLY
CLARIFIES OUR LAW MAKE SURE AND
THAT FOLKS ARE AWARE THAT THESE
THINGS ARE LEGAL UNDER STATE LAW
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN BE USED
IN A WAYS THAT ARE LEGAL UNDER
STATE LAW.
AND REDUCES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THESE DEVICES WHICH ARE ALREADY
ILLEGAL UNDER STATE LAW WILL BE
BROUGHT INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A REASONABLE
COMMON SENSE MEASURE IT HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THINGS GABRIEL WITHOUT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE I'M.
THIS ARTICLE AT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS THAT IS OUT OF THE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ALL TALLY THE VOTE
ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS.
TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO JUMP
AHEAD.
IN THE FILE ORDER.
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY S. B. [inaudible]
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO SENTENCING.
IT'S YOU'RE DAVID CHIU.
THANK MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
ARE RISING BEHALF OF SENATOR
BRADFORD TO PRESENT SP TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE A BILL TO SIMPLIFY
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLEX SENTENCING
LAWS AND ENSURE.
GREATER PROPORTIONALITY IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
UNDER EXISTING LAW OUR STATE HAS
ONE OF THE MOST CONFUSING
SENTENCING STRUCTURES IN THE
WORLD.
SO INDICATE THAT SO INTRICATE
THAT JUDGES PROSECUTORS AND
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE OFTEN
UNCERTAIN WITH THE INTERPLAY
BETWEEN VARIOUS SENTENCING
SCHEMES. TO ADD TO THE PROBLEM
OVER THE PAST FEW DECADES THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE HAS GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY.
INCLUDING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS ON OUR
BOOKS.
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR I HAVE
SEEN THE IMPACT OF THE WAR ON
DRUGS THE TOUGH ON CRIME
APPROACHES TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THIS IS RESULTED OFTEN IN A
CYCLE OF CRIME AMONG
DISADVANTAGED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
WHAT THIS BILL IS A SMALL CHANGE
IN A LARGER SYSTEM WHICH SEEKS
TO ADDRESS PROBLEMS BY RESTORING
SENTENCING PROPORTIONALITY AND
PREVENTING INDIVIDUALS FROM
SERVING MORE TIME? FOR AN
ENHANCEMENT THEN THE UNDERLYING
CRIME ITSELF.
ULTIMATELY THIS BILL WOULD HELP
TO REFINE ARE CONFUSING
SENTENCING LAWS BY INSURING THAT
A FULL TERM OF IMPRISONMENT DOES
NOT EXCEED TWICE A NUMBER OF
YEARS FOR THE BASE TERM.
IT'S A MEASURED AND CAREFULLY
CRAFTED BILL THAT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE ANY ENHANCEMENTS AND
DOES NOT INCLUDE A HOST OF
OFFENSES THAT ARE NO SERIOUS
VIOLENT.
IN NATURE AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISS YOU.
MISS BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE.
VERY STRONG OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
NOT BECAUSE WE SHOULDN'T HAVE A
SIMPLE.
AND WHAT WE SEE HERE
PROPORTIONAL [inaudible]
CRIMINAL CODE.
BUT BECAUSE PASSING THIS LAW.
IS GONNA MAKE LIFE VERY ON
SIMPLE AND DISPROPORTIONATE FOR
THE VICTIMS LITTERED DESPERATELY
UNDERSERVED BY THE US.
THIS GIVES A VOLUME DISCOUNT TO
CRIMINALS.
SO LONG AS THEY GET CENTS FOR
ABOUT FOR THE CRIMES OF THEIR
CHARGE FOR HAVE FOR VICTIMS YOU
CAN HAVE VICTIM AFTER VICTIM
AFTER VICTIM.
WHO IS COMPLETELY THROWN ASIDE
BY THE US?
AND IT ALSO INCLUDES SOME OF THE
GROSSEST MOST SEVERE CRIMES ON
CHILDREN.
LET'S TAKE A FEW EXAMPLES.
LARRY NASSER HAD OVER A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY VICTIMS MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
MANY THE AGE OF FOURTEEN OR
FIFTEEN THEY ARE COMPLETELY
DISREGARDED BY THIS BILL.
YOU ONLY HAVE TO SERVE IF YOU
WERE HERE AND UNDER THIS BILL
HE'D ONLY BE CENTS FOR FOUR OF
THOSE VICTIMS WHAT ARE YOU
SAYING TO THE FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS.
THE OTHER HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
THAT WERE VICTIMIZED BY LARRY
NASSER.
YOU'RE SAYING I'D RATHER HAVE A
SIMPLE CODE IN THIS IS THE ONLY
WAY TO DO IT.
THEY ALSO WOULD NOT BE PROTECTED
BECAUSE THIS DOESN'T COVER.
NON FORCIBLE SEXUAL ASSAULT OF A
MINOR.
ONLY FORCIBLE SEXUAL ASSAULT.
A MINOR IS COVERED BY THIS.
SO WHAT ARE YOU SAYING TO THOSE
VICTIMS OF NON FORCIBLE SEXUAL
ASSAULT I'M SORRY THAT'S JUST.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK THE CRIMINAL SHOULD HAVE
TO SERVE MORE TIME.
FOR WE TALKED A LOT IN THIS
FLOOR ABOUT HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AGAIN THE FASTEST GROWING
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND A SEVERE
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY FEWER BILLS ON
THIS FLORA COME HERE AND GET
PAST TO FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THIS IS ONE WILL ACTUALLY MAKE
IT.
EASIER FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
PERPETRATED HUMAN TRAFFICKING ON
MORE THAN SIX VICTIMS. TO BE
SENTENCED.
FOR I JUST GIVEN EXAMPLE THAT
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION MAKES VERY CLEAR.
YOU HAVE SIX VICTIMS A JUDGE CAN
CURRENTLY [inaudible]
IMPOSE.
A HIGHER SENSE OF EIGHTEEN YEARS
AND FOUR MONTHS UNDER THIS BILL
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF TIME
THEY'RE GONNA SEE FOR THE BASED
TERM IS GOING TO BE 50% OF THAT.
SO THE CRIMINALS GET FREE
VICTIMS [inaudible]
FREE VICTIMS.
THEY'LL GET CENTS FOR A FEW THE
CRIMES AND EVERYONE ELSE THAT
THESE ARE CONSTITUENTS.
OR SOME OF THE WORST GROSSEST
CRIMES THEY'RE NOT ONLY BEING
LET OFF THE HOOK.
THEY'RE NOT CARING FOR THE
VICTIMS.
GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE
[inaudible]
ROBBERY.
YOU COMMIT A ROBBERY AND USE A
FIREARM AND YOU JUST CHARGE IT
AND IT CAUSES GREAT BODILY HARM.
DOESN'T MATTER.
UNDER THIS THAT ENHANCEMENT
DOESN'T MATTER ANYMORE.
AND WE JUST HAD A BILL ACTUALLY
GREAT DOLLARS CO AUTHOR OF IT.
I'M ON BOND STOCKS.
AND EVERYONE HERE SPOKE IN FAVOR
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND CALIFORNIANS
FROM GUN VIOLENCE.
THIS BILL IS SAYING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN WE
WANT A SIMPLE PROPORTIONAL CODE
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER TO US THAT
YOU USED A FIREARM IN THE COURSE
OF A ROBBERY AND CAUSE GREAT
BODILY INJURY.
WE HAVE DONE ENOUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE TO BE LIGHTS ON
CRIME IT'S START IT'S TIME TO
START CARING FOR THE VICTIMS IN
THIS STATE.
AND HOLDING PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
CRIME RESPONSIBLE FOR IT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
MS CARILLO.
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE AS
A PROD CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
S. B..
TWENTY SB. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
FOR DECADES THE TOUGH ON CRIME
ERA THOUGHT POLICIES ENACTED
THAT EXTENDED PRISON SENTENCES
AND INCARCERATED THOUSANDS OF
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR.
THESE TACTICS REMOVE FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FROM OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND KEPT MANY
BEHIND BARS FOR FAR LONGER THAN
THEY DESERVED.
EXTENDED SENTENCES DO NOT LEAD
TO A DECREASE IN CRIME OR
IMPROVE OUR PUBLIC SAFETY WE
SHOULD ROOT OUR POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT ACTUALLY MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER AND PRIORITIZE.
THEIR FAIR STANDARDS IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE ENSURE
THAT JUDGES OVERSEE EFFECTIVE
SENTENCES THAT IT'S BASED ON
CLEAR.
AND LOGICAL STANDARDS AND I
WANNA JUST PERSONALLY BRING UP A
POINT THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
DUBLIN JUST STATED IN TERMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS.
THIS BODY DEBATED YESTERDAY
INCARCERATING. TWELVE YEAR OLDS.
IT DEBATED INCARCERATING YOUNG
PEOPLE.
AND TRYING THEM AS ADULTS WHAT
DO YOU THINK HAPPENS WHEN A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD SHARES A
CELLBLOCK.
WITH A FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD.
MORE THAN HALF OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
THAT ARE THROWN IN PRISON WITH
ADULTS.
ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
INSIDE THE PRISON SYSTEM.
SO WE CAN TALK ABOUT VICTIMS AND
WE CAN TALK ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
ON ONE QUE ON ONE HAND AND THEN.
TALK ABOUT THE VERY DIFFERENTLY
ON THE OTHER HAND.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO CORRECT
MANY OF THE WRONGS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING FOR MANY DECADES.
THIS BILL.
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO REDEFINE
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLICATED
SENTENCING APPROACH AND
REAFFIRMING OUR COMMITMENT TO A
FAIR AND EFFECTIVE.
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
FIRST LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I
WANT TO CLEAR ONE THING UP
CHILDREN DO NOT GET SENT TO
PRISON WITH ADULTS.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN SO LET'S
JUST DISPENSED WITH THAT BALD
HEAD SECOND OF ALL NO VICTIM I
DON'T THINK VICTIMS.
WHEN THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
CRIME THAT WAS COMMITTED AGAINST
THEM?
WHEN YOU'RE THINK WHEN THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE CRIME
COMMITTED AGAINST THEM I REALLY
DON'T THINK THAT WHAT'S FIRST
AND FOREMOST IN THEIR MIND IS
THE RACE?
OF THE PERSON WHO COMMITTED THE
CRIMES TO BRING RACE INTO IT IS
INSULTING IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
COLOR YOU ARE WHEN YOU COMMIT
THE CRIME OR WHAT COLOR THE
VICTIM IS.
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO JUST BE
OUT OF THE CONVERSATION --
THE ARGUMENTS FOR THIS BILL
SUGGESTS THAT.
THE SENTENCING LAWS THEY'RE JUST
TOO CONFUSING.
SO I MIGHT SUGGEST THAT ANYBODY
WHO IS AN ATTORNEY A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY OR ANYBODY WHO
SUGGESTING THAT OUR CRIMINAL
SENTENCING LAWS ARE TOO
CONFUSING.
PERHAPS THEY MIGHT WANT TO
CHOOSE ANOTHER PROFESSION ONE
THAT'S A LITTLE MORE EASILY
UNDERSTOOD BY THEM.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO
MISUNDERSTANDING WHEN IT COMES
TO CRIMES THAT ARE COMMITTED
AGAINST CHILDREN.
AND FOR THE LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT FORTH IN THIS BODY
PARTICULARLY RELATING TO CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN ARE SEXUAL
CRIMES.
YOU ARE SUGGESTING WITH THIS
BILL THAT --
PRIESTS WHO MOLEST CHILDREN.
SHOULD BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
SHE GET A BUY ONE GET ONE FREE
IN THIS CASE IS THAT WHAT YOU
WANT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE WAS
CORRECT IN STATING THAT WE HAVE
PASSED QUITE ENOUGH.
SOFT ON CRIME [inaudible]
PRUE.
CRIMINAL BILLS THIS YEAR ALONE.
THEN I THINK IT'S ENOUGH THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING DO NOT
BE ENTICED BY THE SIREN SONG OF
THIS IS ABOUT RACE.
AND NO THIS IS ONLY ABOUT RACE.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
STOP RACE BAITING AND TALK ABOUT
THE REAL ISSUE IN MAYBE FOR ONE
SOMEBODY HERE.
CAN TALK ABOUT THE VICTIMS HOW
ABOUT THAT.
HIS VICTIMS HAVE A VOICE TO AND
NEVER TO EVER HEAR ANYONE TALK
ABOUT THE VICTIMS WHO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SOME BILL LIKE THIS
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION SPEAK ABOUT IT
THANKFULLY.
BUT IF YOUR HEART IS SO FULL OF
COMPASSION.
THEN SURELY THERE CAN BE SOME
ROOM IN THERE FOR SOME
COMPASSION FOR THE VICTIMS I
URGE A NO VOTE [inaudible]
MISTER MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
URANUS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I UNDERSTAND AND I RESPECT WAS
CENTER BRADFORD IS TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS BILL.
AND I THINK.
WE ALL KNOW THAT WE HAVE PASSED
[inaudible]
SEVERAL MEASURES. TO SWING THE
PENDULUM BACK FROM WAR WE WERE
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES.
WHEN WE WENT TOO FAR?
WHEN WE OVER INCARCERATED
[inaudible]
ESPECIALLY.
PEOPLE FROM COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND SO I UNDERSTAND THE GOAL AND
THE INTENT.
THE GOOD INTENTIONS OF MANY OF
THE BILLS THAT HAVE COME BEFORE
US.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS
[inaudible]
BUT THIS.
IS A BAD BILL.
DOCTOR LARRY NASSER.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIM.
THE MEMBER FROM DUBLIN.
TALKS ABOUT DOCTOR NASSER A
CONVICTED CHILD MOLESTER WHO WAS
A USA GYMNASTICS NATIONAL TEAM
DOCTOR MOLESTED OVER ONE HUNDRED
YOUNG GIRLS MANY OF WHOM WERE
FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
[inaudible]
HAD.
DOCTOR NASSER BIN PROSECUTE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
UNDER THIS BILL.
THE JUDGE WOULD BE TAPPED.
HE WOULD HAVE NO DISCRETION TO
SENTENCE HIM. TO ANYTHING MORE
THAN SIX YEARS TOTAL. FOR
MOLESTING OVER ONE HUNDRED YOUNG
GIRLS.
SO IF ANYTHING ELSE.
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL BILLS COME BEFORE THIS
BODY THAT TALKS ABOUT HOW WE
NEED TO GIVEJUDGES THE
DISCRETION [inaudible] TO STRIKE.
ENHANCEMENTS ARE TO STRIKE PRIOR
[inaudible]
CONVICTIONS.
THIS IS TAKING AWAY FROM THAT
DISCRETION.
THIS IS TAKING US AWAY FROM THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WHICH IS LET
THE PUNISHMENT FIT THE CRIME.
WE SHOULD NOT HAVE DOCTOR NASSER
MOLESTING OVER A HUNDRED YOUNG
GIRLS.
AND IT JUST BE CAPPED UNDER THIS
BILL TO NO MORE THAN SIX YEARS
IN PRISON.
STRONGLY URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
MR CUTTING HIM URANUS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
JUST WANNA TOUCH ON ONE ASPECT
THAT HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED I
THINK IN SOME OF THE VERY
ELOQUENT.
SPEECHES AGAINST THIS.
VERY BAD IDEA --
AND THAT'S THAT IS THIS.
LOOK I SUPPORT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT BUT IF YOU USE A
FIREARM IN THE COMMISSION OF A
ROBBERY OR HOME INVASION.
YOU NEED TO DO SOME PRISON TIME.
THAT IS AN INHERENTLY DANGEROUS
ACTIVITY IN MY CAREER I'VE
WORKED ON CASES WHERE SOMEBODY
BROUGHT A GUN IN TWO MARIJUANA
RIPOFF.
AND THE GUY.
THE VICTIM THAT WAS SITTIN THERE
SELLING MARIJUANA OUT OF HIS
HOUSE HAD A GUN UNDER IT.
UNDER A BED.
AND HE PULLED THE GUN TO PROTECT
HIMSELF.
AND SOMEBODY DOT.
I WORKED ON A CASE WHERE TWO
GUYS HEARD KNOCKING OVER
CONVENIENCE STORES.
STICKING GUNS ON THE FACE OF
SOME POOR CLERK IN A SEVEN
ELEVEN WHO'S JUST TRYING TO MAKE
A LIVING.
HAS A GUN STUCK IN HER FACE AND
THEY DEMAND SHE CLEANS UP THE
CASH.
SHE WASN'T DOING IT FAST ENOUGH
AND THEY SHOT HER IN THE FACE.
MIRACULOUSLY THAT LADY SURVIVE
BOY HITTER CHEN WENT OUT THE
SIDE OF HER FACE AND SHE
SURVIVED TESTIFIED AGAINST THEM
BUT LOOK IF YOU BRING A FIREARM.
IN THE COMMISSION OF A ROBBERY
OR A STRING OF ROBBERIES.
AND YOU WAVE A GUN IN SOMEBODY'S
FACE YOU'RE ENDANGERING THAT
PERSON YOURSELF AND EVERYONE
AROUND YOU.
AND IF YOU GET CONVICTED OF THAT
AFTER YOUR DUE PROCESS AND
YOU'RE RIGHT TO TRIAL.
THEN I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
PUTTING A CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF
YEARS YOU NEED TO GO AWAY.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE LEADING A
JUDGE DECIDE THE NUMBER OF YEARS
YOU NEED TO GO AWAY [inaudible]
TO PRISON I KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFE.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
SEEM KNOW ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM.
CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ARMPIT
COLLEAGUES I DO APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION OF NOT JUST.
HOW ARE WE TOUGH ON CRIME ARE
SOFT ON CRIME BUT HOW DO WE
BECOME SMARTER CRIME IS A STATE
OF CALIFORNIA?
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE OVER A
THOUSAND FELONY SENTENCING LAWS.
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS STATUTES CASE LAWS
RULES OF COURT CONSTITUTIONAL
JURISPRUDENCE THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT NOT JUST FOR CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS.
BUT FOR PROSECUTORS FOR JUDGES
FOR THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE ALSO BE CLEAR THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS
TO AVOID PUNISHMENT IT'S STILL
SIGNIFICANTLY HOLDS PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE CRIMES THEY
COMMIT.
AND CONTRARY TO SOME OF I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE HEARD TODAY.
I AND SOME OF WHAT HAS BEEN
SUGGESTED BY THE OPPOSITION IT
DOES NOT PUT A CAP ON SENTENCES
FOR MURDER.
AND FOR THE MOST SERIOUS SEXUAL
OFFENSES INCLUDING SEX OFFENSES
AGAINST CHILDREN. FOR EXAMPLE
RAPE SODOMY LEWD AND LASCIVIOUS
ACTS ON A CHILD CONTINUOUS
SEXUAL ABUSE OF A CHILD ORAL
COPULATION.
I CAN GO ON AND ON BUT THIS BILL
WILL NOT APPLY TO THOSE OFFENSES.
COLLEAGUES UNTIL WE CAN PROVE.
THAT IF WE HAVE SENTENCES THAT
ARE MANY MANY TIMES MORE THAN
THE BASE TERM OF WHAT SOMEONE'S
BEEN CHARGED WITH UNTIL WE CAN
PROVE THAT THAT IS TRULY A
DETERRENCE.
A CRIME THAT THAT ACTUALLY
INCREASES PUBLIC SAFETY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE TOWARD SMARTER POLICY
CHOICES. TO HELP ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME AND TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS TRULY
SAFE FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
PARTICULARLY.
PARTICULARLY OUR CHILDREN AND
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE.
AND WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO GO
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
SHE WAS CALL
WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK IN THE PRIOR FILE ORDER
THIS WAS.
IN THE FORTIES WE'RE LOOKING AT
FILE ITEM.
FORTY SIX FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
THIS IS SB ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL ONE THOUSAND AND
SEVEN BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY [inaudible]
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS IS A GOOD
BILL [inaudible]
LET'S HELP.
OUR MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS AND
OUR VETERANS.
S. B. SAID TENDS ó SEVEN WILL
WAIVE STATE AND LOCAL TAXES FOR
CHARITABLE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT BILL MEDICAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES FOR
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS.
AND VETERANS UNDER CURRENT LAW
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FUNDS
THESE PROJECTS THEY'RE EXEMPT
FROM PAYING SALES AND USE THAT
USE TAX.
BUT NONPROFIT CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT EXEMPT.
THIS BILL WILL WAIVE STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES FOR THESE
ORGANIZATIONS. FOUR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF MEDICAL
FACILITIES FOR MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS AND VETERANS THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED.
BY OUR MILITARY AND VETERANS
GROUPS.
AND HAS NARY A NO VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI SEEN
NO DISCLOSURE DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TIE THAT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT SP
FOURTEEN FORTY TO THE CORPORATE
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY TO BY
SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALING ARTS
[inaudible]
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT SP FOURTEEN
FORTY TWO BY SENATORS WIENER AND
STONE.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LARGE
RETAIL CHAIN PHARMACIES TO
ENSURE THE STAFF MEMBER IS
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST WHENEVER A
PHARMACIST IS IN THE BACK AT
WORK.
IT IS SUPPORTED BY THE STATE
BOARD OF PHARMACY IT RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THINGS CUNNINGHAM.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS [inaudible]
RESERVE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I FIFTY
THREE NO.
SEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM I'M NOT TAKING
REQUESTS RIGHT NOW.
BACK IN FILE ORDER MEMBERS.
WE WANT TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM.
FORTY NINE WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
FIFTY THIS IS S. B. [inaudible]
TEN THIRTY SIX CORKERY.
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR WEALTH AND ATLANTA LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
MISTER HOLDEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SP TEN THIRTY SIX ALLOWS
A STUDENT PARENT OR GUARDIAN TO
OPT OUT OF HAVING THE RELEASE OF
A STUDENT'S PERSONAL INFORMATION.
CURRENTLY FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS FOR
THE RELEASE OF STUDENTS
DIRECTORY INFORMATION TO THE
PUBLIC UNDER MOST CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS RELEASE OF THIS INFORMATION
IS LED TO TROUBLING ISSUES AND
OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES.
SITUATION SUCH AS THIS HAVE LED
TO THE PERCEPTION THAT THE
RELEASE OF PERSONAL INFORMATION.
MAY BE EMPLOYED IN A MATTER
LEADING TO AN INTIMIDATION IN
RESPONSE UNFAVORABLE TESTIMONY
FROM MEMBERS OF THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS EXACTLY IS TYPE OF
SCENARIO S. B. TEN THIRTY SIX
WILL PREVENT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORD BLOOD IN THE ROLE ON
MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
AYE.
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE ARE GOING [inaudible]
TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RECONSIDER
ITEM THIRTY ADAC EIGHT TEN LOW
AND THEN ORDER THE ITEM TO THE
INACTIVE FILE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED ON
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHTY CA TEN
LOW.
CLERK WILL NOTE THAT THE ITEM IS
BEING MOVED TO THE AN ACTIVE
FILE
.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY TWO S. C. R. [inaudible]
ONE FIFTEEN CORKERY.
MEMBERS WE WANNA PASS
TEMPORARILY ON THAT ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY THREE SB SIX THIRTY FIVE
CORKERY.
SENEGAL SIX THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR HUESO AND OTHERS AND I
PLAN TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I S. B..
SIX THIRTY FILE REQUIRE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO
CONVENE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
VARIOUS STATE AND FEDERAL
PROGRAMS AND AGENCIES.
THE PURPOSE OF DISCUSSING HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN LEVERAGE PROMISE
OWNS AN OPPORTUNITY ZONES TO
MEET STATE LOCAL COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT NEEDS.
AT A CHILD SUPPORT SHOULD NEVER
DETERMINE THEIR DESTINY HOWEVER
THE COMMITTEE THAT A CHILD GROWS
UP ON GROWS UP IN AFFECTS THEIR
ODDS OF GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL ACCESSING HEALTH CARE IN
RECEIVING LIFETIME ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
HAS RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE.
NAME IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLLING TALBOT
I SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
AN IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT THE
FOOD HAS ARRIVED.
SO WE ARE TAKING RECESS UNDER
CALL OF THE SPEAKER REPUBLICANS
WILL BE IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ROOM DEMOCRATS WILL BE IN THE
LOUNGE.
THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL OF THE
SPEAKER WILL BE TAKING.
AND LUNCH BREAK WE'LL RETURN
PROMPTLY AT ONE FIFTEEN PROBABLY
A ONE FIFTEEN WE WILL BE
RESUMING ITEMS STARTING WITH
MISTER MAYES WILL BE TAKING UP
ITEMS AT
ONE FIFTEEN MEMBERS WE
ARE BACK IN SESSION.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE CHAMBERS.
WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
ITEM. FIFTY FOUR SP SEVEN NO.
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SUITABLE SEVEN OH SEVEN BY
SENATE CANNELLA ANOTHER'S AND I
BELIEVE AMERICA.
THANK YOU SOME NEVER MAYES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT STOP COLLABORATE AND
LISTEN.
S. B. SEVEN OH SEVEN CREATES AN
EVIDENCE BASED ELEVEN MEMBER
ADVISORY GROUP TO STUDY THE
VALUE IDENTICAL POLICIES.
AND PARTY'S IMPROVE THE WELLNESS
OF CHILDREN LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
SO QUICK TO THE POINT TO THE
POINT NO FAKIN.
A TWENTY FOURTEEN STATE AUDIT A
TWENTY SIXTEEN LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION REPORT FOUND THAT
MOST CALIFORNIA DENNIS DO NOT
PARTICIPATE DE LA CALLE.
DUE TO ITS LOW REIMBURSEMENT
RATES IN ADMINISTRATIVE
OBSTRUCTIONS.
AS A RESULT ONLY 38% IDENTICAL
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN RECEIVE DENTAL
CARE TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN THIS BODIES SAID A 60%
UTILIZATION TARGET PEDANTIC
HOWLAND WITHOUT.
S. B. SEVEN OH SEVEN WILL BE
MORE DIFFICULT TO REACH A SCHOOL
OF PROVIDING DENTAL CARE THE
CHILDREN WHO NEED IT MOST. FOR
MORE THAN THIRTEEN MILLION LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS DENTICLES
THE ONLY AVENUE TO DENTAL CARE
OUTSIDE OF AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
THIS BILL IS A MULTI YEAR EFFORT
HIM TO IMPLEMENT THE LITTLE
HOOVER'S RECOMMENDATION OF
IMPROVING THE DENTAL PROGRAM
THEREBY ENSURING TENNECO
PATIENTS HAVE ONE LESS THING TO
WORRY ABOUT.
IF THERE WAS A PROBLEM GO ALL
SOLVE IT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY FOUR
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBER WE HAVE AN EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY SPECIAL GUEST TODAY ON
A VERY SPECIAL DAY.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ASSESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM AND
COLLEAGUES AND VERY EXCITED TO
IT'S TO SPECIAL GAS FIRST IS MY
WIFE RACHEL [inaudible]
DAY OUT.
MY SON EVEN IS HAVING HIS THIRD
BIRTHDAY AND I WAS VERY UPSET
ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE TO SEE HIM
ON HIS BIRTHDAY.
MY WIFE VERY GREAT.
WE ARE DELIGHTED TO WELCOME
ANNABA.
HE MAKES ABOUT AS MUCH TO HIS
POINT IS VERY WELL TAKEN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING AHEAD AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM SIXTY ONE SP
TWELVE NINETY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY FOUR
BY SIT AROUND FOR ANOTHER SNACK
RELATED PROFESSIONS OF LOCATIONS.
THANK YOU SEVEN EVER COOLEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
COLLEAGUES AM PLEASED TO RISE TO
PRESENT S. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR
BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
THIS WILL ENACT THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS EQUITY ACT.
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE AIM OF
WITCHES A PORT COMMUNITIES WHICH
HAVE EQUITY PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS.
HAVE A OPPORTUNITY RESOURCE TO
PARTICIPATE IN CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
AS LEGALIZE ON A PROP SIXTY FOUR
THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH
RESOURCES AND FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THESE TYPES OF EQUITY PROGRAMS.
AGAIN A COMMUNITIES AND ALREADY
ARE STRIVING TO OPEN UP THE US
MARKET TO ITS DIVERSE BASE AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE IT'S A VERY GOOD
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES.
I'M SORRY MEMBERS OF THIS.
LIST MEASURE REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
MISTER COOLEY MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM FIFTY SIX SP
TEN TWENTY FIVE MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
WE ARE NOT
I BEG YOUR PARDON
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
ITEM FIFTY NINE S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR BATES AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HOUSING.
SOME MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M
PLEASED TO RISE --
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY SIX BY ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR BATES.
S. B. TALK TWENTY SIX DIRECTS
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO ADOPT A
BUILDING STANDARD THAT WOULD
CLARIFY THE AUTHORITY FOR A
LOCAL BUILDING OFFICIAL TO
PERMIT AN EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
UNIT.
BASED ON THE DATE OF
CONSTRUCTION IT'S BECAUSE YOU
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO DISCUSS THIS
ITEM MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLARKEYOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
SIXTY TWO SP FORTINO NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR WILK ANOTHER FOR NATALIE
DULCIMER HELP THEM HAVING MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR THANK YOU
THIS AMERICA EUROPE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
KNOWN NINE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WILK WHICH WILL UPDATE CURRENT
LAW TO STREAMLINE THE PRODUCTION.
AND CULTIVATION OF INDUSTRIAL
HEMP IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS THE
LARGEST CONSUMER AND INDUSTRIAL
MARKET FOR HIM MATERIALS AND
PRAGUE UP PRODUCTS IN THE UNITED
STATES AND YET HEMP FARMERS ARE
FORCED TO JUMP THROUGH HOOPS AND
THEIR PRODUCTION OF LEGAL.
INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
S. B. FORTINO NINE AIMS TO
CHANGE THAT.
CALIFORNIA IS NO STRANGER TO
DROUGHT LIKE CONDITIONS
INDUSTRIAL HEMP HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE IMMENSE
VALUE TO FARMERS AS IT IS A
NATURAL FIT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ARID CLIMATE.
AND REQUIRES FAR LESS WATER THAN
MOST CROPS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AUTHORIZED
INDUSTRIAL HEMP RESEARCH IN
STATES THAT PASSED LEGISLATION
AUTHORIZING STATE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE TO ESTABLISH PILOT
PROGRAMS IN INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION TO CONDUCT
CULTIVATION. FOR RESEARCH.
S. B. FORTINO NINE WILL BRING
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE LAWS UP TO
DATE BY ADDING PILOT PROGRAM
STATUS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE'S HEMP
PROGRAM AS REQUIRED BY THE BY
THE FEDERAL AUTHORIZATION.
S. B. FORTINO NINE WILL ONCE
AGAIN PUT CALIFORNIA AT THE
LEADING EDGE OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PRODUCTION AND PROVIDE OUR
FARMERS A WATER SAVING
ALTERNATIVE WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
CALIFORNIA'S INDUSTRY SECTORS.
WITH THEM MULTI USE MATERIAL
THAT CAN BE USED TO CREATE
ENERGY BUILD ROADS AND SO MUCH
MORE.
ARE ON A REAL PERSONAL LEVEL I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING TO
LOOK AT THIS AND TO STUDY IT
HEMP SEEDS IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST --
HAS NOT AT SOME OF THE HIGHEST
PROTEIN --
IN IN IN THE WORLD AND IT ALSO
HAS TREMENDOUS INDUSTRIAL USES
WE CAN BRING BACK MANUFACTURING
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY
CULTIVATING HIM.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND IT IS --
AND AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS ITEM MISTER QUIRK.
WELL I SEE SOMEBODY WAVING HIS
ARMS.
I AM SORRY MISTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AS A
MEMBER LACKEY.
CLEARLY I WAS BLENDING IN WITH
THE CROWD BUT THANK YOU.
MEMBERS AYE RISES A CO AUTHOR OF
US SENATE BILL FOURTEEN OR NINE
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE GROWTH.
OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP WHICH IS ONE
OF THE MOST DROUGHT RESISTANT
CROPS AVAILABLE.
ACCESS FOR FARMERS TO GROW
DROUGHT RESISTANT CROPS Y.
CAMPUS ESPECIALLY PORT FOR AREAS
LIKE THE EMERALD VALLEY.
WHERE WATER?
IS US SCARCELY AVAILABLE AND ITS
SUPPORT TO BE WATER CONSCIOUS
THIS BILL DEMONSTRATES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO BEING
A LEADER IN AGRICULTURE NIGHT
COURAGE YOUR SUPPORT.
SOME MEMBER ALLEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I LIKE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE ON THE FLOOR.
THAT COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL HEMP
CULTIVATION REMAINS ILLEGAL
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL LAW.
IF YOU VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
YOU ARE DIRECTLY VIOLATING
FEDERAL LAW AND THEN ANYONE THAT
ACTUALLY GOES AND TRIES TO GROW.
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
WILL BE IN VIOLATION OF THAT LAW
LET'S NOT PUT OUR FARMERS IN
THAT POSITION.
THIS REMAINS ILLEGAL EVEN IF
CALIFORNIA WAS TO PASS LAW IT
WILL STILL REMAIN ILLEGAL
FEDERALLY.
VOTE NO ON THIS MEASURE KEEP OUR
FARMERS OUT OF TROUBLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING THAT NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK ON THE TO RETURN
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
I BEG YOUR PARDON I'M DOING MY
BEST IS SCANNED THE ROOM I DON'T
ALWAYS SEE YOU AS A MEMBER
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SOMETIMES THAT HAPPENS AYE
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
A MISS CARILLO IS THIS THE LAST
TIME YOU ARE SPEAKING ON THIS
FLOOR IS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
[inaudible]
NOT I HOPE NOT I HAVE A COUPLE
BILLS OVER IN THE SENATE IT IT
YOU KNOW HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL.
WELL THEN I WILL RESERVE MY
QUESTION FOR LATER.
IN HERE.
AND NOW I'VE SEEN THAT NO FOR
THE REQUEST TO SPEAK.
A SUMMER COVER EURO.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MISTER PARK
WAS OPEN THEIR OWN.
MEMBERS WROTE REPORT WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE MEMBERS THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR VOTES ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
NOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY TWO
NO ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM A
SIXTY THREE SB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTEEN BY
CENTER NIELSEN ANOTHER'S AND ACT
LIKE A PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT MAKING IT A
CORPORATION ARE.
FOR SOME NEVER GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU I SP FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
WILL HELP PUBLIC AGENCIES
MANAGER PENSION OBLIGATIONS BY
ALLOWING FOR PAYMENTS IN THE
CALPERS MANAGE PRE FUNDING
TRUSTS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
CALPERS THE AUTHORITY TO
ESTABLISH A TRUST WITH
ADDITIONAL OPTION FOR EMPLOYERS
TO PAY DOWN THERE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY TO HAVE DEFINED
[inaudible]
BENEFIT PLAN.
WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT TOOL
FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
RESPONSIBLY MANAGER PENSION
OBLIGATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
MISTER CLARK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS ROAD DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
WELL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ENTIRELY THE BOATS I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM SIXTY FOUR SP
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HILL AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS SP FOURTEEN
FORTY EIGHT IS A PATIENT'S RIGHT
TO KNOW ACT OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN AND THEY SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL AN ITEM NINETY FIVE SP
FOUR SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS TWENTY FIVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON IN SIXTY FIVE AND
MOVE TO ITEM SIXTY SIX MISTER
CORPORATE GREED.
I'M SORRY TO SB ELEVEN OO NINE
MISTER FORECLOSURE.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN OH NINE BY
SOONER BATES ND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES THANK YOU S. HOWEVER
ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN OO NINE BY SENATOR BATES.
WHICH SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC BY PROVIDING
PREVENTIVE EDUCATION FOR ALL
INVOLVED.
S. B. ONE OH NINE SPECIFICALLY
DOES THE FOLLOWING.
IT REQUIRES THE EXISTING
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR PRESCRIBERS TO
INCLUDE THE RISK OF ADDICTION
AND OVERDOSE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
USE OF SCHEDULED TO NARCOTIC
SUBSTANCES.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A FLAG OR OTHER
NOTIFICATION MECHANISM ON ALL
SCHEDULED TWO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE PRESCRIPTION BOTTLES
ON THE ASSOCIATED ADDICTION AN
OVERDOSE RESTS.
IT REQUIRES A DISCUSSION WITH
THE PRESCRIBER. FOR ANY MINOR
RECEIVING AN INITIAL OPIOID
PRESCRIPTION AND LASTLY SENATE
BILL ELEVEN OO NINE REQUIRES AN
INFORMATION SHEET ON THE RISKS
OF OPIOIDS TO BE.
SIGNED BY A MINOR ATHLETE AND
THEIR PARENT OR GUARDIAN.
BEFORE PARTICIPATION ON AN
ORGANIZED SPORTS TEAM.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND AMERICANS DIED OF
OPIOID OVERDOSE IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TOTALS MORE
DEATHS THAN CAR ACCIDENTS IN
THAT SAME YEAR.
EVEN MORE ALARMING IS THE FACT
THAT THE CURRENT DEATH COUNT
EXCEEDS THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE KILLED IN
THE VIETNAM WAR.
CALIFORNIA HAD JUST SHY OF TWO
THOUSAND OPIOID DEATHS IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN ENSURING PATIENTS
MINERS AND THEIR PARENTS HAVE
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION BEFORE
TAKING THESE MEDICATIONS WILL
HELP PREVENT FUTURE ADDICTIONS
AN OVERDOSE WITH THESE DRUGS.
IT NOW ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE MEDICAL BOARD THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION THE DENTAL
BOARD AND THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE.
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
MEMBERS I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING.
NO REQUEST TO DISCUSS THIS ITEM
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS ROAD DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTE?
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES SIXTY
TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN S. B. NINE TWENTY THREE
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR WE KNOW ANOTHER PERSON I
THANK YOU S. A MEMBER BERMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED NO [inaudible]
NO.
I'M SORRY SOME MEMBER LEVINE.
WE DON'T ALL LOOK ALIKE.
YOU DO FROM HERE.
YOU CAN YOU CAN SEE A DOCTOR
HERNANDEZ FOR NEW PRESCRIPTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES ALMOST
NOTHING WE DO IN STATE
GOVERNMENT HAS THE POWER. TO
NEGATIVELY IMPACT AN INDIVIDUAL
THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR COMMUNITY
MORE THAN.
A WRONGFUL CONVICTION.
NOT ONLY DOES A WRONGFUL
CONVICTION REPRESENT THE HEIGHT
OF INJUSTICE BUT WHAT AN
INNOCENT PERSON IS CONVICTED.
THE REAL PERPETRATOR REMAINS
UNDETECTED.
AND CAN CONTINUE DO HARM TO
OTHERS.
IN CALIFORNIA I WITNESS
MISIDENTIFICATION CONTRIBUTED TO
SIXTY SIX KNOWN WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS INCLUDING TWELVE OUT
OF THE THIRTEEN DNA BASED
EXONERATIONS THE ACTUAL
CORPORATES.
IN CALIFORNIA'S DNA EXONERATION
CASES WENT ON TO BE CONVICTED OF
NINE ADDITIONAL VIOLENT CRIMES.
INCLUDING SIX MURDERS AND TWO
RAPES.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
CALIFORNIA MUST IMPLEMENT
EVIDENCE BASED PROCEDURES. FOUR
EYEWITNESS IDENTIFICATION THAT
WILL IMPROVE THE ROT RELIABILITY
A VALID EYEWITNESS
IDENTIFICATION.
THERE IS CURRENTLY KNOW
STATEWIDE STANDARD REQUIRING LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE BEST PRACTICES.
EYEWITNESS IDENTIFICATION
PROCEDURES VARY FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES ARE
AMONG SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS THAT FOLLOW.
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDED
PROCEDURES ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE
OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED TO THIS BILL.
THE LOS ANGELES DICKS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IS NOW IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THE POLICE
CHIEFS ARE NOW NEUTRAL.
COLLEAGUES OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
LAWS WORK BEST WHEN WE HAVE
MINIMUM STANDARDS ACROSS THE
STATE.
WE KNOW.
THAT THESE PROCEDURES WILL LEAD
TO MORE AND GREATER ACCURACY IN
EYEWITNESS IDENTIFICATION MAKING
SURE THAT THE INNOCENT REMAIN
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES AND THAT
THE GUILTY.
ARE INCARCERATED THANK YOU AYE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST HAS BECOME THIS
ITEM MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
[inaudible]
THIS ARTICLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
LEVINE MOVES THE CALL THANK
YOU
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING NEXT A
PILE ORDER TO ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY ONE MADAM PER
MISTER CORPORATE GREED.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR BATES AND OTHERS AND I
VEHICLES THANK YOU SOME EVER
BATES.
I'M SORRY SOME EVER SCHABAS.
THANKS FOR THE PROMOTION A MADAM
SPEAKER.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY ONE
AUTHORIZES SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN
ANY CITY IN THOSE BOUNDARIES ARE
ESTABLISHED.
THAT TRANSPORTATION PLANS WOULD
NEIGHBORHOOD ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ANY VIS IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
THE GOAL IS TO BETTER SURE THE
MOBILITY NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FURTHER OUR
VISION IS SUPPORTING A
SUSTAINABLE AND HEALTHY REGION.
VIBRANT ECONOMY AND OUTSTANDING
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR ALL.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING THAT NO
REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TIED THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM SIXTY NINE S.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE MISTER
QUICK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE
BY SENATOR SKINNER AND OTHERS
TONIGHT.
SOME EVER BURKE.
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SP THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN ENERGY MARKETS ARE
THRIVING ESPECIALLY SOLAR AND
WIND.
HOWEVER A LACK OF STORAGE TO
PROPERLY HARNESS THESE ACCESS
RENEWABLES IS NOT SUFFICIENT.
HYDROGEN STORAGE IS A WAY TO
STORE CLEAN RESOURCES OF PIC
EFFICIENTLY ACCESS SOLAR AND
WIND PRODUCTION CAN POWER THE
PROCESS THE BRAKES APART WATER
TO HYDROGEN THIS HYDROGEN CAN BE
THEN STORED AT THE GAS TO BE
USED REALLY NEEDED AS
TRANSPORTATION FUEL.
OR TO POWER A FUEL CELL OR GAS
TURBINE.
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE
DEFINES THIS FORM A STORAGE AS
GREEN ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN AND
CLOUT.
HE CLARIFIED THAT THE STATE
SHOUT WRECKING.
I DIRECTING THIS EASY TO
ESTABLISH UP TO THREE PILOT
PROJECTS AS BE THIRTEEN NINETY
SIX AN IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURE
A BALANCE GREATEST CALIFORNIA
EXPANDS ITS USE OF RENEWABLE
RESOURCES ON THE GRID I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WRONG.
ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
MR CLERK.
YOU MAKE CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
OKAY --
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON ITEM SEVENTY AND
MOVE TO ITEM SEVENTY ONE SP.
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE THE CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE
BY SENATOR SHARON ACRYLATE
LICENSE PLATES THINK YOU'RE SOME
EVER MERCER TO YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS NOW THAT SURFING
IS CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL SPORT.
LET'S CELEBRATE CALIFORNIA BY
CREATING A AND LAST SUMMER
SPECIAL LICENSE PLATE.
THE COOLEST THING ABOUT THIS
ANALYST SUMMER LICENSE PLATE IS
THAT FUNDS ARE GOING TO GO.
TO THE COSTA CONSERVANCY TO
AMONG OTHER THINGS --
PROMOTE AND INTRODUCED SURFING
TO ENTER CITY IN UNDERPRIVILEGED
CHILDREN AND TEENS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
NARY A NO VOTE AGAIN.
SPECULATE AS FOR A AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOME NEVER GROW.
THANK YOU AND SPEAKER I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT THE ENDLESS
SUMMER --
BRUCE BROWN AND JOHN VON HAMMER
FELL THEY ALL LIVED IN DANA
POINT DURING THE TIME.
THAT WHEN THEY CREATED THE MOVIE
AND SO I WOULD URGE DRIVE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DO NOT SEE ANY FURTHER DEBATE
ON THIS BILL MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BROUGH
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BROUGH DESIRE TO
VOTE. FOR ENDLESS SUMMER.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR AT
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MOVING OUT ITEM SEVENTY TWO S.
B. TEN FIFTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR DODD OTHERS IMMACULATELY
TRIBAL GAMING THE CLEAR ABUSES
HE THEY'RE UPSET CLICK
IMMEDIATELY.
SOME NEVER GRAY.
THANK YOU MEDICARE S. B. TEN
FIFTY ONE RATIFIES. FIVE NEW
TRIBAL STATE COMPACTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MENACE BAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. TO OF THE TRIBES
IN MY DISTRICT THE SEND POST
SQUALL BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
AND THE LAW FOR YOUR BAND OF LOW
SAYING NO IN IN INDIANS.
WILL BENEFIT GREATLY BY THESE
NEW COMPACTS FIRE CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER QUICK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE [inaudible]
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS IS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
MEASURE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO S. B. NINE
OH SIX ITEM.
SEVENTY FOUR THE CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL NINE OH SIX BY
SENATE BILL ANOTHER TONIGHT
LATER MENTAL HEALTH.
SOME EVER WALDRON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
I PRESENT S. B. NINE NO SIX A
BILL WHICH ESTABLISHES
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS FOR PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST.
APPEAR PROVIDER IS A PERSON WHO
HAS LIVED EX.
VARIANCE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND DRAWS
THAT EXPERIENCE ALONG WITH
SKILLS LEARNED IN TRAINING. TO
PROVIDE CRUCIAL SUPPORT TO
CLIENTS IN TREATMENT PROGRAMS
MEDICAID REIMBURSES ó 450% OF
THE COST.
PIERRE SERVICES IN STATES WITH
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM SO
ESTABLISHING THIS PROGRAM WILL
REDUCE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
OUR COUNTY PROVIDERS.
YET CALIFORNIA HAS NOT ACTED.
IT ENJOYS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
AND I DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER PARK WAS OPEN.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM TWENTY FIVE
EIGHT A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN FORTY BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET NOT
RELATE TO EDUCATION FINANCE A
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FORCE
EXPECT IMMEDIATELY PARALYTIC THE
BUDGET.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
THE BILL CONTAINS VARIOUS.
AYE K. TWELVE HIGHER EDUCATION
PROVISIONS AMONG THE MAJOR
PROVISIONS A CHAINSAW LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. TO
DOCUMENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
MAKE THE INFORMATION MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR PARENTS.
OF PROVIDES LANGUISHED INCREASED
OVERSIGHT TO PROVIDE SOME RELIEF
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN FINANCIAL
DISTRESS.
IT ALSO CREATES THE
COMMUNICATIVE FUNDING FORMULA
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TO REVIEW
THE NEW FORMULA THAT IMPLEMENTED
OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK BY
THE THANK YOU SOME EVER BURKE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B..
OR EIGHTY EIGHTEEN FORTY THE
EDUCATION FINANCIAL BUDGET
TRAILER BILL INGLE UNIFIED HAS
BEEN IN STATE RECEIVERSHIP FOR
SIX YEARS BUT IT IS STILL
STRUGGLING.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE REACHED A
TIPPING POINT HOWEVER THIS
TRAILER BILL FINALLY MAKES THE
INVESTMENT SO DESPERATELY NEEDED
IN INGLEWOOD TO BEGIN TURNING
THE DISTRICT AROUND.
WHEN I CAMPAIGN FOR THE C.
NEARLY FOUR YEARS AGO I PROMISE
TO MAKE THAT MY DISTRICT WITH
THAT I WOULD MAKE INGLEWOOD
UNIFIED A PRIORITY --
TODAY THROUGH THE HARD WORK OF
INGLEWOOD SCHOOL HE'S UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT EAGLE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AN ANGLE UNIFIED
SUPERINTENDENTS WE ARE MAKING
GOOD ON THIS PROMISE I WON I
THINK THAT BUDGET CHAIRS FROM
BOTH.
I HOUSES AND I ALL SIX OF THE
SUCCESS OF THE OF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OFTEN DEFINES A
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF AB.
EIGHTEEN FORTY AYE USD IS NOW IN
A PATH TO SUCCESS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY ARE BURIED DEEP IN THIS
BILL -- IS A
CLAUSE WOULD ENABLE YOU SEE TO
PROVIDE BENEFITS BEYOND
FINANCIAL AID. TWO STUDENTS ARE
NOT LEGALLY IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL THIS PROVISIONAL ARE YOU SEE
TO PROVIDE NOT ONLY LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY BUT ALSO THINGS SUCH
AS GRANTS AND CASH AIDS IN THE
FUTURE.
I'LL VERY SIMPLY MEMBERS.
THE IN OUR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM SHOULD BE FOR
THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THIS TAKES OUR RESOURCES AND
THEN WOULD DIRECT THOSE TWO
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT EVEN HERE
LEGALLY IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WITH RISING TUITION COSTS WE
SHOULD BE TAKING A LOOK OUT FOR
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS FIRST VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN AB.
EIGHTEEN FORTY YEAH I'M THANKFUL
THAT -- THIS
IS A THOUGHTFUL MEASURE THAT
RECOGNIZES THAT MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS IN OUR STATE.
THAT REALLY ALL OF THEM STRUGGLE
FINANCIALLY BUT IN PARTICULAR
THIS BILL PROVIDES RELIEF. TO
DISTRICTS THAT ARE DOING THE
HARD WORK. TO MAINTAIN ITS
FISCAL SOLVENCY TO MANAGE PUBLIC
RESOURCES TO INCREASE THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION.
AND THE PORT PROVIDED THROUGH
THIS MEASURE ENABLES THOSE
DISTRICTS TO CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN THEIR STUDENTS AND DOES SO IN
A WAY THAT IS THOUGHTFUL IN
DIFFERENT THAN IT HAS BEEN DONE
IN THE PAST.
IT DOESN'T CREATE ADDITIONAL
DEBT FOR THESE DISTRICTS IT DOES
NOT SADDLE SHORTER WITH DEBT
THAT WILL OUT LIVE THEIR TENURE
IN THE SCHOOLS ON BEHALF.
OF STUDENTS OUT OUR STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR AB.
EIGHTEEN FORTY THANK YOU I DO
NOT I'M SORRY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA JUREK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY A BEACON
FORTY WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
FISCAL RELIEF TO OAKLAND UNIFIED.
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND IT WILL
GREATLY AID IN THEIR ONGOING
PROGRESS TOWARDS GREATER
[inaudible]
FISCAL HEALTH THE DISTRICT ONE
TURN.
MEET CERTAIN CONDITIONS AND
BENCHMARKS FOR FISCAL RECOVERY
SO IT THAT IT'S A GOOD
ARRANGEMENT --
OVERALL OH UST HAS BEEN MAKING
DIFFICULT BUT NECESSARY.
DECISIONS TO STABILIZE THEIR
FINANCES AND DESPITE SOME REALLY
TOUGH DECISIONS THAT THEY'VE
MADE IN ACTIONS THAT THEY'VE
TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES THE DISTRICT.
FORECASTS THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL AND DEEPER CUTS.
WITH THIS BILL [inaudible]
I'M.
THEY ARE ABLE TO MAKE TARGETED
BUT NOT DRACONIAN EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS AND MAKE SURE THERE
ARE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT
STUDENTS ALONG THE WAY.
SO THIS IS OUR ARE A REALLY WELL
THOUGHT OUT PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM NOT SEEING ANY OTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZE WE WILL RETURN TO
MISTER CHANG FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MISTER QUIRK
WAS OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS HARD TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ANTI THE VOTES EYES FIFTY SEVEN
NO ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING AHEAD AND
FILE WATER TO ITEM SEVENTY THREE
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE
BY SENATOR ALLEN ANOTHER'S
NEGLIGENCE OUTWEIGHS.
THANK YOU S. SOME EVER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SP THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE WILL
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TOXIC WASTE
THE POLLUTES OUR STATE PARKS
BEACHES IN OUR OCEANS.
JOKES ARE LANDFILLS AND LITTERS
ARE COMMUNITIES BY PHASING OUT.
TAKEOUT FOOD PACKAGING FROM
STATE FACILITIES THAT IS NOT
RECYCLABLE COMPOSTABLE OR
REUSABLE.
THE BILL CALLS ON CAL RECYCLE TO
THROUGH A PUBLIC REGULATORY
PROCESS DETERMINE WHICH
PACKAGING MEETS THE
SUSTAINABILITY THRESHOLD.
AND THEREFORE CAN BE SERVICED IN
OUR PUBLIC FACILITIES.
BASED ON THE REGULATIONS CAL
RECYCLE WILL DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN A PUBLIC LIST OF
ACCEPTABLE PACKAGING TYPES ON
ITS WEBSITE.
AND THIS WILL ENSURE THAT FOOD
VENDORS CAN EASILY COMPLY WITH
THE LAW.
NOW HERE'S THE COOL PART AFTER
LENGTHY DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
OPPOSITION THE BILL WAS AMENDED
TO TAKE A MATERIAL NEUTRAL
APPROACH INSTEAD OF LISTED --
PACIFIC APPROVE PACKAGING FROM
THE START.
AND NOW ALL PACKAGING
MANUFACTURERS WILL HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONSTRATE
WHETHER OR NOT THEIR PRODUCT
MEETS THE STATE'S CRITERIA.
AND THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE
BROUGHT THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION.
DART INDUSTRIES THE PLASTIC
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION.
ALL IN TO SUPPORT AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE THE FOOD
SERVICE PACKAGING INSTITUTE AND
SEVERAL OTHERS ARE NOW.
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE ALREADY
PASSED SOME FORM OF LOCAL
MEASURE AIMED AT REDUCING THIS
KIND OF WASTE FROM THE FOOD
SECTOR.
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE CALLS
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
STEP UP AND SET AN EXAMPLE FOR
ALL FOOD SERVICE PROVIDERS BOTH
IN CALIFORNIA AND GLOBALLY.
HAVING THE STATE TAKE ACTION
WILL ALSO SPUR THE MARKET FOR
ALTERNATIVE PACKAGING AND DRIVE
DOWN THE COST FOR EVERYONE.
ON BEHALF OF THE SENATOR FROM
SANTA MONICA.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SANTA
MONICA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS WROTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
THE CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ANTI THE VOTES EYES FORTY ONE IT
KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN A
PILE ORDERED ITEM FIFTY ONE S.
B. THREE TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
INOCULATED PEOPLE ATTENDANCE.
THANK YOU A SUMMER EVER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE THIS AFTERNOON TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MEMBERS THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS
THE NEED FOR CALIFORNIA MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
START THEIR SCHOOL DAY NO
EARLIER THAN EIGHT THIRTY A. M..
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
OVER THREE MILLION MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL AGE STUDENTS.
THE AVERAGE START TIME PRETTY
STUDENTS EIGHT OH SEVEN A. M..
THIS EARLY START TIME IS
CONTRARY TO THE SLEEP AND
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS OF OUR STATE
STUDENTS.
MAD ORDER IN THE CHAMBER I'M
SPEAKER.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
YOUR CALLING THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OUR STATE SET STANDARDS
FOR ALL FACETS OF EDUCATION MANY
ASPECTS OF OUR STATE OUR STATE
SCHOOL SYSTEM BUT LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDED NO
GUIDANCE BY OUR STATE REGARDING
THE START TIMES.
WHERE IT WHICH ARE MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR STUDENTS THEIR
SAFETY THEIR HEALTH AND THEIR
LEARNING?
NOW SPEAKER STUDENTS STUDIES
HAVE CONFIRMED.
BUT INSUFFICIENT SLEEP FOUR ARE
STATES TEENAGERS POSES A PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK AND HAS ADVERSE
IMPACTS ON THEIR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS.
THIS BILL SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY EIGHT INSURES THAT OUR
STUDENTS CAN'T FULLY ACHIEVE
ACADEMIC EXERCISE BY PROHIBITING
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL START
TIMES BEFORE EIGHT THIRTY A. M..
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
AS EIGHT NOT ONLY TEACHER FOR
THIRTY YEARS BUT ALSO AS A
MOTHER OF FOUR THIS IS A BILL
THAT.
YES IT IS BACKED UP WITH DATA
AND RESEARCH BUT IT IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS THAT.
THEORY AND RESEARCH COMING
CONFLICT WITH PRACTICALITY.
WE HAVE MANY MANY FAMILIES THAT
DO NOT JUST HAVE JUNIOR HIGH AND
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS WE HAVE SOME
FAMILIES THAT HAVE PRESCHOOL.
ELEMENTARY JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS WE ALSO HAVE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE TO BE TO WORK
EARLY IN THE MORNING AND EVEN
WITHOUT A NAY THIRTY TIME SLOT
I'VE OFTEN SEEN KIDS DROPPED OFF
AT SCHOOLS.
AT SEVEN A. M. OR EARLIER AND
THEY'RE SITTING ON THE STEPS IN
FRONT OF SCHOOLS WAITING FOR
SCHOOL TO START AND I TELL
USUALLY EIGHT O'CLOCK AM.
THIS IS A BILL THAT ALSO WOULD
AFFECT CHILD CARE GIVERS.
IT WOULD AFFECT A TEACHERS
THEMSELVES AS TEACHERS ARE
PARENTS MANY OF THEM WOULD HAVE
TO MAKE DIFFERENT ARRANGEMENTS
IN THE MORNING.
AND IT ALSO WOULD HAVE A FACT ON
AFTER SCHOOL SPORTS IT WOULD
HAVE AN EFFECT ON A STUDENTS
COMING HOME LATER IN THE DAY SO
AS MUCH AS I DO BELIEVE THE
RESEARCH.
I DO HAVE TO OPPOSE SECOND THING
THAT'S A MAJOR ISSUES IS THAT WE
HAVE STUDENTS AND CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES STAYING UP LATER AND
LATER AND LATER BECAUSE THEY ARE
OUT USING TECHNOLOGY TO FALL
ASLEEP.
AND SO THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT PARENTS HAVE TO BE IN
CHARGE OF AND GETTING TO THERE'S
THEIR CHILDREN TO SCHOOL
SOMETIMES A THREE DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS THEIR KIDS GO.
TO THIS COULD BE A VERY VERY --
DIFFICULT PROCESS FOR PARENTS TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH AND LESS WE
HAVE ALL OUR BUSINESSES ALIGNED
AND SO FORTH SO I REGRET.
THAT THAT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
NOW SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I'M YOU KNOW WE'VE SAT
HERE AND I AND I THINK
THROUGHOUT MY TIME IN THIS
LEGISLATURE I ONCE SAT ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THERE A LOT
OF THINGS TO COME FORWARD AND WE
DEBATE.
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR CHILDREN YOU
KNOW IS THIS TESTING RIDE IS THE
WAY WE'RE DOING THIS CURRICULUM
RIGHT AND THERE'S USUALLY DEBATE
ON EITHER SIDE OF THOSE.
WERE PRESENTED HERE TODAY WITH
THE SITUATION WITH NO DEBATE
EVEN THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED.
WILL SAY THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR.
TEENAGERS DO BETTER IF THEY
START LATER.
WE KNOW IT'S BETTER FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
INSERT THE END OF THE DAY IS A
MOTHER.
WITH THREE KIDS AT TWO DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
STRUGGLE.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT
BY MY OPPONENTS. TO THE BILL WHO
TALK ABOUT THE THE WORK HOURS
AND HOW THIS IS INCONVENIENT FOR
WORKING FAMILIES.
AND I FIND THAT AN INTERESTING
ARGUMENT BECAUSE REALLY ALL
SCHOOL HOURS CAN BE INCONVENIENT
FOR WORKING FAMILIES I COME FROM
A DISTRICT WHERE WE HAVE A LARGE
POPULATION.
OF JANITORS WHO WORK TILL TWO
THIRTY IN THE MORNING OFTEN
THREE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
AND THEN HAVE TO WAKE UP AT A
CERTAIN TIME TO TAKE THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL.
BID UP THE WORK HOURS ARE NOT.
STANDARD FOR AN ENTIRE
GENERATION OF PARENTS RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY WORKING CLASS
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE THERE AREN'T
A LOT OF NINE TO FIVE JOBS.
IN SO WELL I UNDERSTAND IN A
TRADITIONAL FAMILY SITUATION
WHERE TWO PARENTS MAY BE ARE
WORKING NINE TO FIVE THAT THAT
THOSE START TIME IN THAT
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY MAY WORK FOR
THEM.
IT'S NOT WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
KIDS.
IT'S NOT WHAT'S TRUE ACROSS ALL
CALIFORNIA IF WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY LIKE WE DO TODAY. TO
ACTUALLY VOTE EIGHT IT IN AND TO
CAST A VOTE FOR A POLICY THAT WE
KNOW IS SCIENTIFICALLY BACKED UP
TO HELP OUR HIGH SCHOOL IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO IT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SOMEWHERE O'DONNELL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO OPPOSE S. B.. THREE TWENTY
EIGHT SURPRISE FOR MANY REASONS.
OUR NUMBER ONE IS WE SHOULD NOT
MICROMANAGE SCHOOLS FROM
SACRAMENTO.
REALLY WHY HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT EVER GOING TO PASS THIS
BILL.
S. B. THREE TWENTY EIGHT WILL
BURDEN WORKING FAMILIES AS NOT
EVERY HOME HAS A STAY AT HOME
PARENT.
OR A PARENT THAT CAN SET THEIR
OWN SCHEDULE TO MONITOR THEIR
CHILDREN AS THEY GO TO SCHOOL.
LATER.
S. B. THREE TWENTY EIGHT WILL
EXPLODE BE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
DISTRICTS WILL HAVE TO BUY MORE
BUSES HIRE MORE STAFF TO FIT THE
KIDS IN A IN A MUCH TIGHTER
WINDOW.
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT WILL LIMIT
STUDENT LEARNING AND ACTIVITIES.
NO LONGER CAN A SCHOOL HAVE A
CLASS THAT STARTS BEFORE EIGHT
THIRTY THIS BILL IS A MISTAKE
LET'S PUT IT TO BED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT WHEN I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES --
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE IN TEACHING
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL --
WE WE VOTED AGAINST THIS BILL
LAST YEAR I DON'T THINK THE BILL
IS CHANGE MUCH.
AND I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE.
THAT ED IN THE WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION.
THE FARTHER AWAY THE DECISIONS
ARE MADE FROM THE CLASSROOM.
THE WORST THOSE DECISIONS ARE.
IT IS VERY CLEAR IN EDUCATION
THAT ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL.
WHY PUT EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE SAME POSITION?
I SUGGEST TO VOTE NO ON S. B..
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT I WORKED AT ONE TIME A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
HAD FORTY ONE SCHOOLS.
AND THE HAD STAGGERED START TIME
SO MY OFFICIAL TIME I WOULD
THINK I CONSIDERED A LATE SCHOOL
MY OFFICIAL TIME WAS AT EIGHT
FORTY FIVE KIDS CAME IN AT EIGHT
FORTY FIVE AND IT WORKS IN
FONTANA.
AND THEY STAGGERED THAT START
TIME SO THAT EVERYBODY CAN GET
TO SCHOOL ON TIME AND IT WORKED
I WORKED THERE FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS.
AND IT WAS FINE PARENTS --
WERE ABLE TO TO SCHOOL WITHOUT
ANY PROBLEMS AND WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT.
ANYTHING BUT THE KIDS AND WHEN
WE START HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT'S BEST FOR KIDS
THAT'S THE CONVERSATIONS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE IN.
I APPRECIATE THAT WE ALL HAVE A
BUSY LIVES AND WE HAVE
DIFFERENCES IN --
RESPONSIBILITIES BIKED RESEARCH
STATES THAT THIS IS GOOD FOR
KIDS AND THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT S.
B. THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOU'RE WRECKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I SERVED ON MY SCHOOL BOARD FOR
OVER TWELVE YEARS BEFORE SERVING
ON THE HUNTING CAN BE CITY
COUNCIL BEFORE COMING HERE.
AND I VERY MUCH VALUE THE ROLE
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND LOOK
LOCALLY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE DECISIONS LIKE
THIS.
AND A BIG PART OF THE REASON WHY
THEY SHOULD MAKE DECISIONS LIKE
THIS.
IS BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A VERY
DIVERSE STATE WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT NEEDS AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INPUTS THAT SHOULD BE
HEARD AND LISTEN TO AND GOING TO
THE PROCESS OF BEING ABLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS.
THEY'RE JUST OVER THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT MANY OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY
MUCH LARGER DISTRICTS IN URBAN
AND SUBURBAN AREAS THAT DOES
SERVE QUITE A FEW FOLKS.
BUT AN AREA LIKE MINE.
THERE COULD BE CONCERNS SUCH AS
BEING ABLE COMEDY FOR SPORTS.
THE TIMING NEEDED FOR THE COMEDY
AT THE SURF TEAM I SCHOOL AFTER
SCHOOL JOBS AND OTHER THINGS.
ARE BUT SAY THERE'S AN AFTER
SCHOOL OR ON AFTER SCHOOL ISSUE
OR ISSUES THERE RELATED ANYMORE
AGRICULTURAL AREA --
WE'RE STUDENTS MAY BE MORE
INVOLVED IN THE FARM.
EACH OF US HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS WITH VERY DIFFERENT
NEEDS.
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN SCHOOL
MORE SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO LISTEN
[inaudible]
PARENTS TEACHERS AND OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE DECISION FOR WHAT IS THE
RIGHT TIME TO BE ABLE TO START
SCHOOL.
THEY SHOULD BE A LOCAL DECISION
FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE YOUR WRITTEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBER
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT I HAVE HAD
CHILDREN IN HIGH SCHOOL FOR THE
LAST SIX YEARS SO I HAVE A LOT
OF PRACTICAL RECENT EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS.
AND WHERE I LIVE OUR FIRST BILL
APPLY SCHOOL RINGS AT SIX FIFTY
FIVE A. M..
AND THAT'S IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ZERO PERIOD SO I'VE HAD FIRST
HAND EXPERIENCE WATCHING MY KIDS
STUMBLE OUT OF BED AND TRYING TO
GET TO SCHOOL AND I KNOW FIRST
HAND THE EFFECT IT HAS ON THEM.
BUT I WAS AMAZED WHEN I WORKED
AT THE RESEARCH SURROUNDING THIS
ISSUE IN THE RESEARCH SHOWS
CONCLUSIVELY.
THAT THIS IS THE SINGLE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE THING WE CAN DO
TO IMPROVE GRADUATION RATES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE RESEARCH IS VOLUMINOUS IT'S
BEEN ACADEMICALLY VETTED AND NO
ONE IS DISPUTING IT NO ONE IS
DISPUTING IT.
NOW I KNOW THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
TAKING THIS ACTION WOULD CAUSE
IN MY OWN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO IT AND WHEN I
ASKED THEM WHY.
THEY SAY WELL WE WOULD HAVE TO
REORGANIZE OUR BUS SCHEDULES WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH A BUS
AVAILABILITY AND WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH AFTER SCHOOL SPORTS
SCHEDULING.
AND THOSE ARE PROBLEMS THAT WE
WOULD NEED HELP SOLVING WE DON'T
HAVE THE HELP RIGHT NOW.
BUT E WILL NEVER START SOLVING
THOSE PROBLEMS.
UNTIL WE AGREED TO WORK TOWARDS
THE GOAL OF STARTING SCHOOL
LATER IN THIS BILL IS THE WAY
THAT WE DO THAT.
LET ME SAY AGAIN THIS IS THE
SINGLE MOST COST EFFECTIVE THING
WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES IN CALIFORNIA I
THINK IT'S TIME WE TAKE THAT
STEP.
PLEASE VOTE YES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM DIRECTLY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ONE THOUSAND TWENTY SIX
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
ONE THOUSAND TWENTY SIX RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE TWO MILLION NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
HIGH SCHOOLERS AND MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS.
THIS AFFECTS A LOT OF PEOPLE.
SO AFFECTS A LOT OF KIDS A LOT
OF TEACHERS.
CENTER THE EFFECT ON THE
TEACHERS THEY BARGAINED.
AND A LOT OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THEY BARGAINED FOR
CONTRACTS AND SPECIFY CERTAIN
START TIME TO WHAT HAPPENS THEY
ALL OF ALL THOSE GET THROWN OUT
THE WINDOW.
WE REALLY WOULD DO WE REVISIT
ALL OF THOSE ISSUES.
THE BUS SCHEDULE.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL FOR RURAL SKIP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BEING ABLE TO
GET KIDS TO SCHOOL ON TIME. FOR
WORKING PARENTS.
I'M GONNA TWO PARENT WORKING
FAMILY.
WITH FOUR KIDS AT DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF SCHOOL.
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT ME BUT WE'RE
NOT THE ONLY ONES OUT THERE.
AND THEIR PARENTS TO HAVE TO
OPEN UP THE STORAGE AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK. TO BE IN COURT AT EIGHT
THIRTY HAVE.
TO OPEN UP THE THE MEDICAL
PRACTICE.
WORK AT THE HOSPITAL.
AND THEY'RE ALL SORTS OF THINGS
PARENTS HAVE TO DO.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS MANY
PEOPLE OF EXPRESSES [inaudible]
THIS IS.
IF THERE IS A ONE ISSUE YOU WANT
A LOCAL DISTRICT TO BE ABLE TO
TAILOR. TO THE KIDS AND THE
TEACHERS AND THE COMMUNITY THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO REPRESENT I
THINK IT'S PROBABLY WHAT TIME
YOUR SCHOOL START.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK I GET IT
SLEEP IS GOOD I'VE GOT AN EIGHTH
GRADER RIGHT NOW HOME.
SLEEP IS GOOD I GUESS I GOT THAT.
NO DEBATE THERE [inaudible]
BUT MOVING THE START TIME BACK
IS NOT NECESSARILY GONNA MEAN
MORE SLEEP FOR EVERY KID.
IT JUST DOESN'T.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVA.
IQ ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
I'M SURE EVERYONE HAS PROBABLY
RECEIVED A LOT OF EMAILS AND
PHONE CALLS ABOUT THIS BILL
KNOWING THAT IT WAS COMING.
IN THE RESEARCH IS VOLUMINOUS.
ON THIS MATTER THAT IT IS BETTER
FOR KIDS TO SLEEP IN A LATER TO
GET MORE.
SLEEP IN THE EVENINGS YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT IS VOLUMINOUS AND YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE IS VOLUMINOUS THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS TO SAY.
THIS IS NOT YOUR DECISION TO
MAKE THIS IS OUR DECISION TO
MAKE AND YOU SHOULD LISTEN TO
THE PARENTS IN YOUR SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS I PUT THIS OUT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA IN MY DISTRICT.
EVERY CD.
I AM VERY SURPRISED AT HOW MANY
FACEBOOK PAGES ARE OUT THERE BY
THE WAY BUT EVERY CITY HAS A
DIFFERENT FACEBOOK GROUP AND I
PUT IT OUT ON ALL OF THEM I
ASKING THEIR OPINION.
I WOULD SAY ABOUT HALF SAID.
THEY LIKE THE IDEA OF THE LATER
START TIME BUT THEY DON'T WANT
US IMPOSING IT ON THEM THEY
WANTED TO BE A SCHOOL DISTRICT
LEVEL DECISION THE OTHER HALF.
SAID THAT IT DIDN'T WORK FOR
THEIR SCHEDULES AND THAT
SACRAMENTO OUGHT NOT BE DECIDING
FOR EVERYONE AS A WHOLE.
WHAT TIME KID SHOULD START
SCHOOL?
SO I THINK IF YOU'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS
IN OU'VE BEEN HEARING FROM YOUR
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
YOU NEED TO LISTEN TO THEM
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WERE SENT HERE
TO DO.
NOT DECIDE THAT WE KNOW BETTER.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THE
DECISION FOR THEM AND NO ONE IS
DISPUTING THE SCIENCE BUT IT'S
NOT JUST SCIENCE THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING THESE ARE PEOPLE'S
LIVES WE HAVE TO CONSIDER AS
WELL THEIR SCHEDULES.
AND WHAT IT DOES TO THE FAMILY --
YOU KNOW SITUATION IN THE
ABILITY FOR PARENTS TO BE ABLE
TO GET THEIR KIDS TO AND FROM
SCHOOL NOT EVERYBODY HAS SOMEONE
WHO'S A STAY HOME MOM YOU CAN
TAKE THEM BACK AND FORTH.
NOT EVERYBODY'S PARENT WORKS TEN
MINUTES AWAY THAT TO COMMUTE
OTHER DISTRICTS OR THEY HAVE TO
COMMUTE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE IN A RURAL
AREA WHICH I KNOW PEARL COUNTIES
WERE PULLED OUT OF THIS BUT SOME
PEOPLE HAVE TO DRIVE AN AWFUL
LONG DISTANCE AND YOU'VE
COMPLETELY UP ENDED.
THEIR LIVES.
SO I WOULD URGE AGAINST THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MORE
RESEARCH MERCER TO YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR PORTANTINO
FOR US.
ALWAYS PUSHING THIS BECAUSE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I I THINK WE
HAVE A VERY HONEST AND IN A VERY --
REAL --
WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH THIS
BECAUSE I I THINK WE'VE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SCIENCE IN
AND AND A LOT OF STUDIES THAT
SHOW ALL THE HEALTH BENEFITS.
AND AND I HAVEN'T HEARD A SINGLE
PERSON A DISPUTE THAT BUT YOU
KNOW I I THINK THE COUNTER
ARGUMENT.
TO YOU KNOW.
YEAH IT'S MY DISTRICT IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE I HAVE ONE
DISTRICT MAN HAND BEACH UNIFIED
THAT'S VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
BUT YOU KNOW THE OTHER DISTRICTS
ARE STRONGLY AGAINST THE BILL
AND THE REASON WHY IS IS WHAT
THE YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THAT.
WE NEED TO DEFER THIS TO THE
LOCAL CONTROL FOR OUR SCHOOL
BOARDS TO TO WORK THIS OUT I
KNOW THAT THEIR PROBLEMS WITH
THAT WITH THE SPORTS SCHEDULES
AND AND AND YOU KNOW TRYING.
TO OF ME STATEWIDE SOLUTION I I
THINK THE REAL SOLUTION HERE AND
I THINK CENTER PORTANTINO IS
CONTRIBUTING YOU KNOW IS IS
MAKING GOT MORE OF A DIFFERENCE
THAN ANYONE IN AND AND MOVING
THIS DEBATE FORWARD --
IS TO HAVE GROUPS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
AMONGST THEMSELVES TO HAVE THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
DISCUSS IT AMONG THEMSELVES AND
THEN TO HAVE THEM BRING THE
SOLUTION TO US RATHER THAN US
IMPOSING A SOLUTION AND FOR THAT
REASON I WANT TO EXPLAIN
RESPECTFULLY CENTER PORTANTINO
WHY I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SOME NUMBER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I BEEN CONFLICTED ON
THIS BILL FOR QUITE A LONG TIME
AND I'VE BEEN CONFLICTED ON THIS
BILL FOR A LOT OF THE REASONS I
THINK A LOT OF MEMBERS ARE
CONFLICTED.
ON THIS BILL IS THAT I'VE HEARD
FROM A LOT OF MY LOCALS --
THAT DO NOT SUPPORT IT AND THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO RAIN RETAIN A
DOUBT WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS THEIR
RIGHT TO DICTATE WHAT THE START
TIMES ARE FOR SCHOOLS.
AND I RESPECT THAT BECAUSE I'M
SOMEBODY WHO'S ALWAYS TRIED TO
BE VERY ATTENTIVE AND LISTEN. TO
WHAT MY LOCALS HAVE TO SAY
BECAUSE THAT MATTERS TO ME AND
HELPS ME MAKE BETTER DECISIONS
AND I'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT --
A LOT OF HYPOTHETICALS ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF WE
CHANGE SCHOOLS TART START TIMES --
BUT I'VE ALSO HEARD FROM SOME
SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT THAT ARE
IN SUPPORT --
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT ONE IN
PARTICULAR A THREE YEARS AGO
SIERRA VISTA MIDDLE SCHOOL.
CHANGED ITS START TIME FROM
SEVEN FIFTY AM TO EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE PM.
SINCE THAT CHANGE.
THEY HAVE SEEN A DECREASE IN
TARDY'S BY GREATER THAN 90%.
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM DROPPED TO
JUST THREE POINT 8%.
THE LOWEST RATE IN ANY SECONDARY
SCHOOL AND THE HOSPITAL APPOINT
THE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THEY HAVE ALSO ONE OF THE
HIGHEST ATTENDANCE RATES IN THE
DISTRICT AT 97%.
AND BECAUSE STUDENTS ARE IN
THEIR SEATS MORE THE SCHOOL HAS
WITNESS ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
INCREASE IN SUSPENSIONS DECREASE.
THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE WILL ENSURE THAT
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS IN OUR
STATE ARE ABLE TO READ.
THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES THAT COME
FROM THE START TIME BORN OUT OF
SOUND SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH INTO
THE SLEEP NEEDS OF ADOLESCENCE.
ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY
THAT RURAL DISTRICTS ARE EXEMPT
SO THOSE CONCERNS SHOULD BE NO
AND VOID.
THERE IS ALSO A THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION ON THIS BILL AND
I THINK THAT THAT IS QUITE
ENOUGH TIME TO GET BUS SCHEDULES
IN CLASS SCHEDULES IN ORDER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I THANK
YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TODAY WHILE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL ON THE BASIS OF ITS
SCIENCE.
AND LONG TERM BENEFITS TO OUR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT I KNOW SOME
MAJOR CONCERNS FOR THIS BODY TO
EXAMINE AS WE MOVE FORWARD. FOR
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE WITH WORKING
FAMILIES THERE STILL REMAINS THE
REALITY THAT CHILDREN WON'T BE
GETTING DROPPED OFF AT SCHOOL AT
LATER TIMES SIMPLY BECAUSE OUR
PARENTS MUST LEAVE.
EARLY FOR THEIR JOBS.
THIS PUTS BURDENS ON THE CAMPUS
IS TO BE OPEN OR TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF SECURITY OR SUPERVISION
IN THE MORNING BEFORE SCHOOL
STARTS.
AMONG OTHER CONCERNS.
FURTHERMORE IN JUST ONE OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY.
THEY'VE ADVISE ME THAT IT'LL
COST OF APPROXIMATELY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO HAVE ENOUGH
BUSES AND REROUTE. TO REROUTE
AND TRANSPORT CHILDREN SAFELY.
SCHOOL WITH THIS NEW START TIME.
WITH NO STATE SUPPORT.
THESE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
ARE HUGE TO CONSIDER AND MUST BE
MITIGATED.
IF WE IS THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT
MAKE IT A POINT TO ASSIST AND
SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS TO
ADEQUATELY.
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL WE WILL HURT SCHOOL AND
STUDENT PERFORMANCE.
RATHER THAN HELP IT.
WHEN I WANT TO LISTEN ALSO TO
THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE CALLED ME?
WHY DID GOING TO COUNSELING
GABBY AND IZZY WHO TELL ME THIS
WOULD BE A GOOD THING?
SO I URGE YOU THAT [inaudible]
WE COMMIT.
TRULY SUPPORTING OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS MOVING FORWARD TO
ENSURE IMPLEMENTATION BOLSTERS.
SO THAT WE CAN.
JULIE HAVE SUCCESS FIRST
STUDENTS AND NOT HINDER THEM AS
WE AS WE IMPLEMENT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MEADOW SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND IT'S INTERESTING FOR
ME ON SOME LEVEL CITY HERE ALLAH
TALK ON THE FLOOR ABOUT THE
DECADES OF EX OF A RESEARCH IN
THE THE THE THE DATA CLEARLY
SHOWS AND VOLUMINOUS RESEARCH
TELLS US.
A THAT'S AN ARGUMENT I MADE
ABOUT THE OVERDOSE PREVENTION
CENTERS.
THERE HAVE THERE HIM THREE
DECADES OF A RESEARCH
OVERWHELMINGLY SHOWING SOMETHING --
BUT TO THREE YEARS TO GET A A
ONE CITY PILOT.
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO THIS FOR
STATEWIDE CHANGE OF START TIMES --
THE BIGGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
MY COMMUNITY IS A STOCKTON
UNIFIED WITH OVER FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN IT --
AND THEY ALSO LOOKED AT THE
LOOKS LIKE IT'S A WAY TO GO.
AND THEY TRIED A PILOT FOR A
YEAR.
AND WAS AN ABJECT FAILURE.
TRYING TO COORDINATE THE BUS
SCHEDULES AND ARTISTS ARE
GETTING WE HAVE BUSES WE THE
CITY BUSES IN.
GETTING KIDS AROUND --
SO WELL I THINK A BILL LIKE THIS
THAT WOULD HAVE SAID.
EVERY DISTRICT SHOULD MAYBE HAVE
A HEARING ON THIS. TO LOOK AT
WHAT WORKS FOR THEM.
THAT WOULD HAVE MADE SENSE TO ME
BUT TO DO A STATEWIDE MANDATE
ABOUT WHAT TIME SCHOOLS ARE
GOING TO START.
JUST SEEMS TO ME TO BE AN OVER
REACH A AGAIN THE DATA CAN
REALLY GUIDE US BUT IT'S UP TO
US THAN TO CREATE GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY.
THAT ALLOWS IT TO ACTUALLY BE
IMPLEMENTED.
I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I HAD
DUBBED DECIDED I WASN'T GOING TO
SPEAK ABOUT THIS AGAIN BECAUSE I
TOLD YOU LAST YEAR.
THAT THERE WAS PLENTY OF
RESEARCH BUT THAT THIS BILL WILL
BE KILLED BY IGNORANCE.
AND IT WAS.
A LET ME JUST SIMPLY SAY A
COUPLE THINGS ONE YOU KNOW THE
WORST SCHOOL BOARD MEETING I
EVER HAD IN MY LIFE.
ABOUT START TIMES.
YOU THOUGHT SOMEBODY HAD KILLED
EVERYBODY'S CHILD STOLEN EVERY
GRANDPARENT ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH BLOWN UP EVERY BUSINESS
BECAUSE WE WERE CHANGING THE
TIME THAT PEOPLE STARTED THE
SCHOOL.
EVERY PROBLEM YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
THAT YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW ABOUT
KIDS BEING DROPPED OFF AT NOT
BEING DROPPED OFF IN WHOSE HOME
WHO'S NOT.
EXIST IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT
YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
IN EARLY AND SOMEONE LADEN
PEOPLE COMPLAIN IF SOMEONE TOLD
COULD NOT DRIVE SO AND SO THE
SCHOOL.
THIS THAT ALL THOSE THINGS EXIST
RIGHT NOW WE DO NOT HAVE A
PERFECT SYSTEM OF SCHOOL
STARTING AND STOPPING TO FIT
EVERY PERSON'S AGENDA IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WOULD DISTRICTS OFTEN DEBATE
THIS ISSUE THEY ARE PARALYZED.
BECAUSE THEY LISTEN TO
EVERYBODY'S INDIVIDUAL ISSUE AND
EVEN WHEN YOU GIVE THEM WHAT
THEY WANT SOMEBODY ELSE STILL
HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM IT'S TOO
LATE IT'S TOO EARLY I GOTTA GO
TO WORK HE'S GOT TO COME HOME.
SOMEBODY AND PICK UP THE BABY SO
MY GARDENS UP THAT EXIST RIGHT
NOW SO LET'S STOP PRETENDING
THAT OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS
PERFECT.
IF YOU EVER SERVED ON A SCHOOL
BOARD YOU KNOW IT IS MOST
IMPERFECT IN TERMS OF THE START
AND STOP TIME AND IS NOT BASED
ON RESEARCH A DATA IT'S OFTEN
BASED ON BUSES RUNNING UP AND
DOWN THE STREET AND A HOST OF
OTHER THINGS THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
SO DON'T PRETEND THAT WHAT WE
HAVE IS A WONDERFUL SYSTEM THAT
WORKS IT DOES NOT.
AND IF YOU WANT TO GO TO SEE
HAVE THE NIGHTMARE GO TO SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING WOULD YOU DECIDE
TO CHANGE THE TIME TO SCHOOLS TO
TRY TO MAKE IT FAIR FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE LAID WHO NOW WANT EARLY.
AND YOU WILL HAVE A NIGHTMARE
AND A MIDNIGHT MEETING AS WE DID
IN SAN DIEGO.
SO I JUST WANT KNOW WHAT YOU
HAVE IS NOT PERFECT.
BUT THE LEASES HAVE SOME
RESEARCH BEHIND IT.
AND IT HAS BEEN MANY YEARS AND
ALTHOUGH SCHOOL BOARD TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE SAME SUBJECT.
FINALLY THIS YEAR SAN DIEGO IS
GOING TO IMPLEMENT IT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TRIED EVERYTHING
TO HELP KIDS AND WHEN THE DATA
COMES BACK AND SAYS THIS WILL
ACTUALLY HELP TO KEEP YOUR
SCHOOLS HAVE THE KIDS IN SCHOOL
HAVE BEEN DOING BETTER SO FORTH
AND SO ON THEN YOU OUGHT TO AT
LEAST LISTEN TO IT.
AND THE REALITY IS WE WILL
ALWAYS HAVE THESE CONCERNS
BECAUSE EVERYONE'S LIFE IS VERY
COMPLEX WE DON'T JUST HAVE
EVERYBODY GOING TO WORK AT THE
SAME TIME COMING BACK THE SAME
TIME.
THE BUSES DON'T ALWAYS RUN THE
SAME WAY ON EVERY COMMUNITY BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN YOU CHANGE THEIR START TIME
PEOPLE HAVE A FIT THEY SAID ALL
DIAGRAM OF THE RUNWAY
EVERYBODY'S GOAL SOME GO HAPPEN
TO EVERYBODY?
THEY ALL JUST.
AND THEY SHOW UP AT SCHOOL ON
TIME.
THAT'S THE REALITY.
SO IF YOU THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HELPS KIDS YOU
SHOULD BOTH.
FOR IF YOU THINK IT DOESN'T HELP
KID YOU SHOULDN'T.
BUT DON'T PUT ALL YOUR EGGS IN A
BASKET BASED ON GROWN FOLKS.
WHAT THEY THINK IS CONVENIENT
FOR THEM?
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
BECAUSE WE WILL SOLVE AS PARENTS
WE SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
ALL OF YOU HAVE.
YOU GOT KIDS IN SCHOOL NOW MANY
OF YOU WORKING TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW LITTLE KIDS GO TO SCHOOL
LATE.
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO SOME PEOPLE BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO BE WORKING A AND YOU'RE JUST
AND YOU ADAPT IN THE SCHOOL
MAKES THOSE THINGS HAPPEN.
SO YOU HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT IS
REALLY GOING TO MOVE THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA FORWARD.
WE TALK ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME
THAT WE SPENT TOO MUCH TIME
TALKING AT ALL PEOPLE AND THEIR
NEEDS.
AND VERY SUBTLE DO WE TALK ABOUT
YOUNG PEOPLE AND WHAT IS GOING
TO REALLY HELP OUR KIDS GET FROM
THE BOTTOM TO AT LEAST THE
MIDDLE IF NOT THE TOP.
IT THERE'S SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAS POINTED OUT BY RESEARCH WE
NEED TO GRAB IT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU TO TURN IT
OVER TO THE SCHOOL BOARDS BAY
WILL BE PARALYZED BY THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE SHOW UP.
I TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY
WENT FROM.
EIGHT TO EIGHT THIRTY AND HOW
SOME BY ANOTHER THE WORLD'S
GONNA FALL APART IN THIRTY
MINUTES.
SO YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU DO IN THIS FOR THE RIGHT
REASON.
AND IF YOU BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO
HELP OUR KIDS WE HAVE TO LEAD
AND MANY OF OUR PORTS WILL BE
HAPPY BECAUSE EVEN THEY WILL
HAVE TO TAKE THE HEAT.
THAT'S ALL THAT WAS DONE BY
THOSE PEOPLE SACRAMENTO SO WE
JUST GOT IMPLEMENTED.
AND HOPEFULLY THEY WILL REALIZE
WHAT THEY REAP THE BENEFITS AS
WE'VE SEEN IN SO MANY CASES AS
WELL AS HERE ON THE FLOOR.
IT WILL HELP OUR CHILDREN.
AND I HOPE THAT'S A CONVERSATION
WE HAVE IS THIS GOOD FOR KIDS.
RESEARCH SAYS YES THEY'RE THE
MAKE OLD FOLKS LIKE US FEEL
SLIGHTLY UNCOMFORTABLE PROBABLY
WOULD SO WHAT WE'VE ALREADY HAD
EXPERIENCE IN SCHOOL WE'VE DONE
WHAT WE DON'T DO.
THIS GIVE OUR KIDS AT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE FOR
S. B..
THREE TWENTY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKERS AND
MEMBERS NO ONE EVER WANTS TO GO
AFTER DOCTOR WEBER BUT HERE I'M
GONNA TRY --
I REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO WHO
SHARED THE X. WHO SHARED BE OF
THE METAPHOR OF WHAT ABOUT THE
KIDS SO LET ME TO SHARE A QUICK
STORY.
I'M SURE DID A LITTLE BIT BEFORE
BUT I AM I I'VE BEEN VERY OPEN
ABOUT IT BUT I DROPPED OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL WHEN I WAS OUT RULES
OF ALL HIGH SCHOOL IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS.
AND THE REASON WHY THAT HAPPENED
WAS BECAUSE I WAS CONSTANTLY
LATE CONSTANTLY TARDY ROOSEVELT
HIGH SCHOOL AT THE TIME HAD A
THREE TRACK SYSTEM REMEMBER WHEN
WE HAD THAT I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
GOOD IDEA.
AND IT STARTED AT SEVEN THIRTY
IN THE MORNING.
I WASN'T DRILL TEAM I HAVE TO BE
ON CAMPUS AT SIX AM AND WHEN WE
WEREN'T.
I HAD TO EITHER WALK TO SCHOOL
WHICH WAS ABOUT TWO MILES OR
TAKE -- THE
AND THE TRANSIT OR TAKE A BUS
AND THERE WAS TWO BUS LINES THAT
I HAVE TO TAKE SO I HAVE TO
LEAVE HOME.
AROUND SIX IN THE MORNING.
IF I IF I DID THIS AND THEIR GOT
THERE THERE GOT TO A POINT WHERE
I WAS JUST TOO TIRED.
THANK YOU I WAS TOO TIRED AND I
WAS CONSTANTLY LATE I WAS
CONSTANTLY TARDY.
AND BECAUSE I WAS TARDY.
SCHOOL AT THE TIME HAD A POLICY
THAT IF YOU WERE TRUANT OR TARDY.
PARENTS AT LU ES DE WOULD GET A
TICKET.
AND YOU WOULD GET FINE.
AND MAYBE PERHAPS THAT YOU MAY
NOT REMEMBER THAT BUT LOW INCOME
PARENTS REALLY CAN'T AFFORD TO
BE GETTING TICKETS BECAUSE
YOU'RE FIFTEEN MINUTES LATE TO
CLASS.
ROTH WELL HAS CHANGED NOW AND
SEVERAL OTHER SCHOOLS HAVE
CHANGED. TO HAVE A LATER START
TIME WHICH HAS DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVED [inaudible]
GRADUATION RATES IN FACT BECAUSE
IF THE SCHOOL STARTS AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK OR EIGHT THIRTY KIDS ARE
ACTUALLY THERE EARLIER.
BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING BREAKFAST
SCHOOL AND FOR MANY KIDS AND
MANY KIDS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
THE ONLY TIME THAT THEY ACTUALLY
GET TO EAT HIS BREAKFAST AND
LUNCH [inaudible]
SCHOOL.
SO THEY'RE GONNA BE THERE
SLIGHTLY EARLIER TO HAVE
BREAKFAST THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
GET DROPPED OFF AT THAT TIME.
SO I JUST WANT US TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE DAILY LIFE LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF THESE KIDS ARE I
REPRESENT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
ELLIE WAS THE IS THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SECOND LARGEST IN
THE NATION I CALLED MY
SUPERINTENDENT.
I CALLED ARBORE PRESIDENT THEY
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING BROUGHT TO THEIR
ATTENTION THEY HAVE CONCERNS.
THERE'S A THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS.
WE CAN FIGURE THIS OUT AND WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
IS THE EXPERIENCE OF THE STUDENT
THAT'S ACTUALLY ATTENDING
[inaudible]
THE CLASSROOM HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE.
THE KIDS ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE
AXES.
EQUITY OPPORTUNITY JUSTICE AND
MIMI A SLIGHT CHANCE AT A BETTER
LIFE AND THE LIFE THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY LIVING.
AND IF THE SCIENCE IS THERE.
EITHER WE BELIEVE EVEN THE THIGH
AND OR WE DON'T.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT KIDS. TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IS.
THE ACTUAL BECAUSE THE SCIENCE
IS THERE.
THE REST OF THE ISSUES WILL GET
TO FIGURE OUT BUT WILL NEVER GET
TO THE POINT OF ACTUALLY
RESOLVING THEM.
IF WE CAN'T MOVE THE NEEDLE
FORWARD AN EDUCATION AND THERE
ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT EDUCATION SO MANY THINGS
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP TODAY WHICH
ARE.
CREDIBLE AND VALID POINTS BUT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT
OTHERWISE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY FACING.
A DECREASE AND DOCTORS AND
NURSES AND TEACHERS AND
ENGINEERS AND IF WE CAN GET OUR
KIDS TO SIMPLY GRADUATE.
THEN HOW ARE WE GONNA INCREASE
THE WORK FORCE FOR CALIFORNIA
AND THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND PLEASE
ALWAYS CONSIDER.
WHAT THE STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY
GOING THROUGH I WONDER GOING TO
SCHOOL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM NOT SEEING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHOPPERS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I REALIZE I'M SHORT SO.
CALLED HERE.
IT I I REMEMBER THIS ISSUE LAST
TIME I SPOKE OUT IN SUPPORT OF
IT SO I'M GOING TO STAY WITH
THAT THING.
BUT I GOTTA TELL YOU AFTER
LISTENING ALL THE DISCUSSION --
THIS IS NOT A NEW ISSUE.
YOU KNOW I I COME FROM THIS
PERSPECTIVE.
OF MY CHILDREN WENT TO NINE
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
AND I CAN TELL YOU.
I WILL THEY WOULD TO SOME OF THE
BEST SCHOOLS ONE OF THEM IS IN
IOWA.
AND IN IOWA WHICH IS WHAT ONE
TWO OR THREE IN THE NATION.
THEY STARTED LATER FOR THE CORE
PROGRAMS.
NOW THEY IT IS ZERO PERIOD BUT
THEY HAD.
THE SAME THING [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
WE TALK ABOUT [inaudible]
I SCIENCE.
WE WORRY ABOUT BUS SCHEDULES.
WERE YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A REAL ISSUE.
AND OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS WE
HAVE.
REDESIGNED OUR ENTIRE.
ENERGY GRID SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
WE ARE CHANGING OUR HOLD
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN THIS
STATE WE BROUGHT IN NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND GOT RID OF A
WHOLE INDUSTRY MOVING OUT OF
FOSSIL FUELS.
WE COULD CHANGE OUR WHOLE
ECONOMY.
UNDER THE IDEA OF PROTECTING
SCIENCE.
WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE SCIENCE ON
WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR OUR
CHILDREN RECOGNIZING THAT?
WE'RE NOT DOING SO GREAT IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK WE'RE LASSEN
MICE I WENT.
FORTY THREE I THINK THAT'S KIND
OF A GOOD THING WHEN I CAME HERE
SIX YEARS AGO WHERE.
FORTY NINE SO WE'RE KIND OF
MOVING DOWN IN QUALITY BUT WE
STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
AND I THINK SCIENCE SHOWS WE
SHOULD DO THIS.
ADDITIONALLY I THINK IT'S NO.
OF TWO MONTHS AGO THE PTA WAS
AGAINST THIS I GOT A LETTER
TODAY THE PTA IS SUPPORTING THIS.
THEY'RE RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE
TO DO MORE FOR OUR CHILDREN TO
GET THEM THROUGH THIS.
AND I LEAVE YOU THIS LAST WILL.
FIVE BECAUSE I'M PROBABLY ONE
THE OLDEST PEOPLE AROUND HERE IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX WHEN I WENT
TO HIGH SCHOOL AND TOWARDS AYE
SCHOOL.
CLASSES STARTED AT NINE AM.
NOW THEY HAD ZERO PERIOD YOU CAN
GO IN EARLIER IF YOU NEED SOME
OF THE THINGS AND MATH AND
THINGS GET EARLY I MEMBER MISTER
HUGHES B. AND THERE.
AT SEVEN THIRTY OR EIGHT BECAUSE
HE SAID HE WORKED FOR A LIVING
NOT LIKE HIS OTHER TEACHERS.
HE WAS A QUITE A CHARACTER.
BUT WE STARTED AT NINE AM.
AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX
CALIFORNIA ACADEMICALLY WAS TWO
OR THREE IN THE NATION.
WE ARE ONE OF THE BEST SCHOOL
SYSTEMS IN THIS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE NEED TO GO BACK WHERE WE WERE
AND RECOGNIZE WHAT WE DO IS YOU
SCIENCE AND DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO ENSURE OUR CHILDREN.
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL AND GO FORWARD.
IF WE CAN A CHANGE OF ECONOMY
AND TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS.
BECAUSE OF SCIENCE.
WE CAN USE SCIENCE ENSURE THAT
OUR CHILDREN HAVE THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I ASK YOU TO VOTE I ON THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR I VOTED FOR
THIS BILL.
IN SPITE OF MANY CONCERNS THAT I
HAD -- THEN
ABOUT THE BILL.
AND I STILL HAVE THOSE CONCERNS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS.
QUESTION THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE ON
THE FLOOR JUST NOW.
IT JUST STRUCK ME THAT THIS BILL
MAY BE MORE THAN ANY I'VE EVER
HEARD IN FOUR YEARS.
EVERY ARGUMENT THAT WAS MADE FOR
OR AGAINST WAS VALID AND EVERY
ARGUMENT THAT YOU HEARD ME YOU
COULD SAY.
IS THE RIGHT THING.
I DID NOT HEAR ANYTHING THAT
SOUNDED MORE CORRECT OR OR NO
THAT'S WRONG.
EVERYTHING I HEARD.
WAS THE FACT.
THAT MIGHT BE A FIRST AT LEAST
WHAT I'VE HEARD ON THIS FLOOR --
THE MY GOOD FRIEND MISTER ALLEN
AS BOOKING AND I'M JUST GETTING
JUST KIDDING I JUST GET.
I WAS STARTING THERE I'M
STARTING THE READING ALREADY --
IT IS A FACT.
IS AN IRREFUTABLE FACT.
THAT THE BRAIN SCIENCE SAYS THIS
IS GOOD.
FOR IT IS ALSO IRREFUTABLE FACT.
THAT IF YOU MAKE THIS CHANGE
[inaudible]
YOU'RE CREATING. FOR MANY MANY
PARENTS A DEPARTURE.
BECAUSE IT IS A FACT.
THAT MOST PARENTS DO NOT HAVE
THE KIND OF FLEXIBLE JOBS.
THAT WE DO.
OR THAT OTHERS DO THAT ALLOW
THEM TO SAY TO THEIR EMPLOYER
[inaudible]
COMING IN.
HALF HOUR LATER OR WHATEVER UP
TIME LATER THAT'S JUST A FACT.
AND IF THIS BILL GOES FORWARD.
AND PREVAILS AND IS SIGNED INTO
LAW.
THE AUTHOR IN THE COALITION
WHOEVER ELSE HAVE TO BE VERY
SERIOUS.
ABOUT HOW TO CREATE.
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED.
THAT CREATES SUCCESS.
AND CONSIDERS THE HARDSHIP THAT
IT CREATES FOR PARENTS YES IT IS
A FACT THAT THE BRAIN SCIENCE IS
GOOD FOR KIDS BUT WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT IT CREATES A HARDSHIP FOR
FAMILIES FOR MANY.
WE SHOULD BE IN A POSITION WHERE
WE'RE HAVING CONVERSATION WITH
FAMILIES AND GETTING INPUT.
FROM OUR FAMILIES AND IT IS A
FACT.
THAT SHOULD IT BE IMPLEMENTED
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A HARDSHIP.
FOR MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR
STATE.
UP SOME DISTRICTS WILL DO THIS.
MUCH EASIER THAN OTHERS YOU
HEARD EXAMPLES TODAY.
FROM A FEW DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY DONE THIS.
BUT THE REALITY IS THIS FOR MOST
DISTRICTS [inaudible]
THIS WILL.
MEAN INCREASED COSTS THAT THEY
HAVE NOT PLAN.
FOR AND WILL NEED HELP. TO GET
IT DONE IN THE PLACE WHERE THEY
WILL HAVE TO LOOK FOR THAT HELP.
IT'S FROM THIS CHAMBER.
THE RED CHAMBER.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS.
USING THEIR LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA OR ANY OTHER
LOCAL DOLLARS.
THEY WILL NEED HELP ON THIS
LEGISLATURE AND FROM THIS AND
FROM THE GOVERNOR. TO GET THIS
DONE.
SO HERE I AM A YEAR LATER.
STILL WILLING TO VOTE.
FOR STILL VERY CONFLICTED.
BUT WANTING MEMBERS TO BE
SERIOUS IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
YOU DO HERE TODAY.
THAT ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
TRUE FACTS AND WE'VE GOT TO GIVE
DISTRICTS SUPPORT.
IT THIS MOVES FORWARD THIS
CANNOT BE AN UNFUNDED MANDATE WE
JUST EXPECTED TO WORK BECAUSE IF
NOT WE DOOM.
THE FAMILIES TO FAIL THE DISHES
TO FAIL.
AND POTENTIALLY THE KIDS TO FAIL
[inaudible]
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
YEAH THANK YOU MEMBERS.
I JUST OF FELT COMPELLED TO
STAND.
THE DEFENSE OF THE POSITION
BECAUSE WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO I DO
NOT FEEL THAT THIS BASED ON
IGNORANCE.
I THINK THE BELIEVING IN LOCAL
CONTROL IS A VERY POWERFUL.
PIECE OF OUR INSTITUTIONAL
GOVERNANCE.
AND I BELIEVE HAVING BEEN A
MEMBER THE SCHOOL BOARD WHICH IS
ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
[inaudible]
PUBLIC SERVICE --
EXPERIENCES THAT I'VE HAD IN MY
LIFETIME.
I'VE HAD THOSE MEETINGS THAT
HAVE GONE WELL INTO THE THE A.
M..
BUT THAT'S THEIR JOB.
AND THAT'S A JOB THAT I I NEVER
REGRETTED.
AND I ALWAYS FEEL THAT IT.
WE NEED TO TRUST OUR LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO KNOW WHAT'S BEST
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND I THINK WE SHOW [inaudible]
THE DEGREE.
OF ARROGANCE THAT WE KNOW BETTER
THAN THEY DO I THINK IT'S
DEPLORABLE AND I DO NOT THINK
IT'S BASED ON IGNORANCE AND I
ANNOUNCED FOR NO. TO US SOME A
FIRST TIME WORK HERE NEXT THANK
YOU AGAIN I PROBABLY WASN'T
GONNA RISE ON THIS BUT I JUST
THOUGHT WE NEEDED PUT THE
PERSPECTIVE.
OF THE EMPLOYER INTO THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS IMPACTS
OUR FAMILIES WERE TALKING ABOUT
DOING IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO
TAKE -- OUR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL AND HOW THAT
WILL IMPACT THEIR ABILITY TO GO
TO WORK AND I'LL TELL YOU AS AN
EMPLOYER AGAIN EARLIER TODAY I
MENTIONED ON THE BUSINESSES THAT
I'VE OWNING CONTINUE TO OWN.
I'M IN THE AGGREGATE I HAVE.
OWN BUSINESSES FOR OVER THIRTY
SIX YEARS I'VE EMPLOYED HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE I'VE LEARNED AN
INDELIBLE TRUTH OF THREE POINTS.
ONE COMPENSATE YOUR EMPLOYEES
FAIRLY [inaudible]
SEEMS RIGHT [inaudible] TO TELL
THEM HOW WELL THEY'RE PERFORMING
[inaudible] THREE NEVER SCREW
WITH THEIR SCHEDULE.
IF YOU WANT TO MAINTAIN AND KEEP
YOUR EMPLOYEES HAPPY.
FOLLOW THOSE THREE TRUTHS.
THIS LAW WILL MESS WITH NUMBER
THREE AND WILL HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WILL
REVERBERATE THROUGH THE ECONOMY
AND IMPACT ALL OF OUR FAMILIES.
UNFORTUNATELY I WILL BE NOT
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
MEMBERS IT APPEARS THAT ALL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
[inaudible]
CEASED.
SEEING NO OTHER REQUEST TO SPEAK
WILL RETURN TO US NOVEMBER
GLORIA FIRST CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND A
SINCERE APPRECIATION TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ROBUST DEBATE
ODDS PROFESSION YOU SEE AN ISSUE
THEY GAVE YOU SO MANY MEMBERS ON
ALL SIDES THE AYE WE HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS.
ON BUT I THINK WHAT THE REFRAINS
I'VE HEARD REPEATEDLY IS
ACKNOWLEDGMENT IT WITHOUT
QUESTION THE SCIENCE SUPPORTS
TODAY'S BILL AND THAT IT'S THE
RIGHT THING FOR KIDS SO I FIGURE
VOTE TODAY'S PRETTY CLEAR BUT I
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
CLOSING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS.
THAT WERE MENTIONED.
FIRST OFF THERE WAS A REFERENCE
THE FACT THIS BILL HAS NOT
CHANGED AND OF COURSE AS YOU
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WHAT YOU'RE IT IS IN FACT CHANGE
THIS BILL EXCLUDES RULE
DISTRICTS.
ARE AND ALSO HAS A DIFFERENT
IMPLEMENTATION DATE THERE'S MADE
MENTION OF IMPACTS TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS ARE THAT
WAS ALSO DRESSED IN THIS BILL
WILL NOT BE IMPLEMENTED.
UNTIL A NEW CONTRACT IS ADOPTED --
THERE WAS MADE MENTION OF LOCAL
CONTROL AND THE DESIRE TO ALLOW
LOCALS TO MAKE THIS DECISION AND
I I I SORT OF CHUCKLE AT THAT
WEB REPRESENTATION SIMPLY
BECAUSE THIS BODY HAS MADE MANY.
MANY DIRECTIONS TO LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS IN THIS SESSION ALONE I
BEGAN ABOUT AT THE STUDIES I'M
THINKING ABOUT CULTURAL
ADORNMENTS I'M BEING DONE RECENT
YEARS AROUND LED OF LEAD PAINT
IN SCHOOLS.
AROUND THE REQUIREMENT FOR PIT
PHYSICAL AT SCHOOL DAYS THAT
POINT OUT A LOT OF THOSE THINGS
ADDRESS.
CHILDREN'S HEALTH THAT THE VERY
THING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS WITH THIS BILL.
MEMBERS EAT I KNOW THAT THIS MAY
BE HARD FOR SOME OF YOU I
CERTAINLY HEARD FROM MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS BUT YOU LISTEN HOW
MANY TIMES HAVE WE STOOD UP
COLLECTIVELY OR INDIVIDUALLY.
AND SAID THAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO
LISTEN TO THE SCIENCE ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE WE SAY AGAIN AND
AGAIN DO THEY NOT SEE WHAT THE
EXPERTS ARE SAYING AND WHY ARE
THEY NOT DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
SO YOU CAN'T GET UP AND SAY THAT
IN THE TURN AROUND AGAIN VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL.
YOU CANNOT RISE UP AND SAY THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE TOUGH FOR
ADULTS WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN ARE
SUFFERING THAT'S IS IF YOU'RE
NOT SUPPORTING KIDS WHAT ARE YOU
DOING HERE.
MEMBERS IT'S THREE MILLION OF
OUR CHILDREN CHILDREN AND MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
CURRENTLY SLEEP DEPRIVED AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE IT FROM THE
GUY FROM SAN DIEGO OR THAT GUY
FROM CLOCK KANATA FLINTRIDGE YOU
CAN TAKE IT.
FROM THE FROM THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF SLEEP
MEDICINE THE CALIFORNIA
ADOLESCENT HEALTH COLLABORATIVE
THAT BITS.
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON OF
EXPERTS IN THIS FIELD WHO KNOW
THAT THE CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING
BECAUSE OF OUR CURRENT PRACTICE
OF STARTING A LITTLE TOO EARLY
AND WHAT ARE THE IMPACTS OF THAT
THEY'RE PRETTY SIMPLE MEMBERS.
THEY CANNOT GET ENOUGH SLEEP AND
SO THEY SEE PERFORMANCE IN THEIR
SCHOOL GO DOWN YOU SEE MEMORY
ATTENTION AND JUDGMENT CHALLENGE
YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
OF TRUANCY INTEROP OUT RATES.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
DANGEROUS TO OUR COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE.
NOT MANY OF YOU KNOW I'M THE SON
OF A MADE IN A GARDENER WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WORKING
FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET IN THIS STATE I'VE LIVED
THAT.
ALRIGHT BUT IT WAS NEVER EASY TO
GET TO SCHOOL FROM MY PARENTS
ARE THAT WE MADE IT WORK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO PAINT
THIS VIVIDLY.
SO WHAT HAPPENS THOSE FAMILIES
WILL KNOW THAT THOSE FAMILIES
TODAY HAVE SOME LITTLE SLEEP
DEPRIVED CHILDREN IN THE STATE.
AND SO WE CAN FIX THAT FOR THEM
IF THAT'S WHO YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT IS WHO THIS BILL
SPEAKS.
TO AND WHAT HAPPENS FOR THE
SCHOOLS THAT MY NEED TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS THE JUST AS THEY DO
NOW FOR AFTER SCHOOL CARE SOME
OF THOSE RESOURCES AND TO AND
DEMONSTRATION AREAS CAN BE
REMOVED FROM THE AFTER THE
SCHOOL DATES THE BEGINNING OF
THE SCHOOL DAY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE CAN MAKE ENDS MEET
MEMBERS THIS IS NOT ABOUT ADULTS
THIS IS ABOUT KIDS AND I'M
ASKING YOU TO VOTE WITH THE
CHILDREN DO IT FOR OUR KIDS DO
IT BECAUSE SCIENCE SUGGEST THEY
DO IT BECAUSE OUR CHAIRMAN IS
ASKING FOR IT.
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO VOTE YES ON
S. B. THREE TWENTY EIGHT IT IS
FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA WITHOUT
MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
SORRY TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
LAURIE MOVES THE CALL
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED HERE MOTIONS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
A PURSUIT [inaudible]
WITHOUT ACTION SHALL BE THE
ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO MOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING OR HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND THEY CAN
THANK CALENDAR SENATE BILL FOR
NINETEEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AND OTHERS NOT RELATING TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE CLEARLY IS
THERE A THICK THICK MEATY LEE.
THANK YOU THE COURT WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WILL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE BOAT'S I
SEVENTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT COUNTERS ADOPTED.
PLEASE READ THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN EYES FIFTY THREE
NO.
ZERO I'M SORRY SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO AND TO THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY THREE I
SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON ITEM SIXTY ONE
S. B..
TWELVE NINETY FOUR A CLERK
PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE TRYING TO PASS
AND RETAIN AN ITEM
SEVEN MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING BACK TO THE CAN TO
THE CONCURRENCE ITEMS.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO PASS AND RETAIN ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB ELEVEN MISTER FOR
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY RULE ELEVEN BY SLIVER
MCCARTY ANOTHER'S INOCULATE
AMERICA NOW THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE OF COURSE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT SINCE THAT BILL THAT
WILL HELP TACKLE TOXIC STRESS
AND THE ACES ISSUE WITH OUR
YOUNGSTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
BY IMPROVING EARLY DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS ASK THE ARRIVAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU HOW I SEE NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM MISTER
QUICK WAS OPEN THERE ARE.
ALL MEMBERS PRODUCE HIGHER TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO ITEM.
EIGHT A. B.. TEN SIXTY TWO THE
CORPOREAL.
SO ME GIRL TEN SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE OF
ACCOLADE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AB TEN
SIXTY TWO IMPLEMENTS RECENT LA
OR RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE
THAT CSU ONLINE PROGRAMS ARE
CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVED.
AND EVALUATED DO AND IN ORDER TO
MEET STUDENT NEEDS ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
DISCUSS THIS ITEM THAT MISTER
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE RUN.
ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM NINE AB TEN
NINETY SEVEN MISTER QUICKLY
THROUGH.
SOME EVIL TEN NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE ANOTHER
SNACK LEGACY PIECES AND PARKS
THANK YOU BACK TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AB TEN NINETY SEVEN I
CREATES DESIGNATED PICNIC AREAS
ON BEACHES AND PARKS.
THAT ARE SMOKE FREE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M
GONNA SUPPORT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SANDRA FELL ON THIS.
ONE WE HAD A LONG CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS BILL INSTEAD OF
TRYING TO BAN SOMETHING WELL
THIS IS ACTUALLY A BETTER IDEA
OF THAT WE HAVE SMOKING AREAS
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO AT
RESTAURANTS.
SO SMOKERS CAN CONGREGATE IN ONE
AREA WE CAN PUT A CANISTER THERE
AND KEEP THE DEBRIS IN ONE AREA
INSTEAD OF MILES AND MILES ON
THE BEACHES.
I DON'T LIKE THE FINE ELEMENT OF
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S WAY TOO
LOW THE GOVERNOR VETOED A TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR FINE BUT CAR PULLS
THREE EIGHTY ONE CELLPHONE
TICKETS A HUNDRED FIFTY BUCKS.
I THINK WE NEED TO INCREASE THE
FINE ON THIS AND THAT'S THE
ISSUE OF THE BILL THAT I'M A
SPORT YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ALL I DO.
MEMBERS IF YOU DO WANT TO SPEAK
ON ITEM PLEASE PUT --
SOME MEMBER LACKEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
I JUST ONE APPRECIATE THE
OFFICER OR THE AUTHOR ACTUALLY
ALLOWING MORE BUT ON THE BEACH
THANK YOU.
IF I HAD KNOWN I WOULDN'T HAVE
RECOGNIZED YOU.
WITH THAT MISTER MISTER CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE MEMBERS VOTERS
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MISTER KIRKE MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE BOATS EYES.
FIFTY TWO KNOWS FOURTEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MOVING NOW
.
TO MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM FIFTY ONE S. B.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL POST
.
MR CLERK WAS CLOSE THE ROLE.
PROBABLY PURSUE HER PLEASE CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS. THIRTY THAT
MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK IN FILE ORDER ITEM
TEN PASS AND PASS TEMPORARILY
ITEM.
TWELVE A. B. TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
THREE CHRISTOPHER PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY THE LAND USE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREAT.
THEY HAVE SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY THREE
AUTHORIZES A MODEST TWENTY FOUR
MONTH EXTENSION FOR TENTATIVE
TRACTION PARCEL MAPS RELAYED
HOUSING IN ECONOMICALLY
DEPRESSED COUNTIES THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU RIGHT VOTE [inaudible]
THIS.
SEEING NOTE REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK MEET YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE ANTI THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
ONE AND NO ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
TEN A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN
MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
THOSE ANOTHER REASON REPUBLICAN
PLOY RETIREMENT.
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISS SPEAKER A I'M
PRESENTING AB FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE%
BOARDS OF CALPERS AND COUNSELORS
THE DIVEST PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT FUNDS FROM ANY
INVESTMENT VEHICLE ISSUED BY
OWNED CONTROLLED ARE MANAGED BY
THE GOERNMENT OF TURKEY.
AS AMENDED IN THE SENATE THE
LIQUIDATION OF INVESTMENTS IN
TURKEY IS CONTINGENT UPON THE
PASSAGE OF A FEDERAL LAW ISSUING
SANCTIONS AGAINST TURKEY.
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A CLEAR
POLICY ON THE GENOCIDE.
AS DEMONSTRATED BY DECADES OF
LEGISLATIVE RESOLUTIONS AND IS
GOING EIGHT AND EXECUTIVE
PROCLAMATIONS.
THIS BILL CONTINUES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ACT APPROPRIATELY
AGAINST COUNTRIES THAT HAVE A
RECORD OF HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AND UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY.
THIS BILL HAS THE ENJOYED BROAD.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
VERY AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DO NOT SEE ANY REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS PRO WHO'S OUR DEVOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. FOR
MOVING OUT ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
NINETEEN FOURTEEN MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN
FOURTEEN BY SIMPLY MEMBER
FLORIDA ACCOLADE THE STATE
GOVERNMENT YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN FOURTEEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THE SAFE PRUDENT USE OF POWER
OPERATED TO THOSE BORN EQUIPMENT
EXCAVATION.
ONCE THE UNDERGROUND FACILITY
SAFE.
EXCAVATION BOARD HAS ADOPTED THE
REGULATIONS A. B. NINETEEN FORTY
WOULD PROVIDE A BALANCED
SOLUTION.
ALLOW ME ESCOVEDO TO PURSUE BEST
PRACTICES ONLY ONE ADOPTION OF
THESE REGULATIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN A REQUEST TO SPEAK MCCORKLE
OPEN THEIR OWN ONEROUS BURDEN
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WHERE MOVING OUT OFF FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
SIX MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ?
ASSEMBLY RULE TWENTY THREE FORTY
SIX BY SOME MEMBER QUIRK
INOCULATED PUBLIC UTILITIES
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
SPEAKER.
SSR AB TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC.
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
AUTHORIZE ELECTRICAL.
CORPORATIONS TO ESTABLISH.
WILD FIRE EXPANSE MORATORIUM
ACCOUNTS.
USER BASICALLY JUST LEDGERS OF
THE PROVOCAR STOOD WILDFIRE.
OUR CHEN AMENDMENTS CHANGE THE
INITIAL DATE FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY FIFTEEN
OTHERWISE IT'S THE SAME BILL.
SUPPORTED BY AYE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS.
HOPEFULLY XIN OF CALIFORNIA
TELLING HIM PLOY USED IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNSEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING A NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CORPUS OPEN THE
ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS WHO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTEEN AB FIVE
FOURTEEN MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ SO MIDDLE FIVE FOURTEEN BY
SOME THE PURPOSE SALAS
INOCULATED SEX.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS SIMPLY BILL FIVE
FOURTEEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO NOTIFY CHILD DAYCARE FACILITY
WHEN REGISTERED SEX OFFENDER.
REGISTERS A NEW RESIDENTS WITHIN
ONE THOUSAND FEET OF THE
FACILITY ROOM.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CORPUS OPEN THE
MEMBERS BONE DESIRE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
STIR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SO MY GOAL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE
PUBLIC ON SOME EVER CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO IS BACK
FROM CONCURRENT THAT WE KNOW
THAT WORKING FAMILIES ARE TRYING
TO MAKE A DOLLAR OUT OF FIFTEEN
CENTS.
THIS BILL.
WOULD ALLOW DISABLED VETERANS IN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES --
AT LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES AND SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES THAT HAVE PROVEN TO
HAVE OPPOSED A POSITIVE SOCIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT.
IT'S BACK UP ON THE SENATE FROM
THE A SUPPORTIVE ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND FEAR O.
NO VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER PARK WAS OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE
KNOW ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM.
SEVENTEEN AB NINE THIRTY NINE
MISTER QUICKLY ST ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THIRTY NINE BY SIMILAR
BELOW AN ACCOLADE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW YOUR RECOGNIZE THAT
VERY MUCH MASSACRE MEMBERS THIS
TACTIC TAG.
TEAMED UP IN EIRE SO IF THEY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE ON ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME ERROR MCCARTY
ANOTHER'S NATALIE INTO ADULT
EDUCATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE IS UP BACK ON
CONCURRENCY WAS THE GOD AMEND
THE SENATE SENSUALLY AT A BILL
TO IMPROVE OUR ADULT EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
MAIN FOCUSING AT LOOKING AT
STRENGTHENING STRENGTHENING OUR
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE.
INTEGRATION PROGRAMS ASK YOUR
IVA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT AS A PROUD
JOINT AUTHOR I LIKE TO THINK.
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP HERE.
OF FOR MANY YEARS --
WE HAVE COUNTED ON ADULT
EDUCATION TO SUPPORT.
THE PARENTS OF OUR STUDENTS IN
THE TOUGH TIMES ADULT EDUCATION
IS ALSO FINANCE OUR K. TWELVE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND HAS
HELPED US TO KEEP THEM GOING.
THIS IS HELPFUL FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO REINVEST IN ADULT
EDUCATION AS A TOOL FOR
SUPPORTING OUR PARENTS SO THEY
CAN SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOTH.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK.
THE PURPOSE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE SORRY TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
MR CLERK.
YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
NINETEEN AB THIRTY TO FORTY
EIGHT MISTER CLARK PLEASE HURRY.
ASSUMING ALL THIRTY TO FORTY
EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AN ACCOLADE THE CIVIL
LAW ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TAKE YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S.
ANNUAL FAMILY LAW OMNIBUS BILL I
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEN NEVER QUESTION TO
BE THE ITEM MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS
WHO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM TWENTY AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME WE WILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER PATTERSON
ANOTHER WAS AN ACCOLADE CARE
FACILITIES ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON.
THANK A MATTER SPEAKER AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS A BACK
ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL SIMPLY INCORPORATED THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
AND INCLUDED CHAPTER IN OUT
LANGUAGE AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY SIX
NEW TO THE SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWENTY
ONE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
MISTER QUICKLY THREE ASSUME
IT'LL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY BY
SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON ANOTHER'S
AN ACCOLADE TO INVASIVE SPEAK.
SENATE MEMBER GRAYSON THINK
ABOUT OF SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ADD LANGUAGE
TO COORDINATE EFFORTS TO
SUPPRESS AN EROTIC EIGHT THE
INVASIVE SHOT HOLE BORE.
AND AUTHORIZE THE INVASIVE
SPECIES COUNCIL TO ESTABLISH
ADVISORY COMMITTEES AND WORKING
GROUPS TO ASSIST IN THE
ERADICATION OF INVASIVE SPECIES
IN CALIFORNIA AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY WILL GIVE CALIFORNIAN
EFFECTIVE PLATFORM. TO FIGHT THE
SPREAD OF INVASIVE SPECIES AND
SAFEGUARD OUR UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENTAL HERITAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I'VE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO DEBATE THIS
FIND THE BILL.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO'S ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY TO
AB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SO MIDDLE SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
NATALIE TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB SEVEN SIX
SEVEN LEVERAGES AN EXISTING GO
BID IS WEB BASED PLATFORM TO
BECOME A MORE POWERFUL SINGLE
ACCESS POINT FOR STATE ECONOMIC.
AND BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
DELETE THE REQUIREMENT TO
ESTABLISH A NEW MASTER BUSINESS
LICENCE CENTER AND INSTEAD
EXPAND GO VISITS EXISTING ONLINE
PROGRAMMING CAPACITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK THE
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS BURDENS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRING TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWENTY
THREE A. B. FIVE SIX FIVE MISTER
QUICKLY ST.
A SWIMMING POOL FIVE SIXTY FIVE
BY SOME MEMBER ROOM ACRYLATE
BILLIG STANDARDS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE
SIXTY FIVE PASSED THE DEPARTMENT
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO REVISIT AND
CLARIFY PORTIONS OF THE BUILDING
CODE AND RESIDENTIAL CODE.
PERTAINING TO LIVE WORK UNITS
WHILE GIVEN THE DEPARTMENT BROAD
FLEXIBILITY IN CONDUCTING THAT
PROCESS THANK YOU ASKED WE WRITE
ABOUT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM MISTER QUIRK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
SIX KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM TWENTY FOUR
A. B. THIRTY SIXTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSUMING ALL THIRTY SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS ARE NOT RELATED MOBILE
HOMES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS IS A
BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE ABILITY
TO ENFORCE THE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENCY LA.
THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD AND REMOVE
SOME OPPOSITION FROM LAST YEAR'S
BILL I ASK FOR CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO REQUEST
HAS BECOME A CONCURRENCE.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
YOU QUIRK YOU MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I WAS FORTY ONE IT KNOWS FIFTEEN
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM.
TWENTY SIX AB NINETEEN TWELVE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO MAY GO NINETEEN TWELVE BY
SOMEWHERE RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
SOME EVER AYE REGUS.
I DON'T SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RIGHTS PRESENT AB NINETEEN
TWELVE WHICH IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENT WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
SEVERAL MONTHS OF OUR PRESENT IN
THIS BILL IN THIS CHAMBER IN
RESPONSE TO THE E. SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY JPA ISSUE WORTH RETIREES
PENSIONS WERE CUT BY UP 263%.
AFTER THE JP LOST ITS ONLY
SOURCE OF FUNDING AND OPERATIONS
AND CALPERS CONTRACT WAS
TERMINATED.
SINCE THEN THIS BILL HASN'T HAD
NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS AS RESULT OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE PUNDITS.
TO REACH A COMPROMISE WHERE MANY
OF THEM HAVE REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED BY PARTS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECT WE
ASK FOR I WANT [inaudible]
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS SIX THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN A. B. TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER CALDERON
ACCOLADE SHORTHAND REPORTERS
THANK YOU AYE SOME EVER KALRA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR NARROWED
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL TO
PROHIBIT AT A STATE.
NON LICENSEE OWNED COMPANIES
PROVIDE COURT REPORTING SERVICES
FROM VIOLATING FOR SPECIFIC LAWS
APPLICABLE TO PROTECTING THE
INTEGRITY AND IMPARTIALITY OF
THE COURT RECORD IN THE MATTER
OF THE DOES NOT ADVANTAGE. ONE
PARTY OVER ANOTHER LICENSEE
OWNED FIRMS BASED IN CALIFORNIA
ALREADY MUST ALL THESE LAWS AND
ARE SUBJECT TO REGULATORY
AUTHORITY BY THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD.
THIS IS A MUCH NARROW BEZEL LE
THEM IT WAS A PASS INITIALLY OUT
OF THIS HOUSE WHICH WOULD HAVE
REQUIRED REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO
FIRM REGISTRATION ON ALL COURT
REPORTING LAWS.
AND REGULATIONS THAT IS THE
INTENT OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR
TO BE A STRONG DETERRENT AGAINST
THE MOST EGREGIOUS ACTIONS THAT
COMPROMISE THE NEUTRAL CARE OF
THE COURT REPORTER'S TRANSCRIPT
BY NON LICENSEE OWNED FIRMS.
WHO HAVE A DISREGARD FOR
FOLLOWING OUR LAWS AROUND COURT
REPORTING?
AB TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR SPONSORED
BY THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD OF
SUPPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
DEPOSITION REPORTERS SO
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS MOVE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
TOM MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELUGU VOTES EYES FORTY ONE NO
TWENTY ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CAN [inaudible]
EFFORT IN.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SO WE WILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE
ANOTHER'S NATALIE TO CANCER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO IS
BACK ON CONCURRENT CHANCES FROM
THE SENATE THE AMENDMENTS TAKE
IN THE SENATE WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN EACH I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU SEEING A NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
I'M SORRY.
SOME MEMBER WALDRON A BRING YOUR
PARDON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU I RISE AS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS LEGISLATION.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WOMEN --
WHO OUR DEALING WITH BREAST AND
OVARIAN CANCER OR AT RISK OF IT
NEED TO BE SEEING A GENETIC
COUNSELOR AND HAVE GENETIC
TESTING AYE URGENT AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU WITHOUT MISTER QUIRK
YOU MAY OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BURDENS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
I AM TWENTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY AB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO WE WILL TO THIRTY SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
ANOTHER SNACK LATER CONSUMER
LOANS SOME EVER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN WOULD EXPAND
ACCESS TO SAFE CONSUMER LOANS BY
RAISING THE UPPER LIMIT OF LOANS
AVAILABLE UNDER THECURRENT
PILOT PROGRAM TO SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THE NEED TO INCREASE THE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE AND SAFE OPTIONS
FOR LOANS GREATER THAN TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IT'S CLEAR.
THE DEPARTMENT BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT REPORTS THAT JUST OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND CONSUMER LOANS WERE
ISSUED IN THE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
RANGE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT
REPRESENTS JUST OVER HALF OF ALL
CONSUMER LOANS ISSUED UNDER THE
CFL.
IN NEARLY HALF OF THOSE LOANS
RANGE IN THE TRIPLE DIGIT
INTEREST RATE.
CONSUMERS DESERVE A BETTER LOAN
PRODUCTS MORE VARIETY OF LOAN
PRODUCTS EXPANDING THE UPPER
LIMIT OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
TO SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED WOULD
PROVIDE RELIEF TO CONSUMERS.
AND WE DO SOBY ADDING
PROTECTIONS AS WELL.
SOME OF THE MANY PROTECTIONS
UNDER THE PROGRAM INCLUDED IN
THESE DO NOT EXIST UNDER CFL
INTEREST RATES CAP IT'S 36%.
LOANS MUST BE UNSECURED LENDERS
MUST COMPLETE UNDERWRITING TO
ENSURE BORROWERS HAVE THE
ABLITY TO REPAY LENDERS MUST
REPORT LOANS TO CREDIT AGENCIES
AND NO PREPAYMENT PENALTIES.
THE PILOT PROGRAM REPRESENTS ONE
HAVING A TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO
UNDER BANKED IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM MISTER
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE RAINN ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I FIFTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORD
AND MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING AHEAD
IN FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
FORTY ONE HR ONE TWENTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN
RELATIVE TO THE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FIRST WOMAN
ELECTED THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MENACE
SPEAKER A MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT HR ONE TWENTY TWO I
ALSO JUST WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT --
THIS YEAR MARKS THE HUNDREDTH
YEAR HUNDRED YEAR THAT WOMEN
HAVE BEEN ELECTED INTO THIS BODY
AND IT FALLS ALMOST IN
CONJUCTION WITH AUGUST.
TWENTY SIX WHICH IS NATIONAL
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY IN WHICH
THAT NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WAS
RATIFIED WHERE IT WAS DEEMED
THAT WOMEN WERE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
SO.
THINGS HAVEN'T BEEN IN EXISTENCE
THAT LONG WE HAVE REALLY NOTICED
THE COULD CONTRIBUTIONS OF WOMEN
SERVING IN THIS BODY AND I THINK
ANYBODY WHO POLL WE TALK TO OUR
WHO KNOWS THAT SAYS IT WILL
NEVER REALLY HAVE FULLY QUALITY
WILL NEVER HAVE REALLY REDUCTION
OF ALL THE DISPARITIES WE FACE.
UNTIL WE HAVE FULLY QUALITY IN
OUR REPRESENTATION AYE WE HAVE
HAD IN THIS CHAMBER THESE TWO
CHAMBERS COMBINED OVER FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED MEN WHO HAVE SERVED
IN THESE AUGUST BODY SITTING IN
THE SEATS.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
OF VANESSA DELGADO WHO WAS JUST
ELECTED --
IS THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVENTH WOMAN WHO HAS EVER
SERVED IN THESE CHAMBERS.
SO IF IN THE LAST HUNDRED YEARS
WE HAVE HAD A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN WOMEN ONLY SERVE IN THESE
CHAMBERS --
THE FIRST FOR WOMEN AYE WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT MAYBE THEY CAME FROM
COASTAL AREAS BUT THEY WERE FROM
KERN iNTY
BUTTE COUNTY.
I AM BERKELEY THE FIRST FOR
WOMEN TO BE ELECTED TO SERVE IN
THIS BODY --
AT THAT TIME THEY WERE SAYING
THAT TO PEOPLE LIKE --
ELIZABETH CUES FROM ORVILLE AND
IT TAKES A MAN OF YOUR OLD MAN
THEY SAID TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
TOUGH WORK OF LAWMAKERS IT'S NO
PT JOB. TO WHICH SHE RESPONDED
ARE THE A RED CROSS WORKERS ON
THE FRONT LINES IN WORLD WAR TWO
OR THAT A PINK TEE JOB AS
THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF OUR
WOUNDED.
IN HERE ON THIS FLOOR TODAY NOT
ONLY ARE WE WERE WERE WOMEN
WHERE MOTHERS WERE SISTERS WERE
DAUGHTERS WERE CAREGIVERS ARE
ALL THOSE THINGS.
BUT WE ALSO REPRESENT
PROFESSIONS ACROSS THIS GREAT
STATE.
WE'RE ALSO FARMERS.
WE'RE ALSO EDUCATORS.
WE ARE ALSO ATTORNEYS.
WE'RE ALSO BUSINESS WOMEN.
WE ARE ALSO JOURNALIST.
WE ARE ALSO LABOR LEADERS.
WE ARE ALSO COMMITTEE ORGANIZERS.
WE ARE ALSO.
FOR FILM INDUSTRY PEOPLE.
WE HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN THE
NONPROFIT WORLD.
AND WE OUR SOLDIERS AND SAILORS.
WE REPRESENT CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SO IN HONOR OF ONE
HUNDRED YEARS OF PEOPLE SERVING
IN THIS BODY MEMBERS AND FOR
WOMEN NOT EVEN HAVING THE RIGHT
TO VOTE FOR THE LAST ONE HUNDRED
YEARS IT TOOK US OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS TO GET THAT RIGHT.
WE'VE MADE FOR UP IN THAT TIME
YOU SEE HOW FEW OF US THERE
STILL ARE WE ARE 25% OF THIS
BODY WE NEED TO BE MORE THIS
SHOULD BE THE RECORD YEAR WHERE
WE ALL RUN FOR OFFICE AND FOR
EVERY MAN WHO WAS SITTING IN
HERE.
I HOPE YOU THANK EACH ONE OF US
EVERY DAY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE ALL
OF US A LITTLE BIT BETTER AS WE
REALLY TALK ABOUT REPRESENTING
THE FABRIC THAT IS CALIFORNIA.
AND THE VALUES THAT WE ALL
REPRESENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS UPON THIS
AND ASK FOR THE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN. FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THERE'S NO THEIR NO COAUTHORS.
MISS YOUR COOLEY.
WELL COLLEAGUES I'M RISE.
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I NOTE THAT IN. NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN ONE OF THE WOMEN WHO
WANT OFFICE WAS ESTO BROTEN OF
STANISLAUS.
WROTE IN IS THE NAME OF MY
DAUGHTER IN LAW IN THE BROKEN
WOMEN I KNOW TODAY ARE NURSES
STUDENTS AND THE MOTHER OF TWO
OF MY GRANDCHILDREN.
THANK YOU MISTER COLIN
[inaudible]
MS.
DOCTOR EGGMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADD SOMETHING HERE CLOSE. TO ONE
POINT OF CLARIFICATION I WOULD
ALSO I WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
REMISS OF IN THIS DAY AND AGE I
DIDN'T ALSO ASK OUR ENGINEERS TO
STAND [inaudible]
ENGINEERS.
ENGINEERS LOOSE JACKET.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE DOCTOR EGGMAN ASKED
THAT THE FIRST ROLE ON THIS
HOUSE RESOLUTION BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ON I WISH WE SHOULD ADD AS CO
AUTHORS ON HR.
ONE TWENTY TWO CO AUTHORS ON HR.
WHEN TWENTY TO THE CLERK WELL?
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY NINE
COAUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE HEARD ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
I OPPOSE SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
[inaudible]
MS FRIEDMAN'S [inaudible]
CONCURRENCE ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN ON THE CONCURRENCE VILE
AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO FIRE SAFETY.
THIS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AMENDMENTS MADE
TO AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN IN THE
SENATE THAT THE FOLLOWING THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS MADE THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES.
REQUIRES A LOCAL AGENCY TO
TRANSMIT COPY OF ITS ADOPTED
ORDINANCE DESIGNATING A VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE
TO THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION.
REMOVES EXEMPTIONS FROM
REQUIREMENTS THAT A LOCAL AGENCY
DESIGNATE A VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES IN A
JURISDICTION WITHIN A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS OF RECEIVING
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH.
FIRE.
WHO CRIERS BEFORE JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO UPDATE
THE GUIDANCE DOCUMENT ENTITLED
FIRE HAZARD PLAYING GENERAL PLAN
TECHNICAL ADVICE SERIES?
AND UPDATE NOT LESS THAN ONCE
EVERY EIGHT YEARS ELIMINATE
CHANGES MADE BY THE BILL TO CAL
FIRES ELECTRICAL TRANSMISSION OR
DISTRIBUTION LINE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS.
EXPANDS AUTHORIZATION FOR ANY
UTILITY TO TRAVERSE LAND AFTER
ABIDING NOTICE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HEARD TO THE LANDOWNER TO
PRUNE TREES TO ABDICATE ANY
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS AND HIGH
FIRE THREAT DISTRICTS.
AS A GERMAN BY THE CPUC MADE
OTHER TECH HELLFIRE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE.
ON THESE A SENATE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL I'M.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS OUT OF
THOSE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
INTEL THE VOTE.
AYE AYES.
FORTY EIGHT NO SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
[inaudible]
MEMBER. TO ITEM SEVENTY S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
BY SENATOR SKINNER AND UPLAND
PEACE OFFICER RECORDS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISS ON MADAM SPEAKER
I TO GET PRESENTS SP FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE BY.
CENTER SKINNER A BILL WHICH WILL
ALLOW FOR A NARROW SCOPE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS TO BE AVAILABLE
VIA A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
CALIFORNIA'S WHEN THE MOST
SECRETIVE STATES IN THE NATION
WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC ACCESS
TO INTERNAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATION RECORDS.
IN FACT TWENTY EIGHT STATES
ALLOW FOR GREATER TO EQUAL
ACCESS OF RECORDS THAN WHAT IS
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WOULD
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS TO
INVESTIGATE RECORDS RELATED.
TO DISCHARGE OF A FIREARM USE OF
FORCE WHICH RESULT IN DEATH OR
GREAT BODILY INJURY.
SUSTAINED FINDINGS OF ON THE JOB
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT FIFTEEN
FINDINGS OF ON THE JOB
DISHONESTY.
AMENDMENTS ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
WERE NARROWLY CRAFTED TO ACCOUNT
FOR PRIVACY AND SAFETY INTERESTS
OF AN OFFICER.
BY ALLOWING FOR ANY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION INCLUDING.
NAME.
MAY BE REDACTED FROM THE RECORD.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
WE'VE NEVER HAD A BETTER TRAINED
OR EDUCATED LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PERSONNEL YET AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE CHALLENGES BETWEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND EROSION OF TRUST.
TRANSPARENCY AND REALLY HELP
BRING BACK TRUST BACK WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
FROM OUR SENATOR FRIEND.
BERKELEY AFTER MANY YEARS OF
DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE I THINK WE
FINALLY HAVE.
FAIR AND REASONABLE PROPOSAL
BEFORE US WHICH WILL HELP
IMPROVE THE PUBLIC TRUST IN OUR
POLICING ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A MEASURE AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SERVICES BECAUSE THAT IS
LIMITED IN ITS CIRCUMSTANCES --
THE EXAMPLES WHEN THIS CAN BE
YEARS THEY MUST BE SUBSTANTIATED
[inaudible]
SERIOUS SEXUAL VIOLENCE --
INCIDENT SO I MAKE SURE WE
FOCUSED ON ISSUES THAT AREN'T
FALSE CLAIMS THAT REALLY WANTS
THAT ARE ARE FACTUAL AND THAT
ARE SUBSTANTIALLY IN THE PUBLIC
NEEDS TO KNOW.
HOW CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME OF
THE MOST?
SECRETIVE LAWS IN OUR COUNTRY
WHEN IT COMES.
TO PERSONAL RECORDS FOR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
UNFORTUNATELY THIS.
PREVENTS THE PUBLIC AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM LEARNING ABOUT
SOME OF THE BAD ACCIDENTS FROM.
A SMALL AMOUNT OF OFFICERS
MAJORITY OFFICERS I DON'T HAVE
THESE INCIDENTS IN THEIR
PERSONNEL FILES.
BUT THIS HAS LED TO A NUMBER OF
OF ALL [inaudible]
ABLE TO CAN YOU TO CARRY A BADGE
AND AND HAVE THIS.
AN ENORMOUS --
JOB IN OUR IN OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR FOR EXAMPLE AND EXPOSE
BY THE LA TIMES JUST TWO YEARS
AGO FOUND THAT HAVE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY OFFICERS HIRED.
A FEW YEARS EARLIER NINETY SEVEN
SHOWED SIGNS OF DISHONESTY.
NINETY TWO WERE DISCIPLINED BY
OTHER AGENCIES WHILE ON DUTY.
TWENTY NINE WERE FIRED OR RESIGN
FROM OTHER AGENCIES FIFTEEN WERE
FLAGGED FOR TRYING TO MANIPULATE
THE RESULTS OF THE POLYGRAPH
EXAM.
A WE DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA BUT ITS
IT PROBABLY A SAFE BET THAT
THERE ARE A FEW OF THESE
EXAMPLES AND OTHER.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THEY WILL NEVER
KNOW BECAUSE OF THE SECRETS OF
LOS -- THIS --
ERODES THE TRUST OF PUBLIC
SAFETY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AT A TIME WE'RE TRYING TO
INCREASE THE PUBLIC TRUST.
AGAIN THIS IS A REASONED.
I FAIR A PROPOSAL AND I ASK THAT
WE A SUPPORT THIS TODAY AND THIS
ALLOWS US TO SUPPORT THE
MAJORITY OF A LOT FORSMAN
OFFICERS THAT ARE DOING THE
GREAT WORK.
AND FOCUSING ON THE ONES THAT
MAYBE I SHOULDN'T HAVE THIS
IMPORTANT POSITION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I WANT TO FIRST OF ALL COMMEND
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS PARTICULAR DELICATE ISSUE.
AND I THINK THAT --
THIS BILL IS A VERY VERY CLOSE.
TO WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE BUT AS
THE CLICHE GOES CLOSE ONLY
COUNTS IN HORSESHOES AND HAND
GRENADES.
THIS ISN'T IT'S NOT QUITE THERE
AND THIS CAME AT THE VERY LAST
MINUTE.
AND THERE WAS EVEN SOME ADMITTED --
DRAFTING ERRORS BECAUSE IT WAS
RUSHED.
BUT SOMETHING THIS CRITICAL
NEEDS TO BE.
COMPLETELY THOUGHT OUT BY ALL
SIDES AND I THINK THERE HAS BEEN
SOME GREAT COLLABORATION AND
THERE ALSO WAS A GREAT NEED FOR
THIS TYPE OF BILL.
ADMITTEDLY THERE'S BEEN SOME
VERY VERY FRUSTRATING
CIRCUMSTANCES ENSIGN --
BRICK CLEAR ABUSES OF OF THE
POSITION AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT TRUST BILL BACK WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
BUT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
THIS PARTICULAR.
IS THAT IT INDICATES THAT --
THE RELEASE OF THESE VIDEOS.
I CAN ONLY BE.
HELD UP AT THE AGENCY DETERMINES
THAT.
THE DISCLOSURE WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY INTERFERE WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT IN THE WORLD IS
SUBSTANTIALLY MEAN?
I THINK THAT'S A VERY AMBIGUOUS
TERM THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE A LOT
OF PROBLEMS AND I THINK WE CAN
DO BETTER THAN THIS BILL IT'S
VERY VERY CLOSE BUT IT'S NOT
QUITE THERE SO FOR THAT REASON I
CAN'T SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
SUNLIGHT AS THEY SAY IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT.
AND WE HAVE TO STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE IN OUR STATE BETWEEN
PRESERVING CONFIDENTIAL RECORDS
[inaudible]
AND PROTECTING.
A PROCESS FOR THE PEOPLE TO
PROTECT US.
AND GIVING PUBLIC THE RIGHT. TO
ACCESS RECORDS.
POURED OVER THIS ONE CAREFULLY
MEMBERS I READ IT.
TOP TO BOTTOM WORD FOR WORD.
I THOUGHT HARD LONG ABOUT IT AND
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I THINK IT HAS [inaudible]
CRITICAL LIMITATIONS I THINK IT
WILL ALLOW WHERE THERE IS A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION YOU CAN
PUT A PAUSE ON THESE REQUESTS
AND TELL THAT INVESTIGATIONS
OVER.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
AND TO BE CLEAR IT ONLY APPLIES.
THESE RECORDS ARE ONLY AVAILABLE
IN THE FOLLOWING CIRCUMSTANCES.
ONE THE INCIDENT INVOLVED THE
DISCHARGE OF A FIREARM.
AT A PERSON [inaudible] TO THE
USE OF FORCE RESULTED IN DEATH
OR GREAT BODILY INJURY. THREE
THE OFFICER WAS FOUND TO HAVE
COMMITTED SEXUAL ASSAULT ON
SOMEBODY IN CUSTODY.
AND FOR THE OFFICER WAS FOUND TO
HAVE COMMITTED DISHONESTY.
IN AN INVESTIGATION ON THE
WITNESS STAND OR IN A REPORT.
MOST OFFICERS OUT THERE MOST LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS ARE
HONEST HARD WORKING PEOPLE
TRYING TO DO A VERY DIFFICULT
JOB AND KEEP A SAFE.
BUT THERE ARE SOME BAD APPLES.
I THINK THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
PUBLIC TO ACCESS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT IF YOU DISCHARGE A FIREMAN
A PERSON IN LINE OF DUTY.
I'VE KNOWN CONSERVE DONE THAT.
THAT MESSES WITH YOUR HEAD.
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS WRONG IT'S
ALWAYS IT'S OFTEN JUSTIFIED.
AND THAT SHOULD COME OUT.
THE THE INVESTIGATION THAT
CLEARS THE OFFICER THAT WAS
JUSTIFIED DISCHARGING A FIREARM.
THAT SHOULD COME OUT PEOPLE
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S WHY THE POLICE CHIEF
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THEM ON BOARD
SAY YES THIS IS THE RIGHT
COMPROMISE THE STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE.
I'M NOT GOING TO PRETEND TO YOU
THAT THIS IS AN EASY VOTE IT'S A
TOUGH VOTE.
BUT I THINK THE SENATOR HAS DONE
A VERY VERY GOOD JOB AND WORKED
WITH A LOT OF INTEREST GROUPS.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU SEE IN
FRONT OF YOU.
IT'S PROBABLY STRIKING THE BEST
BALANCE WE CAN STRIKE AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT I'M
GOING TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LACKEY SPEAK AGAIN. TO MAKE A
CLARIFYING POINT.
YEAH MEMBERS DIE JUST FOR
INFORMATION I SPOKE TO A
DIFFERENT BILL.
THAT'S AUTHORED BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING THAT WILL
BE UP COMING.
AND NOT TO THIS BILL I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY DISCOUNT EVERYTHING I
SAID [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING NOT
PERMISSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER LET'S BILL DOES A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS ARE STILL SOMETHING
TO BE WORKED ON MY CONCERN IS
WILL PUBLIC EXPLODES LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHISTLE BLOWERS.
SCOURGE HIM FOR MAKING DECISION
REPORT THE MOST SERIOUS OFFENSES
OF MISCONDUCT.
AND LETTER TO THE JOURNAL HAVE
NO LEGAL STANDING.
IF BE FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE CURLY
CONTAINS A PROVISION THAT WOULD
IDENTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO HAVE THE COURAGE TO
REPORT.
MISCONDUCT OF OTHER OFFICERS.
THE PROVISION EXPOSES
WHISTLEBLOWERS [inaudible]
OBJECTIVE STANDARD AND WHETHER
THEIR DIGNITY IS RELEASED OR
REDACTED [inaudible]
THE PROVISION --
PROVIDES NO PROTECTION FROM THE
IDENTITY OF A WHISTLEBLOWER
BECAUSE DISTINCT CASES A
MISCONDUCT OR HIGH PROFILE FROM
THE ORGANIZATION.
IN THE HUGE AUTHORS WILL KNOW
WHO WAS THERE AND WHO WASN'T.
IT A TIME IT IS NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARD THE DUTIES
OF WHISTLEBLOWERS.
THIS BILL FALLS VERY SHORT.
IMPROVE PUBLIC TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT BY ENCOURAGING MORE
WHISTLEBLOWING OF MISCONDUCT IN
NOT LESS.
THANK YOU I AM NOT SEEING ANY
OTHER REQUEST TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM.
I WILL RETURN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING FIRST CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU BOTH SPEAKER JUST --
TO TO JUST ADDRESS THE POINT OF
MY DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE FROM
ELK GROVE OF THE BILL EXPLICITLY
STATES IN SECTION TO BE.
FIVE FIVE OUR AGENCY SHOULDER
DOCTOR RECORD DISCLOSE PURSUANT
TO THIS SECTION ONLY FOR ANY OF
THE FOLLOWING PURPOSES. TO
PRESERVE THE ANONYMITY OF
COMPLAINTS AND WITNESSES SO
THEREFORE S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE EXPLICITLY REQUIRES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES REDACT ALL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION.
HAVE ANY FELLOW OFFICER WHO
LODGES A COMPLAINT AGAINST OR
REPORTS MISCONDUCT OF A FELLOW
OFFICER.
BUT BUT THAT'S MAJORITY AGAIN
GOING BACK TO THIS POINT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICE HAVE EXCELLENT
RECORDS.
HAVE NEVER USED SERIOUS FORCE
PROVIDING A LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY CREATE BETTER TRUST
AS WELL AS ACCOUNTABILITY
BETWEEN LOCAL AGENCIES AND THE
COMMUNITIES.
THEY SERVE THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ITEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ABOUT IN HER PLEASE OPEN THERE
ARE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM.
NINETY TWO S. B. TWELVE FORTY
NINE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
SEVERAL TWELVE FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR CALLED YANNI AND
ACTUALLY THE ANIMAL TESTING.
THANK YOU A SOME MEMBER COLOR
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SENATE BILL
TWELVE FORTY NINE PERTAINING TO
THE SALE OF COSMETICS.
BRINGS CALIFORNIA'S HUMANE
STANDARDS IN LINE WITH THE
WORLD'S HIGHEST BY PROHIBITING
THE SALE OF COSMETICS THAT HAVE
BEEN TESTED ON ANIMALS.
THE MEASURES TAKEN SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS THAT NOW FOCUSED A
PROHIBITION ON ANIMAL TESTING ON
MANUFACTURERS AND THEIR
SUPPLIERS.
THIS SUPPLY CHAIN FOCUSES HELPED
REMOVE THE MAJORITY OF
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION AND I
WANT TO COMMEND ALL SIZE THAT
HAVE COME TOGETHER. TO GET US
WHERE WE ARE TODAY INCLUDING OF
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL --
WHO'S WORKED TREMENDOUSLY HARD
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN BRING THIS
TO THE FLOOR OF THE LEGISLATURE.
SP TWELVE FORTY NINE KEEPS
EXISTING PRODUCTS ON
CALIFORNIA'S SHELVES AND ONLY
ADDRESSES NEW PRODUCTS AND
INGREDIENTS THAT GO TO MARKET
AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY ANY PRODUCT ON THE
SHELF TODAY IS GRANDFATHERED
WILL NOT HAVE TO BE REMOVED.
S. B. TWELVE FORTY NINE ALLOWS
ANIMAL TESTING THAT IS MANDATED
BY GOVERNMENT REGULATORY
AGENCIES --
BUT ULTIMATELY THE CORE OF THIS
BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT COSMETICS
THAT ARE SOLD.
OF THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
[inaudible]
DO NOT.
CONTAINED PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
BEEN TESTED ON ANIMALS.
AND I THINK IT'S A HUGE
STATEMENT THAT WERE MAKING AS A
STATEMENT GIVEN THE SIZE OF OUR
MARKET I'M HOPING THAT'LLHELP
MOVE THE GLOBAL CONVERSATION.
ON THE USE OF ANIMALS IN TESTING
FOR COSMETICS.
PEOPLE USE COSMETICS FOR A LOT
OF REASONS BUT I OFTENTIMES.
PEOPLE USE COSMETICS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO LOOK GOOD AND
BECAUSE IT MAKES THEM FEEL GOOD.
BUT NO MATTER HOW GOOD YOU LOOK.
YOU CANNOT FEEL GOOD IF THE
PRODUCTS YOU'RE PUTTING ON YOUR
BODY.
ARE THE PRODUCT OF TESTING ON
ANIMALS.
AND SO I'M ENCOURAGING EVERYONE
TO VOTE AYE ON THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THIS IS THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR CALIFORNIA
TO MOVE IN AND WE KNOW THIS IS
THE BEST THING WE CAN DO TO
PROTECT ANIMALS AS WELL AS MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE FEEL GOOD.
ABOUT THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY'RE
USING ON THEIR OWN BODY BUT THAT
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
CRITICAL BILL. TO PROTECT
ANIMALS WHO WERE NOT ABLE TO
SPEAK OUR ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES.
THIS BILL MAKES IMPORTANT GAINS
FOR ANIMAL WELFARE STANDARDS AND
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA COMPANIES TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS.
SOME OF THE LARGEST COSMETIC
MANUFACTURERS HAVE BEEN CRUELTY
FREE FOR YEARS.
AN ALTERNATIVE METHODS OF
TESTING NOT ONLY FOR COSMETICS
BUT FOR OTHER INDUSTRIES.
IS A GROWING JOBS SECTOR
[inaudible]
MEMBERS CRUELTY FREE LIVING IS A
DECISION. TO RESPECT APPRECIATE
AND LOVE LIFE [inaudible]
ALL LIFE.
EVEN THE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG
US.
IT IS BEEN SAID IN MANY WAYS.
THAT POSITIVE CHANGE BEGINS WITH
FINDING KINDNESS WITHIN
OURSELVES.
SO THAT WE COULD SHARE OUR
AFFECTION.
WITH OTHER LIVING THINGS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT AND
HISTORIC LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THINK YOU A SOME EVER
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER JUST REAL BRIEFLY ONE
AND TWO I STAND UP AND SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL --
AS A FATHER TO TO NAY TWO
TEENAGE DAUGHTERS --
WERE BEGINNING THIS WHOLE MAKE
UP THING.
AND DIE.
AND THAT WE'RE WORKING THROUGH
IT -- I'VE.
ENCOURAGED THEM --
ON THE CRUELTY FREE CHOICES I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT AND THIS
WILL MAKE AVAILABLE MANY MORE
OPTIONS FOR CONSUMERS AYE AND
CALIFORNIA SO VERY PLEASED TO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU I AM NOT SEEING ANY
FURTHER REQUESTS AUTUMN I DO SEE
A FOR THE REQUEST TO SPEAK.
SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT BILL I REALLY --
ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR --
THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON FOR
FOR REALLY LISTENING AND WE HAD
A ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS.
AND APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
A LOT OF THE AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN I THINK IT IT'S A GOOD
BILL.
I'M I'D ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IT THAT
IMPLEMENTATION DATES A LITTLE
BIT OFF BUT I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
EVEN NOW --
THAT PURCHASE COSMETICS TO TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE ARE BRANDS
AVAILABLE THAT ARE ARE A CRUELTY
FREE AND THAT WE CAN LOOK FOR
THAT NOW IN RT I TAKE THOSE
STEPS TO REALLY IN SHORT.
THAT WE SHOULD BE --
SOMETIMES ANIMALS HAVE TO BE
TESTED FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
AND MEDICAL RESEARCH UP BUT WE
DON'T HAVE TO TEST.
ANIMALS TO MAKE SURE MY MASCARA
STAYS ON ALL DAY OR BECAUSE MY
BLUSH SHOULD BE THE RIGHT COLOR
SO THIS GOES A LONG WAY --
TO PROTECTING ANIMALS EN AND I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THIS.
ONE THANK YOU PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECT TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
MEMBERS.
NEXT WE'RE MOVING TO A SOME EVER
ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALIVE
APPRECIATE THE TIME TODAY --
I RISE TODAY IS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF S. B. TWELVE FORTY
NINE YOU KNOW THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN --
LEGISLATION HAS A LOCAL A FACT
OR HAS A STATEWIDE A FACT.
THIS WILL HAVE A NATIONAL IN
FACT IN FACT IN THE CRAFTING OF
THIS LEGISLATION IT'S HAD AN
INTERNATIONAL A FACT BECAUSE WE
HAVE INTERNATIONAL ISSUES THAT
CAME INTO PLAY --
YOU KNOW I I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND OF COURSE THE FOR
MANAGER FOR BRINGING THE SPORT
WILL FOR BUT THIS BILL HELPS
CALIFORNIA BE A MORE
COMPASSIONATE PLACE FOR ALL OF
OUR ANIMALS.
YOU KNOW FROM THE BEGINNING S.
B. TWELVE FORTY NINE SCHOOL WISE.
TO YOU KNOW TO ENSURE THAT WE
PUT A STOP TO ANIMAL TESTING --
WITH REGARD TO COSMETICS PROFIT
PRODUCTS AND IT'S REALLY BEEN
WORTHY OF THIS BODIES ATTENTION
AND AND WHAT ATTENTION THAT IT
IS HAD.
I'D LIKE TO APPLY THE YOU KNOW
THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK IN IT
ALSO INVOLVING A MY OFFICE AND I
APPRECIATE THE IN THE EFFORTS BY
ALL TO GET INVOLVED HERE.
YOU KNOW INITIALLY THIS BILL HAD
SOME ISSUES AND SO IMPORTANT
ISSUES TO RESOLVE.
BUT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
WINDOW THAT THE PRODUCT THAT YOU
SEE HERE TODAY I HAVE --
OF FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT THAT
WERE ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE
WE'RE PLEASED THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
BRING THEM TOGETHER --
AND TAKE TWO OF THE BILL THAT
YOU SEE THAT TODAY'S THE FINAL
PRODUCT.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IT ADDRESSES
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY'S CONCERN
AND ALSO THE COMPETE CONCERNS OF
THOSE OF US.
THAT A LOVE OUR PETS AND CARE
ABOUT THE ANIMALS THAT WE THAT
WE ALL OUR LOVE --
AYE IRONICALLY YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A LOT OF OF RESCUES --
IN MY HOUSE WE HAD FIVE DOGS
SINCE MY WIFE AND I'VE BEEN
MARRIED.
AND THEY'VE ALL BEEN RESCUES OF
OF ONE FORM ANOTHER AND FOUR OF
THEM HAVE BEEN VEHICLES AND YOU
KNOW I THE STORY BEHIND BEAGLES
AN ANIMAL TESTING SO IT REALLY --
PLACE VERY CLOSE TO OUR FOR SEE
IF YOU ONCE AND FOR ALL IN
THIS BILL S. B. TWELVE FORTY
NINE IS ANOTHER GREAT EXAMPLE OF
WHAT YOU CAN ACCOMPLISH WHEN WE
ALL WORK TOGETHER AND WE BRING
EVERYBODY ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER.
AND OUT AND MAKE SURE THAT THESE
THINGS GET OUT WITH THE RIGHT
PRODUCT WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME ON AND I'M TRULY PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHOR ON S. B. TWELVE
FORTY NINE IN ANCHORAGE DRIVE
OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE FORTY NINE ALSO WAS
THE FATHER OF TWO TEENAGE
DAUGHTERS.
WHO ARE NOT JUST FIGURING OUT
THE COSMIC BEING THERE WELL INTO
THE COSMIC BEING?
I LIKE TO ALIGN MY REMARKS A TO
THOSE OF MY DISTINGUISHED
COLLEAGUES EASY INFORMAL CHAIR
OF THE TWO TEEN DAUGHTERS CAUCUS.
THAT.
FOLKS TO MAKE COSMETIC CHAU
SUZETTE COULD BE DONE HUMANELY
AND I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
AUTHOR.
WHO WAS ABLE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND A WIN WIN A
FOR ALL INVOLVED I'M STRICTLY
AFTER I VOTE?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS --
YOU KNOW MY FAMILY MIGHT MY WIFE
AND I WE DO A LOT OF ANIMAL
RESCUE [inaudible]
AND QUITE FRANKLY I I TALK TO
HER ABOUT THIS BILL AND AND I
LIKE MANY OTHERS I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER ON THIS --
I I AM A LITTLE JELLIES BECAUSE
I DIDN'T GET TO ME --
MISS SILVERSTONE WHEN SHE WAS IN
THE BUILDING --
BECAUSE MY WIFE IS A HUGE FAN.
BUT THE IT YOU KNOW FROM LEGALLY
BLONDE TWO I KNOW BRUISER WOODS
WOULD BE APPRECIATE OF OF THIS
BILL.
AND QUITE FRANKLY I I WOULD BE
CLUELESS. TWO WHY ANYBODY
WOULDN'T VOTE FOR THIS LAST FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MEMBERS IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK PLEASE PUT UP
YOUR MIKES NOW OTHERWISE I'M
GOING TO BE GOING BACK TO MISTER.
KALRA FOR HIS CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWELVE SIX TWELVE FORTY NINE I
THINK AT THE BEGINNING EVERYBODY
WAS A COMPLETELY IN FAVOR OF THE
CONCEPT.
THE GOOD SENATOR HIT INTRODUCED.
WHAT I WANT TO COMMEND HER ALSO
FOR WORKING WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS? TO NOW PUT
TOGETHER A BILL.
THAT INCLUDES EVERYONE BUT
REMAINS TRUE TO THE VERY
[inaudible]
CONCEPT SHE WANTED TO TAKE CARE
FROM THE BEGINNING IS TO STOP
ANIMAL TESTING.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU SEEING NOFURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO A SUM EVER KALRA CHRIS
CLOSING BECAUSE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES WHO.
HAVE SPOKEN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AND I JUST WANT TO CLOSE AGAIN
BY THANKING OF SENATOR GALGIANI
AND HER TEAM IN THE WORK THAT
WAS PUT INTO MAKING SURE WE TO
BRING EVERYONE TOGETHER. FOR
THIS IMPORTANT BECAUSE I AND I
ALSO WANT TO THANK SUCH
COMPASSION THE LEGISLATION AND
OF HERE ON THE FLOOR I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM ESCONDIDO WHO'S BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL FROM DAY
ONE I THINK IN CHAU.
BUT HAS SHOWN THAT WORKING
TOGETHER IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION
WE CAN DO RIGHT BY THE ANIMALS
AND BY THE INDUSTRY AT THE SAME
TIME AND SO WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BOTH THINK YOU MADAM CURCUMIN
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE FOR THIS
ARTICLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE.
YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTES I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING NOW BACK IN FILE
ORDER TO ITEM.
EIGHTY TWO AS SHE ARE.
TWENTY NINE QUIRK THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
NINE BY SENATOR PAN OF RELATIVE
TO IMMIGRATION.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER CARILLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENTS SJR TWENTY NINE THE
BEHALF OF SENATOR PAN.
SJR CALLS UPON THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS TO ISSUE A FORMAL
APOLOGY TO ALL IMMIGRANT
DETAINEES WERE FORCIBLY
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS.
AS A RESULT OF THE INHUMANE ZERO
TOLERANCE BORDER POLICIES.
IN APRIL OF THIS YEAR THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATIONS POLICIES
DIRECTLY LEAD TO THE FORCIBLE
SEPARATION.
OF OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
INFANTS AND CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
THE SQUIRREL PRACTICES SEPARATE.
FROM THEIR FAMILIES CAN AND WILL
LEAD TO PROLONGED PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH RISK ASSOCIATED
WITH THE EXPOSURE.
OF HIGH LEVELS OF STRESS IN
CHILDHOOD.
THE ACTIVE SEPARATING A SON OR
DAUGHTER FROM THEIR MOTHER OR
FROM THEIR FATHER IT'S A
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE.
THAT WILL TAKE YEARS TO RECOVER
FROM IF EVER.
THE CRITICISM HAS BEEN SO
WIDESPREAD.
THAT EVEN WORLD LEADERS SUCH AS
THE UNITED NATIONS HUMAN RIGHTS
OFFICE OF THE HIGH COMMISSIONER.
HAVE CHARACTERIZE THESE ACTIONS
ASSYRIANS VIOLATIONS OF RIGHTS
OF THE CHILD AND I MADAM CHAIR
IF I CAN ASK FOR THE CHAMBER TO
PLEASE --
MEMBERS LET'S BE IN ORDER LET'S
LET'S PLEASE KEEP IT TOGETHER
STAY IN ORDER TO GIVE RESPECT TO
YOU'RE CALLING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE AT THE COUNTRY.
SHOULD HOLD OURSELVES TO A
HIGHER STANDARD AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THESE MORAL FAILURES WHEN THEY
OCCUR.
WE HAVE APOLOGIZED FOR THE
WRONGS WE HAVE COMMITTED BEFORE.
THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION
APOLOGIZED FOR THE INTERNMENT OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS DURING WORLD
WAR.
TWO AND THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TEST THE EXPERIMENTS OF THE
NINETEEN FORTIES.
WITH S. J. ARE.
TWENTY NINE WE ASK CONGRESS TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE SHAMEFUL
VIOLATIONS OF HUMAN RIGHTS
[inaudible]
AGAINST CHILDREN.
AND THE DIGNITY THAT THEY HAVE
TAKEN PLACE.
THE INDIGNITY THAT HAS OCCURRED
ACROSS OUR BORDERS.
MEMBERS THIS IS NOT A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WHICH SIDE OF
THE AISLE USE THAT ON THIS IS
ABOUT OUR VALUES AS A NATION.
AND IF YOU PERHAPS MAKE ME.
UP ASSERTION THAT THIS IS A
CRITIQUE OF THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION LET ME JUST TELL
YOU THAT I HAVE PERSONALLY BEEN
CRITICAL OF THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION. FOR SIMILAR
WRONGDOINGS.
BUT THE ACT THAT HAVE OCCURRED
RATE LATELY IN RECENT MONTHS.
HAVE FAR SURPASSED.
WHO WE ARE AS A NATION?
AND SO I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
VOTE AYE.
ON THIS RESOLUTION.
HISTORY HAS ITS I ON ALL OF US
AT THE MOMENT AND HOW WE RESPOND
AND HOW WE ACT.
IN HOW WE TREAT CHILDREN.
SAYS A LOT ABOUT WHO WE ARE.
THE NATION THAN WE HOPE WE ARE
IN THE NATION THAT WE HOPE TO BE.
SOME I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SJR [inaudible]
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
FIFTY TWO S. C. ARE ONE FIFTEEN
ABOUT OF HER PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
RELATIVE TO THE OPIOID CRISIS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR MCGUIRE TO
PRESENT.
SCR ONE FIFTEEN WHICH RECOGNIZES
THE IMPACT OF OPIOID RELATED
DEATHS HAVE HAD ON OUR FAMILIES
NEIGHBORS AND COMMUNITIES.
THE CURRENT OPIOID EPIDEMIC HAS
BEEN DECLARED THE WORST DRUG
CRISIS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
S. C. R. ONE FIFTEEN RECOGNIZES
THE DRAMATIC IMPACT OPIOID
RELATED DEATHS HAVE HAD ON OUR
STATE AND HOW THESE DEATHS HAVE
STRAINED OUR HEALTHCARE SAFETY
NET.
AND OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MR ADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY ONE KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING.
BACK AND FILE ORDER TO ITEM
FORTY SEVEN SP.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE BY SENATOR MITCHELL AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY TO SENTENCING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARISE PRESENT SP.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE A MODERATE
REFORM OF A SINGLE SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT.
THAT ARE INCREASE THE FAIRNESS
OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE BILL RESTORES THE COURT'S
DISCRETION IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE AND AT THE TIME OF
SENTENCING TO STRIKE A FIVE YEAR
SENTENCE WOULD PASS HANDS MEANT
FOR SERIOUS.
FELONY CONVICTIONS.
WHILE MOST SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS
CAN BE DECLINED IF THE JUDGE
BELIEVES THEY'RE UNJUST.
A FIVE YEAR AND HAS BEEN IS
MANDATORY IN ALL CASES THAT IS
APPLIED CONSECUTIVELY FOR EACH
CONVICTION.
THIS ON TOP OF THE BASINS
QUICKLY ADDS UP TO TEN FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY YEAR SENTENCES.
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS
CONSISTENTLY RESULT NO LONGER
PERIODS OF INCARCERATION AND ARE
THE MAIN CONTRIBUTORS TO PRISON
OVERCROWDING.
BUT RESTORING THE COURT'S
DISCRETION LEUCHARS HURT BECAME
RETURNED TO A SPACE WHERE JUDGES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TAILOR
SENTENCES DEPICT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
LENGTHY PRISON TERMS DON'T DETER
CRIMES THEY DON'T REDUCE
RECIDIVISM OF THEY DON'T HELP
REHABILITATION BUT THEY DO LEAD
TO OUR BROKEN FAMILIES HIGH
FINANCIAL BURDENS AND LACK OF OP
OPPORTUNITY.
A FAIR AND JUST DESPAIR AND JUST
SENTENCING REFORM WAS SIMPLY
RETURN JUDICIAL DISCRETION. TO
THE JUDGE'S HANDS WHICH WAS IN
EFFECT BEFORE.
THE MASS INCARCERATION PUBLIC
POLICIES.
PASSED OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES.
I HAVE LITERALLY BEEN IN
COURTROOMS WHERE HAVE SEEN
JUDGES.
NEAR INTENDED NEARLY IN TEARS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO STRIKE
THESE ENHANCEMENTS AND THEY KNOW
THAT EVEN IF THEY'RE GIVING A
BASE TERM OF THREE OR FIVE YEARS.
ON A CONVICTION WHICH FITS THE
CRIME.
BUT THEY MAY BE SENTENCING
SOMEONE.
TO OFTENTIMES IT TO BE FIVE TEN
OR FIFTEEN YEARS --
BUT ADDED TO THAT BECAUSE OF
THIS FIVE YEAR ENHANCEMENT.
AND SO THIS JUST MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT
[inaudible]
GET IT.
THOSE THAT DON'T.
POLICE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAL TO A JUDGE WHO VERY WELL
STILL MAY.
THEN FORCES BUT A LEASE THE
JUDGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
ALL SIDES IN A VALUE IT THE CASE
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
NOT STRIPPING THE POWER AWAY
FROM THE JUDGES [inaudible]
AND HAVING.
INDIVIDUALS LOCKED UP FOR MANY
MORE YEARS.
THEN WHAT FITS THE CRIME FOR
WHICH THEY'RE CONVICTED WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AIBO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I RISE SAW IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
I STAND WITH THE AYE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA STATE THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
LOS ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
LOS ANGELES ALL PARTIES.
PROTECTIVE OF THE PEACE OFFICERS
ALSO RESEARCH.
WHAT'S YOUR THEORY CHERNOBYL
CALIFORNIA.
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THIS BILL
IS TAUGHT YET AND OTHER.
SOFT ON CRIME MANAGERS.
NOT WATER ON ME RE WORD.
SYRIA THE OFFENDERS.
BY DEFINITION THIS BILL REDUCES
SAW SENTENCES. FOR REPEAT FELONS.
WE HAVE A COMMITTED A SERIOUS
FELONIES.
ALL OF THIS SERIOUS OF FOUND ON
THIS ARE VERY DISTURBING
OFFENSES [inaudible]
MOSTLY INVOLVING.
VIOLET VIOLENCE SO WHAT THREATS
ALTHOUGH VIOLENCE SO AGAIN SO
INDIVIDUALS.
IF YOU HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO BE
CARILLO CRIMINAL.
CRIMINAL REPEAT TO HER.
FOUND ON WHAT THE THAT NIGHT YOU
SHOULD NOT EXPECT A TO BE
[inaudible]
LET OF EASY.
I ASK MY COLLEAGUES A FULL.
NO ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN.
I GUESS WE'RE DONE WITH THE FEEL
GOOD BILLS WERE NOW BACK TO THE
LET'S WHAT ALL THE CRIMINALS OUT
OF JAIL BILLS SO --
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT IS A
SERIOUS FELONY.
SOME EXAMPLES FOR YOU.
MURDER.
OR VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER
[inaudible]
RAPE.
SODOMY BY FORCE.
ORAL COPULATION BY FORCE.
LEWD AND LASCIVIOUS ACTS ON A
CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF FOURTEEN
ATTEMPTED MURDER.
ARSON.
EXPLODING A DESTRUCTIVE DEVICE.
THE PRESSURE COOKER BOMB THAT
REMIND YOU OF ANYTHING
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED A SERIOUS FELONY FOR
WHICH THE AUTHOR BELIEVES THAT
SOMEONE SHOULD HAVE A LESSER
SENTENCE FOR HAVING COMMITTED
THESE CRIMES SO TELL ME AGAIN.
HOW YOU THINK THAT --
AS SOMEONE WHO MOLEST CHILDREN.
SHOULD BE GIVEN A LIGHTER
SENTENCE TELL ME HOW YOU THINK
SOMEONE WHO RAPES IN EIGHTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD WOMAN IN HER HOME.
WHAT IS THAT PERSON DESERVE A
LATER SENTENCE?
SO SINCE NO ONE ELSE ONCE AGAIN
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THE VICTIMS
THEN I WILL [inaudible]
TRUST ME.
WHEN I SAY THIS TO YOU?
YOU HAVE DONE ENOUGH THIS WEEK
TO CODDLE CRIMINALS.
HOW ABOUT WE TAKE A BREAK HERE
GIVE IT A REST AND VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM
LOCKER DOUGH.
I THINK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB. THIRTEEN NINETY THREE TO
THOSE OF YOU WHO SAY JUDICIAL
DISCRETION RESULTS IN BY A
SENTENCING.
THERE IS SOME TRUTH TO THAT.
WE SEE THAT EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY WHERE THERE IS DISCRETION
THERE A STATISTICAL BIAS AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINOS.
FROM THE MOMENT OF AN ENCOUNTER
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN OFFICER
DECIDES WHETHER TO PULL SOMEONE
OVER NOT AN OFFICER DECIDES
WHETHER OR NOT TO ARREST.
pPROSECUTORS DECISION TO CHARGE
OR NOT PROSECUTORS DECISION ON
WHETHER TO APPLY ENHANCEMENTS OR
STACK THE CHARGES AND THE
COURT'S DECISION ABOUT THE
SEVERITY OF THE PENALTY.
THIS BILL.
ADDRESSES ONE STEP IN THAT CHAIN.
CURRENTLY THE PROSECUTORS HAVE
ALL THE DISCRETION IF THEY
CHOOSE TO CHARGE THE ENHANCEMENT
THE JUDGE'S HANDS ARE TIED.
THEY HAVE TO IMPOSE THE
ENHANCEMENT.
IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW
PROSECUTORS WILL CONTINUE TO
HALF THEY HAVE IN THE PAST.
USE THEIR DISCRETION AS THEY DO
TODAY TO SEEK THE ENHANCEMET
BUT JUDGES.
THE ONES WE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
WILL ALSO HAVE THE DISCRETION TO
IMPLY TO APPLY THE ENHANCEMENT
OR NOT.
THE EVIDENCE IS VERY CLEAR
MANDATORY MINIMUMS TRUTH IN
SENTENCING DETERMINANT SENTENCES
AND MANDATORY ENHANCEMENTS HAVE
DEVASTATED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES SOMEHOW THE CURE FOR
BIAS ONLY MADE THINGS WORSE.
WE SHOULD FIND REASONABLE
INCREMENTAL BILLS LIKE THIS ONE
TO HELP ON WINE THE LEGACY OF
MASS INCARCERATION AND THE
MISTAKES OF PRIOR GENERATIONS OF
LEGISLATORS.
THESE PRIOR GENERATIONS OF
LAWMAKERS WERE NOT AS DIVERSE AS
WE ARE NOW.
THERE WERE FEWER WOMEN IN THERE
WERE FEWER PEOPLE OF COLOR THERE
WAS NOT AN OUT LGBTQ MEMBER
UNTIL SENATOR SHEILA KEWL IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR THERE WAS
NOT ONE INDIAN AMERICAN MEMBER
UNTIL TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH KALRA WAS
ELECTED.
LAWMAKERS IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES WERE LESS DIVERSE AND
DID NOT BENEFIT FROM THE WEALTH
OF RESEARCH THAT WE HAVE TODAY
TO EVALUATE THE EFFECT OF GET
TOUGH ON CRIME POLICIES.
SO IT FALLS ON US TO ADDRESS THE
BIASES AND LACK OF KNOWLEDGE OF
THOSE PRIOR GENERATIONS OF
LAWMAKERS LET'S DO THE RIGHT
THING TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE AS A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE
HERE FROM THE LOS ANGELES AREA
WHO HAS PROBABLY SHARED MOST OF
THE RESEARCH AND INFORMATION I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU.
BUT ALSO REMIND YOU THAT
PROBABLY WHAT AND COUPLE HOURS
AGO THE COMET WAS MAY ON THE
OTHER SIDE THAT WE NEED TO GIVE
THE JUDGES THE DISCRETION.
BECAUSE THE OTHER ONE WAS DOING
SOME OTHER THINGS AND WE SAID
WAIT A MINUTE WE WERE MOVING IN
A DIRECTION OF JUDGE DISCRETION.
AND THAT IS TRUE AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE ENHANCEMENTS.
IT DOES NOT ELIMINATE ALL THE
OTHER THINGS THAT PEOPLE WANT TO
DO BUT IT SAYS THAT IN THE END.
IT JUDGE SHOULD HAVE THE
DECISION A A TO DO ACCEPT OR
REJECT THE ENHANCEMENT THAT IS
BEING RECOMMENDED BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AS THERE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE EVER
BEEN IN A COURTROOM AND YOU'VE
SEEN WHAT HAPPENS IS ALMOST AS
LIKE A MATH GAME THERE'S THREE
PUT THIS THIS FOR FOR THAT THIS
FIVE WITH THI THAT.
AND I'M JUST BUT NO WOULDN'T AND
I WAS IN ONE COURT ROOM WHERE
SOMEONE HAD A CALCULATOR AND
THEY WERE ACTUALLY CALCULATING
THE YEARS OR HOW MUCH TIME A
PERSON HAVE TO SERVE IN THE NECK
AT SUBTRACT TWO YEARS FOR THIS
OF I MEAN.
THE THE CONCEPT OF JUDGING AND
JUDICIAL DISCRETION HAS BEEN
TAKEN OUT BECAUSE OF ALL THE
MATH AND WE GIVE THEM IN TERMS
OF HOW YOU.
CALCULATE WHO DESERVES TO SPEND
MORE TIME AND WHO DOES NOT SO I
THINK IT IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
THAT IF WE GO BACK AND SAY TO
OURSELVES AS WE SAID A FEW
MINUTES AGO AGAINST THE OTHER
BILL.
THAT WE WON AT THE JUDGES TO
HAVE THE DISK [inaudible]
SOME DISCRETION.
EVERYONE ELSE STILL HAS THE
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY THE THE
SENTENCING THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
TO A BASICALLY ASK FOR
ENHANCEMENTS ALL THAT IS THERE
BUT RIGHT NOW THE LAW SAYS A
JUDGE CANNOT.
CANNOT REMOVE AN ENHANCEMENT
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THAT HE
SHOULD HAVE THAT DISCRETION OR
HERE SHE SAID HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO SAY OKAY IN THIS
CASE.
WE SHOULD DO TEN YEARS OF
ENHANCEMENT BUT WE SHOULD DO
FIVE OR MAYBE THEY SHOULD BE
ENHANCEMENT BASED ON SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS GIVES A JUDGE
SOME DISCRETION TO BASICALLY
DEAL WITH THE INDIVIDUAL CASE
AND THE NEEDS AT A VIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT I BOTH
S. B. THIRTEEN NOT EIGHTY THREE
IN THIS IS NOT BEING SOFT ON
CRIME THIS IS BEING REASONABLE
ABOUT WHAT WE THINK IS IMPORTANT
AND HOW WE PLAN TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BOTH THE THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL IS
SOFT ON CRIME I'M TIRED OF THESE
CONTINUED MEASURES THAT KEEP
GETTING INTRODUCED IN THIS
CHAMBER.
THEY'RE MAKING IT EASIER TO MOVE
PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON OUT OF JAIL
WHO SHOULD BE THERE AND OUT ONTO
OUR STREETS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NOT NO VOTE.
I AM NOT SEEING ANY.
FURTHER REQUEST TO SPEAK IF I'M
WRONG SOMEONE WILL WAVERED ME.
OKAY WE WILL RETURN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA FOR HIS CLOSING
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THINK SO
TO MY COLLEAGUES FROM LOS
ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
[inaudible] FOR SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT.
THESE MANDATORY SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS AS WE'VE HEARD OF
CREATED A HARSH.
AND ARBITRATION SUMMER
PUNISHMENT IS DISPROPORTIONATE.
TO A POOR PERSON'S CULPABILITY
DO NOT SERVE THE INTERESTS OF
JUSTICE AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
CONTRARY OF BIRDS TO COLLEAGUES
IN OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REDUCE ANYONE
SENTENCES.
HE GIVES JUDGES THE DISCRETION
TO ACTUALLY.
DECIDE A SENTENCE THAT FITS THE
CRIME FOR WHICH SOMEONE IS BEING
PROSECUTED. FOR ELEVEN YEARS.
I WAS IN THE COURTROOM.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND I'VE SEEN HOW JUSTICE IS
METED OUT.
AND I'VE SEEN THE FRUSTRATIONS
[inaudible]
A JUDGE'S.
WHO HAD THEIR HANDS TIED AND
I'LL TELL YOU CAN LIST
[inaudible]
I'LL AN ARBITRARY PICK OUT SOME
SERIOUS FELONIES FOR WHICH WE
KNOW.
THE FIVE YEARS IS NOT GOING TO
BE STRICKEN.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT THERE
ARE PLENTY [inaudible]
OF SITUATIONS INCLUDING
SITUATIONS IN WHICH VICTIMS COME
FORWARD AND ASK FOR MORE
LENIENCY.
THEN THE SENTENCE THAT'S BEING
IMPOSED.
BUT EVEN THEIR VOICE CAN'T BE
HEARD IN THE SITUATIONS IN WHICH
IN WHICH THEY MORE LENIENCY THE
REALITY IS THAT WE NEED TO HEAR
EVERYONE'S VOICES CERTAINLY THE
VICTIMS.
CERTAINLY THE PROSECUTORS WHO
ARE THE ONES THAT ACTUALLY MAKE
THE DECISION.
AS TO WHETHER. TO CHARGE THESE
ENHANCEMENTS.
AND THEY DO QUITE FREELY.
BUT WE NEED [inaudible]
SOME [inaudible]
JUDGE. TO MAKE THE DECISION AS
TO WHETHER THE ENHANCEMENT FITS
THE CRIME.
WE NEED TO GIVE OUR JUDGES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT HAVE ALL
SIZE BE HEARD ON THE MATTER AND
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU [inaudible]
ONE THING [inaudible]
IS THAT.
JUDGES ARE BEING SOFT ON FOLKS
THAT HAVE.
SERIOUS FELONIES ARE CONTINUE.
TO COMMIT SERIOUS FELONIES.
GOING TO A COURT OF HOW WATCH
EVERY DAY AND YOU'LL SEE THAT TO
BE THE CASE.
SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WRITE.
THE SYSTEM IN TERMS ADDITION
DISCRETION TO GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR DISCRETION TO
NOT LET ANYONE OFF THE HOOK.
BUT TO LET JUDGES ACTUALLY DO
THEIR JOB WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY BOOK.
THANK YOU MADAM PURPOSE OPEN THE
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER KALRA MOVE THE CALL
AS WE
ARE MOVING NOW FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
FIVE FOR SIXTY MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY BY
SENATOR DALY OUT AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO THE INTERNET.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AS BEFORE
SIXTY WHICH REQUIRES ISPS THAT
ENTER INTO STATE CONTRACTS TO IT
HERE TO NET NEUTRALITY
PRINCIPLES THIS BILL.
IS A COMPANION BILL TO SENATOR
WINNERS BILL S. B. A TWENTY TWO
WHICH CONTAINS STRONG IT
NEUTRALITY PROTECTIONS NO BAKI
NO THROTTLING IN NO PAID
PRIORITIZATION WE ALL REMEMBER
THAT BILL WE VOTED ON IT.
YESTERDAY WITH A STRONG
SUPERMAJORITY.
AS BEFORE SIXTY REQUIRES AN I SP
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE AGENCY
TO PROVIDE BROADBAND INTERNET.
ACCESS SERVICES TO CERTIFY THAT
THEIR SERVICES ARE NET
NEUTRALITY.
COMPLIANT. THREE STATES
WASHINGTON OREGON IN VERMONT
HAVE ALREADY PASSED LAWS
PROHIBITING STATE CONTRACTING
WITH AYE IS PEACE THE VIOLATE
NET NEUTRALITY LEGISLATION AND
SIX OTHERS HAVE SIGNED EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. TO PROHIBIT CONTRACTING
WITH SUCH PROVIDERS AS BEFORE
SIXTY ALONG WITH A TWENTY TWO
SET.
CLEAR REASONABLE STANDARDS FOR
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
OFFER NECESSARY PROTECTIONS FOR
BOTH ONLINE BUSINESSES
[inaudible]
AND CONSUMERS COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM NOT SEEING ANY REQUEST TO
SEE ECONOMIST.
THANK YOU.
A SOME MEMBER OBERNOLTE YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER THERE
IS NO NEED FOR THIS BILL.
EARLIER TODAY WE PASSED.
I'D SERVICE WITHOUT ADHERING TO
THIS PRINCIPLES OF NET
NEUTRALITY THIS BILL SAYS.
THAT NO ONE CAN PROCURE UNIT AT
SERVICE.
THE DOES NOT PER --
HERE TO NET NEUTRALITY SO.
DO YOU IS A METAPHOR WHICH YOU
NORM FOND OF A LATE YESTERDAY WE
PASSED A BILL THAT SAYS THAT NO
ONE CAN WEAR GREEN A HAT IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY YOU'RE ASKING
US TO PASS A BILL THAT SAYS NO
ONE CAN WEAR A GREEN HAT.
IT MAKES NO SENSE THERE'S NO
NEED FOR THIS BILL I URGE A NO
VOTE [inaudible]
Q..
ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK
BESIDES PRESENTER PLEASE WE'VE
AT ME.
SEEING NONE WHATSOEVER BONTA YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES WE CERTAINLY DID
PASS A STRONG NET NEUTRALITY
BILL YESTERDAY IN CALIFORNIA THE
STRONGEST.
IN THE NATION NO LESS WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHERE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE THIS BILL.
IS ALSO IMPORTANT [inaudible]
BECAUSE OF THE POSSIBILITY OF A
PREEMPTION CLAIM BEING BROUGHT
AGAINST YESTERDAY'S BILL THIS
BILL HAS MUCH STRONGER.
GROUNDS TO WITHSTAND SUCH UP.
SUCH A CLAIM SUCH LITIGATION AND
WOOD ASSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
STAYS IN THE VANGUARD OF
PROTECTING NET NEUTRALITY MAKING
SURE THAT TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
ARE NOT USED TO SUPPORT
CONTRACTS WITH EYES PEAS DID
THAT DO NOT SUPPORT NET
NEUTRALITY WHICH IS WHAT WE WANT --
AND AND THAT ARE ARE VOTERS WANT
AND ARE AYE CALIFORNIANS WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE STAND FOR THE
PRINCIPLES OF NET NEUTRALITY SO
THIS IS.
ALSO A PORTABILITY COMPANION
BILL WITH WHAT WE VOTED FOR
YESTERDAY IF YOU VOTED FOR THE
BILL YESTERDAY --
IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA TO VOTE
FOR THIS ONE TOO I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINK YOU WITHOUT MADAM FOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MR BOTTOM OF THE CALL
PAIRED LIFT THE CALL AND I THE
ONE SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HIS IRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
?
MISTER BLOOM ASSET WE REPLACE
THE CALL
[inaudible]
THE SUMMIT.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
WE JUST HAVE ORDER IN THE
CHAMBER BRIEFLY I HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT SOMEBODY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THERE'S A MEMBER OF OUR CAUCUS
YOU'D LAST WEEK --
pIF I DID WHAT I'M ABOUT TO DO.
AND THAT WAS A SAILOR BIT ABOUT
HIM BEFORE --
WE SAY GOODBYE TO HIM TODAY.
THE REASON HE SAID THIS.
IS A TESTAMENT TO HIS CHARACTER.
HE DID NOT WANT THERE TO BE A
TRIBUTE ALL ABOUT HIM FOCUSED ON
HIM.
AND SORT OF A HIT THE ANTI
EGOTISTICAL REACTION WHICH IS
NOT SOMETHING YOU OFTEN SEE IN
POLITICS.
AND I THINK THAT IS ALL THE MORE
REASON WHY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE SAY A FEW WORDS OF
RECOGNITION TO OUR GOOD
COLLEAGUE ROCKY CHAVEZ.
THE MEMBER FROM OCEANSIDE.
WHO IS --
HAVING HIS LAST DAYS OF ANY
MEMBER ON THIS FLOOR.
OTHER HOPING TO SEE AND WE WILL
SEE HIM AGAIN IN TWO YEARS.
I FIRST MET ROCKY NOT AS A
FRESHMAN MEMBER BUT IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN I WAS JUST
BEGINNING TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
AND NOT MANY MEMBERS WHO ARE
HERE AT THIS TIME NO AND IT WAS
HEAVILY DISCOURAGE THAT AT THAT
TIME MY PARTY AND MY CAUCUS HELP.
IN THE RACE I WAS RUNNING IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN THIS IS BEFORE
THE EVEN NUMBERED YEAR ACTUALLY.
AND ROCKY REACHED OUT TO ME AND
ASKED HOW COULD HE HELP
[inaudible]
AND NOT A LOT OF MEMBERS DO THAT
THAT EARLY IN A CYCLE WHEN THEIR
OWN PARTY.
IS TELLING THEM DON'T GO HELP.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THE LEADERSHIP
THAT HE HAS HAD IN THIS BODY IN
THIS TIME AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
YOU OFTEN REMEMBER I'M SURE
THOSE TIMES WHEN HE'S HAD HIS
MIKE UP.
EITHER IN COMMITTEE OR ON THIS
FLOOR AND SAID I'M GONNA TAKE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT APPROACH.
I STARTED TEASING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT YOU CAN ALMOST.
YOU CAN ALMOST BET THAT THAT'LL
BE THE BEGINNING OF HIS REMARKS.
I'M GONNA SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
APPROACH IN EVERY TIME HE WAS
ABLE TO OFFER A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THAT HADN'T ALREADY
BEEN REPEATED.
THAT HADN'T BEEN MADE AND HE
MADE THAT PERSPECTIVE.
SO WELL AND IT OFTEN CHANGED HOW.
WE REACTED TO BILLS IN THAT THE
COMMITTEE ARE ON THIS FLOOR.
HIS COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION.
BEFORE HE GOT HERE AND EVERY
SINGLE DAY SINCE HE GOT HERE IS
EVIDENT IN HIS LEGISLATION AS AS
HIS COMMITMENT TO VETERANS
INCLUDING WOMEN VETERANS.
BECAUSE ROCKY CAME TO THIS
CHAMBER.
VETERANS WILL NOW HAVE BETTER
SUPPORT AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
VETERANS SERVICE CENTERS.
THAT HAVE NEEDED FUNDING FOR
YEARS.
BECAUSE OF ROCKY VETERANS WILL
HAVE MORE SUPPORT NOT ONLY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT IN
CONNECTING WITH JOBS AND
BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY FEMALE
VETERANS BECAUSE OF ROCKY.
AND BECAUSE OF ROCKY YOU YOU
WILL HAVE VETERANS WHO HAVE IN
STATE TUITION IN CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY ARE
ORIGINALLY FROM THAT IS BECAUSE
OF HIS LEADERSHIP AND HIS
SUPPORT.
NOT ONLY FOR EDUCATION BUT
VETERANS.
AND WE ALL NO THE CRITICAL ROLE
THAT HE PLAYED IN HELPING OUR
STATE MEET THE AGGRESSIVE
CLIMATE CHANGE ROLES RULES THAT
WE HAVE SET FOR IT.
THROUGH HIS ACTIVE PARTICIPATION
BRAVERY.
AND LEADERSHIP ON CAPITOL TRADE.
AND SO WE ARE --
I THINK A BETTER BODY BECAUSE
ROCKY HAS BEEN HERE.
I'M I AM PERSONALLY VERY VERY
GRATEFUL. FOR NOT ONLY HIS
SERVICE BUT HIS ENCOURAGEMENT TO
RUN AT A TIME WHEN OTHER PEOPLE
WERE SAYING THERE'S NO WAY YOU
CAN WIN.
AT ALL AND YOUR OWN PARTY WAS
TELLING YOU COULDN'T DO IT.
AND DISCOURAGING YOU FROM DOING
IT.
THAT'S THE TYPE OF LEADERSHIP
THAT ROCKY CHAVEZ SHOWS.
SO ROCKY WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN HERE WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL THAT MARRIED LESS UP
HERE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
YOU AGAIN IN TWO SHORT YEARS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER.
MR DOLLAR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I'D
LIKE TO JUST ALSO.
SAY A FEW KIND WORDS TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE ROCKY CHAVEZ.
TO AND BY THE WAY ON WAS MY SEAT
MATE AND I WANT TO JUST TELL THE
STORY ABOUT THAT BECAUSE HE SAT.
BEHIND ME.
THE FIRST YEAR.
AND THEN --
HIS TEAMMATE A ACTUALLY MIKE
MORRELL WAS MY SEAT MATE AND HE
WENT TO THE SENATE SANTA I HAD
AN OPEN SEAT.
AND UP HIS SEAT MAYBE DIDN'T
ALONG WITH VERY WELL THAT SET
BEHIND ME I WON'T MENTION HIS
NAME BUT HE RAISES MY CAN OFF A
LOT -- SO
ROCKY NEVER HOUSE THE SPEAKER.
HE JUST PICKED THIS STUFF UP THE
FIRST DAY THAT THAT DOES WAS
AVAILABLE AND MOVED UP NEXT TO
ME AND SO I I GOT A SEAT MATE
TOM.
AND A GOOD FRIEND ON TOP OF THAT
AND I WANTED TO SAY.
ROCK WE'RE GONNA MISS YOU YOU'RE
AWESOME.
NEXT YOUR WIFE IN YOUR IN YOUR
FAMILY AND ALSO I'M.
THE ONE THING I REALLY LOVE
ABOUT YOU IS THAT YOU'RE A GUY
WHO JUST MAKES A DECISION.
STICK WITH IT AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY YOU WERE PROBABLY A LEADER
IN THE SERVICE TO USE YOU YOU'VE
BEEN TRAINED TO DO THAT.
AND YOU DO IT WELL AND WE CAN
COUNT ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE THERE I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU BACK.
SOON ANNA GOD BLESS AND THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIMON MEMBER DOLLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
NO -- I
THINK IT WAS YESTERDAY --
WE PAY TRIBUTE TO JOHN MCCAIN
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
EVERYBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT IS
HOW HE WORKED ACROSS THE AISLE
AND HOW HE WAS JUST A VERY
PRINCIPLED MAN AND OFTEN MADE.
A DIFFICULT ECISIONS THAT WERE
THAT WERE NOT IN LINE WITH THE
PARTY DECISION.
AND THAT'S HOW I SEE YOU.
OF SOMETIMES YOU THE LONE
REPUBLICAN ON ON A REALLY
DIFFICULT VOTES AND THAT ARE NOT
IN LINE WITH YOUR PARTY BUT
DOING THE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
A I REALLY HAVE APPRECIATED
WORKING WITH YOU ON VETERANS
ISSUES --
OFTEN WE HAVE --
WE'VE I'VE HAD TO COME TO YOU
AND SAY CAN YOU HURT HELP ME
WORK THROUGH THIS --
I AM NOT A VETERAN MYSELF BUT
THE THE THE INFORMATION AND
EXPERIENCES THAT YOU'VE HAD
REALLY HELPED ME TO BE A MUCH
BETTER AND LEADER.
IN THE ON THE VETERANS COMMITTEE
AND AND THEN OF COURSE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THE MILITARY
COUNCIL HAS BEEN REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE MILITARY BASES.
STAY OPEN AND AND YOUR
BACKGROUND HAS HAS REALLY OF
PROGRESS STATUS IN IN THAT AREA.
SO -- BEYOND
THAT YOUR FOCUS ON ON EDUCATION
AND EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
AND YOUR PASSION FOR MAKING SURE
THAT THAT EVERYBODY THAT'S HERE
EVERY.
EVERY CHILD THAT IS IN THIS
COUNTRY THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
BETTER.
YOU ARE OF A GREAT MAN AND I'VE
REALLY APPRECIATED.
WORKING WITH YOU AND I WILL
REALLY MISS.
YOUR GUIDANCE ROCKY.
THANK YOU SUMMIT ENVIRONMENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I THINK OF THEY PUT ROCKY
IMMEDIATE GATHER A SEAT MATES
BECAUSE THEY FIGURED WERE CRUSTY
OLD VETERANS IF WE GOT INTO A
FIGHT NOBODY WOULD CARE OKAY.
BUT I DO HAVE ONE THING TO POINT
NOW.
TO MY COLLEAGUES.
AND THAT IS AS MILITARY PEOPLE.
ROCKY WAS A MARINE COLONEL.
THAT'S PRETTY HIGH UP IN THE
MARINE CORPS.
AND THE HIGHEST COMPLIMENT I CAN
GIVE THE ROCKY IS IF WE WERE
MOBILIZED.
AND I WAS PUT UNDER HIS COMMAND.
I WOULD GO ALL THE WAY WITH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I KNOW I CAN TALK MISTER VOEPEL --
BUT I JUST WANNA SAY I ROCKET I
CAME IN.
WERE CLASSMATES TOGETHER.
AND HAVE ENJOYED A VERY STRONG
RELATIONSHIP.
ON BEEN WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
TOGETHER WE WE'RE BOTH PASSED BY
AT THAT TIME SPEAKER JUMPER AS
TO GO ON A TRIP FOR FOR FOR
YOUNG LEADERS WE ALL AND WE
LAUGHED ABOUT THAT A LOT.
OF BUT WE WENT BACK TO AT THE
WASH THAT VIRGINIA AREA IT'S
BEEN A WEEK TOGETHER.
I'M AND REALLY DELVING DOWN I
THINK IN THE HISTORY OF THE
GOVERNMENT AND LEADERSHIP AND
AND I AND WE FORMED A REAL BOND
THERE --
UNLIKE JACKIE I WAS THINKING OF
JOHN MCCAIN WHEN WE'RE GOING TO
SAY GOODBYE.
TO I'M OUTS A DIFFERENT KIND BY.
HER.
DATA BUT JUST THE IDEA OF
STARTING IN SERVICE AT A VERY
YOUNG AGE AS I DID.
AND THEN WHEN YOU GET OUT YOU
CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO SERVE
YOUR COUNTRY.
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH KIDS IN
HIGH SCHOOL WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
DOING THIS.
BUT THE SERVICE THAT YOU'VE
GIVEN TO THIS [inaudible]
STATE TO THIS COUNTRY.
INTO THIS BODY.
SOMETHING TO BE PROUD OF I AM
AND I WILL CERTAINLY MISS YOU
AND I LOOK FOR ANOTHER BRAVE
REPUBLICAN.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY TIMES
WHEN I HAVE NEEDED THAT ONE
EXTRA VOTE.
AND I ALWAYS KNOW.
IT'S A BRIGHT JUST ISSUE OF
JUSTICE.
ROCKY CHAVEZ WILL BE THERE
[inaudible]
AMISH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SWING AROUND HERE SITE LOOK
ROCKY I REALLY WANT TO JUST TELL
A STORY ABOUT ROCKY BUT BEFORE I
GET TO THE STORY --
I JUST WANT TO HONOR ROCKY YOU
CAME AND I GOT TO KNOW YOU AS WE
WERE ELECTED CLASS OF TWENTY
TWELVE BUT WHAT A LONG HISTORY
OF PUBLIC SERVICE TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS OF COURSE.
IN THE MARINE CORPS.
SERVICE ON THE OCEAN SIDE CITY
COUNCIL --
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER SIR THE VETERANS
OF OUR STATE AND SENIOR
EXECUTIVE.
POSITION HERE IN CALIFORNIA YOUR
ROLE IN THE SCHOOL THERE OF DOWN
SOUTH SUPPORTING STEM EDUCATION.
BUT THE THING YOU KNOW ABOUT
ROCKY YEARS IT'S YOU KNOW WHAT
HE THINKS ROCKY CAN BE VERY
DEFINITE.
AND EXPRESS THAT THINGS HE
THINKS.
AND OF COURSE I GOT TO KNOW THAT
ABOUT HIM JUST THE CONDUCT OF
HIS WORK.
BUT THE MOST MEMORABLE WAY I
LEARNED THAT IS WHEN I FIRST
CAME HERE.
MY OFFICE WAS THE OFFICE OF MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER RODRIGUEZ HAS.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT AND THAT
THAT'S A NICE OFFICE SOON HASN'T
ESCAPED PACKAGE.
ON THEIR LITTLE SECOND FLOOR
QUARTER BY THE MEMBERS ELEVATOR.
AND WE GOT SETTLED INTO OUR
OFFICE AND I REALIZE ON THE BACK
OF MY ESCAPE HATCH.
EURESIST NATIONAL SCIENCE AND
PRIVATE.
NEVER HAD A PRIVATE ENTRY I FELT
PRETTY GOOD AND THEN I REALIZED.
RIGHT ACROSS THE WAY.
MY GOOD BUDDY ROCKY.
HAS AN ESCAPE HATCH THERE'S NO
SIGN.
SO I THOUGHT I WOULD YOU KNOW.
SETTLE A SCORE THERE AND I MADE
SURE WE GOT A A SIGN FOR HIM FOR
HIS STORE.
IT LASTED ABOUT TWO WEEKS MAYBE.
BEFORE I WALKED OUT ONE DAY AND
NOW THE SIGN READS CARNAL.
A SO WHY I JUST THOUGHT THAT WAS
PRETTY FUNNY THAT --
WITH ROCKY YOU KNEW WHERE YOU
STOOD DID KNEW WHAT HE WAS
THINKING AND PRIVATE WAS THE
WRONG THING TO HAVE ON THE
COLONEL'S BACKDOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY DOCTOR
WHETHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
IT I TO RISE --
TO CELEBRATE MY GOOD FRIEND
ROCKY.
WE ALL CAME HERE AT THE SAME
TIME.
AND WAS REALLY MY FIRST MEETING
OF ROCKY EVEN THOUGH HE WASN'T
SAN DIEGO COUNTY HAD SEEN HIS
NAME A COUPLE TIMES AND THINGS
BUT I'D NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO MEET HIM.
IN I TO LIKE SO MANY OTHERS AS
WELL AS WE'RE REFLECTING ON THIS
PAST WEEK OF JOHN MCCAIN I
THOUGHT OF YOU ROCKY --
BECAUSE YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN ONE
TO REACH ACROSS THE AISLE AND
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN ONE WHO HIT
WAS VERY PRINCIPLE AND THE
THINGS THAT YOU DID.
YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS SHARED THE
FACT THAT THERE ABOUT THREE OF
US THAT ARE IN THE SENIOR CAUCUS
AROUND HERE.
AND AS A RESULT WE HAVE A KIND
OF A DIFFERENT FLAVOR TO THE
THINGS THAT WE DO.
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATED BECAUSE
YOU ARE CLEARLY A PERSON WHO
THINKS ABOUT NOT WHAT IS IT
GOING TO DO FOR ROCKY NOT WHAT
IS YOUR NEXT STEP IN LIFE THAT
YOU WANT TO ACCOMPLISH.
BUT REALLY WHAT IS GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT'S GOOD FOR
OUR KIDS.
AND I KNOW IN THE EARLY DAYS WE
WERE TALKING CHILD HERE.
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND I
REMEMBERED CLEARLY YOU STANDING
UP AND SAYING TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
LISTEN PRESCHOOL IS NOT SOME
KIND OF CONSPIRACY. TO
INDOCTRINATE SMALL CHILDREN YOU
KNOW THIS REALLY WORKS AND YOU
GAVE GOOD EXAMPLES OF A NEW BEEN
TRUE TO THAT EVERY TIME WE COME
UP WITH THOSE ISSUES.
AND OF COURSE I'M GONNA MISS YOU
IN IT COMMITTEE BECAUSE I KNEW
THAT YOU ALWAYS THERE TO FIGHT
THE BATTLE WITH ME ON THE HARD
ISSUES.
AND I WAS RELYING UPON MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES TO COME
FORTH AND YOU ALWAYS THEY'RE
FIGHTING FOR KIDS FIGHTING FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY FIGHTING FOR
THOSE THINGS AND HIGH STANDARDS
THAT WE NEED TO DO.
SOME ANIME ISSUE THE FLIGHTS
COMING DELEGATION ON PLAIN AT
ALWAYS LOOK FOR YOU AND YOU
ALWAYS THERE BUT YOU ALSO ALWAYS
FOCUSED ABOUT THE ROLE OF THIS
PLACE.
IN YOUR OWN PERSONAL LIFE.
YOUR FAMILY YOUR GRAND KIDS YOUR
WIFE THOSE WERE IMPORTANT THINGS
AND YOU UNDERSTOOD THEM THEY
DIDN'T IT DIDN'T GET BLURRED
WOULD WHAT YOU WOULD DO AND
APPEAR.
YOU KNOW YOU LOVE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AS A GRANDFATHER IN AS A
HUSBAND AND YOU APPRECIATE IT
YOUR WIFE IN THE THINGS THAT
TOOK PLACE IN YOUR LIFE AND SO.
I'M GOING TO MISS YOU I KNOW YOU
JUST UP THE ROAD AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL COME DOWN TO SAN DIEGO
QUITE OFTEN TO SEE US.
BUT YOU'VE BEEN A REAL
ENCOURAGEMENT TO ME.
A REAL SENSE OF OF INSPIRATION
YELL OUT MY ANGELO SAID IN HER
PALM PULSE OF MORNING.
WHEN EVERYTHING IS DONE THIS
THREE THINGS THAT REMAIN THAT'S
THE ROCK THE RIVER THE TREE?
AND YOU'VE BEEN A ROCK IN THIS
HOUSE FOR SO MANY FOLKS WHO
STOOD ON YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN THAT TREE THAT SHADE
OF COMFORT FOR ME.
AND YOU'VE SURELY BEEN THE RIVER
BECAUSE BURKE WAS ALWAYS BRING
NEW INFORMATION A NEW
PERSPECTIVE AND YOU'VE BEEN THAT
ROCK RIVER ENTRY IN THIS HOUSE
AND I REALLY THANK YOU FOR BEING.
MY FRIEND MY COLLEAGUE AND I'M
GONNA MISS YOU BUT I KNOW THE
CHIU NEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER IT IS --
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY GET UP TO
SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT MY FRIEND
ROCKY CHAVEZ YOU NOT KNOWN ROCKY
OUT FRANKLY LONG BEFORE I WAS I
WAS ELECTED AYE HE WAS OF COURSE
ELECTED AND I WAS SO --
INVOLVED IN THAT LEO AND I HAD
MET HIM AT ONE OF OUR NO LABEL
EVENTS.
AND JUST ALWAYS STRUCK SOMETHING
WITH ME AND MY BEST FRIEND WAS
IN THE MARINE CORPS ON OFFICER
AND SO WE YOU KNOW WE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT I'MNOT
SURE ROCKY WERE REMEMBERS
REMEMBERS THAT BUT UP.
YOU KNOW I WHEN WE WERE DRIVEN
HIM ABOUT DOING THIS IN HE SAID
HE WAS GOING TO LEAVE AND I
THREATEN TO TACKLE HIM BEFORE HE
GOT OUT BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE RECOGNIZE.
OF PEOPLE THAT OF SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY THE WAY.
COLONEL CHAVEZ HAS --
YOU KNOW ROCKY YOU KNOW.
ENGLISH YOURSELF --
IN MANY DIFFERENT FIELDS OUR
MERRY THANK YOU FOR SHARING HIM
WITH US SO WHEN YOU'RE DOWN WITH
HIM AND THE NEXT TWO YEARS AFTER
HE'S PLAYED A LOT OF GOLF AND
BEEN A KNOWING PLEASE SEND IT
BACK --
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A BACK BUT
I'M GONNA MISS MY FRIEND ROCKY
CHAVEZ SIT BEHIND ME GIVING ME A
LOT OF GRIEF --
WHAT FROM BEHIND ME SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HOW THAT'S GONNA
PRETEND FOR NEXT YEAR SO WHOEVER --
IT ENDS UP BEHIND ME IN THE SOME
IN THE BACK ROW --
YOU HAVE SOME BIG SHOES TO FILL
AS FAR AS THE RIBBING GOES
BECAUSE THIS GUY OTHER THAN NOW
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM PALMDALE
IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE BEST IN
THIS ROOM FOR GIVING ME A HARD
TIME GOING TO MISS YOU MY FRIEND.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
FRANKLY I'M GONNA I'M GONNA MISS.
OUR LATINO CAUCUS MEETINGS BOTH
OF US IN A PHONE BOOTH BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT'S ALL IT IS AT THIS
POINT FOR THE REPUBLICAN LATINO
CAUCUS SO.
IT'S WELL IT'S A LITTLE A LITTLE
AWKWARD I MIGHT MIGHT BE THE
ONLY GUY HERE BUT YOU KNOW WHAT --
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR YOUR
YOUR HARD WORK AND DETERMINATION
YOUR DEDICATION YOUR FEISTY NESS
THAT WE'RE GONNA MISS AROUND
HERE LOTS OF MICROPHONES UP --
YOU KNOW HONORING YOU AND THANKS
FOR US FOR SHARING PART OF YOUR
YOUR LIFE WITH US THANK YOU
ROCKY APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA SOMEONE
NUMBERED JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I CAME IN WITH ROCKY ALSO.
AND ROCKY IS A REALLY GOOD SENSE
OF HUMOR.
AND I REMEMBER ONE TIME WE WERE
TOGETHER WITH ONE OF HIS STAFF
MEMBERS.
AND I STARTED TALKING ABOUT THE
MOVIE UP IN SMOKE.
OF WHICH YOU CAN SHAUN
[inaudible]
AND THINK WE HAD QUITE A FEW
[inaudible] FOR THEM.
AND ICE. ONE IN YOUR STAFF
MEMBERS STARTED SINGING A SONG
YOU KNOW BOUT MAC BEGAN AMERICA
AND AND I THOUGHT YOU KNOW KIND
OF A RACIST SONG.
AND ONE OF IT PART OF THAT SONG
SAYS ABOUT.
MEXICANS HAVE.
OR MARY Y. GIRLS NAY DEBBIE AND
I'M LAUGHING AND AND I KNOW THAT
YOU WERE LAUGHING THE WHOLE LOT
IS SUBMIT YOUR LEFT ABOUT.
MY WIFE'S NAME IS WHAT DEBBIE
AND SHE'S Y..
AND I THOUGHT OH MY GOD I JUST
INSULTED THIS GUY [inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW ROCKY WAS TOTAL
GENTLEMAN --
A HE UNDERSTOOD --
THAT WE HAVE TO GET ALONG ACROSS
LINES.
AND MOST IMPORTANT DESTRUCTIVE A
FRIENDSHIP WHERE WE EVEN TRY.
ON A FEW REMEMBER WE TRIED TO
HAVE FUND RAISERS TOGETHER OF
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
FUNDRAISERS.
BOTH ARE FUND RAISERS ONE THEY
TOLD US IT COULD HAPPEN. TWO ONE
I'M TOLD ME IT WAS ILLEGAL. ONE
OF THEM TOLD ME THAT --
I WOULD GET KICKED OUT A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IF I DID IT.
AND I WON'T EVEN TELL YOU WHICH
OPERATES SPEAKER TOLD ME ABOUT
DOING THIS.
ROCKING I PERSEVERED.
AND WE WENT AHEAD AND HAD.
IT WOULD PROBABLY HAD THE BEST
TIME WE EVER HAD --
COMING TOGETHER AS A AS A
DEMOCRAT AND A REPUBLICAN.
I'M COMING TOGETHER. TO WORK
TOGETHER TO HELP EACH OTHER.
ARE WE WENT ON TO HAVE TWO OF
THEM -- BUT
SECOND ONE WAS EVEN.
MORE FUN THAN THE FIRST ONE AND
I I'M I'M SORRY THAT WE NEVER
REALLY CONTINUED IT ON AND ON
AND ON BECAUSE WHEN WE CAME IN.
SIX YEAR OLDS TO PEOPLE AT SIX
YEARS.
THEY WERE REALLY ACRIMONIOUS TO
ONE ANOTHER THEY DID NOT.
IT LONG AND I THINK.
WE'VE BROUGHT BACK CIVILITY AND
A LOT OF WASTED TO DIS TO
DISDAIN BODY.
SHOWN HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
EVEN THOUGH WE CAN DISAGREE WE
CAN BE WAY.
FAR PART ONE OTHER ON THE
SPECTRUM.
BOB BARR Y. ALWAYS ADMIRED.
IT WHEN WE'RE REALLY REALLY
REALLY REALLY FAR APART AND
REALLY REALLY SOUND LIKE WE
CAN'T GET ALONG.
I SEE YOUR MICHAELA.
AND IN THE VOICE OF REASON.
AND AS SOMEONE SAID TO JOHN
MCCAIN'S OF THE WORLD THAT SAID
IT'S REALLY ABOUT KEEPING.
A HOUSE TOGETHER KEEPING THE
ASSEMBLY TOGETHER KEEPING THE
INSTITUTION TOGETHER IS MORE
IMPORTANT.
THAN ANYTHING ELSE AND YOU
BROUGHT THAT TO THIS HOUSE AND
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO MISS THAT.
SO I'M REALLY GOING TO MISS YOU.
BAKER MISTER JONES SAWYER.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ROCKY
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO COURSE YOUR DISTRICT
IS SEVENTY SIX DISTRICT.
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR BEING A A CALIFORNIA.
WILLING TO FOCUS ON THE ISSUES
AND MAKE VERY CLEAR FOR THE
BEGINNING THAT IT WAS NOT WASN'T
ABOUT BEING PARTISAN.
I HAD THE CHANCE TO SURVIVE YOU
FOR FOUR YEARS ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE.
AND THOSE THAT COMMITTEES WE
DON'T HAVE ICE CHIPS.
BUT I ALWAYS SAID THAT YOU WERE
MY VICE CHAIR FOR FOUR YEARS.
AND JOB WE HAD A GREAT RUN.
WE HAD FOR THAT HISTORIC YEARS
REINVESTING IN OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
BROUGHT TO THE CONVERSATION --
AGAIN ONE TO MAKE SURE YOU
ALWAYS SAID THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
PROCESS THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET.
HE VOTED FOR SOME OF THE BUDGET
REPORTS --
ME ALWAYS I STOOD UP AND MAKE
SURE YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT WAS A
POOR AND NOT JUST CALIFORNIA
KIDS BUT AGAIN AS MR.
RECALL YOUR SEAT MATE SAID THERE
EDUCATE US ON THE IMPACT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND VETERANS
AND THE VETERAN RESOURCE SECTORS
AND AND IT'S TRUE.
YOU HELPED US CRAP A PACKAGE TO
REINVEST IN THOSE PROGRAMS
COMMUNICABLE JUST BUT WHAT YOU
FOCUSED ON EARLY EDUCATION IS
SOMETHING THAT OFTEN I WON'T
FORGET TO AS A AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO MENTIONED YOU
REMINDED US THAT THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT NOT TO JUST INVEST IS
NOT A SOCIAL.
ISSUE.
I'M NOT ABOUT RIGHT OR WRONG BUT
IF YOU WANT CALIFORNIA TO
SUCCEED.
IF YOU WANT OUR KIDS TO SUCCEED.
WIN A STAR ADS ARE PROGRAMS FROM.
ZERO THROUGH FIVE BEFORE KIDS
ENTER OUR OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
AND YOU TOOK SIMPLE.
AND I THINK WE GOT OUT WE CAN
ALL LEARN A FEW LESSONS AND YOU
ON HOW YOU CONDUCTED YOURSELF IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY SO.
WE WISH YOU WELL THANK YOU.
BIGGEST MCCARTY MR MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COLONEL CHAVEZ.
YOU KNOW WHEN I FIRST GOT UP
THROUGH IT WHEN WE FIRST MET HE
REMINDED ME THAT I WAS JUST A
YOUNG BUCK SERGEANT.
AND FREE YOU GUYS I DON'T
REALIZE THIS THE THE ARMY AND
THE MARINES IS ALWAYS HAD A FUN
BANNER.
BETWEEN THE TWO BRANCHES AND
THAT'S CONTINUED ON WITH OUR
RELATIONSHIP AND IT'S BEEN GREAT
HAVING THAT [inaudible]
AND I'M GONNA MISS IT.
AND I'M GONNA MISS THE
LEADERSHIP THE YOU'VE SHOWN.
AND THAT MILITARY MIND SAID OF
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO YOU ARE%
WHERE YOU COME FROM THERE'S A
MISSION TO GET DON.
CUT OUT ALL THE JUNK IN THE
SHOULD GET TO IN WAR
[inaudible]
AND NOW.
I'M GONNA MISS THAT I KNOW WE'RE
ALL GOING TO MISS THAT.
IN I GET ECHO EVERYTHING ELSE
EVERYBODY'S RT SAID BUT I'LL
GIVE YOU ONE FINAL HURRAH.
AND COLONEL FINAL SALUTE
[inaudible]
CARRY ON THANK YOU SIR.
MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
ROCKY I ONE OF THE FRESHMAN IDEA
HERE FROM ALL OF YOUR COLLEAGUES
WHO'VE KNOWN YOU FOR A LONG TIME.
I THINK THEY'RE TWO THINGS THAT
I'VE REALLY REALLY APPRECIATED
ABOUT.
TWO AND ONE OF THEM HAS JUST
BEEN THIS WEEK.
AND THAT'S YOUR POSITION TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
YOU MAY BE CRYING.
I'M TO JANA ANYWAY I'M A CRY
BABY BUT YOU MADE ME CRY WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT.
THESE KIDS NEED EXTRA HELP.
THEY NEED A SECOND CHANCE.
YOU GOT A SECOND CHANCE.
THAT VOICE IS SO IMPORTANT.
WE DON'T HEAR IT.
WE DON'T HEAR IT OFTEN ENOUGH.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY FEELS THAT
WERE HERE WE'VE MADE IT.
LET EVERYBODY ELSE Y. THIRD FOR
THEMSELVES.
YOU DON'T FORGET WHERE YOU CAME
FROM [inaudible]
SO IMPORTANT.
THE OTHER THING IS OUR SCRIPTURE
BIBLE STUDY CLASS SOMETIMES IT
WAS JUST THE TWO OF US WITH.
WITH THE OTHERS BUT EVEN THERE
WAS THIS TALK TOUGH LOVE.
I REALLY APPRECIATED THAT.
BUT EVEN AT THE OTHER THINGS
THAT EVEN BEFORE I I CAME HERE.
I WOULD GO TO THE WOULD VISIT
DOWN IN OCEANSIDE GO TO CHURCH
THERE AND FIRST THING THEY WOULD
NOW SPIN THE NEW THAT I HAD JUST
BEEN ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY IS.
HAVE YOU MET OUR FRIEND WHO'S
YOUR FRIEND ROCKY CHAVEZ.
BECAUSE HAVING BEEN THERE YOUR
TO TELL ME IN NAME YOU'VE GOT TO
GET TO KNOW HIM.
SO CLEARLY YOUR SOUL LOVE TO IN
YOUR COMMUNITY AND THAT WAS A
PLEASURE FOR ME TO HEAR THAT AND
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO KNOW YOU
AND TO STUDY WITH YOU.
AND TO STUDY FROM YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I TOO WOULD LIKE.
TO ADD MY VOICE IS WITH ALL THAT
HAS BEEN SAID THOSE FAR.
ARE ROCKY YOU CERTAINLY HAVE
BEEN AT INSPIRATION --
TOO MANY OF US I KEEP HEARING
THE WORD LEADER LEADER --
LET ME JUST READ.
QUOTE WHEN MY FAVORITE QUOTES
NOT THINK THIS IS REALLY
EMBODIES WHO ROCKY CHAVEZ IS.
PERMISSION TO READ [inaudible]
GEOGRAPHIC [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
A GOOD LEADER INSPIRES PEOPLE TO
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE LEADER.
A GREAT LEADER INSPIRES PEOPLE
TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THEMSELVES
AND CERTAINLY YOU AS AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS PUT ON A UNIFORM TO OF
SERVE THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
I'M YOU HAVE EXHIBITED GREAT
LEADERSHIP.
ARE NOT ONLY THERE BUT ALSO HERE
ON THIS FLOOR --
I'M HAPPY TO BE A PART OF THE
BOW TIE CAUCUS.
WITH YOURSELF AND THAT YOU WERE
PROBABLY BUT ALSO WITH MEMORY IS
THAT YOU NEVER HAVE GOTTEN I'M
WHICH YOU CAME --
YOU STAND HI YOU STAND TALL ON
IN MY BOOK --
I WANT TO SAY TO HIS LOVELY WIFE
AND FAMILY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SHARING THIS GREAT MAN WITH
ALL OF US BECAUSE OUR LIVES
WOULD NOT.
WILL BE DIFFERENT BECAUSE HE'S
PASSED OUR WAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER --
YOU KNOW IT'S FORTUNATE TO COME
IN WITH YOU IN TWENTY TWELVE ON
THE CLASS THEY CAME IN.
BUT EVEN MORE FORTUNATE TO TO
HAVE KNOWN YOU FROM SO MANY
YEARS THROUGH AYE THROUGH SAN
DIEGO POLITICS AND I THINK WE
SHARED A A SIMILAR VIEWPOINT GOT
TO BOND --
THROUGH NO HERE AND I THINK A
SHOULD JONES SAWYER MENTIONED IT
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT [inaudible]
I THE TWENTY TWELVE CLASS KIND
OF MAKING A COMMITMENT TO CHANGE
A LITTLE BIT OF THE CULTURE.
THAT WE HAD SEEN WHEN WE CAME UP
HERE AND VISITED AND YOU'RE
REALLY A LEADER IN DOING THAT.
I AND THAT'S SPEAKS AYE I THINK
GREATLY TO YOUR CHARACTER YOU
KNOW -- MY
OTHER COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
MENTIONED HOW MUCH TIME WE SPEND
AT THE AIRPORT TOGETHER --
IN IN THE TALKS OF OUR FAMILIES.
AND THE LOVE THAT YOU HAVE FOR
YOUR CHILDREN.
AND FOR MARY REALLY SHINES
THROUGH I THINK IT'S AN
INSPIRATION RELATE TO ALL OF US --
THEY'RE NOT WHAT YOU'VE MEANT TO
THE SAN DIEGO DELEGATION AND
WHAT YOU'VE MEANT THIS BODY I
KNOW I I WON'T HAVE TO GO FAR TO
SEE.
IN SAN DIEGO SO SOLVE STILL HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY BUT WHAT THE
BACKGROUND THAT YOU BRING FROM
YOUR MILITARY SERVICE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION HAVE YOU
TRAVELED UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
AND TO LEARN MORE TO SPEAK OUT
ON THESE TOPICS A TO SPEAK TO
LARGE GROUPS INTO SMALL GROUPS.
I YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN WILLING TO
DO THAT AND SO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE I KNOW WAS WILL
STILL SEE MORE OF YOU AYE.
VERY FORTUNATE TO AND LOOK FOR
TO SPEND MORE TIME WITH YOU NOW
THAT YOU BE HOME IN SAN DIEGO A
BIT MORE.
THANK YOU MR MAIENSCHEIN.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
ROCKY I JUST WANTED TO TELL YOU
WHAT AN INSPIRATION YOU'VE BEEN
TO ME AND I KNOW.
A LOT OF TIMES WE DON'T
BUT
YEAH AND CAME INTO THE ASSEMBLY
YOU WERE ONE OF MY ROLE MODELS
BECAUSE I KNEW THAT YOU WERE
SOMEONE.
THE MADE AN INDEPENDENT DECISION
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE THING THAT
YOU VOTED ON AND YOU TAKE ALL
THE OPINIONS INTO ACCOUNT.
AND MAKE YOUR OWN CHOICE ABOUT
WHAT WAS BEST FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I I WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW.
HOW MUCH I ADMIRE THAT ABOUT YOU
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE
TRIED TO EMULATE?
YEAH A LOT OF TIMES I THINK
WE'RE NOT REALLY GOOD ABOUT
TELLING EACH OTHER.
WHEN A FEDERAL MODEL TO US IN
SOME WAY TO MAKE SURE I TOOK
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THAT IF
YOU AND I IN YOUR HONOR?
WE HAVE PURCHASED A FOR EVERYONE
WE GOT IN IN A IN AND OUT
MILKSHAKES --
THERE IN THE MEMBERS LOUNGE --
SO ENJOY THAT BUT THANK YOU
ROCKY AND THANKS FOR BEING A
ROLE MODEL AN INSPIRATION TO ME.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ROCKY --
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY GONNA BE
GONE.
THE THING I THINK THAT I LOVE
MOST ABOUT YOU AND THEN I WILL
MISS.
IS THAT I FOUND SOMEONE ELSE IN
THE CAUCUS WHO WAS ABOUT MY SIZE
SO WE SEE EYE TO EYE.
ON MORE THINGS THAN PEOPLE
REALIZE --
WE STARTED OFF.
GOSH BACK WHEN I WAS CITY
COUNCIL BEFORE EUROPEAN WE
SOMEHOW ENDED UP MEETING ON THE
TRAILING YOU SUPPORTED ME AND I
SUPPORTED YOU AND IT WAS A NICE
LITTLE.
KIND OF REPRIEVE GETTING TO THE
ASSEMBLY RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
DEVELOPED AND THEN OVER TIME
GETTING TO KNOW MARY AND HEARING
ABOUT ALL YOUR KIDS AND YOUR
GRANDKIDS AND ALL THE COOL STUFF
YOU GUYS DO.
AND SO I THINK --
GINO JAY'S SPEAKS FOR MORE THAN
JUST HIMSELF WHEN HE SAYS THAT
THE WAY IN WHICH YOU CONDUCT
YOURSELF APPEAR IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND STICKING YOUR GUNS AND
SOMETIMES STRAYING OFF THE PATH
AND SURPRISING PEOPLE.
WITH HOW YOU VOTE IS
[inaudible]
IS.
AN EXTRAORDINARY THING TO SEE UP
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY ONE I THINK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR YEARS OF
SERVICE TO YOUR COUNTRY INTO
THIS STATE.
AND WISH YOU VERY WELL.
THE GAME IS MELENDEZ.
LAST NOT LEAST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LOOKS
LIKE I'M A BATON CLEAN UP HERE.
YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK OF OF
ROCKY -- I
THINK OF MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
ALL OF YOU I'M HAVE HAVE SAID.
THE ONE THING OF COURSE THAT
STICKS OUT IS THAT HE IS A
MARINE.
AND THAT HE WAS A COLONEL IN THE
MARINE CORPS AND YOU DON'T GET
TO THE RANK OF COLONEL.
WITHOUT BEING HAVING INCREDIBLE
TALENT AND AN INCREDIBLE COMMAND
PRESENCE.
AND I THINK OF THAT PHRASE THAT.
THE FINE MARINES A SIMPLIFY
[inaudible]
ALWAYS FAITHFUL.
AND FOR ME FOR THE TIME THAT I
WAS -- THE
LEADER.
IRAQI WAS WAS ALWAYS FAITHFUL
AND HE WAS ALWAYS LOYAL.
AND IF WE ARE GOING DOWN A PATH
[inaudible]
IF HE WOULD ARGUE WITH ME DEBATE
WITH ME WHETHER WAS THE RIGHT
PATH BUT ONCE THAT PATH WAS SET.
HE STOOD RIGHT NEXT TO ME AND
CONTINUED TO KEEP FIGHTING THAT
FIGHT.
AND AS WE KNOW.
THERE WAS OUT THERE'S BEEN A FEW
TOUGH VOTES --
AND FOR FOR ROCKY THAT IT DIDN'T
MATTER WHAT THE OUTSIDE.
BELIEVE THERE WHAT THE ERRONEOUS
INFORMATION WAS WHEN HE KNEW
THAT IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
HE WAS GONNA DO IT.
IN YOU KNOW MARINES HAVE THAT
OTHER.
THAT OTHER SAYING THAT THE FEW
[inaudible]
PROUD.
AND THAT ALSO DEFINES THE FINES
ROCKY.
THERE ARE MANY OF US.
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S EIGHTY
POLITICIANS.
BUT I THINK THERE ARE FEW
[inaudible]
FEW LESS [inaudible]
STATESMAN ROCKY IS A STATESMAN.
HE IS GOING TO BE MESSED HERE IN
THIS HOUSE HE MESSED.
IN HIS DISTRICT.
IN CALIFORNIA IS GONNA MISS HIM
FOR ALL OF HIS LEADERSHIP AND
ALL OF WHAT HE DID FOR FOR US
THANK YOU SO MUCH ROCKY.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER MAYES
[inaudible]
CHAVEZ.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DEATH.
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE
WONDERFUL COMMENTS AS BASU WITH
MARY HERE BEEN AND LYRICS.
THE YOU KNOW IN IN.
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE MARINE CORPS AND AS I CAME
THROUGH AND I WAS PROBABLY SAY
THE SCOUTS --
NOTHING I LEARNED IT LEADERSHIP
THE MARINE CORPS I DIDN'T
ENCOUNTERING THE BOY SCOUTS
FIRST.
THE THE BEST ANALOGY IS I THINK
THAT THEY GAVE US IS IT'S NEVER
ABOUT YOU ABOUT THE ORGANIZATION.
AND THE USER STORY RANDY SHARED
WITH THAT EARLY I WOULD SAY GOT
RAINED OUT MY STORIES THAT.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU AS A YOUNG
LIEUTENANT COME INTO AN
ORGANIZATION YOU THINK YOU'RE
ALL THAT WITH YOUR LITTLE?
BUTTER BAR AS I'M SURE MATHIS
KNOWS I'M TALKING ABOUT
[inaudible]
THE YOU.
THEY TELL YOU.
THERE'S A BUCKET OF WATER.
PUT YOUR HAND IN IT AND PULL IT
OUT.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IN YOUR HAND YOU KNOW THIS
RECOVERY IS NOT IN THERE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT YOU IT'S ABOUT
THE ORGANIZATION THAT GOES.
FOR AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'VE
TRIED TO CONDUCT MYSELF HEARING
IN THAT LINE I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THE TIME TO SAY.
PUBLICLY BECAUSE I'M SURE
THEY'RE WATCHING THIS SOMEWHERE --
MY CHIEF OF STAFF MICHAEL
O'HANLON --
HE'S BEEN INSPIRATION WITH ME
HE'S BEEN WITH ME FROM THE
BEGINNING.
I FOUND HIM AS A A GUY RUN
AROUND THE DISTRICT NEGROES TO
BE MY CHIEF.
VERONICA BUT DELIA WHO'S BEEN
WITH ME.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN SHOES OF
WE ARE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS --
SHE'S BEEN WITH ME THE ENTIRE
TIME.
I KELLY ASH CAME IN WITH ME JUST
A FEW YEARS AGO BUT TUESDAY.
AYE CHU IS MY AYE SO EACH OF MY
LITTLE FERRET I GO FIND OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS BUILDING.
AND SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE
YOU HAD A GREAT POLITICAL SENSE
AND UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS.
TOM GARCIA AND MY DISTRICT ARE
AN ARMY VETERAN SEVENTY YEARS
OLD.
AYE HE WAS ACTIVE EVERYWHERE.
A TAKING CARE OF THE MILITARY MY
DISTRICT.
AND SOFIA HERNANDEZ --
SHE WAS WITH ME FROM THE
BEGINNING AS AN INTERN IN THE
HOUSE BEEN THERE SIX YEARS.
I JOKE AROUND WITH THEM BECAUSE
HERNANDEZ GARCIA BUT DEALIO
CHAVEZ.
I'M SURE WHEN I LEAVE I THINK
GOT THE MAJORITY TO LATINOS AND
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS WILL BE GONE
[inaudible]
SO.
MAYBE ONE DAY I'LL ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO BE IN THE LATINO CAUCUS
BUT ANYWAY.
YEAH SO THAT'S OF THE PEOPLE
THERE THAT HAVE DONE ALL THAT I
WANT TO LIKE TO THANK --
STEVE MCCARTHY OVER IN POLICY
SPEND SO MANY HOURS WITH HIM AND
WHAT HE'S DONE.
AND CINDY HILLARY IN THE BUDGET
ON BUDGET SAID TO AND IT'S TO
THE GREAT LEADERSHIP OF
OBERNOLTE.
A GREAT PERSON AND EDUCATION BOB
BECKER.
YOU KNOW BOB IS AN ALL WRESTLERS
JUST LIKE I WAS YOU GOT NUMBER
TALK BY ME WRESTLING BUT
ACTUALLY THAT WAS PROBABLY ONE
OF MY THINGS I LIKE TO
ACCOMPLISH MOST.
WAS BOB.
AT KATIE'S FAERIE OVER IN
EDUCATION.
ARE WE GOT ALL TYPES OF
DISCUSSIONS.
ALAN PICKED CACTUS.
HAS ALREADY AND SUB TO WORKING
WITH ME.
I THE FLOOR TEAM GREGORY AND
AMANDA.
IN MY CAUCUS MEMBERS STAFF.
THEN THAT.
THEN THAT WAS SO WONDERFUL SHE
WAS OVER THE BAKER BEFORE NOT TO
THE CAUCUS YOU DOES SO MANY
THINGS.
EVENT TRICIA ROBERT.
AND I'D LIKE TO MENTION ALL THE
DESK PEOPLE APPEAR BECAUSE I WE
SCREW WITH THEM IN THE MORNING
WHO'S OUR FIRST ONE ALWAYS
HEARING EARLY IN THE MORNING.
ME I WAS CHECK IMAGE A WHAT'S
GOING ON IN BLOOD SEVEN OH FIVE
MIGHT WAIT FOR THEM TO GET HERE.
I JUST TO MESS WITH THEM.
AND THE SERGEANTS TO DRIVE US
AROUND TO TAKE CARE OF US.
I WON A HIGHLY READY BECAUSE
IT'S GOES TO THAT STORY THE
BUCKET.
AND THE WATER IS NOT ABOUT US.
YOU KNOW WE COME WE MAKE A
STATEMENT WE MOVE ON BUT IT'S
ALL THESE OTHER PEOPLE IN THIS
INSTITUTION THAT GOES FORWARD.
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT ALL
THESE OLD PEOPLE ON THE WALLS
HERE THE USED TO BE SPEAKERS AND
I THOUGHT THERE'S SOMEBODY.
THEY'RE NOT ANYMORE [inaudible]
IN SO [inaudible]
IN SUMMATION.
WHEN WE DO THINGS HERE HAVE A
LONGER VIEW?
IT'S REALLY NOT ABOUT US.
IT'S ABOUT THE STATE NOW AS WE
GO FORWARD.
AND NOW I'M IN THE LAST PERSON
LIKE TO THANK.
IS MY WIFE MARY MARY WOULD
ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT I'D GET
OUT OF THE HOUSE SHOULD MAKE
SURE I HAD A WATER BECAUSE YOU
ALWAYS HAD THESE TERRIBLE LITTLE.
HEALTH BARS IT TASTES LIKE
CARDBOARD THAT SHE MADE ME EAT
FIVE WOULD LEAVE.
SHE ALWAYS WORRIED ABOUT MAYES
SHOULD BE CALLING VERONICA AND
KELLY MAKES AYE MEETING.
AND SHE'S BEEN HERE AND AND SHE
SAID I CAN'T COME BACK HERE EVER
AGAIN.
AND I'LL JUST SEND IT WITH THIS.
I'LL BE BACK
IT'S CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE.
OF CONCURRENT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS THOSE BILLS ARE AB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHTEEN AB SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR CHOI AND AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN WOULD [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION
.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS I WILL SEVEN FORTY EIGHT ICE
ON MEMBER TING ACTUALLY PEACE
OFFICERS.
VISITING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER SPEAKER.
MAYBE A SEVEN FOUR EIGHT ALLOWS
A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO
WITHHOLD A VIDEO OR AUDIO
RECORDING OF THE CRITICAL SAFETY
AGENCY DEMONSTRATES THE
DISCLOSURE.
WOULD INTERFERE WITH THE
INVESTIGATION FOR FORTY FIVE
DAYS.
A SUBSEQUENT THIRTY DAY DELAYS
IF THE MATTER IS STILL UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
AMENDMENTS TAKE UP THE REQUEST
OF C. H. P. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL TO ONLY.
WHEN AN OFFICER DISCHARGES THEIR
FIREARM OR INSTANCES OF USE OF
FORCE RESULTING?
IN DEATH OR GREAT BODILY INJURY.
AGAIN THIS IS A TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE. TO REALLY GIVE OUR
COMMUNITIES GREATER CONFIDENCE
IN THE TRUST OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE'VE SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE IN ALL OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. TO DEPLOY
ON BODY CAMERAS WERE SPENDING
MONEY TO RECORD THEIR FOOTAGE OF
THIS WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY A STATEWIDE
BASELINE OF POLICY.
POLICY DOES NOT GO AS FAR AS THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE COMMISSION
POLICY.
JUST ALREADY --
IN TRYING TO IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IT ALSO DOES NOT IMPACT.
A POLICY THAT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO HAS ALREADY ADOPTED --
THIS IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT MATTER
IT PROVIDES A GREATER INSIGHT
AND GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN TO
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT ON IT
ACTUALLY DOES NOT FORCE ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. TO RELEASE
THE INFORMATION WALL THE ISSUE
IS UNDER INVESTIGATION COULD
ONLY ASK THAT THEY TELL US.
PACIFIC WE WHY THERE'S A GREATER
INTEREST IN KEEPING A PRIVATE
VERSUS ON RELEASING IT TO THE
PUBLIC WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL FOR AB. SEVEN FOR
A BAKER WAS SHOOTING MISTER
LACKEY YOUR RECOGNIZE.
YES BIGGER MEMBERS UP TO AVOID
GROUNDHOG DAY.
I I JUST WOULD OUST YOU RECALL
MY REMARKS AND I DO NOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT THIS BILL IS A GOOD BILL.
THIS BILL ACTUALLY PROTECTS OUR
MEN AND WOMEN AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM SPEECH JUST
CLAIMS.
IT LIMITS LIABILITY AND SAVES
MANY OF OUR CITIES FROM THE
EXORBITANT COSTS OF ACTUALLY
DEFENDING SUCH CLAIMS.
AND AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDINGS
THAT COME FROM BODY CAMS CAN
ACTUALLY BE EXCELLENT TRAINING
RESOURCES FOR THE YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN THAT ARE ENTERING INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS BILL ACTUALLY PROMOTES
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE NEED WHILE
OFFERING VERY NEEDED.
LAW OFFICER SAFETY --
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE
THAT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THEY CAN HAS
COME UNDER THAT.
THIS CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT AS A FORMER
JOURNALIST I CAN TELL YOU HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. TO HAVE.
THE FOOTAGE OF BODY CAMERAS
AVAILABLE AND I THINK WHAT WE
CAN LEARN IS THAT WE LIVE IN A
SOCIETY NOW.
IN WHICH WE HAVE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND THE INFORMATION THAT IS
GIVEN TO THE PUBLIC IN THE
INTERPRETATION OF THAT
INFORMATION.
IN ANY FOOTAGE THAT IS SHARED.
HELPS OR SOMETIMES DOES NOT HELP --
SHAPE PUBLIC OPINION.
IN A TIME IN WHICH WE WANT THE
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENTTO
SEE EYE TO EYE.
AND HAVE A COMMON GROUND
CONVERSATIONS.
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE INFORMATION
BE AVAILABLE AND TRANSPARENT.
SO THAT THE COMMUNITY HAS FAITH.
THAT THE PROCESS IS MOVING
FORWARD IT ALSO HELPS MEDIA
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE TELLING THE
STORY.
THEN NEEDS TO BE TOLD AND UP IS
AWARE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
CERTAIN CASES THAT HAVE GONE.
ON A NATIONAL LEVEL AND HAVE
NATIONAL PRESENCE SO I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT BILL THE
AUTHOR HAS CERTAINLY.
TALKED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
HAS COME TO AGREEMENTS IN WHICH
HAVE ALSO --
CREATED MORE OF A A PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF AND LONGER
PERIODS OF TIME IN WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN REVIEW.
AND RELEASE INFORMATION TO THE
PUBLIC WHICH WOULD ALLOW
JOURNALISTS TO BE ABLE TO TELL
THE STORY THAT NEEDS TO BE TOLD
AND INFORM THE PUBLIC.
SHAPE OPINION SO WITH THAT I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN MY BOOK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO.
THIS OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION ASK
YOU TO OUR A. B. SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT I THINK THE ADVENT OF BODY
CAMERAS HAS CREATED.
A VERY SERIOUS AND SUBSTANTIVE
ISSUE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PRIVACY BOTH
OF THE PUBLIC AND OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND I
WELCOME.
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THOSE
RECORDING SHOULD BE RELEASED.
HOWEVER I THINK THAT THAT HAS TO
BE A VERY LIBERTE DELIBERATE
DISCUSSION CERTAINLY VERY
COMPLEX TOPIC WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT --
INTERESTED PARTIES AND WHEN WE
TRY AND JAM THROUGH THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION LEYVA SESSION
MISTAKES HAPPEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY.
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION HAS A
VERY SERIOUS DRAFTING HERE AND
IT AND I WANT TO READ YOU FROM
THE BILL WITH YOUR PERMISSION
MISTER SPEAKER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF THE BILL
SAYS IF DISCLOSURE WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY INTERFERE WITH AN
ACTIVE CRIMINAL OR
ADMINISTRATIVE INVESTIGATION.
THE AGENCY SHALL PROVIDE IN
WRITING TO THE REQUESTER THE
SPECIFIC BASIS FOR THE AGENCY'S
DETERMINATION THAT DISCLOSURE
WHAT'S SUBSTANTIVELY INTERFERE
WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
AND PROVIDED THE VIDEO OR AUDIO
RECORDING.
THEREAFTER THE RECORDER RING
RECORDING MAY BE WITHHELD BY THE
AGENCY FOR FORTY FIVE CALENDAR
DAYS.
SO I THINK THAT WAS MEANT TO SAY
AND WITHHOLD.
THE VIDEO OR AUDIO RECORDING BUT
IT SEEMS TO SAY THAT.
THEY DENY THE REQUEST.
THEY TELL THE REASON WHY THEY'RE
DENYING REQUEST AND THEN THEY
HAVE.
TO PROVIDE THE VIDEO AUDIO AND
THEN WITHDRAW IT SO --
I THINK THESE DRAFTING ERRORS
ARE INDICATIVE OF WHAT COULD
HAPPEN WOULD AMENDMENTS GET PUT
THROUGH AT THE LAST MINUTE.
NOW WE NEED TO BE MORE
DELIBERATE ABOUT THIS AND GET IT
RIGHT AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE OR I I KNOW WHAT
[inaudible]
BIGGEST OBERNOLTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THE BILL CLEARLY STATES THE BODY
CAM VIDEO MUST BE RELEASED TO
THE PUBLIC UNLESS THE AGENCY CAN
PROVE THAT THE DISCLOSURE WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY INTERFERE WITH THE
WHILE INVESTIGATIONS ARE
OCCURRING RELEASES COULD
POTENTIALLY TIP OFF POTENTIAL
SUSPECTS A PROVIDE THE SAME.
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADJUST
THEIR STORIES TO COINCIDE WITH
THE RELEASE VIDEO LET'S NOT
INTERFERE WITH THE ONGOING LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS.
LET'S VOTE NO IN AB SEVEN FOR A
BACON IS WALDRON.
SEEING AND HEARING OTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER TING YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU IT'S SPEAKER --
WITH OUR RESPECT TO THE LENGTH
OF TIME THAT WE'VE WORKED ON
THIS BILL YOU'LL NOTICE NUMBERS
AB SEVEN FOR A THIS WAS A AYE TO
YOUR BILL --
WE NEEDED TO TO YOUR BILL AND
LAST SESSION --
SPAIN GREATER TIME TO LIBERTY
DISCUSSING THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE --
WE HAD NUMEROUS --
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
REINFORCED WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
REACH AGREEMENT BUT DESPITE --
NOT A BE ABLE TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION WE DID SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWED THE BILL AGAIN --
TO SPECIFICALLY USE BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE ONLY IN THE USE OF FORCE
AREAS -- DO
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG
BEAR MATCHING THE DRAFTING NEAR
THE DRAFTING AREA WAS ACTUALLY --
DONE DURING AMENDMENTS IN JUNE
SO AGAIN IT WAS NOT SOMETHING
THAT LAWS ARE DONE LAST LAST
WEEK OR YESTERDAY.
UNFORTUNATE A LEAD THE ERROR WAS
ONLY BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION A
COUPLE DAYS AGO AND WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE AMENDMENTS IN TIME
BECAUSE OF THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR
ROLE.
WE ARE SUBMITTING A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL WHICH WAS SUBMITTED
ON AUGUST TWENTY NINTH AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FIGURES CORRECT --
THE LEGISLATION SHOULD READ
PROVIDE THE ESTIMATED DATE. FOR
THE DISCLOSURE OF THE VIDEO OR
AUDIO RECORDING --
AGAIN IT'S SOMETHING THAT
BECAUSE WE HAD DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION THE PETITION FOR
THE LEGISLATION IS NOT UNTIL
JULY OF TWENTY NINETEEN I SHOULD
THE BILL PASS AND BE SIGNED.
THEN WE WOULD ANTICIPATE
BRINGING CAR CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION VERY EARLY NEXT YEAR
WITH AN URGENCY BECAUSE TO HELP.
GET THAT --
GET THAT TO IMPLEMENTATION SO
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. SEVEN FOR A THANK
YOU MISTER KING THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
SHE MOVED CALL.
YOU DAHLE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
WELL WE HAVE THIS BILL LONG CALL
I'D LIKE TO TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO SEE IF YOU KIND WORDS ABOUT
MY GOOD FRIEND JOBS ALLEN
[inaudible]
SO -- AS YOU
KNOW WE CAME IN TOGETHER ACOSTA.
TWELVE THE BIGGEST CLASS AND I
WILL THIS YEAR.
A COUPLE THINGS TRAVIS CAME TO
MY FARM.
IT'S BITS OF TIME WITH ME UP
THERE.
AND I MADE HIM RIDE MY HARVESTER
FOR ABOUT WHY THINGS HAPPEN DAY
OR SO.
AND YOUR JOB IS ALWAYS WELL DONE
UP AND HEADED JAIL IN THE HAIR
AND AND BY YOU KNOW THE DAY WE
HAD PLENTY A CHILD.
IS HERE AND WE HAVE A GREAT TIME
UP THERE ARE TO FAR ENOUGH BUT I
WILL SAY.
THEY DID THE THING THAT --
I'M GONNA MISS MOST ABOUT TRAVIS
THIS.
YOU NEVER DID YOU GET CAUCUS I
MEAN THE FIRST COUPLE WEEKS WE
WERE HERE YOU TELL ME LET'S BLOW
THIS PLACE UP.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW QUITE WHAT HE
MEANT BY THAT BUT IT'S HIS
CHARACTER TO DO THINGS --
FULL STEAM.
YEAH HE CAME IN AND MADE A
MOTION TO REMOVE OUR LEADER.
AND NEVER GOT A SECOND IF I
RECALL.
BUT ANYWAY JOBS --
BEEN JOINED THE TIME THAT YOU'VE
BEEN HERE WITH US I'M GONNA MISS
YOU.
GONNA MISS OUT OF THE THE DEBATE.
THE FRIENDSHIP --
GLAD TO SEE YOUR BEAUTIFUL
FAMILY THAT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVE
ACQUIRED SINCE --
YOU'VE BEEN ON THIS FLOOR SKIN
TO SEE ALL OF YOU HERE.
YOU'VE AVAIL ME ANYWAY TRAVIS --
SAY TOUCH WE LOVE YOU AND NOW
GOD BLESS.
THEY USE A DOLLAR.
MR HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS [inaudible]
I TRAVIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO WISH YOU THE
BEST OF LUCK. TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH AS HE RUNS
FOR GOVERNOR TO TAKE BACK CAL.
WHO PLACE THEIR WRITING THIS
LITTLE EARLY [inaudible]
WELL TRAVIS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S BEEN SIX
YEARS SINCE YOU'VE BEEN ELECTED
TO THIS BODY IN FACT YOU WERE A
BIG PART.
OF ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES
WHILE I SERVED AS MAYOR
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND THAT WAS
YOUR WORK IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE
TO DEFEND THE BEACH BON FIRES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HUGE ISSUE FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE FAMILIAR IS A CLASH BETWEEN
THE A KIM DE.
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
THE AREA KIM DEAL WITH TRYING TO
GET RID OF WOOD FIRE BEACH ONE
FIRE BONFIRE RINGS.
IN THE COASTAL COMMISSION WAS IN
FAVOR IN FACT WHERE THINGS THAT
I ASKED WAS THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE SOLVED BY ONE OF TWO
THINGS MOST LIKELY LITIGATION
LEGISLATION YOU CARRIED THE
LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT.
OFF FOR THE BEACH BOND FIRINGS
IN A LOT OF YOU VOTED FOR THAT
BILL AND I THINK YOU OFFER MUCH
FOR THAT.
IN FACT IT'S STILL INDELIBLE IN
MY MIND ABOUT THE BIG SLOGAN
KEEP YOUR MITTS OFF OUR PETS IN
FACT THERE IS A HASHTAG YOU'LL
FIND PLENTY OF IT --
AS A RESULT BUT YOUR YOUR WORK
ON THAT WAS VERY COMMANDED IT
SEEMS LIKE YESTERDAY THAT I JOIN
YOU ON THIS FLOOR --
BOTH OF US REPRESENT THE CITY
HUNTINGTON BEACH IN FACT IT IT'S
ALMOST LIKE THEY WERE TRYING TO
LITERALLY CUT THE CITY IN HALF
BUT THE REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE.
I IT'S PRETTY MUCH ALMOST FIFTY
FIFTY AND IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH YOU OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. ONE THING I HAVE TO
SAY THAT DURING YOUR CAREER AS
AN ASSEMBLYMAN YOU'VE
ACCOMPLISHED QUITE A BIT AS A
LEGISLATURE.
YOU HAD FIVE BILL SIGNED INTO
LAW ON YOU.
BUT NOT THAT MUCH ELSE.
WELL I GUESS THAT'S IT SO BY
HANGING.
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING THERE IS
MUCH TO CELEBRATE IN YOUR LIFE
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS.
YOU MET AND MARRIED YOUR LOVELY
WIFE ARIAL WHO'S HERE TO JOIN US.
LAST YEAR SHE GAVE BIRTH TO
CAROLINE WHO'S HERE
CONGRADULATIONS.
AND CAROLINE JOINS A CHARLATAN --
AERIAL ARIAL IS YOU AND YOUR
BEAUTIFUL FAMILY THAT TO YOU
HAVE WHAT THIS YEAR SO IT'S SO
GREAT TO SEE.
ALL OF YOU.
YOU EVEN HAD YOUR NAME PRINTED
IN THE GUINNESS BOOK OF WORLD
RECORDS.
INCREDIBLE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN YOU
JOIN WITH OTHER SURFERS IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH TO SET THE
WORLD RECORD FOR THE MOST PEOPLE
TO RIDE ON A SINGLE SURFBOARD
* REPORT WHICH HUGE THE BIG
BOARD.
AYE IS STILL BY THE
INTERNATIONAL SURFING MUSEUM IN
DOWNTOWN HUNTINGTON BEACH.
THE ORGANIZED SAID THEY WANTED
TO FIT MORE SURFERS ON TO THE
BOARD.
BUT THEY HAD TO MAKE ROOM FOR
YOUR FLEXING OF YOUR MUSCLE
[inaudible]
WELL.
WELL THERE'S BEEN SOME GREAT
MOMENTS WE GOT TO WITNESS IN
YOUR LIFE YOUR CAREER.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SOME
MOMENTS THAT WERE NEVER GONNA BE
ABLE TO SEE HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE YOU'RE
WRITING A THANK YOU NOTE TO
LOGGER LORENA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
FOR LETTING YOUR BILL OUT
APPROPRIATIONS --
YOU'RE SHOWING UP PROPERLY ON
TIME FOR LEGISLATIVE FLOOR
SEPARATE SICKENING.
YOU'RE FORMING A BROMANCE.
WITH ASSEMBLYMAN IAN CALDERON.
YOU'RE NOT KNOWING WHERE THE
CAMERAS ARE WHETHER IT'S IN THIS
CHAMBER.
OR OUTSIDE OF THE BUILDING.
AND FINALLY WILL NEVER SEE YOU.
LISTENING TO THE WORDS.
POINT WELL TAKEN MISTER ALAN.
BUT ONE THING THAT I DO HAVE TO
SAY IS THAT TRAVIS ALLEN YOU
HAVE PRESS THE BOUNDARIES ON
DISSENT HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
AT A TIME WHEN SUMMER SEEKING
DESCENT.
WORKS TERMINATION OF OTHER
POINTS OF VIEW WHETHER IT'S IN
THE LEGISLATURE HERE WITH IN
CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO THINK AT THIS POINT WE
WON'T GET TO SEE YOU.
BECOME OUR NEXT GOVERNOR.
BUT I THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
GREAT [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY AFTER YOU COULD
AFTER YOU TO TERMS.
AND THE GOVERNOR WE COULD HAVE
SEEN THEM PUT YOUR GUBERNATORIAL
PAINTING.
COMMISSION FOR DISPLAY IN THE
CAPITAL IN HONOR OF YOUR PUBLIC
SERVICE PERMISSION USE A PROPER
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
IT.
SOME WOMEN TRAVIS ALLEN.
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT YOU DESERVE
THIS RECOGNITION FOR YOUR CAREER
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
I WISH SINCERELY YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY.
THE BEST IN YOUR FUTURE
ENDEAVORS WHICH I'M SURE
INCLUDES A PART IN PUBLIC LIFE I
KNOW YOU'LL DO WELL.
AND THIS IS YOUR PARTING GIFTS
BUT I GIVE TO YOU.
IN WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN YOUR
GUBERNATORIAL PAINTING WHICH I
HOPE WILL TO BE DISPLAYED AT
SOME POINT IN THIS BUILDING.
CONGRADULATIONS TRAVIS ON YOUR
TERMS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
WELL I WAS EXPECTING THE PROP
BUT WOULD BE --
TRAVIS ALLEN NOW SITTING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S CHAIR.
WHAT IS OUR LIVES WITH DIFFERENT?
IN JUST A LOOKS LIKE GOAT IN
JUST SORT YEAR.
ANYWAY I TRAVIS SAW OR THE
MISSING.
U. S. MY SEAT MATE.
WHEN I ARRIVED TO HOW ASSIST
SITTING ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE?
OF THE CHAMBER.
AND THERE YOU ARE LEFT ME IN THE
TEAM OVER HERE AND I FOLLOWED
YOU AND THEN THE STEER YOUR
SHIPMATE DOT AND ARE NOW.
WHO WOULD BE?
MAY HOLD THE ENEMY I'VE KNOWN
YOU.
ARE EVEN BEFORE I GOT HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
AND NOT MANY DIFFERENT --
POLITICAL EVENTS.
AND HE HAS BEEN NOT TOUCHING ME
EVERY TIME.
I MET YOU.
DO KNOW WHAT THAT.
TESTING OUR QUESTION WAS.
TO WHAT'S MY NAME WAS MY FITNESS
[inaudible]
BECAUSE I WHEN CALLING HIM ALAN
TRAVIS AUTO TRAVIS AND I
COULDN'T.
ANYWAY -- I
WAS A TEASING HIM EVERY TIME WE
IN WHEN HE WAS WALKING AND HAY
GOVERNOR.
AND HE WAS SO SOMEDAY SOMEDAY SO
WHO KNOWS I HIS ARE STILL YOUNG.
AND THAT WE ARE HOLE --
FOR THAT --
SOMEDAY ó AND THE GOVERNOR'S
TO A DESK.
MY IN THE MEANTIME I'LL BE
MISSING YOU.
LEFT MY SEAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI.
THIS MONDAY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I GUESS.
NOT EVERYBODY GOT THE WORD THIS
IS IN A ROAST --
SO PERHAPS THE OTHER MEMBER FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH NEXT TIME WE'LL.
GET THE MEMO --
TRAVIS I'VE HAD.
A PLEASURE SERVING WITH YOU
APPEAR I THINK YOU HAVE THE MOST
COURAGE OUT OF THE MOST.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO CRITICIZE YOU OR WHO
LAUGHED IT OFF.
WHEN YOU CHOSE TO RUN FOR
GOVERNOR?
I DIDN'T SEE ANYBODY ELSE
STEPPING UP TO THE PLATE.
AND YOU DID BECAUSE YOU SEE YOU
STOOD UP FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN
AND YOU SAID VERY CLEARLY YOU'RE
GONNA FIGHT FOR CALIFORNIA WHEN
YOU FELT.
WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
CALIFORNIA AND YOU TOOK ALL THE
ERRORS THAT WERE SLUNG AT YOU.
AND YOU DID IT WITH A SMILE ON
YOUR FACE YOUR HEAD HELD HIGH.
AND YOU DID A FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
SHARE YOUR VALUES AND THAT'S
SOMETHING TO BE PROUD OF
CERTAINLY NOT SOMETHING TO MOCK.
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR --
YOUR FAMILY IS BEAUTIFUL YOU ARE
BLESSED MAN NAY IN THAT
BEAUTIFUL BABY GIRL THAT WOULD
TO MEMORY THERE IN YOUR
BEAUTIFUL WIFE AND WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY MISS YOU.
AND YOUR VERY DISTINCT WAY OF
CALLING SOMEBODY OUT FOR SOME OF
THE NONSENSE BACK TO YOU HERE ON
THIS FLOOR TODAY.
MAKES.
BACON IS MELENDEZ MISTER LACKEY
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS. FOR
SOME OF YOU YOU KNOW REALIZE
THAT -- WHEN
I FIRST GOT HERE TO THE ASSEMBLY
TRAVIS WAS MY SEAT MATE
[inaudible]
AND I'M I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR
THAT.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT --
I'M ALSO THANKFUL THAT I DIDN'T
ALWAYS LISTEN BECAUSE HE ALWAYS
WANTED ME TO SPEAK.
AND HE JUST HAS A DIFFERENT
ENERGY THAN I DO IN A DIFFERENT.
STYLE OF OF TRYING TO ADVOCATE.
WHAT HE BELIEVES AND?
BUT I REALLY DO ADMIRE THE FACT.
THAT HE IS TRULY COMMITTED TO
WHAT HE BELIEVES AND AND
UNAFRAID.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS A TRAIT
THAT WE SHOULD ALL ADMIRE.
AND THE I DO ADMIRE IT AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
SETTING THAT EXAMPLE.
ALL THE WAY TO THE END.
AND IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE THAT
YOU'RE NOT ALONE ANYMORE THAT
YOU'RE ENJOYING WHAT'S MOST
BIBLE [inaudible]
YOUR FAMILY [inaudible]
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY MR
STEINER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF MEETING
TRAVIS WHEN HE FIRST CAME OUT TO
MY DISTRICT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND WALKED PRECINCTS AND PUT
YARD SIGNS INTO A LOT OF HOMES.
AND THEN ICE ON THE NEXT TIME A
YOUNG REPUBLICANS EVENT WHERE HE
WAS SPONSORING THE WHOLE THING
AND THEN THE NEXT YOUNG
REPUBLICAN THEN THE NEXT YOUNG
REPUBLICAN AND TRAVIS HAD AN
ARMY.
OF PEOPLE OUT THERE KNOCKING ON
DOORS AND GETTING THE MESSAGE
OUT THERE OF WHY IT MATTERED TO
SHOW UP WHY IT MATTERED TO CARE
AND WHAT WAS IN IT FOR THEM
TRAVIS HAD THE PASSION.
THAT I SAW LACKING IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE POLITICAL OFFICE FOR SO
LONG AND IT GAVE ME THE SENSE OF
LIKE WOW YOU KNOW WHAT I'M DOING
SOMETHING THAT REALLY MATTERS.
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF YOU MAY I
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE I WANT
TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
FAMILY I THINK YOUR WIFE IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY DELIGHTFUL YOUR TWO
DAUGHTERS ARE BEAUTIFUL AND YOU
ARE VERY BLAST.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL FUTURE
AND I'M JUST GLAD THAT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO BE A PART OF YOUR YOUR
LAST FOUR YEARS TRAVIS.
THEY CAN BE STEINORTH.
YOU GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THINK MISTER SPEAKER WHAT CAN I
SAY ABOUT TRAVIS ALLEN YOU KNOW
A WE'VE HAD A GREAT FRIENDSHIP.
THE TIME THAT WE'VE SERVED
TOGETHER HERE --
IN THE ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
AND THE AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
CELIBATE TRAVIS IS DEFINITELY
THE CONSERVATIVE ENERGY
PERSONIFIED --
YOU KNOW HE NEVER STOPS I DON'T
THINK HE EVER SLEEPS.
YOU KNOW IN A AND WHEN I FIRST
CAME IN HERE HE WAS ALWAYS ONE
TO COME OUT OF SIGHT QUE HERE'S
HERE'S WHAT WE SHOULD DO LET'S
TALK STRATEGY YOU KNOW LET'S.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE A LOT OF YOUR
SPEECHES SEEN ON AND HE ALWAYS
ENCOURAGED ME.
AND THAT MEANT A LOT TO A A
LEGISLATOR WHO WAS JUST COMING
IN.
AND THE TRYING TO FIND HIS PLACE --
YOU KNOW IN THIS BODY AND ALWAYS
VERY ENCOURAGING AYE MEMBER --
AND SOME VERY GOOD MEMORIES BUT
ONE OF THEM IS WHEN HE CAME IN
MY OFFICE WITH THE BOOK.
THEY SAID YOU NEED TO READ THIS
BOOK RIGHT HERE YOU KNOW.
AND AND THE VERY AT OUT WILL GET
INTO THE DETAILS BECAUSE
PROBABLY HALF OF THIS ROOM
PUBLIC DOESN'T LIKE IT VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
BUT IT.
IT EXEMPLIFIED TRAVIS IN THAT IT
SAID -- THE
FORWARD OF THE BOOK --
SAID.
EVERYBODY'S GOT A GAME PLAN
UNTIL YOU PUNCH HIM IN THE MOUTH.
THE POINT BEING IS THAT TIME.
NO SOMETIMES YOU GOT TO DO THE
AGGRESSIVE THING SOMETIMES YOU
GOTTA CATCH PEOPLE OFF GUARD.
AND THEN POLITICS TO DRIVE HOME
A POINT TO DRIVE HOME.
A MESSAGE YOU KNOW --
AND I THINK TRAVIS THROUGHOUT
YOUR TIME HERE YOU HAVE ALWAYS.
YOU'VE ALWAYS DONE THAT YOU
STOOD UP FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN
YOU DON'T MAKE ANY BONES ABOUT
IT.
AND EVEN THOUGH PEOPLE MAY
DISAGREE AT TIMES AND THEY
RESPECT YOU FOR THE FACT THAT
YOU STAND FOR YOUR BELIEVE STAMP
YOUR PRINCIPLES AND I THINK
THAT'S WE SHOULD ALL BE
DEDICATED.
TO THEM.
THE OTHER THING THAT COMES TO
MIND IS THE TIME THAT WE BOTH
VOTED NO ON SOMETHING IN OUR
BUTTON ARE NO BUTTON BROKE AT
THE VERY EXACT SAME TIME POPPED
OFF OF OUR DESKS.
AND I LOOKED OVER TRAVIS YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT I SAID MAN THAT MUST
OF BEEN A REALLY BAD BILL.
AND AND IT WAS --
SORRY IF THAT WAS YOUR BILL --
COLLEAGUES --
BUT TRAVIS SAID YOU KNOW THE
PRECIADO THE TIME --
APPRECIATED THE ENERGY.
AND YOU KNOW EVEN MORE SO THE
THING THAT I'VE ENJOYED SEEING
AS YOU STEPPING INTO A
FATHERHOOD ROLE AND AND AND HOW
MUCH HOW SERIOUSLY YOU TAKE THAT --
YOU KNOW THE SMILE ON YOUR FACE
WHEN YOU FIRST CAME IN HERE YOU
SAID HEY MAN I HAVE A BEAUTIFUL
DAUGHTER.
AND WIFE AND PAVE AND AND WHEN
HE SAID HEY WE'VE GOT ONE MORE
ON THE WAY --
SO THAT'S BEEN AWESOME DE TO
WATCH AS WELL MAN I WISH YOU THE
BEST OF LUCK IN ALL YOUR FUTURE
ENDEAVORS.
AND WE WE ARE GOING TO MISS YOU
AROUND HERE.
EVEN IF SOME OF THESE FOLKS
MIGHT NOT ADMIT IT THEY ARE
GOING TO MISS YOUR RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
YOU'RE BROKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TI I
DON'T KNOW OF WHAT TO SAY --
I I FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE RESIDENTS OF
ORANGE COUNTY FOR STEPPING UP TO
THE PLATE.
AND OF BEING ONE OF OUR
REPRESENTATIVES --
AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM HUNTINGTON
BEACH SAID I THINK YOU REALLY
FIRST MAJOR MARK ON THAT IRING --
THE FOLKS IN LOS ANGELES THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW WE LIVE AT
THE BEACH NOW FAMILIES COME DOWN
THOUGH BRING FOOD DOWN THOUGH
SIT DOWN OR SUNSET STARTLES
BONFIRE SENATE'S.
KIDS REMEMBER THAT THE REST OF
THE LIFE AND THEN THEY BRING
THEIR CHILDREN DOWN IT IT'S JUST.
IT'S A IT'S A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THING AND IT JUST IT
REALLY STRUCK A CHORD IN YOUR
LEADER ON THAT SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT --
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS --
I WANNA SHARE TWO STORIES ONCE
ALREADY BEEN SHARED BY.
THE TWO THINGS I REMEMBER ABOUT
YOU IS THAT IT'S INAPPROPRIATE
ARE.
YOU WALKED IN HERE ON CRUTCHES
WOULD SUNGLASSES I'M LIKE DUDE
WHAT DO YOU DO.
GOING ON THE MEMBERS LARGER SUM
NAM I GOT IT I GOT IT AND YOU
DIDN'T YOU SPOKE ON THE FLOOR
NOT ONCE BUT TWICE [inaudible]
AND I JOKED WITH THE ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IT WAS KINDA LIKE A
WEEKEND OF BERNIE SEEMED
[inaudible]
TO AND THE OTHER THING I'LL SAY
THAT PROBABLY ONLY.
CALLING FROM FULLER TEN OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ANAHEIM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE AND OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH
[inaudible]
WOULD KNOW [inaudible]
IS THAT.
EVERY MONDAY MORNING.
OR THURSDAY AFTERNOON.
WE'D BE SITTING ON SOUTHWEST
FLIGHT.
TWELVE FORTY TWO AND THERE'D BE
A PAGE.
YES SIR COULD DURING THE CALL
BUTTON IF THERE'S A TRAVIS ALLEN
ON THE PLANE.
EVERY TIME HE WOULD BE THE LAST
INDIVIDUAL ON THE PLANE.
COMING PAROLIN DOWN THE AISLE.
TAKE IN THE LAST MIDDLE CITY.
I DON'T LIKE.
SCHOOL OWNER WOULD.
BARELY BARELY MADE THE FLIGHTS
BEFORE THEY CLOSE THE DOOR.
SO.
THOSE ARE THE TWO MEMORIES I
HAVE THE TRAVIS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO RUN INTO YOU AT THE
BEACH ONE MORE BACK HOME.
ARIEL IT'S GREAT TO SEE AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS NOW IF YOU NEED
US TO TAKE HIM OFF YOUR HANDS I
KNOW HE'S GONNA BE AROUND A LOT
MORE NOW.
YOU KNOW JUST LET US NOW.
AND WE CAN TAKE IT OFF YOUR
HANDS FOR DARE TO HEAR FEE GETS
TO BE A PROBLEM BUT TRAVIS THANK
YOUR SERVICE AND ENJOY YOUR
FAMILY GOES BY FAST [inaudible]
HERE -- AND
NOW HE'S AS TALL AS ME SO REALLY
DOES GO BY FAST BUT GOOD LUCK
TRAVIS.
THANK YOU MISTER BRO MISTER
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES TRAVIS IT'S AN HONOR
TO RISE --
IT'S JUST REFLECT UPON YOUR TIME
HERE [inaudible]
AND THIS BEING CALIFORNIA NEW
BEING THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND ON THIS DAY WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT.
JOHN MCCAIN LINE IS STEVEN
WASHING DE SEE.
AND FOR THOSE YOU THAT I GOT TO
THE BUNDLE OF STICKS.
THEIR COVER ON THE FLOOR.
TONIGHT.
I HEARD A LONG TIME AGO THE
EXPRESSION.
SPEAKING OF CALIFORNIA.
IT TAKES ALL KINDS TO FILL A
FREEWAY.
YOU NO WHICH IS A VERY
CALIFORNIA EXPRESSION FOR JUST A
VARIETY [inaudible]
OF LIFE.
AND I THINK --
I CAN ASSURE YOU ALL.
THIS IS PROBABLY MY FORTY FIRST.
LAST NIGHT OF SECTION.
IN MY CAREER THAT I'VE BEEN
AROUND [inaudible]
THERE'S ALWAYS.
BIG PERSONALITIES IN THIS
BUILDING.
THERE'S ALWAYS PEOPLE WERE SORT
OF IN THE MIDDLE.
THERE'S ALWAYS PEOPLE WHO TEST
THE BOUNDARIES.
AND YET THIS IS THIS GREEN
CARPET.
THAT WE TALK ABOUT. FOR WHICH
YOU ALWAYS HEAR PRIVILEGES
[inaudible]
TRAVIS ALLEN.
WHEN THE GREEN CARPET?
WHERE WE COME AND TRY TO WORK ON
THE FUTURE TOGETHER?
AND I THINK --
WE'RE IN AN ERA CERTAINLY WIN
THE BOUNDARIES OF WHAT OUR
DEMOCRACY IS IN ITS MEANING OF
BEING TEST.
AND WHAT IS MOST ASSUREDLY IS A
TIME IN WHICH PEOPLE COME
TOGETHER KIND WORK ON THE FUTURE.
WITH DIFFERENT VIEWPOINTS WE
REPRESENT. FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
ALMOST FORTY MILLION PEOPLE VERY
DIVERGENT VIEWPOINTS.
AND THERE IS AN ERROR IN THIS
INSTITUTION WHEN IT WAS EASIER
FOR MEMBERS ACROSS THE AISLE. TO
WORK THINGS OUT.
I REMEMBER IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE AFTER ALL OVER PRINT
EARTHQUAKE.
KEN MATTER WILLIE BROWN MAJORITY
LEADER OF THE SENATE SPEAKER IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
DID A HANDSHAKE DEAL. TO RAISE
TAXES TO REBUILD OUR STATE.
BECAUSE IT WAS MOST OFFICIAL WAY.
TO MOVE WITH ALACRITY.
AND BUILD A BETTER FUTURE FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY.
YOU KNOW YOU.
YOU PROBABLY TWIST PEOPLE'S TAIL
MOUNT AGAINST MY FIRST BOSS LIKE
TO SAY [inaudible]
BUT A THIS CHALLENGER JUST KIND
OF WORKING TOGETHER.
RECOVERING THE MEANING OF THIS
INSTITUTION.
BUT WE ALL REPRESENT DIFFERENT
VIEW POINTS.
AND TO TAKE US BACK IN THE
DIRECTION OF RESPECTED EVERY
MEMBER HERE. FOR THE
CONSTITUENCIES WHO REPRESENT FOR
THE VIEW POINT TO REPRESENT.
I'VE ALWAYS FELT THAT REPRESENT
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH ABOUT THE
REPRESENTATIVES IT'S FINDING
REPRESENT OF IDEAS.
AND FOR THIS WE JUST NEED ALL OF
THESE DIVERSE VOICES WHO WAY AND
TO HELP US FIND.
A WORKING CENTER.
SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO IN OUR
DELIBERATIONS TRYING FIND A
WORKABLE CENTER.
AND EVERY VOICE MATTERS.
EVEN THOSE THAT SORT OF MAKE A
SMASHER TEETH THAT.
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE HERE.
THAT I DO THINK YOU REPRESENT ON
ASPECT OF OUR DEMOCRACY THAT IS
PRECIOUS TO US ALL.
THAT WE BRING OUR CONSTITUENCIES
HERE WE ADVOCATE FOR THAT WOULD
TRY TO FIND A WORKABLE CENTER.
AND HOPEFULLY WE EMBODY THE
IDEALS OF WHAT. TO FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT [inaudible]
AND I DEFTLY FEEL THAT WHAT WE
DO HERE CALIFORNIA.
IS IMPORTANT THE NATION PORT OF
THE GLOW --
NOT JUST BECAUSE THE SIZE OF OUR
ECONOMY BECAUSE THE SIZE OF OUR
IDEALS.
AND IT REMAINS TRUE IS THE
WRITER THE BOOK OF PROVERBS SAID
SO LONG AGO.
AS IRON SHARPENS IRON SO ONE
PERSON SHARPENS ANOTHER.
AND MAY WE ALL GET SHARPER IN
OUR WORK --
HERE.
BIGGEST COOLEY MISTER THURMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MY MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES --
HAVE S. -- I
DON'T HAVE A BUDGET JOKES FOR
YOU.
I DON'T HAVE ANY PLANS FOR YOU I
THINK --
HERE IT'S MOST OF THOSE DURING
THE TIME HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY --
I DO YOU THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU AND YOUR
BEAUTIFUL FAMILY.
AND CONGRATULATE YOU BECAUSE IT
IS VERY HARD TO PUT YOUR NAME ON
THE BALLOT.
INTO TRYING REPRESENT DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES OF A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN YOUR DISTRICT
AND WHILE.
OUR VIEWPOINTS ARE PROBABLY
QUITE OPPOSITE IN.
THERE'S NO SURFING IN MY
DISTRICT AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE'VE FOUND THE BUDGET ISSUES
THAT WE AGREE UPON.
I THINK ANYONE WHO PUTS THEIR
NAME ON THE BALLOT ATTEMPTS TO
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE THERE
DISTRICT --
DESERVES --
TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED --
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE SEATS ARE I
HAVE BEEN HERE SINCE THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED'S.
IN THE SCHEMEOF THINGS ONLY A
FEW.
ONLY A HANDFUL OF PEOPLE.
HAVE SAT IN THE SEATS AND YOU
CAN COUNT YOURSELF AMONG THEM.
AND HOPEFULLY YOUR CHILDREN WILL
REMEMBER THAT AND PERHAPS THEY
TOO WILL ASPIRE TO SERVE IN THE
VERY SEATS WHERE THEY ARE
SITTING RIGHT NOW --
YOU I RESPECT YOU FOR YOUR
COURAGE AND NOT BEING AFRAID. TO
OFFER A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
WAS FAR FROM MY PERSPECTIVE --
BUT IT SAYS A LOT THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO SAY.
EVEN WHEN YOU'RE THE ONLY PERSON
WHO WOULD GET UP TO SAY.
AND NOT TO PUT YOUR NAME ON THE
BALLOT.
AND RUN FOR STATEWIDE OFFICE IS
A HUGE HUGE --
CHALLENGE AND IF YOU TOOK THAT
ON AND YOU GOT OUT THERE AND YOU
JUST KEPT ON GOING TO BLOW OUR
DISCOURSE. TO THIS CONVERSATION --
AS I SAID I KNOW THERE ARE A LOT
OF THINGS WE'VE AGREED ON ON A
POLICY LEVEL BUT I THINK WE
AGREE ON THIS.
AND THAT'S LOVE FOR FAMILY.
LOVE FOR THIS INSTITUTION LOVE
FOR THIS STATE ENOUGH FOR THIS
COUNTRY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MISTER CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
MY MATH.
ME AND TRANSIT AYE WE WE
CONNECTED EARLY ON WHEN WE FIRST
GOT ELECTED BECAUSE WE CAME
TOGETHER AND WE SHARE THE
PASSING OF SURFING AND SO WE
TALKED ALL THE TIME ABOUT
SURFING IN WHERE YOU'VE GONE.
YOU NOW WHERE I'VE GONE WHERE
HE'S GONE IN DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE WANTED TO DO RELEASE
INTO SURFING AND AND I WAS
ALWAYS GETTING THESE RANDOM TEXT
TO BEGIN A DUTY IN.
HERE SWELLED GOING WHO I'M GOING
THERE FOR THE WEEKEND YOU DOWN
LIKE.
GIVE IT A FIVE HOUR FLIGHT.
AND I'M MARY THERE'S NO WAY.
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN BUT GOOD
LUCK ANY WOULD DO IT A FLAT
ALIVE FOR THE WEEKEND TO SWELL
AND COME BACK TO BE YOU KNOW.
THE HERE FOR MONDAY LATE FOR
SESSION AND YOU KNOW HOW.
IT WAS ALWAYS REALLY COOL THOUGH
THAT HE WAS JUST YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE HIS DRIVE.
AND YOU KNOW.
HE WAS WHO HE WAS IN THE NEVER
APOLOGIZE FOR AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S AN ADMIRABLE THING --
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT
OF US THAT WOULD DISAGREE WITH
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HE SAID
HE CERTAINLY MADE MY JOB MORE
DIFFICULT.
BUT IT I HAVE BUT I THINK HE'S A
GOOD PERSON AT ITS CORE IN AND
AND I I'M SO HAPPY --
TO SEE WHERE HE'S COME THAT.
THE POINT IN HIS LIFE WHERE HE
SAT WITH HIS BEAUTIFUL FAMILY WE
GIVE YOU GET REALLY.
GORGEOUS FAMILY SHOULD BE SO
PROUD OF AND HOW IMPORTANT LINE
IS TO ME AND ALL OF US --
AND USE YOUR VERY FORTUNATE --
TRAVIS I WE WE WE SHARED
SOMETHING THAT I'LL NEVER FORGET --
EARLY ON YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS
WAVE IT'S CALLED THERE'S THIS
PLACE CALLED HOLLISTER RANCH
WITH.
THE LAND IS PRIVATE BUT THE
BEACHES ARE PUBLIC --
AND IT'S KIND OF A MYTH WITHIN
SERVING BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO GET THERE BECAUSE
THE PRIVATE LAND THERE'S REALLY
NO ACCESS THERE.
AND SO IF YOU WANT TO SERVE
THEIR YOU CAN AND YOU GOT TO
DEAL WITH THE LOCALS WHO ARE THE
RESIDENTS ARE NOT GOING TO
NECESSARILY BE ALL THAT FRIENDLY.
BECAUSE THAT'S THEIR HOME THEIR
THE LOCALS ARE BUT YOU PROBABLY
GOT A WALK ABOUT THREE MILES IN
ORDER TO GET IN IF YOU DON'T
KNOW SOMEBODY THAT'S GONNA ALLOW
YOU TO GET IN THERE AND AND YOU
HAVE TO KNOW SOME OF YOU
ACTUALLY.
LIVES THERE EYES OF WHAT THE GUY
FOR THE START OF PATAGONIA LIVES
JIM CAMERON HAS A HOUSE THERE
AND THEY'RE TOTALLY OFF THE GRID
THERE'S THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE LIVING OFF
THE GRID.
THAT SOLAR POWER IN THAT LITTLE
SMALL REFRIGERATORS --
AND AND SO WE WERE ABLE TO FIND
A WAY TO TO GET IN THERE TO GET
A TOUR OF THE PLACE AND WE
TURNED IT THIS WHOLE DAY WE GOT
A TOUR WE TORE THE PLACE.
WE GOT TO SERVE TWICE THERE'S
COUPLE DIFFERENT SURF SPOTS WE
SERVED OUR MORNING SESSION IN
THE WE SERVED AFTERNOON SESSION.
AND IT WAS A REALLY GOOD TIME WE
JUST CAO TALKED ABOUT OUR LIVES
AND THINGS THAT WERE IMPORTANT
TO US AND YOU KNOW WE GOT TO
KNOW EACH OTHER AS PEOPLE AND
AND I KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW WHAT HE'S TALKING
PUBLICLY AND HE YOU KNOW HE SAYS
CERTAINLY I I I I THINK THAT
THERE ARE. TWO DIFFERENT SIDES
OF TRAVIS I AND I GOT TO SEE HIS
HUMAN SIDE I GOT TO SEE WHO IS --
AS AS AN INDIVIDUAL --
WE GIVE YOU KNOW THAT SOMEBODY
WHO CLEARLY LOVES HIS FAMILY AND
HIS KIDS AND AND YOU'RE A GOOD
GUY BROWN AND I REALLY
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW. ONE DAY I HOPE WE
GET TO GO IN CONCERT AGAIN IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT AS YOU NOW
UNDERSTAND WITH KIDS.
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE MAY YEAH AND
BY THE WAY THE SERIAL THAT
CAROLINE'S EATING.
CHARLIE STILL LEADS IT MY
CHARLIE SILLY THAT AND GOING TO
GO AWAY.
IT'S LIKE A FAVORITE --
BUT MAN.
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF FUN I'M GOING.
TO AND I'M GONNA MISS HAVING YOU
HERE NOT HERE BUT HAVING YOU
HERE.
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ALWAYS CALL ME UP YOUR
BODY AND NOW YOU BE A BODY FOR
LIFE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
MR MATHIS DIRECTNESS.
SO LOT OF LIKE IT'S IS ALREADY
KIND OF BEEN SAID I I THINK THE
FIRST TIME I MET TRAVIS WAS THAT
A MY FIRST REPUBLICAN PARTY
CONVENTION IN AT THIS HUGE
ENTOURAGE AND IT WAS T. A. T.
A.'S MAN.
AND AND THEN I GOT TO KNOW
TRAVIS AND I I DIDN'T GET TO GO
SURFING WITH THEM BUT WE DIDN'T
GET TO GO WAKE BOARDING A COUPLE
OF TIMES.
AND AND I'LL NEVER FORGET WHEN
HE ASKED TO BORROW MY TRUCK TO
MOVE HIS BOAT.
AND IN DID HAVE THE BALL IN HOW
THE WIRING IS THIS HUGE MASS
THINGS LIKE DID WHERE WE TALK
ABOUT WE FIGURE THIS OUT.
WE WE GOTTA MAKE TAHOE.
BUT WHEN EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT
YOUR DRIVE MAN.
IT DIDN'T MATTER WHAT YOU WERE
DOING.
YOUR FULL THROTTLE.
ON EVERYTHING YOU DO.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
EVERYBODY LOVES ABOUT SHIA.
AND I I REMEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
TELL ME YOU KNOW HATE YOU DON'T
TO BE A DAD.
AND AND I KNOW A LOT OF US FOR
LIKE A WELCOME TO THE DADS*
IS.
AND AND THEN WE SAW THIS LOVELY
ICONIC PHOTO YOU WITH THE
SUNGLASSES AND THE CRUTCHES AND
A. ARMOR JOKING WITH YOU GOING.
THAT'S THE LAST TIME WE'LL EVER
TALK BACK TO OUR LOCAL TO BEING
MARRIED --
BUT NOW THAT WE ALL WISH YOU
WELL.
AND YOU KNOW WE KNOW YOU WILL
SEE AROUND.
SHELVE JUST TAKE CARE ENJOY THE
FAMILY AND WILL SEE AGAIN.
THANK YOU SIR.
SEEN NO OTHER QUESTIONS BIG
[inaudible]
MR OUR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR DEATH.
WHAT ONE OR?
NO A I JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS BEEN INCREDIBLE
HONOR. TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS CAPACITY IT'S
INCREDIBLE ON BUILDING MY FAMILY
UP HERE WHEN I WAS FIRST WORN IN
ACTION BROUGHT MY MY MOTHER CHU
SAT NEXT TO ME.
AND NOW I'M JOINED BY THE NEXT
GENERATION I'M.
MY CHAU OFFICE LITTLE SQUIRMY
BABY RIGHT HERE.
MY IS MY YOUNGEST REYES BABY
CAROLINE NINE MONTHS OLD.
AND THEN THERE'S MY NINE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER RIGHT NEXT YEAR
CHARLOTTE.
AND MY BEAUTIFUL WIFE ARIELLE.
AND I GOTTA TELL YOU GUYS.
THIS IS BEEN.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE --
IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE
VINEGAR WILL SERVE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA IT'S A QUICK STORY.
WHEN I FIRST GOT IN --
SPEAKER JOHN PEREZ WAS OUR
SPEAKER.
I THINK SHE'S GOT A HUNGRY TIRED
RIGHT NOW.
SPEAKER JOHN PEREZ WAS SPEAKER
AND HE WAS A BIG GUY IN
LITERALLY EVERY SENSE OF THE
WORD.
CAST A SHADOW ENTIRE BUILDING.
AND I HAD NO IDEA WHO THIS GUY
WAS ANY INVITED ME TO LUNCH A
COUPLE OF YOUNG MEMBERS.
AND WE WERE IN HIS OFFICE AND I
STARTED ASKING SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT UNIONS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
THERE IS LIKE RECENTLY UNION
SHUTDOWN OF SOME GROCERY STORES.
AND I I KNOW MISS GONZALEZ WOULD
APPRECIATE THIS.
AND I START ASKING SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT YOU KNOW WHY WAS
REALLY NECESSARY TO PUT THESE
WORKS OUT A DIFFERENT WAY.
AND IN JOHN YOU CHOOSE CREDIT
WAS VERY VERY CIVIL VERY
TACTFULLY CEO.
OR TO TALK BUSINESS LUNCH BUT
YOU SEE.
I'VE NEVER REALLY BEEN MUCH OF A
POLITICIAN AND I HAD NO IDEA OF
THE SUBTLETY YOU CAME WITH BEING
THE SPEAKER.
SO OF COURSE I PRESSED ON AND I
KEPT ON THE CURIOUS
HAVING NO CLUE THAT HE WAS GOING
TO COST ME ALL OF MY COMMITTEES
AND THEY GET THE BOOT INTO THE
SMALLEST OBVIOUS IN THE ENTIRE
BUILDING THE VERY NEXT DAY.
SO THAT WAS MILDLY FIRST LESSONS
BUILDING BUT YOU KNOW THAT THE
THE NEWSPAPERS ASK ME NO TRAVIS
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS THIS YOU KNOW BEGIN SMALL
STARTED LOSING YOUR COMMITTEES.
AND I SAID LOOK YOU KNOW IT'S AN
HONOR TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IN ANY OFFICE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AND I YOU KNOW I FEEL THAT
WAY EXACTLY SAME TODAY AS I FELT
THIS VERY FIRST DAY WALKING ON
THE FLOOR AFTER SIX YEARS
CERTAIN PEOPLE CALIFORNIA'S YOU
ALL WELL KNOW WHY I RAN FOR
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE.
AND A RED FOR A VERY SIMPLE
REASON WHICH IS I'VE THE VISION
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE VISION IS
VERY SIMPLE I BELIEVE THAT
CERTAIN THINGS MATTER IN THE
STATE.
THINGS LIKE JUSTICE THINGS LIKE
EQUALITY THINGS LIKE LOW TAXES
WHO GET GREAT BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT STRONG BORDERS
RESPECT FOR THE CONSTITUTION ALL
OF THESE THINGS THAT I BELIEVE
IT NEEDS TO BE A CALIFORNIAN
AMERICAN.
AND YES EVEN A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SURFER.
AND AND SOMETIMES AS YOU KNOW I
MIGHT BE THE ONLY PERSON
SPEAKING ON THIS FLOOR SOMETIMES
A YOU KNOW I MIGHT BE THE ONLY
PERSON VOTE NO.
AND AS JEANS GALLAGHER POINT OUT
I THINK I VOTED NO TO ME TIMES
I'VE I'VE YOU BROKEN THE BUTTON
OFF MY DESK.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU.
THERE ARE MANY VOICES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE REPRESENT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE'S FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
THAT NEVER GET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EVEN KNOW WHAT GOES ON HERE
THEY THEY'RE SO FAR REMOVED FROM
POLITICS THEY DO SEE THE NET
EFFECT OF OF WHAT WE DECIDE
APPEAR.
IN THE REASON IRAN WAS VERY
SIMPLE I BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS BALANCE AND I STILL FEEL
THAT VERY STRONGLY.
SO I FELT THAT WAS MY BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY REPRESENTED
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA IN THE BEST
CAPACITY POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING VERY SIMPLY THIS WAS
NEVER MY LIFE'S ASPIRATIONS BE
IN POLITICS THIS WAS NEVER DREAM
OF MINE.
MY DREAM WAS SIMPLY NEED YOU
RIGHT IN THE WORLD AND AFTER I
DID YOU MEASURE SUCCESS IN
BUSINESS I UNDERSTOOD THE DIVIDE
MEAN GIVEN MUCH THAT MUCH WOULD
BE EXPECTED.
AND IF I COULD SOMEHOW GIVE BACK
AND SOMEHOW MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE IN CALIFORNIA
BETTER PLACE.
AND I WOULD DO IF MY FULL BEING
WITH MY FULL ENERGY AND WITH
EVERY SINGLE BREATH THAT I'VE
HAD.
SO FOR ALL THE KIND WORDS DAY I
I I THANK YOU ALL SO VERY MUCH
IT'S AN HONOR TO SERVE WITH YOU
ALL.
I WAS IN THE DEBATES ARE JUST
COUPLE MONTHS AGO I YOU ME OF
OUR YOU KNOW HEARD WHERE LINES
IF IT GOT SPREAD AROUND THE
ENABLE THAT.
BUT THERE'S NEVER BOARD THAT
DEBATE WHERE THEY ASK YOU WHAT
YOUR BIGGEST SACRIFICE.
AND AND I ANSWER VERY CLEARLY
RUNNING FOR IN BEING IN
POLITICAL OFFICE BECAUSE I WILL
TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THAT THIS IS
OFTENTIMES.
A COMPLETELY THANKLESS JOB ALL
OF US HAD BETTER THINGS WE DO
WITH OUR TIME.
THERE'S THINGS WE DO WITH OUR
FAMILIES THEIR BUILDING OUR
BUSINESSES.
BUT INSTEAD WHICH USED TO BE
HERE AND TRY TO LEAD PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA DECIDE WHAT'S BEST
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT WE MAY
NEVER HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT THAT IS
THE HIGHEST SERVICE IT IS A
MASSIVE SACRIFICE.
BUT IT'S ALSO AN INCREDIBLE
HONOR AND IT'S BEEN MY HONOR.
SO WITH THAT --
I'M SURE --
THAT WE'RE ALL HERE FOR EACH
OTHER AGAIN AND GOD WILLING AND
MY MY WIFE WILLING TO HEAR A LOT
MORE FOR ME AS WELL.
THANKS SO MUCH AND YOU BETTER
BELIEVE WE'RE TAKE BACK
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THAT'S
MEMBERS PER ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING ITEMS TO
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY SEVEN OH NINE
MCCARTY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AB SEVEN FORTY SEVEN CABALLERO
TO WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE IN
AB NINE EIGHTY SEVEN COM OTHER
DIVE TO NATURAL RESOURCES. TO
COUNTER YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOIN WILL SUCCEED TO A
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES
TO ME TODAY.
DURING THE DINNER RECESS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO HEAR
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE DOT AND
ROOM FORTY TWO WILL.
TO AND NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN KAMLAGER-DOVE OF IN FOR
ROOM.
FOR FORTY SEVEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER
.
MEMBERS WILL STAND IN RECESS
UNDER CALL THE SPEAKER UNTIL.
SEVEN FIFTEEN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE WILL BE ME
ROOM.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN AGAIN MEMBERS WE
ARE UNDER RECESS FOR DINNER
UNDER CALL THE SPEAKER.
WE WILL RECONVENE AT SEVEN
FIFTEEN SHARP
.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING BACK INTO
SESSION PLEASE RETURN. TO YOUR
PLACES.
ON THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN. TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SO THAT WE MAY
[inaudible]
GO BACK.
IN THE SESSION
.
MISTER DALI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO TAKE THIS TIME.
TO I GIVE A FAREWELL TO OUR MY
GOOD FRIEND MARC STEINORTH WHO
HAS BEEN IN OUR CAUCUS FOR
SOMETIME AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SHARE A FEW OF THE
EXPERIENCES THAT WE'VE HAD OVER
THE DAYS.
AS A AS A FELLOW BUSINESS OWNER --
I FIND MYSELF I FIND MYSELF
CHATTING WITH MARK IN TALKING
ABOUT THE DETAILS.
OF WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE WELL
OF SEATTLE LOT MORE EMPLOYEES
AND I'VE EVER.
HAD TO MANAGE BUT HIS EXPERIENCE
IN BUSINESS --
THEY DID WELL TO OUR CAUCUS HIS
SUITS TO HUMOR --
I KNOW THAT --
SIMMER MAIENSCHEIN IN HIM --
I KNOW THESE MAY ACTUALLY
MAIENSCHEIN IS MISSING HIM NOT
NO OFFENSE THERE MISTER
GALLAGHER BUT I SAID I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SET BEHIND THEM.
AND BECAUSE THE AYE AYE YOU MOST
YOU PRIVATE I'M DEAF IN MY LEFT
EAR AND SO I WAS BECAUSE THE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT BUT I
WISH IT SHARE THIS WITH YOU THAT
THERE WAS NEVER A DULL MOMENT --
WHEN THEY WERE TOGETHER THEY
WERE CONSTANTLY DOING STUFF AND
I WAS ALWAYS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET IN ON IT BUT --
THEY CAN HAVE THEIR OWN LITTLE
LIKE.
BREAUX THING GOING ON THERE
ANYWAY.
MARK BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU --
I WISH YOU SUCCESS IN YOUR
FUTURE AND THANK YOU GOD BLESS.
BAKER IS VALID.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOU I MISTER SPEAKER
AND THAT MARKETS BEEN.
REALLY GREAT SERVING WITH YOU
YOU.
HAVE BROUGHT AT A PERSPECTIVE TO
THIS PLACE THAT AS A BUSINESS
OWNER WHOSE OWN MULTIPLE
BUSINESSES AND BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL IN YOUR PERSONAL LIFE
IS THAT MISTER DALLI SAID THAT
WHAT I MISS MOST IS THAT.
IS KIND OF THE SNARKY COMMENTS
YOU ALWAYS HAD --
SO YOU YOU HAVE TO ADMIT STARKEY
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH -- BUT
ALWAYS YOU KNOW HOW FUNNY YOU
ALWAYS WERE HOW ON HOW MUCH YOU
MADE CAUCUS LUNCHEON JOY BOL.
AND I'LL MISS YOU ON OUR LITTLE.
KINDA ISLAND OFF IN THE CORNER --
BUT I WISH IT I WISH YOU ALL THE
BEST I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA YOU'RE
STILL GOING TO DO GREAT THINGS --
AND IT'S BEEN GREAT SERVICE DO
SO ALL THE BEST TO YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY.
THANK YOU MR MAIENSCHEIN.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES AYE AYE TOO WILL MISS YOU
MARK BUT I WILL NOT BEING.
I WILL NOT MISS YOU --
BECAUSE PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THINK
THAT I AM YOU.
SO -- AND WE
HAD A WHEN I FIRST GOT HERE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN IT WAS A
HALF MISTER HADLEY.
MISTER STEINORTH AND ME AND I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES I
WAS I WAS MISTAKEN FOR MISTER
STEINORTH.
OR MISTER HADLEY SO --
EVEN BY MEMBERS OF MY OWN CAUCUS
SERVICE SO IT.
I WISH YOU THE BEST --
I WON'T MISS YOU FOR THAT BUT I
WILL MISS YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER STEINORTH.
MISTER MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YOU GUYS ARE VERY SLOW I KNOW
IT'S LATE BUT WE A LOT LONGER TO
GO.
MR MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE
THANK YOU ARE MISTER SPEAKER.
MARKER GONNA MISS YEAH.
YEAH THE THE TRUTH IS THAT THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS --
I WOULD TELL YOU THERE HAD NOT
BEEN THE HARDER WORKING MEMBER
OF THE ASSEMBLY THEN.
AND BEEN MARKED NOT ONLY WAS HE
DOING AT THIS WORK A FULL TIME
WHICH IS WE ALL KNOW IT'S MORE.
THAN A FULL TIME JOB BUT MARK
ALSO.
AND HAD HIS BUSINESS WHICH SHE
WORKED A FULL TIME.
SO ARE DISTRICTS --
R. RIGHT NEXT TO EACH OTHER NICE
TO SAY THAT I KNEW.
MARKS DISTRICTS IT JUST AS WELL
AS HE BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT WAS THE CASE BECAUSE MARK
WORKED HIS DISTRICT WAS AT
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE.
EVENT -- HE
KNOCKED ON AN AWFUL LOT OF I
KNOW THAT PEOPLE OF YOUR
DISTRICT --
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT YOU AS YOU
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THEM THEY WAS
PRETTY DIFFICULT FOR ME WHEN
MARK DECIDED.
I'D TO RUN FOR THE US SUPERVISOR
[inaudible]
BECAUSE MARK RAN AGAINST MY
FORMER BOSS NAM WHICH MADE IT A
LITTLE TOUGH.
AND WHAT I AM MEMBER TELLING
MARK WAS --
WAS MARK YOU PUT ANY KIND OF AN
AWKWARD POSITION YOU'RE KIND OF
PUT ME IN A PLACE WHERE.
EITHER HAVE TO SUPPORT MY MOTHER
BECAUSE SHE WAS I WAS THE CHIEF
OF STAFF TO HER IN HER JOB OR
ONE OF MY BEST FRIENDS --
MARKET I ARE GOOD FRIENDS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE GOOD FRIENDS --
IT'S SAD TO KNOW THAT YOU WILL
NOT BE SITTING BEHIND ME --
WHEN WE COME BACK IN SESSION IN
IN JANUARY --
BUT I KNOW THAT ANY TIME THAT
YOU NEED ME.
OR ANY TIME BUT I NEED YOU ARE
JUST A PHONE CALL AWAY --
SO -- ANYWAY
WE'RE GONNA MISCHIEF BLOOD
RATHER.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES MISTER
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
WELL I AM PLEASED TO RISE HERE
FOR YOU MARK --
COURSE I HAD TO AIR FORCE BASES
THE CLOSED IN THE EIGHTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THE NINETIES
[inaudible]
AND I I GUESS YOU COME OUT OF
THE CULTURE YOU KNOW WHAT WE NOT
IS SOMEBODY ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE AIRFORCE WAS A WING THAT
BABY.
THAT THAT'S HIM.
ARE I APPRECIATE YOUR ROLE
PARTNERSHIP OF THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES.
NOW STAND IN ORGANIZATION --
I GOT TO SAY YOUR CITY RANCHO
CUCAMONGA IS THE ONE THAT ALWAYS
BUGGED ME BECAUSE EVERYONE HEARD
RANCHO.
CUCAMONGA.
AND ALL THE OTHER RANCHERS
MISTAKE SORT OF WHERE THE YOUR
SHADOW.
WHICH INCLUDES RANCHO CORDOVA.
RANCHO MURRIETA.
RANCHO SANTA FE [inaudible]
YEAH.
RANCHO MIRAGE AND RANCHO PALOS
VERDES.
ALL IN THE SHADOW OF THAT DARN
CUCAMONGA.
WHAT IS A CUCAMONGA ANYWAY
[inaudible]
BUT SO AYE I DO WISH YOU GREAT
SUCCESS IN ALL YOU DO.
AND AYE I KNOW YOU HAVE.
PROVIDE A VERY IMPORTANT
CONNECTION TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS
A STATE GOVERNMENT.
YOU BETTER REAL PARTNER WITH
SALMON ROLL ADVOCATE FOR THEM
[inaudible]
AND WORK HARD JUST TO CONNECT
THEM -- WITH
WHAT WE DO HERE.
AND EVEN LOOKING BEYOND YOUR
TIME OF SERVICE AT DOING THAT
AND I I THINK --
OUTSTANDING REPRESENTATION.
AND YOU LEAVE A GREAT ROLE MODEL.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY CAN MISTER COOLEY MR MATHIS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'D
JUST LIKE TO REMEMBER --
MISTER WOODS I MEAN --
MY DEAR FRIEND MARC STEINORTH --
MARK GONNA MISS YOU MAN I'M
GONNA MISS ALL THE OTHER CRAZY
SNARKY LATE NIGHT CONVERSATIONS --
THE I THINK SOME OF MY FONDEST
MEMORIES ARE GONNA BE ARE VERY
LATE NIGHT CONVERSATIONS ON
TALKING ABOUT ABIGAIL THE
EXPLORER.
AND I HOPE YOU STILL GOTTA DAHLE
BROTHER.
BUT WE WE WENT THROUGH A LOT
TOGETHER MAN AND IT'S SOME GOOD
MEMORIES AND WE'RE WE'RE STILL
YOU BEAT UP ON SOME LEVEL BLOOD
[inaudible]
IT'S THE I KNOW YOU GOING TO DO
SO.
GREAT THINGS AND I KNOW YOU CARE
ABOUT YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR
COMMUNITY A LOT SO LOOK FOR
SENIOR AFTER THE TAKE CARE.
THANK YOU SIR.
DOCTOR CHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
NO MORE GUY FIRST MET YOU IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN YOU ARE BOTH RUNNING.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
AND I WAS UNSUCCESSFUL WINNING
THE ASSEMBLIES.
I CAME BACK AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO ONE FIRST WHAT CALL WAS YOU.
I CALLED TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
YOUR HELP I NEED ENDORSEMENT
FROM THE SAN WE COUNTY GOP PARTY.
YOU CAME OUT AND SUPPORTED ME.
NOT ONLY DID YOU COULD NOT
SUPPORT ME ENDORSED ME.
AT YOUR OWN RISK.
WELL YOU MADE PHONE CALLS FOR
THE ENTIRE SENATE COUNTY.
REPUBLICAN PARTY A YOU DIDN'T
HAVE TO DO THAT YOUR TARGET SEAT
YET OTHER THINGS ON YOUR PLATE.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU DID
THAT YOU ENCOURAGED ME TO WRITE.
YOU SAID THAT YOU WANTED ME TO
BE THERE WITH YOU.
I'VE ENJOYED THE TIME THAT WE
SPENT TOGETHER BUT THE MORE
IMPORTANT I REALLY PREFER THE
FRIENDSHIP THAT WE HAD.
DURING THE SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
WERE ABLE TO COME TO HANG OUT
AND TALK TO GET TO KNOW EACH
OTHER.
I SEE YOUR DEDICATION DAY IN AND
DAY OUT.
EVERY WEEK YOU'RE GOING BACK.
WALKING PRECINCTS MAKING PHONE
CALLS RAISING MONEY TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL. FOUR
YOUR RACE BOLTON THE FOR THE
BETTERMENT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S NOT A THING THAT WE CAN
SAY.
DEPRECIATE YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE DONE
AND THE SACRIFICES THAT YOU MADE
YOUR OWN PERSONAL COST.
SO I CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
BUT ANOTHER THING I'M REMEMBER
MARK BY IS [inaudible]
HIS QUIRKINESS.
MARK IF THEY QUIRKY INDIVIDUAL
SO PROCLAIM.
HE'LL SAY FILL.
I'M NOT COMING TO YOUR EVENT I'M
SOCIALLY AWKWARD I'M NOT GONNA
COME YOUR VAN.
BUT IN THE END.
YOU WOULD BE EITHER AT MY EVENT.
IN THE YEAH AND WOOD GOES ALL
THE EVENTS EVEN THOUGH YOU SELF
PROCLAIMED TO BE SOCIALLY
AWKWARD.
YOU'RE IN DURING YOUR FUNNY
YOU'RE SMART AND ALSO YOU ALWAYS
ATTENTION DETAILS WOULD COME BY
AND WE SEE FEEL YOU'RE WEARING
THE SAME SHIRT AGAIN AND HIS
WALK AWAY.
FEELING AWARENESS SAME SHOES
AGAIN AND JUST WALK AWAY AND
THAT WOULD MAKE ME CHANGE MY
SHIRT IN FACT I CHANGED THE
SHIRT BECAUSE YESTERDAY YOURSELF
WHEN THE SAME SHIRT.
I'M GOING TO MISS OUR RIGHTS
BACK AND FORTH FROM SACRAMENTO
NOTES ON TERRY AIRPORT AND BACK
AND FORTH FROM ONTARIO. TO
SACRAMENTO.
BUT I KNOW IN WHATEVER YOU
DECIDE TO DO WHETHER IT'S GOING
TO BE IN THE PUBLIC LIFE FOR THE
PRIVATE LIFE YOU WILL SUCCEED.
YOU WILL SUCCEED NOT ONLY
BECAUSE YOU'RE INTELLIGENT.
WE'RE DEDICATED MOST OF ALL.
YOU HAVE HEART.
I REMEMBER SO MANY TIMES THE
WHICH EMOTION INVESTED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU HAVE
THESE BLOW OUTS TO REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS LUNCH BUT YOU DID IT
BECAUSE YOU CARED.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE AS EXCITING.
NOT SENIOR BLOWOUTS [inaudible]
BUT CERTAINLY.
THIS YEAR THE CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT BE AS GOOD.
WITHOUT HAVING YOU HERE.
I THANK YOU I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SACRIFICES.
I APPRECIATE.
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU DON.
HAVE GRADUATING MY FRIENDS THE
NEXT CHAPTER LIFE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN.
MISTER ROAD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
MARK IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO SERVE
WITH.
JOY KNOW YOU OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS CITY OF FRANCE --
THE FIRST STORY I WOULD SAY
ABOUT MARK IS YOU KNOW WE ALL
GOT UP HERE AND FOURTEEN AND
WE'RE LOCKING TO SECURITY ONE
DAY.
AND ONE OF THE SECURITY GUARDS
LOOKS AT ME AND SAYS MRS
STEINORTH GOOD MORNING.
AND AND ANOTHER SECURITY GUARD
WAX AMONG THE ARMY GOES IT'S
PEROT SPIRO SO.
MISTER HADLEY MISTER STEINORTH
AND I OFTEN GOT CONFUSED THE
FIRST COUPLE OF MONTHS.
COUPLE OF MONTHS UP HERE --
THE SECOND STORY I WANT TO SAY
ABOUT MARK IS HE DIDN'T OF THAT
THAT EIGHTEEN T. PARKING GOT
THAT DUGOUTS WE THIRTY FIVE
SEATS.
AND HAVE ONE LEFT AND SO THEY
BROKE.
WANT TO COME WITH ME CHURCH I'M
A HUGE BASEBALL FAN HE KNOWS
THAT.
SO WE'RE RIGHT CARE EVEN WOULD
FIRST BASE AND HE'S GOT HIS SON
WITH THEM AND I TRYING TO GET
HIS SON EXCITED YOU KNOW YOU GET
A BALL.
GET HIM INTO THE GATE AND A FOUL
BALL WAS HIT AND IT STUCK RIGHT
IN THE NETTING.
OF OUR BUCKS.
AND WAS A KEY LET'S GET THIS
QUALITY UMPIRE MOVED OVER SO
QUICKLY TO GRAB IT.
THE HOLE DUG OUT WHEN I'M TRYING
TO GET THE BALL FOR MARK SOME.
AND SO WE SHAME THAT UMPIRE SO
BADLY THAT AFTER THE INNING HE
WALKED OVER AND PERSONALLY
HANDED THE BALL TO MARK STONE.
AND I NEVER SAW SMILE ON VOIGTS
FACE -- LIKE
THAT.
AND THE FINAL STORY AND I THINK
THIS IS THE ONE THAT I WILL
REMEMBER MARK FOR EVER.
IS IF YOU BET EVER BEEN IN HIS
OFFICE UPSTAIRS.
AS HE'S TWO CLOCKS. ONE CLOCK
HAS A TEMPLATE THAT SAYS SAME
BURNABY ENOUGH.
AND THE OTHER CLOCK AS A
TEMPLATE THAT SAYS SACRAMENTO.
AND IN THE EXACT SAME TIME
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
AND AND I I THINK.
I THINK THAT RIGHT THERE
ENCOMPASSES MARK STEYN NURSES
WIT AND HUMOR.
AND THOUGH I WILL REMEMBER THOSE
CLOCKS.
AS LONG AS I LIVE AND I THINK
THAT'S AWESOME.
JUST ONE WISH YOU THE BEST A
LOCK ENJOY YOUR TIME BACK.
IT'S BEEN AN HONORS.
MEMBERS WILL PROP PAUSE THE TRIP
BEFORE MOMENT.
I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVEN
SEVEN POINT TWO I'M REFERRING
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS TO COMMITTEE.
AB TO THREE FIVE O'DONNELL TO
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT. EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT LOW TO
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN TO
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN GIPSON
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR GONZALEZ
FLETCHER TO WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE.
IN AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE GIPSON
TO LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT.
I'M ALSO REVISING MY EARLIER RE
REFER ALL OF AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE HAVE A YEAR TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
AND I'M INSTEAD REFER WE
REFERRING THE BILL TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND A JOINT WILL.
SIX TO EIGHT FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO ME UPON
CALLED THE CHAIR IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM AGRICULTURE HERE
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE HAVE A
YELLOW.
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
HERE AB ELEVENTH ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS HERE
AB TWENTY FIVE ONE KANSEN CHU
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION TO HEAR
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT LOW.
LABOR EMPLOYMENT TO HEAR A. B.
TALK TO THIRTY FIVE A DONALD AND
AB TWENTY SO FIVE GIPSON.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HERE A. B.
TWELVE OR FIVE JONES SAWYER AB
SEVENTY NINE MCCARTY AND A. B.
FIFTEEN SEVEN SEVEN GIPSON AND
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE TO HEAR
AB SEVEN FORTY SEVEN CABALLERO
AND IF YOU.
TO BEFORE IT'S ALSO FLETCHER
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
A CHUBBY ORDER.
MEMBERS WILL RESUME OF WITH
TRIBUTES.
MISTER HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
YEAH EVEN THOUGH THAT --
MARC STEINORTH AND I WERE SWORN
IN ON THE SAME DAY I JUST A
RIGHT OVER HERE.
NO ONE SEEMS THAT CONFUSE ME
WITH HIM.
AND ARE FOR MY COLLEAGUES FROM
OUR RANCHO CORDOVA.
I ALWAYS THINK OF IN THE OLD
WARNER BROTHERS STYLE RELEASED
THEIR CURRENT SHOW [inaudible]
LONGER [inaudible]
BUT MARK.
WE USED TO HAVE BE ABLE TO SEE
HERE THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE AYE
FIRST TERM BY OVER HERE ON THE
RIGHT SIDE SO THEY MOVED OVER TO
THE FAR LEFT SIDE.
SOME REASON I NO THAT'S ABOUT
BUT I REALLY MISS YOU AND I'M
GONNA MISS EVEN MORE THAT YOU
WON'T BE HERE IN ASSEMBLY WITH
US I WISH I'D.
BE IN A POSITION TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE ON BUT DOES.
I REALLY ADMIRE.
YOUR INTENSITY IN YOUR
PERSISTENT SIDE YOUR BUSINESS
ACKERMAN --
IN YOUR DEDICATION ESPECIALLY
THAT -- THAT
YOU HAVE OUT HERE.
AND LIKE ON MANY OTHERS HAVE
EXPRESSED.
AYE ABA A CERTAIN UP ON IS FOR
THE V. BITING WIT AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SHARE IT THOUGH
WITH THAT WITH ALL OF US --
WHETHER IT'S INVITED OR NOT --
A ANA THAT'S A CERTAINLY OF BUT
BUT VERY MUCH --
WILL MISS YOU HOPE THAT THERE'S
AN THERE'S INSTANCES WHERE WE
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE YOU BECAUSE
THIS IS.
I AND I BOUGHT ADMIRE VERY MUCH
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO --
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS I'VE
BEST WISHES IN ALL YOUR FUTURE
ENDEAVORS AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU AGAIN MARK STONE
.
MISTER BERMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A THIRD
OF THE MARK COCKETTES THAT'S
MARKET TO SEE --
I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T --
GET UP THE SYSTEM WORDS ABOUT MY
FRIEND MARC STEINORTH --
I BECAME CHAIR OF A POLICY
COMMITTEE MET LAST YEAR
UNEXPECTEDLY --
I THINK ONE THE FIRST BILLS I I
HAD TO WORK WITH WAS A BILL THAT
THAT MARK HAD --
WHERE WE DIDN'T SEE EYE TO EYE
DIRECTLY ON THE POLICY BUT THE
INTERACTIONS THAT WE HAD?
WE'RE SO ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
WHEN POLITICS IS SO.
KIND OF BITCHY ALL A CAN AND YOU
KNOW.
HEIGHTENED --
SENSITIVITY THAT EVERYTHING WERE
SO POSITIVE --
AND WERE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
THE ISSUES WERE ABLE TO FIND THE
BILL THAT WE CAN BOTH AGREE ON
WE'RE ABLE TO GET ADDED THE
COMMITTEE OF THE ASSEMBLY.
US REALLY I WAS REALLY HAPPY
ABOUT THAT --
AND THE NIGHT I SAW IN THE PAPER
THE OTHER DAY THAT THE GOVERNOR
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THEM IS THAT
AYE AYE ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKES
US MY WHOLE --
AND I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
[inaudible] FOR THAT
[inaudible]
LESSON LEARNED [inaudible]
I'M.
BUT THEN A COUPLE MONTHS LATER
WORK WAS UP IN THE BAY AREA AND
WE'RE AND THEY'VE BEEN TOGETHER
IN EVERY.
WE COME TO AN INTERVIEW --
AND SO WE SAT --
AND WE'RE TALKING IN I MAYBE I I
THINK I SHOULD YOU WERE AND I
SAID SO MANY NICE THINGS --
AND AFTERWARDS ABOUT ALTHOUGH I
GET RIGHT MARK MIGHT BE A THIS
IS POINTING YOUR RUNNING FOR
SUPERVISOR ABOUT MARK MERCK
MIGHT BE A TARGET I'M I CAN
SHOVEL MY COCKINESS. FOR SAY SO
MANY NICE THINGS ABOUT ABOUT
MISTER STEINORTH --
BUT I'M AT THE MALL --
BECAUSE EVERY INTERACTION I'VE
HAD WITH MARK HAS BEEN SO
POSITIVE SO FRIENDLY --
I'VE LEARNED A LOT THAT'S BEEN
YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT POLICY WAS VERY
SUBSTANTIVE.
UM SO I WISH WE HAD A CHANCE TO
SERVE MORE TOGETHER BUT I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE VERY
HAPPY.
WHATEVER YOU DO NEXT AND I HOPE
OUR PATHS CROSS AGAIN.
FIGURES TO BERMAN MR KILEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
WHAT TO SAY ABOUT MY GOOD FRIEND
MR STUFF?
BUT IS INSPIRED ME A LOT OF WAYS
INCLUDING MY RECENT FORAY INTO
THE WORLD OF FACIAL HAIR
ALTHOUGH.
AS SOON AS MINE APPEARED HIS
DISAPPEAR SO I'M NOT QUITE SURE
WHAT TO MAKE OF THAT.
STARTED WAS MY FIRST IT MADE IN
THIS.
RIGHT HERE ACTUALLY I WAS A
FRESH ARRIVAL HE WAS ON A
GRIZZLED VETERAN OF THE
LEGISLATURE ACT PASSED WITH
SHOWING ME THE WAYS OF THE WORLD
WHICH HE DID WITH THE MINIMUM
AMOUNT OF WHICH I APPRECIATED.
I KNOW COME TO THINK OF IT EVER
SINCE WE RE SHUFFLED HERE IS
BECOMING A LOT OF WHAT A GREAT
STEVE MADE.
ON A CABALLERO AS AND COME TO
THINK OF IT WHEN WE WERE SEAT
MATES HE'S BECOMING A LOT OF
WHAT A GREAT SEAT MATE
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
SADA.
BUT IT IS NOT A GOOD WAY THOSE
VALUES HERE HELP MAKE SOME
REALLY GOOD [inaudible]
HUMANS.
AND IF YOU KNOW THEM THAT'S KIND
OF INTENSE GUY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
BUT NOT THE BENTLEY NOT INTENSE
IN THE WAY WHEN THE SUN SHINES
DIRECTLY IN YOUR EYES BUT IN A
GOOD CONSTRUCTIVE.
IN THE WAY THAT MAKES YOU WANNA
STOP AND LISTEN AND THINK
BECAUSE IT'S AN INTENSITY HORN
OF SINCERITY AND CONVICTION.
AND A DESIRE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
THAT'S THE ONE THING I CAN SAY
OFFERED STEINORTH IS THAT MY
EXPERT IT'S ALWAYS SOMEONE.
TRY TO DO THE RIGHT THING IT'S
TAKEN PUBLIC SERVICE SERIOUSLY
AND BESIDES IS A REALLY FUNNY
GUY AND REALLY CARE.
BAKER MISTER KILEY.
MS BIG TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND AYE
I KNOW WE TALKED A BIT ABOUT HOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME PROBLEM
TELLING YOU PARKS AND SERVER
COLLEAGUES ARE FIRST YEAR MISTER
HADLEY AND MISTER WAY.
I I NEVER GOT THAT UNTIL MISTER
MULLIN CALDERON THE WRONG CALLED
MISTER HADLEY THE MEMBER FOR
RANCHO CUCAMONGA SO WHY IS THAT
BECAUSE YOU.
YOU KNOW YOU LOOK DIFFERENT
UNTIL YOU CAME BACK FROM A BREAK
AND YOU HAD PART OF YOUR HAIR IN
A DIFFERENT WAY THAN THEY REALLY
WERE.
WIND WAS ALL WE COULD TALK.
BUT I TO YOU KNOW WE SAID WE THE
SNARK.
I'M ALSO VERY VERY LOYAL MAN YOU
ARE ONE LOYAL PERSON.
YOU'RE LOYAL TO YOUR STAFF
CERTAINLY YOUR FAMILY.
THE CAUCUS THE MATTER WHAT
DIFFICULT POSITIONS IN
CHALLENGES THAT PRESENTED FOR
YOU AND THAT IS REALLY HARD TO
FIND PEOPLE.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR LOYALTY
AND FOR HAVING ANOTHER TARGET IN
THE CAUCUS --
FOR HOW VERY VERY HARD YOU WORK
MAN YOU WORK HARD [inaudible]
AND I SAW THAT YOU KNOW WHOSE
SOMETIMES NO LECTURES THE
ELECTIONS ARTICLE OVER ON
ELECTION.
AND SEE THERE'S BALLOT COUNTY
AND I'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
SEVERAL ELECTION CYCLES WITH
OTHER CANDIDATES.
I HAVE ONLY ONCE SEEN THE ACTUAL
CANDIDATE WILLING TO BE PART OF
THE FOLKS WHO STAND THERE FOR
HOURS.
NO CHAIR I MEAN TENER TOOK REAL
SIT HERE FOR TEN TO TWELVE HOURS
MAGIC FOR TWO WEEKS STANDING
TENER TWELVE HOURS A DAY IN THE
SAME PLACE BECAUSE YOUR ELECTION
DEPENDED ON I HAVE NEVER SEEN A
CANDIDATE WILLING TO BE THERE
ROLL UP THE SLEEVES BE THERE.
RIGHT WITH THE VOLUNTEERS IN THE
STAFF AND EVERYONE ELSE JUST.
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF AN
ELECTION.
AND SO --
THAT'S REALLY INCREDIBLE AND I I
DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION A CALIFORNIANS HAVE
TO THANK MARK FOR AND THAT IS
YOU CAN NOW SAVE AND RESCUE
ANIMAL [inaudible]
VEHICLE.
BY BREAKING INTO IT IS A GOOD
SAMARITAN LAW BECAUSE OF MARK.
AND BECAUSE HE SAT OUT IN A CAR.
AND SWEAT ABOUT TWENTY POUNDS
OFF IT WAS GROSS THAT'S THE
IMAGE IT'S BURNED HARM I REALLY.
BUT PET OWNERS OF PETS AND WAS
REALLY DO HAVE YOU TO THANK FOR
THAT LAW.
AS WELL AS SOME REALLY GREAT
IDEAS ON HOUSING WHEATIES MARK
ABOUT YOU KNOW PETS IN HIS CARE
FOR ANIMALS BUT HE'S HE'S BEEN A
REAL LEADER ON HOUSING
LEGISLATION AS WELL WITHIN OUR
CAUCUS.
AND SO YOU COME UP WITH GREAT
BILLS.
INCLUDING THE ONE WHERE YOU NEED
TO DO SOME PRE TAX EARNINGS TO
START TO SAVE AWAY AS WELL JUST
LIKE A FIVE TWENTY NINE SAVINGS
PLAN TO CREATE A GREAT IDEA.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
SEEING NAKED PASSED BY THE
GOVERNOR SOMEDAY BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THAT IDEA.
THANK YOU --
WE WILL REALLY REALLY MISS YOU I
WILL MISS A FELLOW TARGET --
IN THE IN THE CAUCUS WELL THAT
FOR TWO GREAT GREAT SUCCESS FOR
YOU AND YOUR BEAUTIFUL KIDS AND
THEY GIVE US BAKER.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK.
OF THIS GUY WHERE.
OUR LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
SO I COULDN'T --
I COULDN'T RESIST --
HAVING THE LAST WORD --
IT IT'S IT'S BEEN AN INTERESTING
COUPLE YEARS BECAUSE I'VE HAD A
SEAT MATE THAT DISAPPEARED AND
THEN I SAT BY MYSELFFOR A
PERIOD OF MONTHS AND THEN I GOT
MOVED OVER TO SIT NEXT.
TO OF MISTER STEINORTH AND I
JUST HAVE TO TELL YOU IT'S BEEN
A TREMENDOUS PLEASURE TO BE ABLE
TO SIT NEXT TO SOMEONE WHO HAS.
THE SENSE OF HUMOR AND KIND OF
CONSTANT CHATTER CHATTER THAT I
DO MYSELF IT WAS REALLY LONELY
DISCIPLINE MYSELF IF THERE'S
NOBODY TO SIT AND TALK --
TO BUT BUT I I I DO WANT TO
ANSWER --
MAKE GOOD FRIEND READ A QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT RANCHO CUCAMONGA
MEANS AND AND IT'S IT'S RANCHO
CUCAMONGA AND REALLY WHAT IT
MEANS IS --
REALLY CRAZY DO DID SO I THAT'S
WHY HE'S FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA
CUCAMONGA --
BUT MARK I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
IT IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE YOU ARE
A TREAT TO SIT NEXT --
TO YOU KNOW THAT THE FACT THAT
WE'RE FROM DIFFERENT PARTIES
MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO DIFFERENT
YOU USE THE RED BUTTON I USE THE
GREEN BUTTON AND THAT'S THE WAY
IT IS.
BUT BUT JUST BEING ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT ISSUES AND TALK ABOUT ON
LIFE AND DOWN KIND OF HOW THE
DAY IS GOING AND HOW THE MORNING
SPEND IT SO.
IT'S BEEN GREAT TO HAVE YOU AS A
SEAT ME SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WISH YOU THE BEST IN YOUR
NEW ENDEAVORS AND WE'RE GONNA
MISS.
THEY CAN DISCOVER WHERE.
IT'S JUST I KNOW IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
WELL THANK YOU FIRST I WANTED TO
SAY --
EARLIER TODAY WAS REFERRED TO AS
MISTER HADLEY.
A JOKE ACTUALLY LOBBYIST CAME UP
TO ME AND SAID --
MISTER HADLEY I'M LIKE HE'S NOT
EVEN SERVING ANY OF OUR COME ON
HE'S READY TO READY FOR GOVERNOR
FOR CHRIST'S SAKE --
BUT YEAH THAT WENT REALLY WELL
AND THEN --
MISTER WOOD IT'S YOU KNOW I DID
RECEIVE YOUR OPPOSED WITH THE
WARRIORS TROPHY.
AND THAT WAS PRETTY NICE AND
THEN THE SERGEANTS BUT YOUR
PLACARD IN FRONT OF ME AND IN
COMMITTEE MULTIPLE TIMES.
BUT THAT'S OKAY SO I WAS CHAIR
OF HEALTH.
I'M PUTTING IT ON MY RESUME.
AND THEN IN THAT STORY COMING
FROM CHAT ABOUT BETWEEN HIS BEST
FRIEND'S MOM MY FIRST QUESTION
WAS PLEASE TELL ME ON THE BEST
FRIEND IN THAT STORY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE THE MOM
THAT'S A LITTLE TOO MUCH FOR ME
AND I DON'T CALL IT SNARK.
I CALL IT FULLY FLUENT IN
SARCASM.
I'VE WORKED VERY HARD ON MY
SECOND LANGUAGE SO PLEASE
RESPECT THAT.
ANYWAY I DO WANT TO DISARM POINT
OUT FIRST I I JUST WANT TO JUST
EXPRESS Y ABSOLUTE GRATITUDE TO
THE PROFESSIONALS THAT MAKE THIS
THIS --
ENTITY THIS ORGANIZATION THIS
INSTITUTION BRIAN AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY TO TO THE OFFICE OF
THE CHIEF CLERK INTO DOTS AND
AND TO SEE YOU AND TO ALL OF YOU.
YOU ARE JUST ABSOLUTE
PROFESSIONALS AND I AM JUST
EXIST AND ARE WORKING WITH YOU
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT ALSO AND
THEN ALSO RECOGNIZE RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF AND OUR SPECIAL
SERVICES YOU YOU PROTECT US YOU
MAKE SURE THAT THE WHEELS ARE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THAT THE TRAINS RUNNING ON TIME.
AND YOU JUST DON'T GET ANYWHERE
NEAR AS MUCH SATISFACTION.
FROM YOUR JOB WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU DO FOR
US EACH AND EVERY SINGLE DAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES I IF I MADE
FRIENDS WITH THIS GENTLEMAN ON
THE FIFTH FLOOR NAME DARRYL AND
DARRYL AND I HAVE GOT THIS THING
GOING DOWN DOWN.
BUT YOU KNOW AS WE KNOW WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COME THROUGH
HERE THAT DG ASK WORK THEIR
TAILS OFF WHEN WE LEAVE THEY
CONTINUE TO WORK AND THEY MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE COME BACK HERE
THAT EVERYTHING IS SPOTLESS AND
SHINING RIGHT.
AND WE DON'T GIVE THEM ANYWHERE
NEAR THE RECOGNITION SO I'M I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THEM INFANCY EACH
PIECE.
AS WE COME IN AND OUT OF THIS
BUILDING WE SEE SEE HP IS WE
GREET HIM AND WE WAY THEY
PROTECT US.
THEY REALLY DO WHEN THEY NEED TO
GET SPECIAL RECOGNITION.
AND THEN MEMBER SERVICES IN OUR
POLICY STAFF I KNOW THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE THEIR MEMBER
SERVICES AND POLICY STAFF IN THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE THEIRS.
BUT I MEAN ALL OF THE WORK THAT
THEY PUT IN AFTER WE GO HOME AND
THEY SPEND HOURS AND HOURS
LABORIOUSLY GOING OVER THESE
BILLS GIVING US OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF
THAT HARD WORK BECAUSE WITHOUT
THAT NONE OF US WOULD BE ABLE TO
FUNCTION INTO OUR JOBS VERY WELL.
AND THEN.
AND I DID JUST IF YOU DON'T MIND
JUST SPEAK OUT A SHOUT OUT TO
THE RESIDENCE THAT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
JUST THANK YOU FOR THE PRIVILEGE
AND HONOR.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO SERVE YOU FOR
THESE FOR YEARS IT IT YOU KNOW I
GREW UP IN A MILITARY FAMILY I
WAS BORN ON MAY THIRD AIRFORCE
BASE.
I WAS I WAS BORN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND T. YOU KNOW AT THAT POINT IN
MY LIFE FOR IT ANY POINT THERE
AND I NEVER THOUGHT THAT I'D
EVER HAVE THE CHANCE TO SERVE IN
THIS CAPITAL.
THIS IS JUST AN AMAZING
PRIVILEGE THAT EACH AND EVERYONE
OF US WE WE SOMETIMES JUST
FORGET ABOUT.
WHAT WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DEAL IT
IS IN THE?
WE MAKE AND HOW IT IMPACTS THE
LIVES SO MANY PEOPLE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE.
IT IS JUST IT'S IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT WE JUST
CAN'T TAKE FOR GRANTED AND I'M
I'M JUST DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT CHANCE THAT I'VE HAD OVER
THESE FOUR YEARS.
AND THEN TO MY CHILDREN.
I I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL I AM TO THEM FOR THE
SACRIFICES THAT THEY'VE MADE FOR
ALL THE EVENTS THAT I WASN'T
ABLE TO ATTEND BECAUSE THE HARD
WORK THAT YOU'VE HEARD THAT.
THAT IS MENTIONED IT AND YOU
KNOW THE HEAD OF THE PRECINCT
THAT THEY HAVE HAD TO KNOCK ON
DOORS AND AND THEY HAVE BEEN
THERE WITH ME AND MY DAUGHTER
SHE'S FABULOUS SHE'S EIGHTEEN
SHE MOVED INTO COLLEGE TODAY ON
HERE AND NOT WITH THEIR THE
COLLEGE.
AND SHE EITHER A GREAT THING
WHERE SHE WOULD KNOCK ON THE
DOOR AND SHOULD STOP AND LOOK AT
THE DOOR AND SHE WOULD SAY
SOMETHING POSITIVE.
ABOUT THAT HOUSE BEFORE THE
PERSON CAME TO THE DOOR SO SHE
ALREADY HAD A SMILE READY TO GO.
AND MY SON HE MADE SURE HE WORE
HEALY'S.
SO THAT IF HE WENT FROM HOME TO
HOME TO HOME HE WAS HAVING A
PRETTY GOOD TIME DOING AT THE
SAME TIME AND AND AND OF COURSE
HE FORGOT TO TIE SHOES EVERY
TIME SO I LEARNED WHAT THE WORD
ACTUALLY.
BECAUSE HE WOULD RUN OVER THEM
AND I HAVE TO REPLACE THE
SHOELACES YOU CAN LOOK A BACKLIT
IF IF YOU WISH BUT I I JUST I'M
ETERNALLY GRATEFUL. FOR THEIR
DEDICATION AND SACRIFICE AND
ALLOWING ME MY DREAM I BE ABLE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THE WAY THAT THEY'VE
ALLOWED ME AND AND I HOPE THAT
IN SOME WAY.
THAT THEY HAVE SEEN THE WORK
ETHIC THAT I'VE BROUGHT TO THIS
JOB AND AND I'M HOPING THAT THAT
STICKS WITH THEM IN THAT THAT
WILL HELP THEM IN THEIR CAREER
IN THEIR FUTURE.
AND THEN. TO MY STAFF.
THIS STAFF NOT JUST HERE BUT THE
STAFF AND THE DISTRICT THE STAFF
THAT THAT ARE HERE NOW IN THE
STAFF THAT WERE WITH ME IN THE
BEGINNING. FOR THEIR UNFLINCHING
LOYALTY.
I I KNOW WHEN I DECIDE NOT TO
RUN AGAIN.
YOU KNOW SOME OF MY STAFF JUST
DECIDED NOT WE'RE STICKING WITH
YOU WHERE WE'RE GONNA RIDE IT
OUT UNTIL THE RAILS FALL OFTEN.
THAT'S DISLOYALTY AND AND THAT'S
JUST BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IN AND
WHAT MATTERS AND THEY UNDERSTOOD
WHAT WAS AT STAKE FOR THE STATE
OF ALIFORNIA IT'S FOR THE SAKE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY REALLY PUT THEIR EFFORT
IN THEIR HEART INTO IT AND JUST
DO ALL OF MY STAFF MEMBERS I
DON'T KNOW WHICH CAMERA IT IS WE
WILL ALWAYS BE FAMILY.
WE WILL ALWAYS BE FAMILY.
ON A PERSONAL NOW.
I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
RELATIONSHIPS AND THE
FRIENDSHIPS THAT I'VE MADE IN
THIS CHAMBER THESE THESE THESE
RELATIONSHIPS WILL LAST WAY
BEYOND OUR TIME TOGETHER HERE.
IN THE LAST WAY FURTHER THAN
THAT AND THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
OUTSIDE WATCHING THAT ARE IN THE
HALLWAYS THERE ARE SOME GREAT
RELATIONSHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
BEEN BUILT THERE IS WHILE AND I
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW DEEPLY
GRATEFUL I AM. FOR ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT AND FOR YOUR KINDNESS
OVERALL OF THESE YEARS AND TO
ALL OF US IN THIS CHAMBER JUST
PLEASE REMEMBER.
KIND TO EACH OTHER.
BE COURTEOUS TO EACH OTHER.
WE MAY COME FROM DIFFERENT
VANTAGE POINTS BUT WE'RE ALL
HUMAN BEINGS BETTER LOOKING FOR
EXACTLY THE SAME THING WE WANT A
BETTER CALIFORNIA.
THEN WHAT WE CHOSE OUR WHAT WE
SAW WHEN WE DECIDED TO DO THIS
JOB WE HAVE DIFFERENT POSITIONS
ON THE WAY THAT WE SEE THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE ALL CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA SO PLEASE
JUST REMEMBER THAT AS WE LOOK AT
EACH OTHER WE HAVE THESE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AND DEBATES.
THERE IS NOT A RIGHT OR WRONG.
THERE ISN'T THERE IS WHAT MAKES
SENSE IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
NEED TO STRIVE TOWARDS OUR GOAL
TOGETHER.
NICE WHEN SAY THANK YOU FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART FOR THIS
PRIVILEGE AND RESPONSIBILITY AN
OPPORTUNE
[inaudible]
EGGMAN STEINORTH.
MEMBERS OF MY TO ANNOUNCE THE
LABOR EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING NOW IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM
.
MEMBERS OF THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE ASK THAT
YOU GO TO MEET THE RULES
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ROOM NOW
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING NOW BACK
[inaudible]
TO BUSINESS.
WE ARE MOVING TO AB SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR WITHOUT REFERENCE TO THE
FILE.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE SUMMIT WILL SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER CHOI AN
ACCOLADE TO ENTER COUNTY
ADOPTION SOME MEMBER CHOI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AB IS SEVEN TONY FOR PREVIOUS IN
THE PAST THIS FOR ALL ONE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN HAS TO
RECEIVE DOES ZERO NO VOTES.
THIS BILL IS SOUGHT TO PROTECT
OUR ADOPTED CHILDREN FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
BY THE US PARENTS.
FROM BECOMING UNDOCUMENTED
ALIENS.
SUBJECT TO DEPORTATION LATER.
BY SIMPLY FINDING SIMPLIFYING
THE KORAN RE ADOPTION SYSTEM.
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO WERE TAKEN
TO ADDRESS US SOME OF THE
CONCERNS.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
AND THE IT PASSED.
I UNANIMOUS EARLY IN THE MORNING
I URGE YOU WHEN I VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
ONE AT NOSE ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW.
WITHOUT REFERENCE OF THE FILE TO
A. BE NINETEEN NINETEEN MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN NINETEEN BY
SOME MEMBER WOULD NOT BELIEVE
THE PRICE GOUGING.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TAKING THAT
SPEAKER AB NINETEEN NINETEEN
CLOSES THE NEW RENTAL LOOPHOLE
IN EXISTING PRICE GOUGING LAW.
THAT GOES BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
ENJOYED OBVIOUSLY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE THE THANK YOU.
I SEE NO.
MEMBERS REQUESTING TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MISTER WOOD MOVES THE CALL
SOME MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE TO
TAKE UP.
ITEM ONE ON SECOND READING S. B.
TWO FORTY FOUR LATA WITHOUT
REFERENCE OF THEIR REFUND.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
WE ARE MOVING NOW. TO S. B. TO
FORTY FOUR WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
THE FILE.
THE CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LLOREN ACCOLADE OF
PRIVACY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS WE ALL
KNOW.
THAT GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA CLICK A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT ARE
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THE PUBLIC IN
ORDER TO DO THEIR JOBS
ADMINISTRATIVELY.
WHAT SP TWO FORTY FOUR IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THAT
INFORMATION DIDN'T TO ENSURE
THAT IT IS NOT BEING GIVEN OVER
IN WAYS THAT WE WOULDN'T EXPECT
AS CITIZENS OF THE STATE?
ENSURE THAT THOSE AGENCIES ARE
ABLE TO HOLD ON TO THAT
INFORMATION AND KEEP IT
CONFIDENTIAL.
AMENDMENTS OR TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY NARROW THE BILL QUITE A
BIT.
AND THEY ENSURE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION SO THEY CAN DO ITS
JOB BUT THIS IS THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE NEED TO STEP UP
AND SURE THAT THEY HAVE PRIVACY
BECAUSE THEY'RE ENGAGING WITH
BASIS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SP.
TWO FORTY FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER --
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT TO SPEAK
OUT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I TRIED TO READ THE BILL'S MY
LET'S SAY DIRECTORS A LAWYER SHE
READS A BILLS THIS IS A GOOD
BILL.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS TO NARROW
IT SOME DEGREE BUT IT ADDRESSES
IMPORTANT ISSUES OF CONCERN TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING NO OTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
SOME MEMBERS DON'T MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER. TO ITEM FORTY NINE
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY SOONER WHO HUESO AND
ACKLEY AND YOU RATES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISE YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WAS SO I AM
PRESENTING SB.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT A BILL
WHICH AUTHORIZES A PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANT.
CERTIFY WHEN DISCONNECTING
SERVICE THAT IT WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL. TO THE PERSON A
BECAUSE THE ITEM NEEDED FOR THE
FOR THE ELECTRICITY IS A
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TO SUSTAIN
THE LIFE OF THE CUSTOMER.
BY MAKING THIS SMALL CHANGE IN
LAW WILL NOT ONLY INCREASE
AWARENESS OF THE MEDICAL
BASELINE ALLOWANCE TO PROMOTE
ACCESS AS WELL.
MAKING EFFORTS TO INCREASE
ELIGIBLE PARTICIPATION WILL
SUPPORT SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WHO
REQUIRE EXTRA SYSTEMS.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS WROTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
TO CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. SEVEN
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING OUT ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR ACTORS AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE THE MEDI CAL.
SO MEMBER ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE WILL DISMANTLE
BARRIERS COUNTLESS PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIANS FACE BY ALLOWING
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS TO BILL
MEDI CAL FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
ON THE SAME DAY THAT THEY
PROVIDE OTHER MEDICAL SERVICES.
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
PATIENTS ARE OFTEN FIND FOUND TO
NEED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
DURING THEIR PRIMARY CARE VISIT.
HOWEVER IF THEY RECEIVE
TREATMENT THROUGH MEDI CAL FROM
BOTH A PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER AND
A MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER ON THE
SAME DAY THE HEALTH CENTER WILL
ONLY BE REIMBURSED FOR ONE VISIT.
AS A RESULT THESE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS MUST EITHER EAT
THE COST OF THE SECOND VISIT OR
REFER PATIENTS TO RETURN ON A
SUBSEQUENT DAY.
MEMBERS WE SHOULD STRIVE TO
INTEGRATE CARE AND TO PROVIDE
ALL NECESSARY TREATMENT TO
UNDERSERVED PATIENTS ONCE WE GET
THEM IN THE DOOR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SENATE
BILL.
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I SEE NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM MISTER FOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS HERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES SOME MEMBER CALDERON.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO TO TAKE UP
ITEM TO A ONE S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE DODD WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO UMMAH
AT S. B.. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE TO
QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY ONE BY
SOONER DOT NUMBERS ARE NOT
REALLY THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
TO CLEARLY WISHES HERE THAT MAKE
IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU AT SOME EVER.
TELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THAT YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
AW AS MILITANT TWENTY ONE IS A
CLEAN A BILL TO THE BILL THAT WE
PASSED ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO.
AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE RABBIT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICKLY IS OPEN
THE MEMBERS BOWED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
THE CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE A ROLL
AND TALLIED THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
IT'S NO ZERO THE URGENCY EYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS ARE ON THE
MEASURE THAT MEASURE PASSED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
FORTY FIVE S. B. TWELVE HUNDRED
MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL TWELVE HUNDRED BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACCOLADE
FIREARMS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL TWELVE
HUNDRED BY SENATOR SKINNER.
WHICH THREATENS AND OF AND
EFFECTIVELY [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY FOR
CALIFORNIA GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER CALL THE G. V.
R. O..
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
SENATORS CAN AUTHORIZE ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FOURTEEN X. ABSENT
CALIFORNIA'S GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER AS A TOOL TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FAMILY
MEMBERS.
THAT COULD USE THIS TO DISARM
LOVED ONES WHO WERE THREATENED.
TO COMMIT AN ACT OF VIOLENCE I'M
IN THE COMMUNITY OR HARM
THEMSELVES.
NUMBER ONE GB R. O. X.
ELIMINATES.
FEES ISSUED BY THE G. R. O. TO
COSTS TO REMOVE COSTS VARIOUS
FOR SAFETY. TWO AT MAGAZINES TO
THE LIST OF ITEMS.
THAT A PERSON IS PROHIBITED FROM
POSSESSING UNDER THE G. V. R. O.
REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUE
THE GP R. O. TO VERBALLY ASK THE
RECIPIENT IF THEY HAVE GUNS OR
ASSESSOR HE'S SO THAT THE BAR OR
IN PARTS AND MAGAZINES CAN BE
REMOVED.
FROM AYE PERSONS PERSON.
THIS BILL HAS STRIPPED IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY [inaudible] TWELVE
THE SENATE BILL TWELVE HUNDRED
IS ARMED A LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON
SENATE BILL.
TWELVE HUNDRED THANK YOU OF SOME
EVER BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SP
TWELVE HUNDRED M. GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
ARE ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MEASURES THAT WE'VE SEEN AND
STUDIES FOR PREVENTING GUN
VIOLENCE AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THEY ARE ACCESSIBLE.
THAT PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS AND
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THEM
THROUGH THE COURTS AND OTHERWISE
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
MEASURE DOES IT'S A SMART BILL
IT SHOULD HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK.
THE CLERK IS OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY CENTER STERN OPERA AN
ACCOLADE TO AFRICAN SPECIES
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU WAS SURE MEMBERS.
OF MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB
FORTY SEVEN PROHIBITS POSSESSION
OF ANIMAL TROPHIES AND OTHER
BODY PARTS IN ELEVEN ICONIC
AFTER ENDANGERED SPECIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EARLIER EARLIER THIS YEAR WE
LOST SUDAN THE LAST MALE
NORTHERN WHITE RHINO.
SUDAN IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF A
LARGER TREND PACING MANY OF THE
MOST ICONIC AFRICAN ANIMALS.
SAVANNAH ELEPHANTS POPULATION TO
DECLINE BY 30% BUT 200-072-00014
AFTER ALLIANCE HAVE DECLINED BY
43% WHICH IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY BLACK RHINO
POPULATIONS.
HAVE DECLINED BY 97%.
EVIDENCE IS MOUNTING THAT TROPHY
HUNTING IS NOT BENEFICIAL TO
CONSERVATION.
STUDIES SHOW TROPHY HUNTING IS
LINKED TO POPULATION DECLINES IT
ALSO SUB STUDIES ALSO SHOW THE
EFFECTS OF TARGETING MATURE
MAINLY MALE ANIMALS CAN
DESTABILIZE A POPULATION.
AND REMOVE IMPORTANT GENETIC
MATERIAL.
NOT ONLY ISSUE ACCOUNTING NOT
BENEFICIAL TO THE SURVIVAL THE
ANIMAL POPULATIONS BUT DOES NOT
PROVIDE NEARLY THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OTHER FORMS OF THE
CULTURE TOURISM DO.
IN FACT CHOPPY HUNTING BRINGS IN
LESS THAN A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN TOURISM
SPENDING TO EIGHT COUNTRIES THAT
WERE STUDY AT A SEVENTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY AND TOURISM PENDING OR
JUST ZERO POINT 78%.
EVEN WORSE JOB HUNTING IS
WILLING TO INCREASE POACHING
ILLEGAL WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING IS
THE FOURTH MOST LUCRATIVE
CRIMINAL INDUSTRY WITH THE VALUE
ESTIMATE BETWEEN SEVEN AND
TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
EACH YEAR.
ALL THESE REASONS BE ENOUGH TO
WARRANT ACTION BUT ACTIONS TAKE
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO WE CAN
CONSERVATION EFFORTS MAKE WHAT
WE DO HERE IN CALL CALIFORNIA
EVEN.
MORE IMPORTANT.
OVER THE LASTYEAR THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION RECENTLY REMOVED
A BAN ON IMPORTATION OF ELEPHANT
AND LIE AND TROPHIES.
S. B. FORTY SEVEN HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND IS
SUPPORTED BY MANY ENVIRONMENTAL
AND ANIMAL WELFARE ADVOCATES.
AND OF THE EVEN.
TODAY WAS FURTHER CLARIFIED NOT
THAT.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO STOP THE
IMPORTATION.
OF THESE TROPHIES AYE AND TO
TARGET THOSE THAT ARE.
REMOVING THESE PRODUCTS INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
IN ANY CASE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE --
MEASURED I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
STERN FOR AUTHORING.
BIGGEST CALLER THIS FRIEDMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU --
MISTER SPEAKER I WAS ACTUALLY
NOT.
THE BILL TODAY BUT AFTER READING
THE BILL IN BEING VERY CONCERNED.
ABOUT SOME ASPECTS OF THE BILL I
WANTED -- TO
ADDRESS YOU AND TOP TELL YOU
ABOUT SOME OF THE DISCUSSIONS
I'VE HAD WITH THE BILL'S AUTHOR
WHEN THIS BILL CAME UP IN
COMMITTEE I HEARD AND COMMITTEE.
AND HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. FOR ONE THING THE GOALS OF
THIS BILL ARE EXTREMELY
MERITORIOUS YOU KNOW I HAVE A
YOUNG DAUGHTER AND I WORRY EVERY
DAY THAT I WILL ONE DAY HAVE TO
TELL HER THAT THOSE BEAUTIFUL
ANIMALS THAT SEE SEASON BOOKS.
DON'T EXIST ANY LONGER.
BUT YOU CAN'T SEE THEM IN THE
WILD THAT MAYBE THERE'S ONE OR
TWO LEFT IN ZOOS BUT THEY ARE
ALL PRACTICALLY. FOR ALL
INTENSIVE PURPOSES OFF THE
PLANET THAT MIGHT SEEM.
FAR FETCHED BUT THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF POACHING
RIGHT NOW.
BUT I WAS WORRIED ABOUT THE BILL
AND THE REASON I WAS WORRIED IS
BECAUSE OF SOME OF YOU DON'T
KNOW THIS BUT AFTER I HAD MY
CAREER IN THE FILM INDUSTRY I
BECAME AN ANTIQUES DEALER.
AND ICE THE DEAL IN ANTIQUE
INVENTED STORY.
AND SOME OF THAT VINTAGE STORY
IN FACT QUITE A LOT OF IT
OCCASIONALLY WILL HAVE IVORY AND
OTHER TYPES OF MATERIAL AND
BECAUSE THE BILL BANS POSSESSION.
I WAS AFRAID ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
IF SOMEBODY IF SOME OVERZEALOUS
PROSECUTOR STARTED TO GO AFTER.
SOMEONE FOR THEIR GRANDMOTHER'S
BROOCH.
AND I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WASN'T THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND THAT COULDN'T HAPPEN IN
THE BILL.
BUT I ALSO DIDN'T WANT A
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE HAD TO
PROVE THEMSELVES THAT THEY HAD.
OWNED A PIANO WITH IVORY KEYS
FOR TWENTY YEARS OR THIRTY YEARS.
I HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION SAY
WITH THE BILL'S ADVOCATES IN THE
BILL'S AUTHOR THAT CERTAINLY
WASN'T ITS INTENT AND HE WAS
WILLING TO PUT A LETTER INTO THE
FILE WHICH HE DID. TO CLARIFY
THAT NUMBER ONE IT WOULD BE IT
WAS HIS INTENT THAT THE AND
BURDEN OF PROOF WOULD BE ON THE
PROSECUTORS ON THOSE WHO WANT.
TO REST PRESS CHARGES AGAINST
SOMEONE THEY WOULD HAVE TO PROVE.
THAT THE ITEM WAS NOT OWNED FOR
MANY YEARS AND SECONDLY IT WAS
ALSO NOT AS INTENT TO HAVE
PROSECUTION OVER DIMINISH THIS
SMALL AMOUNTS OF THE MATERIAL
SUCH AS YOU WOULD FIND IN
VINTAGE JEWELRY.
THAT LETTER IS NOW IN THE FILE
AND NEXT YEAR I'M COMMITTED TO
DOING A BILL TO CLARIFY THIS.
SO THAT THE LAW IS A LITTLE BIT
CLEARER AND DOESN'T LEAD TO THE
OVERZEALOUS PROSECUTION OF SOME.
ANTIQUE MALL OWNER WHO HAS A
TEENY PIECE OF JEWELRY IN A
SHOWCASE BUT CERTAINLY NOT AN
IMPORTER OR SOMEONE WHO EVEN
WOULD KNOWINGLY PUT THIS
MATERIAL OUT FOR SALE.
WITHOUT I'M VERY COMFORTABLE
WITH THE BILL RITE NOW AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE
TIME IS RUNNING OUT. FOR THESE
AMAZING AN ENDANGERED ANIMALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BIG IS FRIEDMAN MISTER GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
SO I WANTED TO RISE BECAUSE I I
SHARE MANY OF THE SAME CONCERNS --
THAT THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM
GLENDALE THAT HAS POINTED OUT --
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
OBVIOUSLY A VERY WELL
INTENTIONED.
ONE AND I THINK EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM WOULD PROBABLY AGREE
WITH THAT INTENTION.
THE ISSUE IS ABOUT HOW BROAD.
THIS THIS BILL REACHES
[inaudible]
AND THOUGH I UNDERSTAND THE
COMMENTS --
FROM MY COLLEAGUE.
A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL DOES IT
REALLY DO THAT.
AND MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS
COULD GO AFTER PEOPLE
RETROACTIVELY COULD GO AFTER
PEOPLE.
WHO MAY BE IN POSSESSION OF
JEWELRY OR SOME OR A BROOCH OR
SOME KIND OF THING THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED?
UNDER THIS BILL AND FACE
PROSECUTION.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S JUST.
AND THE OTHER POINT THAT I WOULD
BRING UP THAT I THINK IS OFTEN
LOST IN THIS DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
IS.
THAT MANY OF THE HUNTERS.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR THE
GREATEST CONTRIBUTORS TO
CONSERVATION EFFORTS IN AFRICA
THAT ARE PROTECTING THE SPECIES
TODAY.
AND SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
GROUPS LIKE SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL YOU TALK ABOUT
MANY OF THEIR MEMBERS WHO.
WHO ARE HUNTERS?
BUT WHO ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
THEY'RE NOT POACHERS THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM WE HAVE IS WITH POACHERS
THAT'S WHO WE HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH.
AND WHO ARE LEADING TOO THE
DECIMATION OF SPECIES.
IT'S NOT WITH RESPONSIBLE
HUNTERS WHO ACTUALLY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE. TO THE CONSERVATION OF THE
SPECIES [inaudible]
AND SO.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THAT IN MIND.
AND AS WELL AS NOT EVERY SPECIES.
UNDER THIS BILL IS A THREATENED
SPECIES SO AGAIN THE THE ALL THE
SPECIES THAT ARE COVERED BY THIS
BILL.
IS NOT TARGETING THE MOST
ENDANGERED SPECIES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SO AGAIN I THINK
THAT THAT WE NEED SOME MORE WORK
ON THIS BILL IT CAN WAIT TILL
NEXT YEAR.
AND I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE SO
THAT WE CAN GET THIS RIGHT IN
THE NEXT SESSION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
MR MAKES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU IT'S INTERESTING
ACTUALLY FINDS OF A FIND MYSELF
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN.
OF THE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
FROM GLENDALE AND AND MY
COLLEAGUE HERE IN FRONT OF ME.
I AM I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THIS EVENING BUT I DO THINK
THAT IT ACTUALLY.
NEEDS SOME SOME MORE WORK AND
THE TRUTH IS OF THE ELEVEN
ANIMALS THAT ARE ON I THIS LIST
NINE OF THEM ARE --
THREATENED AND I THINK ITS
IMPORTANT FOR US FOR THE SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN.
I DO THE BIT THE LITTLE BIT THAT
WE CAN A TO BE ABLE --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
KILLING ANIMALS THEY SHOULDN'T
BE SHOULD BE KILLED WHILE I
UNDERSTAND --
I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER THE AS
THE CITY.
THAT NECKLACE LIKE AS IT MY TO
SEE BIEBER BUT THAT IS --
THAT IS MY OTHER OF MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES.
THE FINE MEMBER FROM EAST
NICOLAS.
WHAT WHILE I AGREE WITH HIM I DO
THINK THAT LED TO THE JOURNAL?
THREE GALLAGHER THIS ONE REMIND
THE GENTLEMAN --
FROM COACHELLA.
DID NOT EVERY OTHER MEMBER NOT
EVERYTHING NORTH OF THE
TEHACHAPI IS.
IS THE SAME.
MISTER GALLAGHER THAT POINT IS.
WHILE TAKING A MR DAYS I'D NOTE
THE OUR AND THAT THE AGENDA THAT
WE HAVE BEFORE US THIS EVENING
[inaudible]
PLEASE CONTINUE.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT TO SAY.
ANYWAY I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL THIS EVENING BUT IT DOES
NEED SOME MORE WORK AND I'M
GONNA WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM GLENDALE I'M NEXT
SESSION IN AN EXPEDITIOUS MANNER
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE. TO TO
FIX AFTER A FEW OF THESE LITTLE
LOOPHOLES THAT THAT HAVE BEEN
FOUND THE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK MISTER KALRA
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OUR
DONE BICKERING WITH ONE ANOTHER.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO
SEE THE BIPARTISAN WORK ON THIS --
AN AND IN PARTICULAR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE FOR
ABOUT RAISING THIS ISSUE --
AND ARE.
SENATE AUTHOR FOR IT KNOWLEDGE
IN IT AND MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BUT AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE
INDICATED --
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO WAIT IN
TERMS OF PUTTING THE PROPER
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE STATE OF OUR
SIZE HAS.
IN TERMS OF SETTING OUR VALUES.
THESE ANIMALS WE CERTAINLY NOT
THE WAY FOR THESE ANIMALS TO BE
ON THE ENDANGERED OR EXTREME
ENDANGERED LESS BEFORE WE START
TAKING ACTION MANY TIMES IT'S
OFTEN TOO LATE IF WE WAIT THAT
LONG.
SO I'M INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE
I ON S. B. PORT.
EIGHTY SEVEN BIG MISTER KALRA
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLICK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY SIX
KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THE BILL IS ADOPTED
MODE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
YOU KNOW I MET MEMBERS THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING NOW IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM.
AGAIN AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING NOW IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM.
AND MEMBERS AFTER THAT I
COMMITTEES COMPLETE WITH THEIR
WORK THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE MEETING
WILL BE I CALLED ALSO IN THE
SAME IN THE ROOM RULES COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM FORTY SEVEN SP
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THE CLERK
WILL POST.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE NO THIRTY ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM ONE THOUSAND
OFFICERS IS NOT. ONE THOUSAND
TWO WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE
FOR AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL POST.
MEMBERS ROADS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MISTER QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL AND HOP ON A BE NINETEEN
NINETEEN MISTER CLERK PLEASE
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY NINE KNOWS FOR THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL AND ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NINETY ONE SP
ONE SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
MISTER BLOOM.
CLOSE THE ROLLER NOTICE
RECONSIDERATION [inaudible]
MISTER QUIRK
.
MISTER BLOOM OUR SUGGESTION IS
THAT YOU REPLACE THE CALL.
REPLACE THE CALL OKAY WE'LL
REPLACE
.
WHAT IS YOUR POINT OF ORDER
POINT OF ORDER THAT BILL HAS
BEEN? THREE TIMES ON CALL.
ALREADY UNCALLED FOR THREE TIMES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR POINTING
THAT OUT TO US
.
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING NOW IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM ALL
MEMBERS OF THE OCCASIONS THE
COMMANDS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE GO IMMEDIATELY TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE ROOM WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TAKING UP
BUSINESS ON THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT THE
REQUEST OF THE OTHERS PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS THE
INACTIVE FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE
S. B. C..
THE ONE AND ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
FIVE SEVENTY TWO QUIRK SILVA AND
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE GLAZER WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
EIGHTY SIX SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE
BY SENATOR STERN ACCOLADE TO
ELECTRICITY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE REQUIRES THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR TO TAKE
SPECIFIED ACTIONS BY DECEMBER
FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY BACILLUS
TAPE THE COMMERCIALIZATION OF
MICRO GRADES OR DISTRIBUTION
CUSTOMERS OF LARGE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DO NOT SEE ANY MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE MISTER.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
GARCIA MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT AFTER THE CONVEYANCE
COMMITTEE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS MANY
WILL BE ON BOARD TO GO NOW.
BE READY FOR THAT.
COMMITTEE AND FOLLOWING THAT
WILL BE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION.
SO IF YOU'RE ON THOSE COMMITTEES
PLASE PAY ATTENTION FOR WHEN I
CALL YOU INTO THE RULES ROOM.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL IN S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER TING WHOOPS CALL
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM
TO TEN FROM THE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILES AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SOME LABOR MULLIN AND
OTHERS IN THAT RELATE TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN MISTER MOLYNEAUX
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWO
FOUR NINE THE CALIFORNIA
DISCLOSE ACT WAS A LANDMARK
CAMPAIGN FINANCE DISCLOSURE LAW.
POLITICAL ADS ARE NOW REQUIRED
TO ADHERE TO NEW FORMATTING IN
EARMARKING REGULATIONS MAKING IT
EASIER FOR VOTERS TO KNOW WHO
THE TRUE FUNDERS ARE BEHIND AN
AD.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
SOCIAL MEDIA DISCLOSE ACT WILL
ALSO BE ANOTHER NATION LEADING
CAMPAIGN FINANCE DISCLOSURE LAW
ON POLITICAL ADS APPEARING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO THE SENATE
TO ADDRESS HOW THE INFORMATION
REQUIRED UNDER THE BILL SHALL BE
PRESENTED ON THESE PLATFORMS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS ALSO APPLY TO ADS
APPEARING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
TRANSPARENCY IS NEEDED FOR ALL
POLITICAL ADS REGARDLESS OF THE
MANNER.
IN WHICH THEY APPEAR TO VOTERS
LET'S HAVE CALIFORNIA CONTINUE
TO LEAD THE COUNTRY AYE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS FOR
POLITICAL ADS OF ALL KINDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THE SUPPORT MEASURE.
THANK YOU A SOME MEMBER
STEINORTH YOU'RE RECOGNIZED YES
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL FOR ALL OF US THAT.
SEEK PUBLIC OFFICE AT THE PEOPLE
THAT SUPPORT US HAVE THE REALLY
JUST PUT THEIR NAMES OUT THERE
SO THAT THE PEOPLE THERE VOTING
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHERE THIS
MONEY IS COMING FROM TO HELP US
WITH OUR CAMPAIGNS.
I I BELIEVE THAT THEY BELIEVE IN
THIS LEGISLATION I I REQUEST
EVERYONE ELSE SUPPORT THIS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ALSO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT ENCOURAGE
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME
TRANSPARENCY IS NOT SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE AFRAID OF IT SOMETHING
WE NEED TO SHINE LIGHT INTO AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THE THANK YOU.
I AM SEEING NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK I WILL RETURN YOUR
MULLIN PRETTY CLOSING OR THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND TAKING MY
COLLEAGUES WE HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THE DISCLOSE ACT.
LET'S HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
SUPPORT FOR THE SOCIAL MEDIA
DOES CLOSE ACT AND LET'S HAVE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE THE COUNTRY ON
THIS ISSUE.
ASPERA AIBO THINK YOU MIGHT THAT
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS SYSTEM REQUIRES FIFTY
FOUR VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
SOME NEVER
MULLIN MOVES THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK SO.
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN OH
SEVEN MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SO MICHAEL TWENTY SEVEN OH SEVEN
BY SLIVER MULLIN LIKELY VOTERS.
SOME NEVER MULLIN.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SEVEN OF SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKING IN THE SENATE ADDRESS
COSTS RELATED CONCERNS.
BY INCLUDING A COST CAP IN THE
MEASURE THIS BILLS WERE ST
RECEIVE STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WE ARE MOVING NOW
TO ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
FIVE BY SOME UBER MULLIN MAC
RELATE TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
AND FINALLY MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE AS A CLEAN
UP IT RELATES TO LAST YEAR'S
DISCLOSE ACT THAT WILL PROVIDE
NECESSARY IN TECHNICAL CLEAN UP.
TWO THE LANDMARK LEGISLATION A
SMALL NUMBER OF TECHNICAL ISSUES
AROSE.
THAT NEED FURTHER CLARIFICATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE TWENTY ONE
FIFTY FIVE SEEKS TO PROVIDE THAT
CLARIFICATION MORE SPECIFICALLY.
THIS MEASURE CLARIFIES
DEFINITIONS OF ADVERTISEMENT
MASS ELECTRONIC MAILING AND MASS
MAILING AS WELL AS PROVIDES FOR
SOME CLARIFICATION TO FORMATTING
REQUIREMENTS.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
SOME MEMBER MULLIN MOVES
THE CALL.
WE ARE MOVING NOW.
THE FILE ITEM TO GO TO AB ONE
EIGHTY MISTER QUICKLY ST.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD NEVER FOR
NATALIE TO MEDI CAL THE CLEARLY
WISHES XEROX THAT PICKED
IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB ONE
EIGHTY WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE'S REQUIRED DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. TO
ESTABLISH A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
TO DEVELOP GUIDELINES FOR
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS OR RURAL HEALTH CLINICS
TO DETERMINE WHAT QUALIFIES AS
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS UNDER THE PAY
FOR PERFORMANCE PROGRAM.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
FOR THOSE YEARS WITHOUT
GUIDELINES DEPARTMENT SHOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO RECOUP THESE PAYMENTS
WILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUIRK WAS OPEN THE
WRONG ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES EYES FIFTY SIX
NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY EYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS IT BUT NOSES
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING OUT ITEM TO A
THREE EIGHTY THIRTEEN THIRTY THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SO WE WILL THIRTEEN THIRTY BY
SIMPLY MARIA'S INOCULATE PARK
PROPERTY DECLARE MAY OF SIERRA
PACIFIC IMMEDIATELY THINK YOU'RE
SOME VARIOUS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN THIRTY IS A
STRAIGHT FORWARD MEASURE THE
PROVIDES AUTHORITY TO THE COUNTY
OF SANDRA DINO. TO MOVE AYE
YELLOW PARK LOCATED IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE UNINCORPORATED
AREA OF BLOOMINGTON. FOR MORE
APPROPRIATE AREA.
THIS WOULD ONLY OCCUR ONCE
LOCATION IS PURCHASED AND
PROVIDES AN EQUAL OR GREATER
RECREATIONAL VALUE COMPARED TO
THE CURRENT LOCATION.
AYE ALLEN PARK IS CURRENTLY IN
AN AREA ADJACENT TO A FREEWAY
SURROUNDED BY PRIMARILY
COMMERCIALIZED COMMERCIALLY
ZONED PROPERTIES.
AND THE PLAN IS TO MOVE IT TO AN
AREA FURTHER AWAY FROM THE
FREEWAY NEXT ONE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND ACROSS
THE STREET FROM A LIBRARY.
THIS WOULD BE DONE WHILE STILL
MAINTAINING ACCESS TO GREEN
SPACE FOR THE COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE
AT ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD AND WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
ITEM TWO OH FIVE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY TWO MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS NOT ONLY
TO FIRE INSURANCE TO CLEARLY YOU
SEE THEIR OF THICK PICKING ME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY TWO WILL EXTEND BY ONE
YEAR THE TIME ME FIRE VICTIM HAS
TO REPLACE THEIR HOME.
AFTER A CATASTROPHIC FIRE WHICH
WILL PREVENT STRESSFUL BATTLES
WITH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
SENATE AMENDMENTS RESOLVE
CHOPPING ISSUES AND AB URGENCY
TO THE END TO ENSURE THE POLICY
TAKES EFFECT BEFORE THE FALLS
LISTS.
FIRE SEASON THIS FALL THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT EVEREST BECK
FULLY ESCRIBIR.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM MISTER
CORPORATE OPEN THE MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEMBERS IS REQUIRES FIFTY FOR
ALL MEMBERS VOTE REQUIRED TO
VOTE.
MR QUIRKY MAY CLOTHES THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE SIXTEEN
KNOWS ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTEEN KNOW ZERO ON THE MEASURE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM REFERRING THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
TO COMMITTEE.
AB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT A CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOIN WILL SIX TO A THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT. TO
ALLOW THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HERE S. B. SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR UPON CALLED THE
CHAIR IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ROOM.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER WE'RE MOVING
OUT OFF FILE ITEM TO A SIX AB
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME AGO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE TERMS TO
CLEARLY TO SEE THEIR OF
SIGNIFCANTLY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS URGENCY MEASURE
FOR INSURANCE REFORM TO HELP
NATURAL DISASTER SURVIVORS
IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICKLY IS OPEN TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRING TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I FIFTY SIX KNOWS HERE
ON THE MEASURE THE SENATE.
AS OUR CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING OUT ITEM TO A
SEVEN AB NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SO MIDDLE
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
THE CLEARLY YOU SEE THEIR UP
SIGNIFICANTLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
MADAM SPEAKER AB NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE WILL RATIFY THE TRIBAL
COMPACT FOR THE BIG VALLEY BAND
OF POMO INDIANS.
OF THE BIG VALLEY RANCHERIA
ACCOUNTS S. CONSTITUENT TRIBE OF
MINE IN LAKE COUNTY.
THE BIG VALLEY BAND OF POMO
INDIANS IS A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED INDIAN TRIBE THAT HAS
BEEN LIVING IN THE CLEAR LAKE
AREA FOR NEARLY TWELVE THOUSAND
YEARS.
THE TRIBE'S CASINO LAKEPORT
PROVIDES REVENUES TO SUPPORT
VITAL PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR
TRIBAL MEMBERS AND RESIDENTS IN
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES ALIKE.
COMPAQ RATIFICATION WILL ENSURE
THE TRIBE TO CONTINUE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE CULTURAL AND
ECONOMIC VITALITY OF ITS TRIBAL
MEMBERS AND LAKE COUNTY AS A
WHOLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF MR COURT
PLEASE OPEN THE RUN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY
AYE SIXTY ONE NO ZERO IN THE
MEASURE THE SENATE [inaudible]
HEARD IN.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED. TO LIFT
THE CALL.
I'M PREPARED TO LIVE THE CALL ON
ITEM EIGHTY SIX SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
PURPLE CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW
THE BOATS AYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS.
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING OUT ITEM TO AWAIT
<c.green> BE NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THE</c>
CORPOREAL.
A SWIMMING HOLE NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE A TRIBAL CAME CLEARING
YOUR SEE THEIR UP SIGNIFICANTLY.
SOME IRAQI R. CURRY MADAM
SPEAKER AB NINETEEN SIXTY SIX
WILL RATIFY AN AMENDMENT TO THE
TRIBAL COMPACT FOR MY
CONSTITUENT TRIBE.
THE HUBBLE LITTLETON MODEL POMO
OF UPPER LAKE.
THE UPPER LAKE RANCHERIA WAS
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED TO
BENEFIT A GROUP OF HOMELESS IN
LAND LISTS POMO INDIANS IN THE
CAR LIKE AREA IN THE NINETEEN
HUNDREDS.
TODAY THE HAVE A MOTEL BOWL POEM
ALL OF THE UPPER LEG ARE FOCUSED
ON THE ACTIVITIES TO PRESERVE
POMO CULTURE AND REDISCOVER LOS
TRADITIONS SPIRITUAL BELIEFS AND
LANGUAGES.
THIS COMPACT AMENDMENT WILL
CREATE COST SAVING OPPORTUNISM
ALLOW THE TRIBE TO FURTHER
INVEST IN THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS OF THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER KIRKE MAKE CLOSER ON
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN MISTER
QUICKLY.
THREE SO ME BILL TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN BI ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AN ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS THE
CLEARLY YOU CAN SEE THERE OUGHT
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU S. SOME NEVER BONTA
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE IT
WOULD AUTHORIZE A PHARMACY TO
PROVIDE PHARMACY SERVICES TO
PATIENTS.
OF SAFETY NET CLINICS THROUGH
THE USE OF AN AUTOMATED PATIENT.
SPENDING SYSTEM SENATE
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY TO CONDUCT A PRE
LICENSURE INSPECTION AT THE
PROPOSED LOCATION REQUIRE A
PHARMACY HOLDING AN AUTOMATED
PATIENT DISPENSING SYSTEM TO
COMPLETE AN ANNUAL.
SELF ASSESSMENT AND ADD AN
URGENCY BECAUSE THIS WILL HELP
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE DELIVERY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
DEBATE THIS ITEM MISTER CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY AYE SIXTY
ONE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE
THE SENATE.
IT'S OUR CONCURRED IN
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
HE S. TM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING NOW IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
PLEASE REMOVE YOURSELF TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE ROOM IF YOU'RE
ON THAT COMMITTEE.
NEXT BUILT NEXT WE ARE MOVING TO
ITEM.
TWO ELEVEN AB TWENTY THREE OH
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO MIDDLE TWENTY THREE OH NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM ACTUALLY
THE COURT FACILITIES ARE CLEARLY
YEARS IF YOU DON'T TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
SOME MEMBER BLOOM THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE OH NINE
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
IN THE SENATE ADDED THE MENTAL
HEALTH COURTHOUSE IN THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES.
AND TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS THIS BILLS RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY.
THANK YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSER UNTIED
THE VOTES AYE SIXTY NO ZERO THAT
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE YOU WILL
BE MEETING SHORTLY.
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM SO
PLEASE STAND BY.
WE ARE WORKING A SUPPLEMENTAL
PLOW.
I BELIEVE WE'RE AT VIOLENT.
TO TWELVE A. B. [inaudible]
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACT LIKE A FIRE
PROTECTION.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
STRENGTHENED OVERALL EMERGENCY
RESPONSE STANDARDS DURING AN ACT
OF FIRE TO BENEFIT.
ALL FIRE RESOURCES BOTH PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NAME IS A HERE CURSING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL ITALIAN BUT I FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS ON CALL.
REPAIR TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
SIXTY S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
THE CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WISHED ABOUT
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE.
ICE NINE THOSE FORTY SEVEN THAT
MEASURE [inaudible]
MALES
.
MEMBERS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN SP
NINE TWENTY THREE THE CORPORAL
HER.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS EIGHTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS PREPARED WITH THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE SP
[inaudible]
FOUR SIXTY CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MISTER BONTA REPLACES THE CALL
MEMBERS PREPARE LET THE CALL.
THIS IS S. B. [inaudible]
TWO FORTY FOUR LOCAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED ABOUT ICE
FORTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY FOUR
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
[inaudible] SEVENTY S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
WORK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALBOT EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY SEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND I WILL LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
AT NINETY ONE SP ONE SIXTY BLOOM.
CLERK WILL POST.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND SALAS ABOUT EYES.
TWENTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN
THAT MEASURE FAILS.
AND NOW MEMBERS OF THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
COMMITTEE GEO COMMITTEE WILL NOW
BE MEETING [inaudible]
COMMITTEE ROOM.
SHE I WILL BE BEATING AND ROLLS
AND AND MEMBERS OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE YOU ARE UP
NEXT IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM
AFTER.
THE GEO COMMITTEE MEETS SO GEO
COMMITTEE WILL MEET RIGHT NOW
AND THEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WILL MEET.
OFF THE FLOOR THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM
.
MEMBERS WE ARE WORKING THIS
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM CHIU.
THIRTEEN MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
WILL JOCKEY.
THIS IS FILE AND TO THIRTEEN
THIS IS A BE. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT I'M SORRY I'M SORRY IT'S
NOT A JOCKEY THIS IS.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER'S A. B..
COMING BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME THE RIVER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ACCOLADE MEDICO.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCY AMENDMENTS TAKING ON
SENATOR TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHAPTER IN OUT AMENDMENTS.
A VIRUS HAVE PLANS FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL YOU VOTE ICE FORTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT IN.
FILE ITEM.
TO FOURTEEN MISTER HOLDEN IS OFF
THE FLOOR WE WILL [inaudible]
PASS TEMPORARILY.
FILE ITEM TO FIFTEEN MISTER
COOPER.
WE WILL.
PASS TEMPORARILY MISTER HOLDEN
HAS RETURNED TO THE FLOOR.
WE WILL TAKE OUT FILE ITEM.
TO FOURTEEN THIS IS AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY FOUR HOLDEN CORP WILL
POST HER MAKE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SIXTY
FOUR BY SOME RIVER BEHOLDER THAT
POLITICAL REPORTERS.
MISTER HOLDING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY FOUR REAFFIRMS
AND CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW. TO
ENSURE ALL PARTIES INVOLVED IN A
CONTESTED MATTER PROVIDED A
COURT REPORTER. TO TAKE DOWN THE
VERBATIM RECORD OF THEIR CORE
PROCEEDINGS SO THAT FUTURE
PROCEEDINGS CAN FUNCTION WITHOUT
JUDICIAL DELAY.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE ENSURE
THAT A COURT REPORTER HAS TO BE
PRESENT IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
WITH THE PROCESS AND GAINED AT
SEA I YOU.
AS A SUPPORTER.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY FOUR WOULD
ENSURE THE EFFICIENCY AND
ACCURACY OF A COURT PROCEEDING
TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
LITIGANTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RELIABLE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY
THREE KNOWS.
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
AND MEMBERS OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IS NOW
GOING TO BE MEETING IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM OFF THE FLOOR.
THIS IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
ON DECK WILL BE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE PLEASE BE
READY.
FOLLOWED THEN BY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE VIEWS ARE
SERIES OF MEETINGS OFF THE FLOOR
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM
LOCAL GOV IS NOW MEETING
[inaudible]
WE ARE.
IN FILE ORDER.
ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
IT'S YOUR COOPER HAS RETURNED TO
THE FLOOR.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
TO FIFTEEN WHICH IS AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY NINE CORKERY.
SO ME BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
NINE BY SIMPLY RIVER COOPER AND
OTHERS ARE LIKELY TO PRIVACY.
MISTER COOPER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY NINE PASSED WITH UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT ON CONSENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
SENTIMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING IN THAT CO AUTHORS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER SCENE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON NUMBER FUNDS
ARE TO VOTE ON NUMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW ABOUT EYES
FORTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US ON THE FLOOR OF
THE ASSEMBLY WE HAVE THE MAYOR
OF THE GREAT CITY OF OAKLAND THE
HONORABLE LEVY SHAFT JOINING US
ON THE FLOOR TONIGHT WELCOMING
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING IN FILE
ORDER.
ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE THIS IS
FILE AND TO SIXTEEN A. B..
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY NINE BY SOME MEMBERS
JONES SAWYER AN ACCOLADE THE
CANNABIS MISTER JONES SAWYER.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THAT WAS QUICK IF.
I MISHEARD JONES SAWYER YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
OUR TECHNICAL AND AT THE REQUEST
OF DEPARTMENT.
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
COR CALDERON ON THIS ADDED THAT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
IF YOU'RE NOT IN COMMITTEE
PLEASE COME TO THE FLOOR.
MISS JONES SAWYER MOVES A CALL.
STAYING FILE ORDER FILE ITEM.
TO SEVENTEEN IS AB THIRTY EIGHTY
NINE BY MR DARMAN CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY EIGHTY NINE
BY SOME MEMBER REPAIRING OTHER
CYNICALLY THE SUIT FINANCIALLY
MAKING APPROPRIATION ARE FOR
FIVE YEARS INTERRUPTS EXPECT
IMMEDIATELY [inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB.
THIRTY EIGHTY NINE THE FINAL
BILL.
BUT I WILL PRESENT IN THIS
LEGISLATURE I'M HONORED THAT
THIS BILL.
HAS HAD ITS PURPOSE AND MISSION
SUPPORT FOSTER YOU IT BUILDS.
ON AN EARLIER BILL THAT I
INTRODUCED IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
TO GUARANTEE THAT ANY YOUNG
PERSON EMANCIPATING FROM FOSTER
CARE WILL HAVE MONEY TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE CHAFEE GRANT.
I'M HONORED THAT YOU ALL JOIN ME
IN PASSING THAT LEGISLATION THAT
WAS LATER.
INCORPORATED AS A TRAILER BILL
TO ENSURE THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE MONEY TO GO TO
COLLEGE PART OF THAT BILL.
EVERY YEAR THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE
WERE LEFT ON A WAITING LIST
BECAUSE OF LACK OF FUNDS.
AND THEY WERE UNABLE TO RECEIVE
[inaudible]
HIV GRANT.
THIS BILL BILLS ON THAT WORK
RECOGNIZING THAT MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO EMANCIPATE FROM
FOSSIL YOU.
ARE NOT ABLE TO UTILIZE THIS
GRANT BECAUSE IT CURRENTLY AGES
OUT OUR CAPS OUT OF THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO AS YOU KNOW MANY
FOSTER YOU.
HAVE TO TAKE MORE TIME TO
COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATION AND
THIS YEAR WE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND.
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR USE AGE
TWENTY SIX ON I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
HER WORK. TO GET THIS
INCORPORATED IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW OUR
STATE AGENCIES TO DO OUTREACH TO
MAKE SURE THAT FOSTER YOUTH.
KNOW ABOUT THE BILL AND CAN USE
THESE RESOURCES.
IT DOES REQUIRE URGENCY SO THAT
WE CAN SUPPORT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
URGENTLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
ON AB.
THIRTY EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU MRS
THURMAN.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLE ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE?
MEMBERS THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON
THE URGENCY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH
THOUGH
.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENT.
MEASURE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO TAKE A MISS QUIRK SILVA
AS ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TWO ZERO FOUR AB. FIFTEEN FORTY
SEVEN FOR COREY.
SOME GO FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
SOME ME BARBARA QUIRK SILVA
ANOTHER TONIGHT LEGACY FINANCING
MAKING APPROPRIATION AFFORDED
CLEARLY USES EITHER OF
SIGNIFICANTLY.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN
MAKES PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES TO
FINANCING AUTHORITIES THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE UP.
ABOLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT FINANCING
ADVISORY COMMISSION AND
MODIFYING PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAPITAL ACCESS
PROGRAM FIRST SEISMIC SAFETY IN
THE SALES AND USE.
TAX EXCLUSION PROGRAM.
THESE PROGRAM MODIFICATIONS HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL MONTHS AND ARE INTENDED
TO BETTER ALIGN THE PROGRAMS
WITH CURRENT MARKET CONDITIONS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVE YOU NOW AS
A UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
PLAYERS OUT OF THE VOTERS AND
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO GO.
THIS TAKES [inaudible]
FIFTY FOUR CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLLING TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SHOULD FIVE NO ZERO ON
THE BILL.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
WE'RE FILE ITEM.
TO EIGHTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN FIVE MISTER GIPSON.
I BELIEVE THE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE IS NOW
MEETING WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
COMMITTEE IS NOW WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE.
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM
[inaudible]
THESE COMMITTEE MEETINGS ARE
HAPPENING RIGHT OFF THE FLOOR IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE RIGHT
NOW.
AND MISTER GIBSON.
YOU HAVE FILED AND TO YOU
EIGHTEEN AB [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN THE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
BY SOME WE'VE EVER GIPSON OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE COMEDIAN PARA
MEDICINE [inaudible]
MR GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
WHICH WILL ENSURE A COMMUNITY
PARA MEDICINES AT ALTERNATE
DESTINATION.
PILOT PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO EXIST
AND PERMIT PROGRAMS CAN BE
FORMED MEMBERS WE HAVE A
HEALTHCARE CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS CRISIS IS EVIDENT WHEN
PEOPLE CALL 911- AND
FIREFIGHTERS AND PARAMEDICS
RESPOND TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE EMERGENCIES.
ONLY.
TO ONLY TO HAVE THE PATIENCE
SENT TO AN OVERCROWDED <c.green> ARE</c>
WHERE THEY DO NOT RECEIVE THE
PROPER CARE NEED IT.
OUR LOVED ONES.
ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE THE RIGHT
CARE AT THE RIGHT TIME BECAUSE
OUR PARAMEDICS ARE ABLE TO EACH
BE TRANSPORTED. TO TO BE
TRANSPORTED TO ALTERNATE
DESTINATIONS SUCH AS MENTAL
HEALTH CARE CENTERS OR SO BRING
CENTERS PARAMEDICS ARE.
ALREADY TRAINED. TO STABILIZE
OUR LOVED ONES WHEN THEY ARE
FACED WITH A HEART ATTACK OR
STROKE.
OR SERIOUS ILLNESS THAT REQUIRES
A SPLIT DECISION COMMUNITY PARA
MEDICINE ALLOW ARMS SPECIALIZED
TRAINED PARAMEDICS TO PERFORM
OUTSIDE THEIR TRADITIONAL ROLE
TO ENHANCE ACCESS TO CARE.
SUCH AS IN AND FREQUENT NINE ONE
ONE CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
THAT HAVE SHOWN TO BREAK THE
CYCLE. TO GET THE PATIENTS THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED AT ONCE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
GIVES LOCAL AGENCIES THE OPTION
TO DEVELOP THESE PROGRAMS AND
REQUIRE THE STATE AUTHORITY. TO
DEVELOP A MINIMUM MEDICAL
PROTOCOL WITH HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AND LOCAL MEDICAL
DIRECTORS.
IT IS A THOUGHTFUL BALANCED
APPROACH THAT GIVES LOCAL
AGENCIES THE FLEXIBILITY EASE.
WHILE ENSURING A CERTAIN
STANDARD OF CARE IS MET AT EVERY
PROGRAM THIS BILL IS THE RIGHT
[inaudible]
THIS BILL.
IS RIGHT FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
PATIENTS WHEN NEEDED THE RIGHT
CARE AT THE RIGHT TIME WE TRUST
OUR PARAMEDICS AND FIREFIGHTERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE.
ON ASSEMBLY BILL [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN MISTER BONTA
[inaudible]
YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES ARISES A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
I SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON ON THIS ISSUE THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT AND WHERE I EARLIER
HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING AS
VICE MAYOR.
HAS RUN ONE OF THESE.
OUR PILOT COMMUNITY PAIR
MEDICINE PROGRAMS IN THE DATA.
IS FANTASTIC WITH RESPECT TO THE
POSITIVE RESULT IT HAS ON THE
COMMUNITY SO --
THESE PROGRAMS WORK MORE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
PROGRAMS AS WELL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THEY RESPONSA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
PLEASE RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THIS A VERY GOOD BILL.
IT ENSURES ENTERS.
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
PUBLISHED IT WRESTLES COME TO
THE AID OF SOMEONE ON THE STREET.
THEY WILL END UP IN A PLACE
WHERE THEY WILL BE AIDED.
AT THAT TIME --
IT'S A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
FLEXIBILITY AND RESPONSIVENESS
MIRED XIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU ARE SORRY FOR THE LATE
NOTICE MISTER SPEAKER --
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I
THINK IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE
NEEDED SERVICES --
AT AT THE SCENE WHERE THEY'RE
REALLY NEEDED I'M I DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO WORK ON
IN THE FUTURE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM IS
INTEGRATED INTO --
THIS A NEW APPROACH TO A
PROVIDING SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR I AND
OTHERS IN MAKING THAT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
SAYING KNOW ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN AND WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBER FROM CARSON FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
AS A BALANCED SOLUTION TO
APPROACH A PROBLEM THAT I AM ALL
TOO FAMILIAR WITH.
SIMPLY PUT OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS
ARE CROWDED AND HAVING TO
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE TO AN OVER
ABUNDANCE OF PATIENTS CAN GET
VERY DIFFICULT SOMETIMES
SOMETHING I'M A LITTLE TOO
FAMILIAR WITH.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES PILOTS TO
AIM TO REDUCE THESE ET VISITS BY
CREATING ALTERNATIVE DESTINATION.
IT ALSO ADDRESSES THE CONCERN OF
MINE AND ENSURES THAT PATIENTS
ARE NOT DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN
THE PROVISION OF CARE JUST AS WE
DO NOT DISCRIMINATE IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM.
THIS BILL STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN ALLOWING LOCAL CONTROL
AND HAVING STATEWIDE STANDARDS
TO PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
SAVE IS A SAFE WAY TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF PATIENTS WHO SEEK CARE
IN THE E. D.. TO KEEP THEM WELL
WITH POST DISCHARGE FOLLOW UP
AND INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND I URGE AND AYE VOTES TODAY
FOR AB.
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN THANK YOU.
BACK ARAMBULA.
NOW SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE WORKED
HARD TO COME UP WITH A
COMPROMISE WE BELIEVE THAT --
WE HAVE A COMPROMISE THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS BEFORE US TONIGHT --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN WITH THAT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
SMALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE
[inaudible]
ON THE NO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
INTEL IN THE EYES FOUR NINE
THOSE FOURTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE IS
NOW MEETING IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM.
WHICH IS RIGHT OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
AND MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER.
AB ARMY FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO NINETEEN A. B.. NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY MS KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
THE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SOME THE RIVER KAMLAGER-DOVE
UP ANOTHER CYNICAL IN
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
[inaudible]
MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT MY VERY FIRST BILL.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY SEVEN I KNOW
THAT MADE EVERYONE TURN AROUND I
KNOW [inaudible]
AND DON HAYS ME BRAUDEL HAZMI.
I LOVE SPORTS BUT FOR ME MAYBE.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN HAS NEVER BEEN
ABOUT BUILDING A SPORTS ARENA.
MOSTLY BECAUSE I AM A BULLS FAN.
IT HAS BEEN ABOUT THOUSANDS OF
JOBS AND ECONOMIC EQUITY FOR
INGLEWOOD AND THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES THAT I AM PROUD TO
REPRESENT.
YET THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE STATE OF
THE ARE PRIVATELY FUNDED
FACILITY. TEN THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTION JOBS ONE THOUSAND
PERMANENT OPERATIONAL JOBS AND A
VERY STRONG LOCAL HIGHER
PREFERENCE ENSURING THESE JOBS
COME TO AND STAY IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW FOR MILLIONS
IN POTENTIAL PUBLIC REVENUE FOR
PARKS LIBRARIES MENTAL HEALTH
AND HEALTH ACCESS AND OTHER
SERVICES CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
COMMUNITIES QUALITY OF LIFE.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DIRECT
AND INDIRECT ECONOMIC BENEFITS
FOR LOCAL BUSINESSES.
ALL WHILE TRANSFORMING ACRES OF
VACANT LAND THAT'S BEEN BLIGHTED
FOR YEARS AND SITS DIRECTLY
UNDER THE LOS ANGELES FLIGHT
PATH WHICH IS NOT SUITABLE FOR
MUCH ELSE.
I WANT TO THANK MY INGLEWOOD
COLLEAGUES ESPECIALLY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BURKE AND THOSE FROM THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES FOR
THEIR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
PROBABLY THE VERY TIRED LABOR
LEADERS AND COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
WHO ARE HERE TODAY IN THE
GALLERY AND IN THE BACK.
THIS BILL DEMONSTRATES THAT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION DO NOT
NEED TO BE MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE IN
FACT WITH THIS BELL I DARE SAY
WE ARE SETTING A NEW GOLD
STANDARD FOR GREEN STANDARDS.
AB NINE NINETY SEVEN REQUIRES
OUR PROJECT TO MEET THE SAME
STRICT ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
HAS MANY OTHER PROJECTS UNDER
SEEK WHAT AND OTHER STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL STATUTES.
IT REQUIRES A FULL AND
COMPREHENSIVE III OUR LEAD GOLD
CERTIFICATION A NET ZERO ENERGY
STANDARD WHICH IS THE HIGHEST IN
THE NATION 15% REDUCTION IN
VEHICLE TRIPS.
A TRANSPORTATION MANAGEMENT PLAN
ENTRANCE OF DESIGN AND
ASSISTANCE.
ON SITE AND LOCAL MITIGATION A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
INTO A MISSION REDUCTION SOLAR
ROOFING AND ENFORCEABLE METRICS
TOWARDS ADMISSION GOALS.
I'M TIRED JUST THINKING ABOUT
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT INGLEWOOD
WILL GET FROM THIS BILL.
I CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF ALL OF THE COMMITTEES
THAT THIS BILL HAS GONE THROUGH
ESPECIALLY THE CHAIR OF OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE. FOR
MAKING THIS BILL CLEANER GREEN
STRONGER.
SO WITH A HUMBLE HEART.
I ASK YOU TO JUDGE THIS BILL ON
THE MERITS OF ITS TANGIBLE
BENEFITS FOR INGLEWOOD AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SEQUEL GIVES
PEOPLE HEARTBURN A ON THIS FLOOR.
AND IT HAS CHALLENGES AND NEEDS
TO BE PART OF A LARGER MORE
DELIBERATIVE STATEWIDE
CONVERSATION.
BUT THIS BILL IS ABOUT FIXING
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES IN ONE PART
OF OUR STATE.
NOT FIXING EVERY PROBLEM
EVERYWHERE.
AND WE SHOULDN'T ALLOW THE
PERFECT TO BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD. FOR MANY OF YOU IN THE WAY
IT.
DOESN'T TOUCH OUR DISTRICT
PROBABLY NOT EVEN CLOSE.
AND YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING
HOW IS THIS GOING TO HELP YOU.
BECAUSE MOST OF US COME HERE TO
FIGHT FOR OUR OWN DISTRICTS.
BUT WE'RE OFTENTIMES VOTING ON
ISSUES THAT HAVE A LARGER IMPACT.
AND THIS BILL WILL.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT JOBS IN JOB
SAVE FAMILIES.
THIS BILL WILL CEMENT THE HOME
OF AN NBA FRANCHISE.
INTO A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT IS ON
THE PRECIPICE OF REVITALIZATION.
AND IT WILL CREATE AN ECONOMIC
MULTIPLIER EFFECT.
THAT WILL HAVE INGLEWOOD.
SEE THAT KIND OF TAX REVENUE
BASE THAT IT NEEDS AND DESERVES.
TO TACKLE THE ISSUES THAT IT
FACES AND THOSE ARE INTEGRATED.
AND MANY OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WERE HAVING. EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THIS ENTIRE PROCESS --
AND WHILE I AM CERTAINLY
INTERESTED AND BUILDING MAKING
SURE THE ARENA GETS DEALT TO
COME TO INGLEWOOD.
I'M EQUALLY EXCITED MAYBE AND
SING A TRIANGLE DEFENSE WHAT I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE TONIGHT.
IS ARE AYE VOTE ON AB
[inaudible]
NINETY SEVEN EIGHTEEN NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THEY WAS KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
MR ACOSTA [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
HAS BEEN A I'LL A LONG ROAD NOT
ONLY FOR THIS BILL BUT FOR THIS
PROJECT -- I
DID SEE A SPEAK ON THIS AND VOTE
ON THIS IN A NATURAL RESOURCES
LUCKY MY COMMENTS VERY BRIEF
[inaudible]
YOU'RE WELCOME [inaudible]
AND I YOU KNOW IT BOTTOM LINE
HERE IS THAT --
PSALM.
SOME OVER BOB.
RELIEF AND SOME STREAMLINING --
IS BETTER THAN NOT I'D LIKE TO
SEE THIS OP PLAN ON A BROADER
BROADER SCALE AS I'VE MENTIONED
MANY MANY TIMES IN MY TWO YEARS
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
HOWEVER THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PROJECT FOR AN IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY I AM --
A VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT IT NINE
COURAGE SHOP MY COLLEAGUES --
THROUGHOUT THIS CHAMBER TO
SUPPORT A. B. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
AS WELL THANK YOU.
THEY WAS CASA [inaudible]
MISS BURKE [inaudible]
URANUS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY SEVEN AND
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK AUTHOR
FOR THAT TIME AND ENERGY SHE HAS
PUT INTO THIS BILL AS YOU HAVE
HEARD IT'S BEEN AN EXTREMELY
LONG ROAD --
THIS BILL DOES CREATE THE
HIGHEST IN ARE FOR ANY STADIUM
BUILT BUILDING WE'VE SEEN YOU
SHE TOLD YOU ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
THIS PROJECT IS ESTIMATED TO
CREATE TEN THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION
JOBS FOR THE REGION ONE THOUSAND
PERMANENT JOBS.
APPEALING INCLUDES A 30% LOCAL
HIRE REVISION AND A 15% LOCAL
APPRENTICESHIP GOAL.
THE PROJECT DESIGN ALSO INCLUDES
A NEW OPEN SPACE FOR THE
COMMUNITY INCLUDING COMMITTEE
FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF
COMMUNITY MEETING SPACE FOR THE
USE BY THE COMMUNITY.
OTHER COMMITTEE BENEFITS BEING
CONSIDERED AS PART OF A FULLY
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THAT HAVES
INCLUDED OUR COMMUNITY GROUPS
ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDS AND
PROGRAMS EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR ENGLAND RESIDENTS
AND BUSINESSES.
PUBLIC NOTICES JOB FAIRS AND
WORKFORCE OUTREACH PROGRAMS.
IT IS ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT OUT THERE'S ABSOLUTE NO
PUBLIC SUBSIDY FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT THAT'S BEEN IN THE
CITY OF INGLEWOOD.
I WORK FOR THE CLIPPERS CONTINUE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE RESIDENTS
OF THE CITY OF INGLEWOOD AND
WITH INGLEWOOD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS TAG INGLEWOOD
RISING I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY MISS BURKE CHAU HOLDING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD
RISE -- TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WELL I
THINK THAT.
OF THIS IS BEEN A PROJECT THAT
HAS BEEN BEFORE US IN THE PAST.
AND IT DESERVES OUR SUPPORT
YOU'RE DEALING WITH A COMMUNITY
THAT AS WAS POINTED OUT HAS
[inaudible]
SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES.
AND WITH THE LOSS OF
REDEVELOPMENT COMMUNITIES LIKE
THIS ARE VERY CHALLENGE TO BE
ABLE TO FIND WAYS OF CREATING
ECONOMIC STIMULATION.
THIS JOB THIS PROJECT WILL BRING
JOBS TO THE COMMUNITY.
SO BRING ECONOMIC VITALITY.
AND I THINK IT'S LONG OVERDUE IN
TERMS OF THE NEEDS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR AREA OF INGLEWOOD.
AND AS WAS POINTED OUT.
IF THIS PROJECT DOES NOT GO
FORWARD THEN WHAT YOU'RE LEFT
WITH IS AN A BANDED AREA.
REPRESENTING MANY ACRES.
IN AN URBAN COMMUNITY.
IT BECOMES A MAGNET FOR CRIME AS
IT HAS BEEN IN THE PAST.
AND THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TURN AROUND AND BRING HOPE. TWO
A COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN
LOOKING FOR THIS TYPE OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR MANY YEARS.
I JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
ENDORSING THIS PROJECT.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN MISTER
TANG [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST
WANT TO RISE VERY.
ARE BRIEFLY I THE DISTINCT HONOR
I IN MY FIRST YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO CARRY A SIMILAR
BILL. TO HELP BRING THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS.
TO SAN FRANCISCO AND I REALLY
WANNA.
IT'S VERY CHALLENGING --
VOTES --
REALLY WANT TO CONGRATULATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LA ON MAKING THIS
HER FIRST BILL I KNOW HOW
CHALLENGING IS TO BALANCE.
ENVIRONMENTAL STAKEHOLDERS BRING
TOGETHER THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
BRING TOGETHER ON THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO STAND IN
OR AB NINE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS TAMAR SHOULD
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION BUT IT'S A
LITTLE LATE FOR ANY KIND OF
HAZING.
IT'S A LEGITIMATE QUESTION.
IS THIS YOUR FIRST BILL.
YES IT IS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WELL I KNOW WE'VE DONE.
SOME SIMILAR SEQUENCE
STREAMLINING FOR THE AMAZING
SACRAMENTO KINGS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND AND WE'VE SEEN THIS
BEAUTIFUL GOLDEN ONE ARENA JUST
DOWN THE STREET.
AND I KNOW WE'VE.
DONE THIS FOR THE WORLD CHAMPION
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
I BELIEVE THAT'S CORRECT RIGHT
[inaudible]
BUT INGLEWOOD.
ENGLEWOOD IS ALWAYS UP TO NO
GOOD.
AND EVEN HOLLYWOOD.
HASN'T GOTTEN THIS KIND
EXEMPTION.
AND SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE IS IF
YOU COULD PLEASE JUST MAYBE
SPECIFY HOW THIS CHANGES.
THE CURRENCY.
PROCESS.
AND I WOULD LIKE SOME SPECIFICS
IN MAYBE SPECIFICALLY IF YOU
COULD EXPLAIN HOW IT CHANGES
PUBLIC RESOURCE CODE. TWO ONE
ONE SIX EIGHT POINT SIX POINT.
EIGHT OUR I I REALLY WANT TO GET
SOME SPECIFICS ON HOW THIS
REALLY WORKS TAKING NOTES YES
OKAY SO.
THAT WILL BE MY QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR --
MISTER SPEAKER.
I'D LIKE TO ANSWER MY CLOSE.
TAKE HIS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
NOW REMEMBER.
ON MY OWN TIME I DOUBT I POINT
OUT THAT THAT QUESTION WHEN YOU
ANSWER THAT QUESTION IS REMEMBER
HE IS A WARRIORS FAN
[inaudible]
AND LOOK NO BIAS OKAY.
NO BIAS AT ALL WHICH GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MR PEROT ANON WARRIORS FAN
[inaudible]
GO CELTICS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AYE VOTE
FOR ALL SECRET EXEMPTIONS
BECAUSE I THINK ALL PROJECTS TO
GET SECRETS ENGINES.
MY ISSUE IS THAT WE TOOK UP A
BILL YESTERDAY ON KIDDIES THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECTS MY DISTRICT
THAT WENT TO THE SECRET PROCESS.
AND THEN SOME MONKEY POLITICAL
BUSINESS ADDED TWO MORE LAYERS
ONTO IT SO WHEN PROJECTS
LEGITIMATELY GO TO A PROJECT.
WE SHOULD RESPECT THAT AND
APPROVE IT AND I VOTED FOR THE
LAST ONE FOR THE FOOTBALL
STADIUM AND I WILL VOTE THIS --
ONE BUT WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK
AT THIS AND NOT PICK AND CHOOSE
JUST BECAUSE WE BUILD A
BASKETBALL ARENA FOOTBALL
STADIUM --
DID YOU SEEK EXEMPTION BUT I
WOULD ENCOURAGE --
DE OWNERSHIP TO LOOK AT THE
SACRAMENTO KINGS OUR EXAMPLE.
AND SAVE ABOUT TWENTY TO FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN CONSTRUCTION
COSTS AND INVEST IN A FEW NEW
PLAYERS SO THAT.
I ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WELL SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM IS KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU --
SO JUST IN CLOSING I WANT TO SAY
THAT.
JUST LIKE A JOHN WOODEN PLAYBOOK
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE
FUNDAMENTALS.
HOW DO YOU WIN A GAME?
YOU LEARN TO TIE YOUR SHOES.
HAVE YOU HELP A COMMUNITY.
YOU BRING DIGNITY AND JOBS.
AND THAT IS WHAT AB NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN WILL DO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
DO.
DAVIS KAMLAGER-DOVE WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE NO.
ZERO THOUGH SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE. TO
TAKE UP.
S..
NINE ONE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ONE THIS IS THE
CONFERENCE REPORT.
S. B. NANO ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE ALL NIGHT NO ONE BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES.
MR HOLDING EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
THIS EVENING TO PRESENT S. B.
NINE NO ONE ON THE FIRE.
WILDFIRE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
REPORT.
A BEFORE I BEGAN I WANTED TO
TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
THE CONFEREES FROM THIS HOUSE
WHO DID AN OUTSTANDING JOB.
IN TERMS OF NAVIGATING THROUGH
SOME VERY CHALLENGING AND VERY
COMPLICATED.
SUBJECT MATTER.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE --
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER.
WHO HAS DONE A FANTASTIC JOB IN
TERMS OF HIS SUPPORT AND HIS
GUIDANCE IN TERMS OF MANY
ASPECTS OF WHAT WE HAD TO
DELIBERATE OVER?
SAMBAR TO DO YOU KNOW.
YUCCA VALLEY AND HELD.
FOR EACH OF THESE MEMBERS HAS
CONTRIBUTED A GREAT DEAL OF
INSIGHT IN THEIR OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES AS IT RELATES.
TO THEIR COMMUNITIES BURNING.
AND IT WAS VERY INSTRUCTIVE IN
TERMS OF GIVING US GUIDANCE IN
TERMS OF HOW WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO FOCUS ON THE ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES THAT THEY HAD BROUGHT TO
THE FORE.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT.
WE STARTED THIS PROCESS
RECOGNIZING THAT [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA.
HAS BEEN UNDER A DROUGHT
CONDITION FOR MANY YEARS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS IMPACTED.
ON THE EFFECTS OF ARE STATE IN A
VERY DRAMATIC WAY.
THIS YEAR NEARLY A MILLION ACRES
IS BURNED.
AND NOT ONE OF THOSE FIRES
BECAUSE BY UTILITIES.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
SAW DRAMATIC IMPACT ON OUR STATE.
FROM FIRES IN THE NAPA VALLEY
COMMUNITY.
AND IN VENTURA COUNTY.
AND AS A RESULT OF THOSE FIRES
THERE'S THE POTENTIAL FOR
LIABILITY.
THAT HAS BEEN A DRIVING FORCE OF
CONVERSATION TO BEGIN THIS YEAR.
WHEN WE STARTED THIS YEAR?
WE HAD A NUMBER OF UTILITIES
ACTUALLY ALL THE UTILITIES
PRIVATE.
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES MAKE
THEIR WAY TO THE CAPITAL MANY OF
THEM TO YOUR OFFICES TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACT.
THE FIRE WAS HAVING ON THEIR
OPERATIONS ON THE POTENTIAL
THEIR BUSINESS AND THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE SOLVENT AND
CONTINUE TO OPERATE.
AND AS WE MADE OUR WAY THROUGH
HEARING A LOT OF THE KIND OF
COMPLICATED ISSUES AND THINGS
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE.
IT KIND OF BOIL DOWN TO THE
POINT WHERE THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY AND MANY EFFORTS AND
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE OUR
LEADERSHIP.
IN BOTH HOUSES IN OUR GOVERNOR
TO MAKE STATEMENTS TO TRY TO
CALM MARKETS AND TRY TO CALM
FEARS.
BUT IT BECAME VERY CLEAR THAT
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY NEEDED TO
GET ITS ARMS WRAPPED AROUND.
THIS IN A VERY [inaudible]
DRAMATIC WAY.
AND SO THIS CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
WAS ESTABLISHED BY BOTH HOUSES
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AND WE WILL COME TO YOU TONIGHT.
WITH OUR FINDINGS [inaudible]
THIS REPORT.
IS BUILT ON THE FOLLOWING GOALS.
TO ENSURE RECOVERY FOR FIRE
VICTIMS.
STABILIZE UTILITY IN THE MARKET
TO PREVENT ADVERSE REPAIR
IMPACTS DUE TO INCREASE BECAUSE
OF FINANCING.
AND POSSIBILITY OF BANKRUPTCY.
IMPROVE GRID SAFETY IMPROVE
VEGETATION AND FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT.
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE REPORT
ALSO ADDRESSES THE MERIT OF
ISSUES WITH THE CORE FOCUS ON
PREVENTION TO REDUCE WILDFIRES
IN THE ELECTRICITY.
ELECTRIC UTILITY AND REPAIR
IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH
WILDFIRES.
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
FRAMEWORK MAKES COMPREHENSIVE
CHANGES TO STRIP AND FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
VEGETATION.
VEGETATION REMOVAL
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE AND
UTILITY COMPANY INSPECTIONS.
IT'S CRITICAL TO NOTE THAT
NOTHING IN THE REPORT WILL
CHANGE THE TRIAL COURT
PROCEEDINGS WHICH CONSIDER
DAMAGES FOR WHILE FIRE VICTIMS.
BUT IT WILL ENSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE TO
COMPENSATE THOSE VICTIMS.
THIS REPORT INCORPORATES THE
SAFETY MEASURES CONTAINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JULY PROPOSAL.
EXPAND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS HARDENING
SUCH AS UNDER GROUNDING AND
INSULATION WIRES AND PULL
REPLACEMENT.
SPANS WILDFIRE PLAN REQUIREMENTS
FOR PO USE BY REQUIRING PLANS
FOR ALL WILDFIRE RISK
CIRCUMSTANCES NOT JUST THOSE FOR
CATASTROPHIC FIRES.
REQUIRES PO USED TO CONSIDER
SAME MEASURES AS REQUIRED FOR
THE IOUS.
THIS REPORT MAKES VARIOUS
CHANGES INCREASE ACTIVE
MANAGEMENT OF PRIVATE AND
FEDERAL LANDS TO REDUCE FIRE
RISK.
REQUIRES WHEN THE STATE
PURCHASES DEVELOPMENT RIGHTS TO
CONSERVE FOREST LANDS AND THOSE
LANDS ARE ACTIVELY MANAGED
INCREASING THE PACE AND SCALE OF
ACME ACRES TREATED.
SMALL LANDOWNERS WILL BE GIVEN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
REGULATORY RELIEF TO CONDUCT
FUEL TREATMENT.
ON THEIR LANDS.
SPECIFIED FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS ON FEDERAL LAND.
WHERE THE STATE PROVIDES FUNDING
OR STAFF USING THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY WHICH ONLY?
WE'LL ONLY BE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE NEPA INSTEAD OF BOTH
SEE CORPS AND NEPA.
LANDOWNERS WILL BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP LIFETIME
TIMBER HARVEST PERMITS TO MANAGE
THEIR LAND. FOR THE LONG TERM.
THIRTY SECONDS HOLDEN REALLY
[inaudible]
WELL.
JUST IN CASE WE'RE HAVING
TROUBLE WITH THE TIME MISTER
HOLDEN WILL GIVE YOU A MINUTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
EVEN BETTER.
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THAT
THERE'S A GROUP THERE IS A
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTOOD.
THAT THERE IS A GOING FORWARD.
AS WELL IS A RECOGNITION THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN FIRES NEEDED TO
BE ADDRESSED.
THIS REPORT ALSO RECOGNIZES
MENDIS MUCH ACETO BECAUSE OF THE
FLOODS NEEDED TO BE INCLUDED IN
THIS CALCULATION.
IT GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THERE TO BE A CAP.
ON THE ON THE UTILITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CPUC TO
REVIEW.
AND THEN PROVIDE A STRESS TEST
BUT THE IDEA IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DRILL DOWN AND AND
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A ADEQUATE
AMOUNT.
OF STAKEHOLDER INVESTMENT AND
THEN THAT WHICH WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR RATEPAYERS.
TO RESPOND TO WOULD BE COVERED
UNDER STE UNDER --
FINANCING PLAN.
GOING FORWARD WE'RE CHANGING THE
RULES TO ALLOW FOR THE CPUC TO
NOT PROVIDE FOR STRESS TESTS BUT
ALLOW FOR THEIR BE OPPORTUNITY.
TO GO FORWARD AND TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT.
WILL ALLOW FOR THE CPUC CREATING
DIFFERENT STANDARDS ALLOWING A
LITTLE BIT OF FLEXIBILITY FOR
UTILITIES TO BE EVALUATED UNDER.
THERE'S ALSO A MUTUAL AID THAT
IS INCLUDED IN THIS.
LOW INCOME AND VERY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS WOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM
THIS.
FROM THE A TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
SEVENTEEN AND GOING FOR PROPOSAL.
THIS WAS IT HAS IT BUILT INTO IT
WORKER PROTECTION.
AND IT ALSO PROVIDES FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR BLUE RIBBON
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENTED. TO
REVIEW ADDITIONAL ISSUES THAT
THIS COMMITTEE WAS NOT ABLE TO
FULLY VET.
THERE MAY BE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
REMARKS.
AS WE PROCEED BUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLD IT.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO WORK RIGHT
TO LEFT WILL GO WITH MISTER
MAYES AND I'M GOING TO WORK MY
WAY ACROSS THE ROOM [inaudible]
MISTER MAYES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
MEMBERS I KNOW AT THIS LATE HOUR
THE LAST THING WE WANT TO HEAR
IS -- MORE
SPEECHES BUT I DO THINK THAT FOR
THIS.
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THERE IS NO
ISSUE.
THAT WAS AS INTENSE AS THIS
I WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
CHAIRMAN OF HAVE YOU ANY FOR ALL
OF HIS WORK ON THIS ALSO THE
CHAIRMAN OR THE CO CHAIR.
OF THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
THERE ARE MANY OF US HERE IN
THIS CHAMBER WHO WORKED FOR
MONTHS.
ON THIS THEIR WAS INFORMAL
WORKING GROUP [inaudible]
THAT MATT.
WEEK AFTER WEEK AFTER WEEK
STARTING THIS THERE'S A MORE
FORMAL GROUP THAT MET.
WEEK AFTER WEEK AFTER WEEK
STUDYING THIS AND I WAS ON BOTH
OF THOSE WORKING GROUPS AND ALSO
ENDED UP SERVING.
ON THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AS
WELL.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS
ISSUE.
IS EXCEPTIONALLY COMPLEX.
BEFORE YOU THIS EVENING.
THERE IS A CONFERENCE REPORT AND
I DID NOT VOTE FOR THIS
CONFERENCE REPORT ON TUESDAY
EVENING BECAUSE THE LAST MINUTE.
LANGUAGE BEFORE US I WASN'T
COMFORTABLE AND I HADN'T SEEN IT
YET.
BUT I RISE AT THIS EVENING TO
TELL YOU THAT I SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE REPORT.
IT IS NOT PERFECT.
IF YOU ARE A PROGRESSIVE
[inaudible]
THERE ARE.
ISSUES INSIDE OF THIS.
REPORT THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
WANT TO VOTE ON IF YOU'RE A
CONSERVATIVE.
THERE ARE THINGS HERE THAT YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO WANT. TO VOTE
ON EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US CAN
FIND PROBLEMS IN THIS REPORT AND
YOU CAN FIND AN EXCUSE. TO NOT
VOTE ON IT.
BUT IF YOU BELIEVE.
IN GOVERNING IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
WHAT WE THAT OUR RESPONSIBILITY
HERE IS THE WORK TO TRY TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS.
THEN I THINK WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US THIS EVENING.
IS A MEASURE THAT WE CAN ALL.
SUPPORT IT IS NOT PERFECT.
BUT IT IS GOOD.
I DO BELIEVE IT NEEDS SOME
PIXIES.
AND WHEN WE COME BACK NEXT YEAR
FOR THOSE OF US.
THAT WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
COME BACK WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
[inaudible] TO SOLVE.
THOSE FEW FIXES.
BUT BEFORE US THIS EVENING.
IT IS A GOOD MEASURE.
AND IT IS WORTHY OF YOUR YES
VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
THING MISMANAGED DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS --
THIS ISSUE IS DEEPLY PERSONAL TO
ME.
THE TUBS FIRE.
RAVITCH MY DISTRICT. FORTY FOUR
PEOPLE DIED.
OF FIVE THOUSAND HOMES DESTROYED.
HUNDREDS OF BUSINESSES DESTROYED.
I'VE LIVED THIS EVERYDAY SINCE
OCTOBER NINTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND I WILL LIVE THIS
FOR THE YEARS TO COME AS WE
STRUGGLE TO REBUILD THE FABRIC
OF OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT BILL.
BUT IT IS THE BEST WE CAN DO
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
I HAVE FOCUSED ON FROM DAY.
ONE THE VICTIMS.
THOSE WHO DIED.
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR HOMES AND
NEED TO REBUILD.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL STRIKES
THE BALANCE TO HELP US TO MOVE
FORWARD.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE FUTURE
VICTIMS AND THAT'S WHY HAVE
FOCUS SO MUCH ON THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
I THINK MOST OF THE CONVERSATION
HERE TONIGHT.
IS ABOUT WHETHER THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE STRUCK THE RIGHT
BALANCE AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE.
BUT I DO LINE IN THE SAND WHEN I
SAID WE NEEDED TO PUT PEOPLE
FIRST.
AND BY THAT I MEAN VICTIMS.
AND THOSE WHO MIGHT BECOME
VICTIMS IN THE FUTURE.
BUT PREVENTION HAD TO BE A PART
OF THE OVERALL SOLUTION. TO ME
THAT MEANS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
AND RESOURCES FOR OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THIS
PACKAGE DEDICATES ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS.
EACH YEAR THAT MEANS A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EFFECTIVE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
FIRE PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PER FRIES PRESCRIBE FUEL AND
FUEL REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
THERE IS ALSO FUNDING TO ALLOW
FIREFIGHTERS TO PRE POSITION IN
ORDER TO BETTER RESPOND TO FIRE.
AND DIRECTION FIRE SIZE AND
DIRECTION.
THIS REPRESENTS WOULD THE
LARGEST COMMITMENTS TO FIRE
PREVENTION IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY AND IN MY OPINION IT'S
LONG OVERDUE.
ADDITIONALLY THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT POLICIES IN THIS BILL
WILL ENCOURAGE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO BETTER PLAN FOR WILDFIRE AND
MAKE IT EASIER FOR LANDOWNERS TO
CONDUCT FUEL REDUCTION ON THEIR
OWN LAND.
SPECIALLY LA SMALL SMALL
LANDOWNERS.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE PACKAGE
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN MAKING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AFFORDABLE.
AND PROTECTING OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES BUT MAKE MAKE NO
MISTAKE.
AS A PROUD ENVIRONMENTALISTS I
WILL WORK CLOSELY.
I WON'T TOLERATE ABUSES.
IN CLOSING WE CAN'T STOP THE
SEVERITY THESE WILDFIRES WITHOUT
DEALING WITH THE CAUSES.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE.
CAN REDUCE THE SEVERITY OF THE
FIRES.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT ONE MAJOR
FIRE OFFSETS ALMOST EVERYTHING
THE STATE DOES.
WHEN WE GO TO TO TRY TO REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS ON A YEARLY
BASIS?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
COLLEAGUES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY COULD ACT WOULD MISS LEVINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT.
OF THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE BUT
I MUST RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
WELL THERE ARE IMPAIR MANY
COMMENDABLE PROVISIONS REGARDING
FIRE PREVENTION.
INCLUDING INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS IN BETTER
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
THIS DID NOT NEED TO BE JOINED
TO THIS BAIL OUT.
IT STILL LEAVES UTILITY RATE
PAYERS.
ON THE HOOK.
ON THE HOOK FOR HUGE COSTS DUE
LARGELY. TO UTILITY NEGLIGENCE
MEMBERS THE WORD NEGLIGENCE.
DOESN'T EVEN APPEAR IN THE BILL
WHICH IS INDICATIVE OF HOW
LIMITED IS IT IS [inaudible]
IN TERMS A RATE PAIR PROTECTIONS.
IN THE MOST CRITICAL SECTION OF
THE BILL ON COVERING THE COST OF
WILD FIRE DAMAGES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT STATES.
THAT THE P. YOU SEE SHALL
CONSIDER THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS FINANCIAL STATUS.
IN DETERMINE THE AMOUNT A
CORPORATION CAN PAY.
WITHOUT HARMING RATEPAYERS ARE
MATERIALLY IMPACT IN ITS ABILITY
TO PROVIDE.
ADEQUATE AND SAFE SERVICE.
THIS STRESS TEST [inaudible]
PROCESS WILL ULTIMATELY
DETERMINE HOW MUCH A UTILITY.
AND ITS SHAREHOLDERS WILL PAY
FOR THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRE DAMAGES [inaudible]
SO.
THIS PUTS A CAP THAT COULD WELL
PROVE TO BE A DISPROPORTIONATELY
LOW.
ONE THAT ALLOWS IN THE POUND
SIGN MAJOR COSTS TO RATEPAYERS
TIED. TO UTILITY NEGLIGENCE SO
AGAIN IT'S A CAP [inaudible] FOR
SHAREHOLDERS.
BUT NOT FOR RATEPAYERS.
LET'S REMEMBER THAT CAO BUYER
HAS FOUND THAT PJ ANY VIOLATED
LAWS REQUIRING PROPER
MAINTENANCE IN ELEVEN INSTANCES.
AND THAT COULD ADD TO THE COST
OF LAW LAWSUIT SETTLEMENTS
SUMMER THOSE.
AFTER THE SAN BRUNO DISASTER
THAT DISASTER.
WHERE PIPELINE APPEAR GINNY
PIPELINE BLEW UP A NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE PEOPLE IN THE SANCTITY OF
THEIR OWN HOME [inaudible]
WERE KILLED.
THAT AMOUNTED TO MORE THAN A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS IN LAWSUITS
SETTLEMENTS.
WHILE THOSE SETTLEMENT PAYMENTS
WILL NOT BE CONSIDERED PER P.
GINNY COST RECOVERY FROM
RATEPAYERS.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY PREVENTS THE STRESS
TEST.
FROM BEING APPLIED TO PGM EASE
FINANCIAL STANDING AFTER.
ASSESSMENT PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN
APPLIED.
AND HAVE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED ITS
FINANCIAL STATUS.%
I SUCH IN ADDITION TO PAINT
REPEATING EASE NEGLIGENCE
DIRECTLY.
RATEPAYERS COULD BE ON THE HOOK.
FOR ADDITIONAL COSTS RELATED TO
LAWSUITS.
SO ONCE THE IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL
THREAT HAS PASSED.
SHAREHOLDERS AND WALL STREET
UNDERWRITERS CAN RETURN TO THEIR
SAFE DEPENDABLE PROFITS WHY RATE
PIERCE WILL KEEP WRITING TRACKS.
TO PAY FOR DAMAGE THEY DID NOT
BECAUSE MEMBERS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THE COST OF OUR
CHANGING CLIMATE WILL BE A
SHARED.
ONE WE WILL HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO INCREASE OUR INVESTMENT IN
FIRE FIGHTING AND PREVENTION
EFFORTS.
IT WE WILL SURELY HAVE COSTS
FROM FIRES.
YET TO COME.
COST WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
[inaudible]
THE COSTS OF NEGLIGENCE SHOULD
NOT FALL PRIMARILY ON RATEPAYERS.
THE UTILITY AND ITS SHAREHOLDERS
NEED TO SHARE RISK.
NOT BE CAPPED BECAUSE OF A
STRESS TEST THEY CAN'T SOCIALIZE.
THE COST OF DISASTER.
WHILE PRIVATIZING ALL PROFITS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL DOES NOT
RESOLVE THAT IMBALANCE.
REMEMBER EVEN WHEN CONGRESS
BAILED OUT THE AUTOMAKERS.
THE AUTOMAKERS PAID THEM BACK.
THEREFORE DESPITE.
THE PROACTIVE FIRE SUPPRESSION
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL.
I ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
ON S. B. [inaudible]
NINE OH ONE MISTER DALLI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IN AYE RISE.
IS SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE A ONE
AND I WANT TO SHARE.
WITH MANY OF YOU --
WE'RE HAVING BEEN HERE SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AS YOU KNOW
I'VE TALKED ABOUT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
AND THE REST FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WILDFIRES FROM THE DAY I CAME
HERE.
AND MAYBE I SPOKE AGAINST BILLS
THAT WE WERE USING [inaudible]
AND CARBON.
AS FOR TRANSPORTATION AS WHERE
WE SPEND MOST OF OUR RESOURCES
BECAUSE I THOUGHT.
WE SHOULD PUT MORE THOSE
RESOURCES TOWARDS.
EWING VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE CAME TO THE POINT LAST YEAR
WHERE WE SAW CATASTROPHIC
[inaudible]
WILD BUYER.
OVER FIVE THOUSAND HOMES BURNED
DOWN THAT'S WHY WE'RE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION TONIGHT.
BECAUSE THOSE FIRES AND NOT A
CASES WORK BECAUSE BY UTILITIES.
BUT I WILL SHARE THIS WITH YOU.
THAT WHAT ONE OUT A TEN FIRES IS
STARTED BY UTILITIES.
THE OTHER NINE ARE STARTED BY.
AUTOMOBILES LIGHTNING MANY OTHER
THINGS.
I HAVEN'T CHRISTIAN USE A PROP
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THIS IS CAL FIRES.
FIRE THREAT MAP.
IF YOU'RE IN RED.
YOU'RE GONNA BURN.
I DON'T KNOW NGUYEN BUT YOU'RE
GONNA BURN.
I SEE A LOT OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE LIVING DOWN HERE.
MAYBE A MILLION FROM HERE UP.
BUT THAT YOU'RE WATERSHED.
THAT YOU'RE WILDLIFE.
THAT YOUR FARMS IN THE WHITE IN
THE VALLEY THERE.
WE BURNED ONE POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES JUST THIS YEAR. SEVEN
PEOPLE DIED.
IN REDDING CALIFORNIA.
WHEN A FIRE TORNADO?
FIRST TORNADO CALIFORNIA TO KILL
SOMEBODY WAS A FIRE TORNADO
JEREMY STOKES LOST HIS LIFE.
BITING THE SPIRES.
NOW WE KNOW ONE THING.
FIRE CANNOT BURN WITHOUT FUEL.
YOU TAKE YOU AWAY FROM THE FIRE.
FIRE KIPPER.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A WIN
[inaudible]
OXYGEN.
IF IF IGNITION AND YOU HAVE TO
HAVE FUEL.
I'VE BEEN ASKING SIX YEARS TO
REDUCE.
VEGETATION AND FUEL.
YOU'RE GONNA BURN IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING FAST.
AND I WAS WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE MEMBERS ON MY COMMITTEE.
ON THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE
HAVE FINALLY.
CAME TO A POINT.
WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY DO
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
[inaudible]
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WILL
REDUCE THE RISK.
EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE A HOMEOWNER.
IT'S GONNA DRIVE YOUR CHURCH
RATES DOWN.
IF YOU DRINK WATER.
IT'S CAN PROVIDE MORE WATER WE
DO VEGETATION NAMES IN THE FORCE.
WE'D TO EXPAND ON TOOLS LIKE
GRAZING IN THE 300-010-0023
THOUSAND FOOT AREA.
ON THE COAST YOU WHO LIVE ON THE
COAST.
WHERE THERE'S BRUSH?
YOU NEED RESOURCES TO DO.
MASTICATION IT'S A MACHINE THAT
BRUSHES IT DOWN BECAUSE YOU
NEEDED TO STAY ALIVE.
SO THAT WHEN IT RAINS IT DOESN'T
WASH IN THE OCEAN THAT'S WHERE
THIS MONEY IS GOING TO BE SPENT.
I WON A CIRCLE BACK TO THE
UTILITIES AND BUT MY PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT.
IT'S NOT PERFECT BILL.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS A
PERFECT BILL.
THE WRANGLINGS THAT WENT BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN THE HOUSES WAS
DIFFICULT.
BUT I WILL SHARE WITH THIS WITH
YOU. TO DO NOTHING. TO DO
NOTHING.
WOULD BE ON US.
WE'VE DONE SOMETHING.
IT'S NOT PERFECT.
BUT I THINK IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I AM PROUD TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT I CAN VOTE.
FOR S. B. NINE A ONE BECAUSE I
CAN GO BACK TO MY CONSTITUENTS
AND ALL OF YOU CAN DO THE SAME
THING.
WE NEED TO TURN CALIFORNIA FROM
RED.
BACK TO GOLD GOLDEN STATE LIKE
IT IS AND WERE WE HAD A HUNDRED
YEARS.
A FIRE SUPPRESSION IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA GET OUT OF
THIS SOON.
IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME TIME BUT
THIS IS A STEP AND I JUDGE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE PUT RESOURCES. TO
REDUCING CARBON TO IMPROVING
WILDLIFE AND IMPROVING.
THE AREAS WHERE FIREFIGHTERS CAN
GET AND SAFELY.
JERRY STOKES Y..
IS HOME WITH THREE CHILDREN.
AND HERE HE'S NOT GOING TO BE
THERE EVER AGAIN.
THE FORTY FOUR PEOPLE IN THE
TUBS FIRE THAT LOST THEIR LIVES
THE DOCTOR WOULD SIFT THROUGH
THE ASHES TO DIGNIFY THEM. TO
THEIR GENERAL.
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IS A TOUGH VOTE I GET
THAT.
BUT YOU CAN GO HOME MANY IN YOU
WHO ARE THOSE RED AREAS WHICH IS
MOST OF THIS STATE.
IN START DOING THE RIGHT THING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI MEMBERS
WILL BE MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION.
FROM WE ARE LEFT TO RIGHT MISS
WALDRON.
THANK YOU --
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK ON THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEES THE
WORKING GROUPS AND EL ALL IT'S
BEEN GOING ON I'M AS A MEMBER
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WANTED
TO BE SURE TO RISE TO BECAUSE
THIS IS A STATE.
WIDE APPROACH WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
IT AS A STATEWIDE APPROACH THAT
MAP CLEARLY SHOWS.
THAT THIS WHOLE STATE IS AT HIGH
RISK --
HAVING JUST GONE THROUGH THE
LILAC FIRE.
IN MY DISTRICT LAST FALL AND
BEING IN A ROOM.
IN FALLBROOK CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
BROUGHT IN ALMOST A THOUSAND
RESIDENTS WHO HAD BEEN EVACUATED
FROM THIS ONE PARTICULAR AREA
THAT HAD COMPLETELY BURNED.
THROUGH A WHOLE NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHERE SENIOR CITIZENS LIVE?
PEOPLE IN THEIR UPPER SEVENTIES
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES.
AND REALIZING THAT OF THAT GROUP
HUNDREDS OF THEM WOULD NOT HAVE
A HOME TO GO BACK TO BUT THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WHO.
AT THAT TIME WOULD HAVE A HOME
AND WHO WOULDN'T
AND IT WAS SO DEVASTATING TO BE
THERE IN THAT AND THE WONDERING
OF WHAT WAS GOING ON YOU KNOW
LOTS OF CONCERN.
THE FIRE SPREAD FIFTEEN HUNDRED
ACRES IN LESS THAN AN HOUR
BECAUSE ONE THE SAN AND THE
WINDS BLOW IN MY AREA THERE'S NO
STOPPING IT.
AND WITH THE VEGETATION AND AND
YOU KNOW WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO
GET AHEAD OF THESE THINGS AND
WITH FIRE BREAK SOME PLANNING.
WHERE YOU KNOW LOOKING AT THAT
AGAIN WE'RE MOVING INTO FIRE
SEASON WHEN I GO HOME AND I'M
DREADING WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
BRING WHEN THE SANTA ANA WINDS
START TO BLOW --
ARE UTILITY COMPANY SAMPRAS THE
GENIE HAS DONE A AND CREDIBLE
JOB OF KEEPING AHEAD OF IT.
THEY'VE --
YOU KNOW WE'VE ALL LEARNED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FROM THE BIG
BLAZES THE WHICH CREWS IN THE
CREEK FIRE THE WAY HE'D OF FIRE
IN THE COCOS I COULD GO ON AND
ON BECAUSE EVERY FOUR YEARS WE
SEEM TO HAVE ANOTHER.
BIG FIRE --
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LET THE
SESSION GO AND NOT START TO TAKE
THIS.
AND AND MOVE HEAD WITH THAT WE
NEED TO START IT'S A GOOD START --
WE CAN AFFORD TO GO THROUGH
OTHER FIRE SEASONS IN YEARS OF
NOT TAKING CARE THIS VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
AND SOME OF THE OTHER DEALS WITH
THE UTILITIES ORIGIN I'VE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON
[inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I I'M I WAS NOT A AND
ONE OF WAS A PRIVILEGE ERA THAT.
AND THE PUNISHMENT TO BE ON THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE --
BUT I WATCHED MOST OF THEM AND I
AND I SERVE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND I AM.
SOMEBODY HAS BEEN VERY
INTERESTED AND INVOLVED IN THIS
TOPIC AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AND AS PEOPLE SAID IT IS NOT A
PERFECT BILL AND I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING THAT WE EVER DO IN THIS
BUILDING IS PERFECT NOR CAN
ANYONE ASK US. TO WORK TOWARDS
PERFECTION BECAUSE WE'RE HUMAN
BEINGS DOING THE BEST WE CAN IN
AN INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED
ENVIRONMENT.
BUT I TELL YOU SOMEBODY WHO
LIVES IN THE VALLEY.
AND WE'RE ALL VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR AIR.
AND THE PRICES BAR OF OUR ENERGY
THAT WE HAVE HAD TO HAVE OUR AIR
CONDITIONING IS RUNNING MORE
THAN I HAVE EVER HAD MY PUP MY
POWER BILLS HIGHER THAN IT'S
EVER BEEN BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE OUR WINDOWS OPEN.
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SO SMOKEY AND
PEOPLE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
BREEZE.
BECAUSE OF THE FIRES THAT ARE
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY FROM US
BUT THE BUT THE SMOKE COMES DOWN.
AND EVERYBODY SUFFERS FROM IT --
AND THERE WAS UP A FEW MEMBERS
OF THE OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WHO
HAPPEN TO BE UP IN THE MOUNTAINS
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO --
WHEN ANOTHER FIRE BROKE OUT?
A AND WE HAD TO BE EVACUATED OUT
OF A PLACE --
AND I TALK WITH SOME OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER THAT TIME
AND SAID WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW LETTING PEOPLE KNOW
WHEN THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
AN OF CHP OFFICER SAID WE'VE
LEARNED THAT SOMETIMES THEY MOVE
SO FAST THERE'S NO TIME.
THERE'S JUST NO TIME.
AND AND JUST ONE OTHER ISSUE WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT MUCH IS
WILDLIFE.
AS WE WERE BEING EVACUATED OUT
AND AS WE WERE GOING DOWN DARK
ROADS.
ALL YOU COULD SEE ON THE SIDES
OF THE ROAD WERE EYES OF ANIMALS.
HUNDREDS OF ANIMALS WHO ARE
RUNNING FROM THE FIRES.
TRYING TO FIND SOMEPLACE SAFE
AND AND THERE ISN'T ANY PLACE
SAFE.
SO FOR THOSE ANIMAL LOVERS THINK
ABOUT THAT.
AND THEN ALSO SAY IF YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT RATES GOING UP.
IF WE DO NOTHING.
RATES ARE ARE ARE GONNA GO UP.
AND THEN I'LL TALK BRIEFLY JUST
AS A SOCIAL WORKER.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO AS A GOVERNMENT WHAT OUR
CHARGE IS?
IT'S I HOPE WE HAVE PEOPLE TRUST
IN THEIR GOVERNMENT.
AND TRUST THAT WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE THAT
WE'RE DOING THE VERY BEST WE CAN.
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
LEVEL OF ANXIETY THAT PEOPLE
HAVE WHO LIVE IN FIRE DISTRICTS
WHO DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO GO TO BE SAFE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE A HOME TO GO TO WHO
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SCHOOLS
GOING TO GO ON IN THE MORNING.
WHO WHERE WHOLE NEIGHBORHOODS OF
LOW INCOME FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
WIPED OUT AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE
INSURANCE?
THAT LEVEL OF ANXIETY.
IT WE CAN'T JUST WISH IT AWAY.
IT TAKES ACTION IT TAKES PEOPLE
SAYING WE'RE PUTTING PLANS IN
PLACE WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL THE
DATA WE CAN IN THIS IS THE BEST
THAT WE CAME UP WITH IN THIS
AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND WE'RE GOING TO THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING ON AND THAT WE'RE
NOT WALKING AWAY FROM IT THEY
WERE TO CONTINUE COME BACK IN
THE FALL WE'RE GONNA WORK ON
THIS WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT EVEN
BETTER WHERE TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THIS.
BUT HERE ON THIS LAST DAY OF
SESSION THIS IS THE BEST WORK
THAT WE'VE COME UP WITH.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A HOPE WOULD
BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN RATES.
DEEPER UTILITIES IN BUSINESS TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR FOREST.
AND TO GIVE [inaudible]
CALIFORNIANS SOME PEACE OF MIND
THAT THERE LEGISLATORS ARE DOING
THE BEST THAT THEY CAN. TO PASS
LAWS [inaudible]
PROTECT THEM.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
MISTER STONE.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AND FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN.
FROM PASADENA BUT THIS TOGETHER
AND MINORITY LEADER WHO REALLY
WORKED HARD ON THIS DEAL IN THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
SPENT SO MUCH TIME ON THIS.
THE DILEMMA THAT I FIND IS THAT
WE'VE CONFLATED TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS AND ONE IS.
PROTECTING P. GENIES LIABILITY
WHICH IS REALLY BACK AND THEN
THIS STARTED OUT OF A PANIC.
ABOUT PROTECTING P. JEANNIE.
ALL ON THE BACK AND WITH REALLY
NO TALK ABOUT THE FRONT END
WHICH IS EXACTLY THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
THE HARDENING OF THE SYSTEMS ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
DONE TO PREVENT FIRES FROM
GETTING WORSE ONCE THEY START
BECAUSE FIRES WILL START.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO SEE THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT'S BEING PUT IN
HERE. TO GO CLEAN UP SOME OF
THESE PROPERTIES BECAUSE THERE
HASN'T BEEN A LOT OF MONEY
THAT'S DONE THAT.
I'M A LITTLE WORRIED ABOUT SOME
OF THE RELAXATION OF THE RULES.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MARKETABLE TREES ON
THEIR PROPERTY ARE GOING TO BE
HAPPY WITH THAT RELAXATION.
AND THEY'RE GONNA CUT.
BUT THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
GOING TO DUE THE FIRE MANAGEMENT
THAT WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT
THAT WE'RE EXPECTING HERE.
IF WE PUT USE YOUR OF MONEY UP
FRONT.
THEN WE CAN SAY THIS IS WHAT WE
EXPECT YOU TO DO WITH THAT MONEY
SO I THINK THAT'S MONEY GOING TO
BE VERY WELL SPENT.
THERE'S ALSO SOME MONEY FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS WE ASK THE FIRE
CHIEF WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING
FOR THE EXPIRED SEASON THEY SAID.
MONEY FOR EQUIPMENT FOR PRE
POSITIONING FOR USING THE
PREDICTIVE TOOL SO THAT WE KNOW
WHERE THE FIRES ARE GOING TO BE
STARTING TO HAPPEN.
HOW WE CAN KNOCK THEM DOWN
BEFORE IT HAPPENS [inaudible]
SO.
THAT PIECE OF IT.
IS ACTUALLY A LOT BETTER THAN I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE AND I HAVE
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
BIEBER WHO REALLY UNDERSTANDS
HE'S ONE OF THE FEW FOLKS HERE
WHO'S DONE LAND USE.
AND DONE FORESTRY AND
UNDERSTANDS THE PATTERNS IN THE
PRACTICES IN THOSE INDUSTRIES
AND WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF WE
JUST LOOSEN UP REGULATIONS OR IF
WE FIND A WAY TO GET
[inaudible]
PROPERTY OWNERS DO THE WORK THE
WAY WE EXPECT THEM TO DO.
BUT WE'VE ALSO CONFLATED THIS
WITH THE LIABILITY FEES AND AND
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IN VERSE
AND LIABILITY IN ALL THAT THAT
HAS BEEN.
A MECHANISM. TO GET MONEY INTO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED TO BE
REBUILT AFTER THE FIRE THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THAT IS.
AND INCOME INVERSE CONDEMNATION
THE THE THESE RULES A KATYUSHA
RULES THAT APPLY TO PGD BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S SORT OF IN BETWEEN A
PUBLIC ENTITY IN THE PRESIDENT.
HE GETS THE BENEFIT OF BEING
THERE [inaudible]
IT MONEY.
GUARANTEED RAIDER TURNED BUT THE
THE DOWNSIDE TO THAT. TO THEM IS
HAVING TO TAKE ON ALL THIS
RESPONSIBILITY AND STUPIDLY FUN
ON THE SHAREHOLDERS.
THEY'RE NOW THEY'VE MADE
DECISIONS.
THAT HAVE PUT THAT EQUITY THAT
SHAREHOLDER EQUITY POTENTIALLY
AT RISK.
AND THOUGH NOW THE
CONFLAGRATIONS OF COST SO MUCH
THAT THEY'RE VERY VERY WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT THAT REPRESENTS I
GUESS WALL STREET IS.
AND BONDING AGENCIES AND ALL
THAT ARE VERY WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY TO SURVIVE THROUGH
THIS WE HAVEN'T REALLY TESTED
[inaudible]
AND DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED AND I DO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE TRYING TO
HELP OUT ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
VIABLE UTILITY AFTER ALL OF THIS.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL THAT
IF WE DON'T DO THIS RIGHT.
THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
TELLING OUR CONSTITUENTS OF THE
END OF THE DAY SORRY YOU GOT
BURNED OUT BUT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY FOR YOU TO REBUILD.
THAT'S JUST WHAT WE DEAD.
AND IF WE ARE SITTING HERE IN
FIVE SIX YEARS SEVEN YEARS FOR
FOR OTHERS.
AND UTILITIES ARE STILL FLASH
AND HAPPY.
AND THE RATEPAYERS ARE STILL
CONTINUING TO PAY THAT MONEY.
THEY'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT US
AND SAYING WHAT DID YOU DO.
SO I'M VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE BACK END AND THE FOCUS OF
THE BACKEND.
AND EVEN THOUGH THEIR PROVISIONS
IN HERE TO GET PGP HARD TO DO
THE WORK UP FRONT.
AND I LOVE THEIR ADS TALK THAT
WE'RE GONNA DO THIS WE'RE GONNA
DO THAT.
AND I KEEP ASKING MYSELF WHERE
WERE YOU TEN YEARS AGO.
AT DOING THE HARDENING IT DOING
THE PREDICTIVE TOOLS THAT
HELPING US MAKE SURE THAT THESE
FIRES DIDN'T GET OUT OF HAND TO
BEGIN WITH BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S
BEEN IRRESPONSIBLE ES DE JEANNIE
BECAUSE THEY'RE FIRED AND SAN
DIEGO.
THEY HAD TO DEAL WITH THAT
THEY'VE ACCIDENT PRETTY GOOD JOB
[inaudible]
OF SENDING UP SO WE HAD THOSE
EXAMPLES IN CALIFORNIA OF STUDY
OF WHAT TO DO FOR A UTILITY.
SO YOU'VE GOT TO VOTE ON THIS ON
YOUR OWN CONSCIENCE WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA DO.
IT'S SO COMPLICATED WITH
CONFLATED SO MANY THINGS IN HERE
THIRTY SECONDS REYES DOWN
DIFFICULT TO TO KNOW WHAT THE
RIGHT ANSWER IS BUT FOR THOSE OF
US WHO ARE GOING TO BE AROUND
FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS IF WE DO
PASS THIS.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO NGUYEN
AND AND COOP ACT IF NECESSARY
MONEY TO GET BACK TO OUR
RATEPAYERS. TO HOLD PGD ANY
OTHER UTILITY ACCOUNTABLE FOR
MAKING SURE THEY'RE DOING THEIR
PART IF WE'RE GONNA DO OUR PART
BY PUTTING THE MONEY ON THE
TABLE AND ENSURING THAT WE'RE
DOING VEGETATION AND FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT DECISION WERE WORKING
WITH A LOT OF UNKNOWNS INCLUDING
NOT EVEN KNOWING WHAT THE RATE
ISSUE IS WITH PGD BECAUSE WE
DON'T SEE THEM OR SHARE WITH US
THEIR FINANCIALS.
SO IT'S VERY HARD TO KNOW WHAT.
WHAT THE UPSIDE IS WHAT THE
DOWNSIDE IS [inaudible]
SO.
GOOD LUCK IT'S AFTER TEN THIRTY
WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF TIME AND WE
HAVE ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
DECISIONS I THINK THAT WE HAVE
FACED IN A LONG TIME.
AS MR STONE SAID WE'RE RUNNING
OUT OF TIME [inaudible]
SO WE'RE WE HAVE THREE MORE
MICROPHONES TO MORE MICROPHONES
UP AND THEN A CLOSE MISTER
VOEPEL.
HOW GOOD VAST MISTER SPEAKER?
ALRIGHT I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S THE BACK
AT WE HAVE TO DO IT TO SOME
GREAT EXTENT.
BUT THE REASON I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS THE FRONT
END.
NEXT SESSION THERE ARE SOME
POSITIVE THINGS WE CAN DO FOR
THE FUTURE ONE OF THEM IS HAVE
THE POWER COMPANIES THE FOUR
MAIN ELECTRICAL POWER COMPANIES
ESTABLISH A JOINT POWER
AUTHORITY.
SO THE TAKEN PRE FUND SOME OF
THESE CLAIMS.
WITH THAT JOINT POWER AUTHORITY
THEY CAN ALSO ADD RE INSURANCE
FOR CATASTROPHIC CLAIMS.
SO THERE PREFONTAINE THAT
ESTABLISHES THE RISK FOR WALL
STREET THAT ESTABLISHES THE RISK
LEVEL FOR THE STOCKHOLDERS IT
JUST BECOMES.
A PART OF DOING BUSINESS
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
TWO THE INSURANCE SERVICES
ORGANIZATION I SO THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT DETERMINE ALL THE FIRE
AREAS AND BASICALLY DETERMINE
LEVEL ONE THROUGH FOUR HOW MUCH
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY FOR YOUR
INSURANCE PREMIUM.
THEY'VE BEEN TRACKING THESE
FIRES SINCE.
NINETEEN FIFTY AND THE I ALSO
AREAS ARE SET UP TO PROTECT
INSURANCE COMPANIES.
WE CAN LOOK AT THAT.
IT'S SEE ABOUT REDOING THE I SO
AREAS THAT COULD SAVE A LOT OF
MONEY.
ANOTHER ONE IS FAIR PLAN
FINANCING THAT'S RUN BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S OUR
INSURANCE COMPANY BASICALLY.
I WOULD RECOMMEND THAT WE PUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR WHATEVER NUMBER
EVERYBODY COMES UP WITH.
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH THEIR RISK.
THAT WOULD LOWERED THEIR
PREMIUMS AND IT WOULD GIVE THEM
A BASS LINE THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY INSURER THESE PEOPLE
THEIR END OF RED AREAS
[inaudible]
THEN LASTLY.
SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC HAS AN
INCREDIBLE SYSTEM FOR
CONTROLLING.
THEIR GRIT.
THEY'VE OF STAB US CAMERAS
INFRARED ANOTHER TECHNOLOGIES TO
DETECT FIRES THROUGHOUT THE GRID.
THAT ALLOWS ANY SECTION OF THE
GRID TO BE POWERED DOWN. FOR
FIRE LIGHTENING ANOTHER THREATS
ASUS ESTATE.
HAD THAT SYSTEM UP AND RUNNING
RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE A OF WEATHER
CENTER.
AND THE LAST TOUR THREE FIRES
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE.
TO PAY HIM NAYLA SO THE
FIREFIGHTERS CAN GO IN THERE AND
SAFELY PUT OUT THE FIRES AND IF
THERE'S LIGHTNING HER BIG STORMS.
THEY CAN SHUT DOWN THEIR POWER
PART OF THE GRID WALLAH YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY.
POWER DRIVEN FIRES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ENGLISH VOEPEL MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
AS A MEMBER OF THE WILDFIRE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE I CAN TELL
YOU THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT.
COMMITTEES I'VE HAD TO WORK ON
THERE ARE SO MANY CRITICAL
ISSUES THE FIRST WHICH HAS BEEN
MENTIONED IS. TO MAKE OUR
VICTIMS HOLE.
THAT WAS NUMBER ONE FOR
EVERYBODY WHO'S INVOLVED IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
CONTINUING OUR PATH TOWARDS A
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE.
AND AS MENTIONED EARLIER
REDUCING THE FUEL LOAD.
AND ALSO PROTECTING OUR
RATEPAYERS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP OF OUR CHAIR.
SOMEONE MEMBER HOLDEN.
AND THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT THIS WAS NOT
GOING TO BE IN THE EASY SOLUTION.
I'M VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WAS DONE.
THE DETAILS THAT WE LEARNED THAT
WOULD WE HAVE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THIS PLAN.
AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID THERE WERE
THINGS ARE ADDED AND SUBTRACTED.
EVERYTHING WAS DONE ALWAYS
KEEPING IN MIND WE HAVE TO COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION.
IT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID THAT THIS
IS NOT A PERFECT A BILL.
BUT I CAN UNEQUIVOCALLY TELL YOU.
THAT IT'S NOT A BAILOUT.
AND THAT IS THE BEST THAT WE CAN
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY WITH THE
TIME AND THE INFORMATION THAT
WAS PROVIDED TO US.
MOVING FORWARD WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE INVESTING ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
DURING THE NEXT FOUGHT GOOD THEN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. FOR
MANAGEMENT FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND GRID HARDENING.
IN ADDITION WE ENSURE THAT IN
CASE OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
THE UTILITIES WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND FAIR AND JUST COSTS WILL BE
EVALUATED.
MEMBERS THERE'S PLENTY AT STAKE
WITH OUR VOTE TODAY BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY.
WE HAVE TO LOOK TO THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND THE STATE.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN TAKING
THIS STUFF.
BUT NECESSARY VOTE. TO ALLOW THE
VICTIMS.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
MOVE FORWARD.
I DON'T I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I DON'T [inaudible]
ALL DEBATE.
AND DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED.
MISTER HOLDEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID IT ALL.
WE HAVE FOUND OURSELVES IN A
POSITION WHERE.
THE NIGHT BEFORE WHICH THE CLOCK
STARTED ON THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR
RULE.
WE STILL WEREN'T SURE EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO.
WE WERE AGONIZING OVER THE
ISSUES AND IMPACTS ON RATEPAYERS
SO JUST LIKE WHAT YOU ALL HAVE
HEARD IN WHICH YOU'RE AGONIZING
ABOUT TO DIE AS WELL.
WE WEREN'T EXACTLY CLEAR THE
DIRECTION.
WE LEFT HERE ABOUT TWO O'CLOCK
IN THE MORNING WHICH WAS
ACTUALLY [inaudible]
WEDNESDAY MORNING.
WITH AT LEAST A DIRECTION.
IT WAS A HARD POSITION TO FIND
OURSELVES IN BUT LIKE MANY OF
YOU WHO POINTED OUT TONIGHT.
IDEAS THAT YOU BELIEVE NEED TO
BE INTEGRATED INTO A PLAN GOING
FORWARD.
THERE A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION.
THAT IS BEING ESTABLISHED. FOR
THE PURPOSES OF LOOKING AT THIS.
EFFORT INTO MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE.
A GOOD PLAN.
THAT IS AN DURING.
AND THAT OTHER IDEAS THAT CAN BE
INTRODUCED WE HAVE ANOTHER
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
WHERE WE CAN COME BACK AND LOOK
AT OTHER ELEMENTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL THAT MAY NEED TO BE
LOOKED AT?
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US.
TONIGHT AS WAS POINTED OUT.
REQUIRED A LOT OF HOURS.
A LOT OF THE LIBERATION.
QUITE FRANKLY A LOT OF ANGUISH.
BUT IS WHAT THE IS NINE ONE
COMMITTEE.
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IS
PRESENTED TO YOU.
AND WE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AGO.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR THE ROBUST
DEBATE.
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF
ALL
MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
THE CLERK [inaudible]
WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FORTY FIVE KNOWS TEN
THE CONFERENCE REPORT IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS AND THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE WITH
FILE ITEM.
THREE ZERO THREE IS FILE ITEM
THREE OH THREE AB [inaudible]
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER RUBIO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DEPLOYMENT
[inaudible]
MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WRITE TODAY TO PRESENT
THE ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN EXCEPTION TO THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT
PAGA.
UNDER VERY SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES.
UNDER THE BILL.
PARKER WOULD BE WAIVED ONLY IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
AND ONLY FOR WORKERS WHO ARE
COULD OUR COVERED BY A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
THAT SPECIFICALLY PROVIDES. FOR
A GRIEVANCE AND BINDING
ARBITRATION PROCEDURE.
THIS LEGISLATION HAS IN THE PAST.
PROVIDED FOR SPECIFIC STATUTORY
WAIVERS.
DIFFERENT TO ME TO WE AGREED
UPON AND LEGALLY BINDING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS.
THESE AGREEMENTS PROTECT WORKERS
FOR ISSUES SUCH AS OVERTIME PAY.
MEALS AND REST PERIODS.
SICK LEAVE AND EVEN.
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
STATUTES.
THESE CONTRACTS WRITER RATIFIED
BY WORKERS AND MANAGEMENT
PROVIDE A FAIR BALANCE AND
PEACEFUL SOLUTION. TO ISSUES IN
THE WORD WORKPLACE.
BOTH THE STATUTORY AND
CONTRACTUAL.
MORE THAN HALF A CHECK CENTURY.
MORE THAN HALF A CENTURY STATE
AND NATIONAL LABOR LAWS HAVE
ENCOURAGED THIS PROCESS BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES CERTAINTY. TO
DISPUTE RESOLUTIONS.
THAT IS CRITICAL FOR EMPLOYERS
AND AT THE SAME TIME PROVIDE
JUSTICE FOR WORKERS WITHOUT
LENGTHY AND COSTLY LITIGATION.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR PROTECTS
THE PROCESS BY CLOSING A
LOOPHOLE IN THE PROGRAM.
THAT ALLOWS THE GRIEVANCE.
AN ARBITRATION PROCEDURE TO BE
SIDESTEPPED OR IGNORED.
I ENCOURAGE YOU IF YOU HAVEN'T
ALREADY TO TAKE A QUICK LOOK AT
THE LETTER FROM SECURITY PAVING.
LARGE REPUTABLE UNIT CONTRACTOR.
IT TOOK FIVE YEARS TO RESOLVE.
AND RESULTED IN THE FIFTY DOLLAR
AWARD TO AN EMPLOYEE WHILE
COSTING THE COMPANY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN LEGAL FEES.
THESE TYPES OF CASES WHICH COULD
EASILY BE RESOLVED THROUGH
GRIEVANCE AND ARBITRATION IF
NECESSARY ARE.
ARE APPEARING MORE AND MORE.
THERE IS NO DISPUTE THAT UNIT
CONTRACTORS THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES
SET THE STANDARD FOR WAGES JOB
SAFETY AND TRAINING IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
PASSING A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR
WILL ALLOW.
THAT TO CONTINUE WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME ALLOWING POCKET TO
CONTINUE. TO GIVE LOW WAGE AND
ON PAPER REPRESENTED WORKERS WHO
STAND ALONE FACING EMPLOYERS THE
ABILITY TO FIGHT FOR WHAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED.
TO I HAVE ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THIS BILL IS.
IS SPECIFICALLY WRITTEN TO
ADDRESS ISSUES IN THE LABOR
QUOTE COVERED BY PAGA.
IT DOES NOT IN ANY WAY RESTRICT
THE ABILITY TO TAKE LEGAL ACTION
FOR DISCRIMINATORY OR OTHER
CLAIMS OUTSIDE OF PICA.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS ON A. B. [inaudible]
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR MISERY THIS.
THE CURRENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR
ARE THE LAWSUIT THAT MISS RUBIO
MENTIONED HAPPENED IN MY
DISTRICT --
WHERE THE PLAINTIFF RECEIVED A
MERE FIFTY DOLLARS AWARD AFTER
FIVE YEAR TWO MILLION DOLLAR
LEGAL BATTLE --
AB SIXTY FOUR SIMPLY CLOSE
ASSIST LOOPHOLE BY WAVING PAGA
FOR UNION EMPLOYEES WHOSE WORK
IS COVERED.
BY A CBA. FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU S.
CATCHER DEBATE.
A CLUB IN THE ROLE MEMBERS FUNDS
ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES
EYES.
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FOURTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MEMBERS THESE ARE CONCURRENCE
ITEMS.
FILE AND THREE OH FOR AB.
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR MR
THURMAN CORKERY AT SOME REAL
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR BY
SELLING A MEMBER THURMOND TO
THAT PLAINTIFF CLEMENT.
MISTER THURMAN.
THEY HAVE A SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RISE WAS AN AB TWO THREE THREE
FOUR THIS IS A BILL TO PROMOTE
WORKPLACE SAFETY.
AND BY DOING THREE THINGS
PROVIDING THAT EMPLOYERS FAIR TO
RECORDED INJURIES CONTINUOUS
VIOLATION UNTIL DISCOVERED BY
CAL OSHA OR CORRECTED. TO THAT
IN A CONVENE AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IT THE FEDERAL OSHA
REVERSES AN IMPORTANT ELECTRONIC
REPORTING RULE OF INJURIES AND
FINALLY THAT IT PERMITS
DISCLOSURES OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION DATA. FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY ON BEHALF OF OUR
WORKERS IN A SAFE WORKPLACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS THURMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED ABOUT ICE
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
THREE OH FIVE AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE CABALLERO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN SIXTY FIVE
BY SOMEONE MEMBER CABALLERO
ACTUALLY TO AGRICULTURE.
MS CARRIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE ESTABLISHES THE
AGRICULTURAL STATE
SUSTAINABILITY COUNCIL IT
REQUIRES ACCOUNTS OF THE PLAN.
FOR REGULATORY ALIGNMENT CITY
GROW OR COMPLAINTS REDUCE COST
TO THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY AND
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
A CONCURRENT.
THANK YOU MISS CABALLERO
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU
THAT EYES FIFTY THREE KNOWS FOR
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM THREE OF SIX AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TO CORKERY.
AS A MEAL TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA
EMPLOYMENT.
IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AS THIS THIS THIS IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE THE LABOR CODE PER THE
REQUEST THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ADDED
CHAPTER NOT LANGUAGE ASK ME I
THAT'S HOW WE DO IT.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OF A CLERK
LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE THOUGH ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
AND SALAS ABOUT EYES FOUR NINE
THOSE ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THREE
OF SEVEN AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
MISTER TANG CLERK WILL READ.
SOME ELEVEN EIGHTY FOR BY SOME A
MEMBER TING AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN TRANSPORTATION MISTER
TANK.
THEY CAN A SPEAKER AB ELEVEN THE
FOUR CODIFIES THE DISTRICT BILL
CODIFIES AN AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES LIKE UBER IN
LEFT. TO GO FORWARD WITH THE A
BALLOT MEASURE IN NOVEMBER AND
ASK OUR VOTERS FOR A TWO THIRDS
VOTE. FOR A RIDE --
FOR A FEE PER EVERY RIDE IN A IS
ONLY FOR SAN FRANCISCO AND IT IS
WITH ITS EXPRESS AGREEMENT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE.
TO ALLOW US TO GO TO THE VOTERS.
FOR THANK YOU MISS TING.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN ROLL-ON BETTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILING THREE AWAIT AB SEVEN
OWN NINE MR MCCARTY CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN ON NINE BY
SOME THE MEMBER MCCARTY AND
ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION MR
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU CONCURRENCE ON A
DISTRICT BILL THEY TO THE
GOVERNANCE AND TAXING.
AUTHORITY OF OUR LOCAL REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT ASKING
RIVA THANK YOU.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
BUT IT IS OUT OF VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYES
FORTY TWO NOS TWENTY SEVEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM THREE OH NINE MAYBE
TWELVE OF FIVE CORKERY.
AT SOME LEGAL TWELVE OF FIVE BY
SOME THE MEASURED SO WHERE
ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWELVE FIVE DEMAND IN THE SENATE
TO IMPROVE THE LOS ANGELES
METROPOLITAN AUTHORITY'S ABILITY
TO CONTRACT WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES.
ENTERPRISES FOR OUR RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS LETTER TO SANTA VOEPEL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY VOTE.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL ITEMS WITHOUT AN
URGENCY WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
THROUGH FILE ITEM. THREE
FOURTEEN TO BONTA IS FILE ITEM
THREE FOURTEEN AB SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE SEVEN THIRTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER FUNDS AND OTHERS
NOT TELLING HIM BY MIDDLE
QUALITY.
WHICH BONTA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A. B.
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR WILL ALLOW THE
OAKLAND A IS A TEAM THAT'S BEEN
ROOTED IN OAKLAND FOR THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS TO BUILD A NEW
STADIUM.
THAT THEY CAN CALL HOME UP FOR
THE LONG TERM FUTURE AND
REMAINED ROOTED IN OAKLAND FOR
THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS WITH THE
PROJECTS.
CONTEMPLATED IN THIS BILL IT
WILL CREATE GOOD JOBS IT WOULD
BE FULLY PRIVATELY FINANCED IT
WILL HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
OTHER COMMUNITY BENEFITS AND
WILL FULLY COMPLY.
WITH A SEQUEL IN AN E. I. OUR
THE ONE ELEMENT THAT HOUSE IS AN
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY SOMETHING
WE'VE SEEN IN MANY BILLS IN THE
PAST AND SOMEWHAT TO THE ONE
THAT WAS ON THE FLOOR.
EARLIER TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINK RESPOND MS THURMAN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
ARISES A JOINT AUTHORED AB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR EYES YOU HEARD THIS
BILL WILL HELP THE ACE TO BUILD
A NEW STADIUM --
IN THE CITY THAT CONTEMPLATES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
RESPECTS THE PEOPLE OF OAKLAND
IN THE REGION WHO SUPPORT THE
OAKLAND MAYES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
[inaudible]
YOUR BRO.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS ONE ARISE AND
SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUE FROM OPEN
HOPE WOULD BE BUDGET DRIVEN
CUTTING.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
THOUGH [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT I SIXTY
KNOWS TO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK AND PICK UP MISS COVER
EUROS ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE TWELVE AB SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN MCCORKLE READ SOME LEGAL
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CABALLERO AND ACT LIKE
THE WATER.
WAS COMING ERA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN CREATES UNDER THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS OFFICE TO ADJUDICATE
IMPORTANT WATER RIGHTS MATTER.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
IS GOOD GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE
LEGISLATION THAT ENSURES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WATER RIGHTS
HOLDERS RECEIVE CONSTITUTIONAL
DUE PROCESS AND FAIRNESS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
TAKING HIS CAREER SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TYLER I SIXTY ONE KNOWS FIVE
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE FIFTEEN AB.
TWENTY FIVE OH ONE KERKORIAN.
AT SOME LEGAL TWENTY FIVE OH ONE
BY SOME THE MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DRINKING
WATER.
MISTER KANSEN CHU.
SECTOR MISTER SPEAKERS AND AND
MEMBERS OF AB TWENTY FIVE ALL
ONE IS FACT ON CONCURRENCE.
A RECENT AMENDMENT TO THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE STATE BOARD TO
APPOINT AND CLARIFY THE ROLE OF
THE ADMINISTRATOR. TO HELP
OVERSEE AND FACILITATE A
CONSOLIDATION WHERE IS
APPROPRIATE.
DISPEL MORE SECURE SAFE DRINKING
SOME OF THE COLORFUL INDIANS
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITY AND
FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORATE RURAL.
MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE AREA VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY ABOUT ICE FOR THE
WINDOWS TWENTY SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT.
NOW WE'RE GOING.
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE FOR URGENCY
ADAMS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE FOR ITEMS THAT
ARE STILL ON CALL WHICH WE WILL.
FOR WHICH WE WILL LIFT THE CALL
BEFORE WE TAKE UP OUR FINAL
URGENCY ADAMS.
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM A FIVE THIS IS S.
BEFORE SIXTY THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS FEDERAL WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO THEM.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE EYES TWENTY SIX KNOWS
THIRTY FOUR THAT MEASURE FAILS.
MEMBERS HAVE PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL THAT FILE ITEM. TWO
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
NINE JONES SAWYER.
QUIRK POST.
ON THE RISPERDAL WISH TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS FEDERAL
WISHED ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE EYES.
FIFTY SIX KNOWS NINETEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND I'M GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
TO TEN THIS IS AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT MULLIN CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THOUGH.
I SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND AND NOW.
THANK YOU MEMBERS NOW I'M GOING
TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
FEDERAL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE.
I SIXTY THREE KNOWS FIVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
R. CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE URGENCY
ITEMS ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM.
THREE ZERO ONE AB TWO THREE FIVE
O'DONNELL CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL ACTUALLY
TO APPRENTICESHIP DECLARE THERE
IS EITHER A TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER O'DONNELL MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWO THIRTY FIVE A
SAVAGE IS A TWO PRONGED PROCESS
FOR APPROVING STATE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
ESTABLISHES PRE A* PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
UNDER THIS BILL THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP COUNCIL WILL
CONTINUE TO OVERSEE THE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION AND FIRE
FIGHTING PROGRAMS HOWEVER.
CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF
PARTNERSHIPS STANDARDS WILL NOW
APPROVING ESTABLISH STANDARDS
FOR ALL OTHER PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS FOR APPROVING PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THING WHICH ARE NOT ON SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THAT I%
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
BILL THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
THREE OH TO AB.
TWENTY SIX OH FIVE CORPORAL RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX OH FIVE
BY SOME MEMBER GIPSON AND OTHERS
AND I PLAN TO IMPLEMENT THE KIND
OF THEIR AND SEE THEIR UPS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER GIPSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
OH FIVE WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE
REFINERY SAFETY IS KEPT AT A
PRIORITY.
OF THIS BILL ALLOW REFINERY
WORKERS TO CONTINUE TO KEEP THE
WALKIE TALKIES OR DURING REST
BREAKS SO THEY CAN BE CONTACTED
IN CASE OF EMERGENCY.
IF THERE'S AN INTERRUPTION THEY
WILL EITHER HAVE THEIR BREAKS
RESCHEDULED OR RECEIVED A HOUR
OF PAY TO MAKE UP THAT TIME.
THIS BILL HAVE RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHAT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OF A
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
SEVEN KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE AIR
AND CI SEVENTY SEVEN THOSE ARE
ON THE MEASURE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE WILL NOW SHOW TO FILE ITEM.
THREE TEN AB. FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN GIPSON CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY TO DRINKING WATER
DECRYING THE URGENCY THERE OUGHT
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THIS GIPSON.
WAS A SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL --
FIFTEEN SEVEN SEVEN WHICH WOULD
HELP PROVIDE CLEAN THOSE
RESIDENTS BEING --
AFFECTED BY THIS THE TIVO WATER
DISTRICT THERE IS CURRENTLY A
WATER CRISIS IN MY DISTRICT
RESIDENTS ARE BEING --
SERVICE BY CITY BAR EXPERIENCING --
WATER ISSUES WATER ISSUES THAT
WE WON'T TOLERATE OURSELVES
THEY'RE RECEIVING A BROWN WATER
COMING OUT OF THEIR FAUCETS
BATHTUBS CORRODED PIPES POOR
MAINTAIN INFRASTRUCTURE AN AGING
PIPES.
THE TABLE LACKS THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND TECHNICAL
EXPERIENCE ON TO ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD
TO APPOINT.
AN ADMINISTRATOR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AYE VOTE ON FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THEY WAS GIPSON SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF AT ALL OF EVER
SWEATER DECIDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS AREA VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL.
COUNTY THAT I SEVENTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
SEVEN THOSE ARE ON THE BILL.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THREE
ELEVEN IS AB. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
BEGINNING TO CLEAR THE URGENCY
THERE OUGHT TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MR LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT EXTEND THE SUNSET
ALLOWING FOR MAJOR SPORTS LEAGUE
CHILD ROLE FOUNDATIONS TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING.
HUNDREDS OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
SARAH VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF HERE'S OUR TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FIFTY SIX KNOWS TEN ON
THE URGENCY AS FIFTY SIX NO TEN
ON THE MEASURE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
AND FILE ITEM THREE THIRTEEN IS
AB.
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR CORKERY AT
SOME LEGAL TWENTY FIFTY FOUR BY
SEVEN MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
AND OTHERS AND I PLAN TO STATE
PARKS DECLARE THEIR INTO THEIR
UP TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
A. B. --
TWENTY FIFTY FORWARD PURPOSE
PROHIBIT FOR PROFIT ACTIVITY
RELATED TO OVERNIGHT
ACCOMMODATIONS AT STATE PARKS.
WHICH IS NOT GRANTED PRIOR
APPROVAL BY THE DEPARTMENT
SUBJECT TO EXISTING PENALTIES
FOR VIOLATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
RULES AND REGULATIONS THIS IS A
GREAT BILL AND I HOPE IT'S HAD.
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
COMMITTEE AND HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SAYING THAT NO DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I SIXTY
NINE NO.
ZERO ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
DAY WE'VE BEEN.
GIVING TRIBUTES TO OUR OUTGOING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF REMAINING DEMOCRATS
WHO WILL BE LEAVING [inaudible]
THE CHAMBER.
COME THIS DECEMBER.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MISTER
MCCARTY WHO WILL BE SPEAKING IN
REFERENCE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TONY.
THURMOND MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD
LIKE.
TO RECOGNIZE OUR FRIEND.
FROM THE FIFTEENTH DISTRICT
[inaudible]
TONY THURMOND.
TONY THE TIGER.
MY NICKNAMES HERE.
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY VERY PROUD
OF YOUR SERVICE HERE TO THE
STATE ASSEMBLY AND ARE RECOGNIZE.
WHAT YOU BROUGHT TO THIS BODY?
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING
THE WAY WE'RE GONNA BE SHAPING
PUBLIC POLICY FOR YEARS TO COME.
HOPEFULLY IN THE EDUCATION
AROUND.
AND I JUST WANTED.
TO TALK ABOUT YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS
AND YOUR PRESENCE AND THE TONYS
THAT WE NOW.
TONY THURMOND TONY THE TIGER.
BUT THE ONE I WANT TALK ABOUT
FIRST IS TWENTY THE DAD.
IT'S YOU HAVE TWO BEAUTIFUL
SMART CONFIDENT YOUNG LADIES
DOCTORS.
GOT INTO THEIR TEENAGE THEIR
TWEEN TEENAGE YEARS MY IN JADEN.
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO THEM.
IS BAR NONE.
SEE YOU GO EVERY DAY TO THE
AMTRAK STATION TO RUN HOME.
GO HOME TWO HOURS COME HOME NEXT
TO OURS GO HOME AGAIN. FOUR
HOURS A DAY COMMUTING AND SOME
PEOPLE WOULD SAY WHY.
DID YOU WANT TO GO HOME TO YOUR
DAUGHTERS TO BE ABLE.
TO SEE THEM IN THE MORNING HELP
TAKEN TO SCHOOL BE PART OF THEIR
LIVES AND SO.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
RECOGNIZE ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT'S
A BIG PART OF WHO YOU ARE.
IN YOUR COMMITMENT TO THEM.
IS IS ALWAYS ON DISPLAY AND
ADMIRABLE --
TOLD ME THE AMERICAN STORY.
YOU TALK YOU'VE TAUGHT US ABOUT
YOUR EXPERIENCE.
A THE SON OF IMMIGRANTS.
WHO GREW UP IN?
AND FACE UNBELIEVABLE TRAGEDY IN
YOUR LIFETIME.
AND YOU OVERCAME IT.
YOU WERE A KID WHO COULD HAVE
BEEN A STATISTIC THAT YOU HAD
PEOPLE THAT LOVED YOU.
I TOOK CARE OF YOU AND CENTER ON
YOUR WAY.
EVER SO VERY GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POLICY LANDSCAPING HERE
TODAY.
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
A TONY THE SOCIAL WORKER.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU CHAIRED THOSE
BUDGET SUB ONE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS [inaudible] ONE CHAIRED
THEM FOR HOURS AND HOURS ON END.
MOST OF THE COMMITTEES HAD
[inaudible]
TIMERS [inaudible]
pYOU STAYED THERE AS LONG AS
PEOPLE WANTED TO TALK.
AND IT ENDS YOU ARE.
YOU NEVER GAVE IN.
AND THE OTHER BUDGET PROCESS YOU
CAME TO MISTER TING.
DOCTOR WEBER AND ALL OF US WITH
A LIST. THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
THAT YOU WANTED TO SPEND. TO
TACKLE THE WELLS THAT YOU STOP
FACING OUR COMMUNITY
[inaudible]
HEALTHCARE [inaudible]
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SOCIAL SERVICE IS.
AN YOU WANTED TO GO YOU WANT TO
DO IT ALL.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY.
BUT YOU ARE A SUPER STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE THAT DID NOT
HAVE A VOICE.
TONY THE ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATE.
FOCUSING ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MAKING
SURE THAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
MOVEMENT DIDN'T LEAVE BEHIND
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE YOUR RICHMOND.
TONY THE ADVOCATE FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH FIGHTING FOR AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE FOR EVERYBODY.
WORK ON ISSUES LIKE SMOKE FREE
PUBLIC PARKS.
TONY THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
ADVOCATE.
CHAMPION FOR EARLY EDUCATION.
MAKING SURE IN THIS LANGUAGE
LEARNERS HAD THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED IT.
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
IDEAS INNOVATIVE IDEAS TO FOCUS
ON TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND THAT
TEACHER PIPELINE.
AND LASTLY ON A FOCUS ON TONY
THE CONSCIENCE OF THIS --
OF THIS INSTITUTION.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU SPOKE YOU SPEAK
YOU SPOKE FROM THE HEART WITH
ELOQUENCE BUT ALSO.
AT WILL WE WE SEE IT IN YOU AND
I THINK YOU WERE ABLE TO BRING A
LOT OF THAT.
DEBATES WE SEE HERE ON THE
ASSEMBLY FULL FLOOR.
AND YOU REMINDED ME AND ALL OF
US OF THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
VOTES THAT WE TAKE ON A DAILY
BASIS.
SO YOU'RE NOT BE I FORGOTTEN WE
KNOW YOU'RE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
ENGAGE IN PUBLIC POLICY.
AND THAT WE WISH YOU WELL AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOUR YEARS ON
THE SCREEN CARPET THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GO HOME [inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
YES MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK
GOD MR.
DARMAN THERE FOR ALL THAT WE'VE
DONE.
YOU KNOW WE WE CAME CLOSE ON
YOUR MEMBERS OF A TRIP WE CAME
HOME FROM --
LAKE TAHOE.
AS LITTLE JOKE FROM THE EIGHTY
FIRST THEN WE TALKED OF HOW THE
TRIP BACK IN HOW PEOPLE ARE
FALLING ASLEEP.
WITHOUT THAT BECAME A FRIENDSHIP
BETWEEN US ME AND MY WIFE AND IN
OTHERS.
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP YOUR PASSION HERE
DERMOT YOUR DETERMINATION OF
BECOME WE HAVE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT DO HER.
REPRESENT FOR ALL THE GOOD THAT
YOU HAVE TO OFFER.
ARE YOU NEVER BEFORE DONE YOURS
REMEMBERED NOW MISTER ON THE FLY
BALL FIELD.
ACTION WE HAVE OUR OUR GAME HERE
IN.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FRIENDSHIP.
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THE GOOD TIMES NOT ONLY IN THIS
BUILDING BUT OUTSIDE THIS
BUILDING.
OF ALL THE THINGS YOU'VE DONE
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE
YOU'VE BEEN A GOOD FRIEND AND
YOU ALWAYS BIGGER FRIEND AND
LOOK INTO FORWARD TOWARD WHICH
DO.
NOT ONLY HERE BUT IN THE FUTURE
SO THANK YOU AND GOOD LUCK IN OF
THEM AGAIN THANK YOU AND ALSO I
CALLED HIM TO GET IT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUSINESS IS ALL FLETCHER.
I MEANT LIKE THIS WAY
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST MET YOU
BECAUSE UNLIKE ANYTHING I'D EVER
DONE BEFORE AYE ENDORSED YOU
BEFORE I MET YOU JUST BASED ON
YOUR STORY.
I THOUGHT ANYONE WHO HAD THAT
STORY -- HAD
TO BRING A GOOD PERSPECTIVE TO
THIS PLACE.
AND YOU HAVE.
AND I'VE BEEN SO PROUD TO SIT
NEXT YOU.
ATTY HERE YOUR PASSION COME
THROUGH AND EVERYTHING.
NOW REMEMBER --
DURING THE HOLIDAY BREAK
[inaudible]
LAST YEAR.
WHEN YOU CALLED TO TELL ME THAT
YOU HAD DECIDED?
YOU'RE GONNA RUN FOR ANOTHER
OFFICE.
SAID MAYBE WE COULD SIT DOWN
TALK ABOUT IT.
IN THE WAS AND A MOMENT WHEN I
THOUGHT TO ASK WHO ELSE IS RUN
MEAN.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS WHAT DO
YOU CARE ABOUT BECAUSE?
THE ONLY THING I COULD THINK OF
IS.
IF THERE IS ONE PERSON ONE
PERSON THAT I'VE WORKED WITH.
THAT I WOULD COMPLETELY TRUST.
THE FATE OF MY CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION IN THE HANDS OF ITS
TWENTY THIRD.
AND I STILL FEEL THAT WAY.
I AM PROUD.
I WILL SAY AS MUCH AS I'M GONNA
MISS YOU ON THE FLOOR AND MISS
[inaudible]
YOU'RE JUST.
EVERY WONDERFUL THING ABOUT YOU
BRING YOUR GIRLS UP HERE IN JUST.
SEE NO I WILL NOT MISS YOU
DURING APPROPRIATIONS.
BECAUSE LIKE THE BUDGET PROCESS
WHEN HE CAN'T GET. THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET.
HE OFTEN COMES HANDS OUT. TO THE
APPROPRIATIONSMEETING.
AND LITERALLY GOES. ONE BY ONE
OF BILLS THAT COST. FIFTY
MILLION A HUNDRED MILLION. TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN WOULD PUSH ME.
AND SAY AND I'D SAY WELL IT'S
NOT THE BUDGET AND TONY OF
COURSE WOULD SAY YEAH BUT LIKE
WHAT WE STAND [inaudible]
FOR WHO CARES.
SO WE CAN'T PASS ALL THESE
THINGS THAT ARE UNFUNDED HE'S
LIKE WHY.
WHERE IS THAT WRITTEN?
WHAT RULE BOOKER Y. YOU'VE SEEN?
AND INVARIABLY IT LEAVE THE MY
STAFF I GET FRUSTRATED LIKE
THOSE.
ARGUING FOR UNFUNDED TO UNDER
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR BILLS
[inaudible]
A BUT IT'S HAVE PASSION.
IT'S A QUESTIONING AND IT'S
ALWAYS DOING THE RIGHT THING
THAT I'M IN A MESS AND I WISH
YOU GODSPEED.
AND GOOD LUCK.
AND WE HOPE TO SEE YOU NEXT YEAR.
PUSHING US ON SOME BILLS OF YOUR
OWN AS WELL [inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS --
I WHEN KNOW WORDS SAY FAREWELL.
TWO ONE HAVE OF THE PANAMANIAN.
NOT PANDA MANIA.
BUT WE ARE THAT TO CAUCUS.
SO MR THURMAN IS MY PANAMANIAN
BROTHER [inaudible]
AND I I AM VERY PROUD OF MY
PANAMANIAN BROTHER --
LIKE PANAMANIAN BROTHER HAD
NEVER HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
IN HIS LIFETIME TO VISIT --
HIS MOTHER'S NATIVE.
PANAMA.
AND TELL THE SPEAKER MYSELF
[inaudible]
HE AND A PRO --
TEN TRAVELED TO PANAMA ON THE
INVITATION OF THE MAYOR OF
PANAMA CITY. FOR THE OPENING OF
THE SPENDING.
EXPANSION OF THE PANAMA CANAL.
AND I GOT TO SEE MR THURMAN FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
IN PANAMA.
TAKING THE BUS FIFTY MILES
ACROSS THE ISTHMUS. TO THE CITY
OF COLOGNE.
ON THE ATLANTIC SIDE.
WHERE HE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET SOME OF HIS RELATIVES FOR
THE FIRST TIME?
SO I HAVE GOTTEN VERY CLOSE TO
MY PANAMANIAN BROTHER.
WE SHARE SOME CAUCUSES IN COMICS.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ALL OF
YOU KNOW THIS BUT MR THURMAN
PROBABLY BELONGS TO MORE
CAUCUSES THAN ANYBODY ELSE ON
THE FLOOR OF THIS ASSEMBLY.
AND JUST TO LIST A FEW OF THEM.
THE PANAMANIAN CAUCUS OF TO THE
LATINO CAUCUS.
THE JEWISH CAUCUS.
THE BLACK CAUCUS.
I HOPE I GOT AMONG.
THE TRAIN CAUCUS.
BUT AYE I WILL MISS MR THURMAN I
HAVE NOT AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO SAID --
BEAT A TEACHER MYSELF I'VE NEVER
MET.
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS A
BIGGER HARD. FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
SO I'M GONNA MISS MY PANAMANIAN
RATHER [inaudible]
MS FRIEDMAN.
I THINK YOU.
AYE TONY THURMOND IS.
I WAS GOING TO BE VERY SPECIAL
TO ME.
BECAUSE TONY THURMOND WAS MY
SEAT MATE. FOR MY FIRST
[inaudible]
TERMINATE ASSEMBLY.
AS MY SEAT MATE.
HE WAS MY MENTOR.
AND HE WAS REALLY THE PERFECT
MENTOR FOR ME [inaudible]
BECAUSE HE HAS OF WISDOM.
ABOUT HIM THAT HE EXUDES EVERY
TIME HE OPENS HIS MOUTH.
AND SPEAK SO ELOQUENTLY AS HE
ALWAYS DOES.
EMPLEOS OFF THE CUFF ON SUBJECTS
THAT IMPASSIONED HIM.
AND WHEN HE CHOOSES TO SPEAK HE
SPEAKS THE SAME WAY THAT HE
VOTES AND THAT'S WITH A
RIGHTEOUSNESS.
THAT ALWAYS IMPRESSES ME.
AND I THINK IN THE WHOLE YEAR
AND A HALF THAT WE SAT TOGETHER
I CAN THINK OF ONE TIME THAT WE
VOTED IN A DIFFERENT WAY AND NOT
JUST BECAUSE YOU ALWAYS PRESS MY
MY MY A BUTTON WHEN I WASN'T
AROUND --
WITH MY PERMISSION --
BUT BECAUSE WE REALLY SEE AYE
AYE ON SO MANY THINGS --
BUT ONE OF THE WAYS THAT HE
REALLY --
IMPRESSED HIMSELF ON ME AND MADE
AN IMPACT ON ME IS.
THE COMMUNIST BY WHICH HE
CARRIES HIMSELF.
HE DOESN'T GET EXCITED AND HE
DOESN'T GET ANGRY [inaudible]
HE'S DETERMINED.
AND HE'S FORCEFUL WHEN HE SPEAKS
BUT HE DOES IT WITH HIS WISDOM.
AND NOT WITH HIS TONE.
AND EVERY TIME I WOULD WATCH HIM
SPEAK I WOULD SIT THERE AND
THINK.
I WANNA BE JUST LIKE HIM WHEN I
GROW UP.
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING MY MENTOR
IN MY FORMATIVE YEAR.
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING ON TO A
REALLY BRIGHT FUTURE.
IN LEADERSHIP AND CONTINUED
SERVICE AND I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
WE WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
[inaudible]
MR LEVINE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TASK EVER SAT.
AT HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY SUB THE
ONLY DESK EVER SAT OUT BUT IT'S
THE FIRST.
AND MY VERY FIRST SEAT MATE.
I ALSO SAID GOODBYE TO HE WAS MY
NEIGHBOR TO THE NORTH WEST
HASBRO.
AND I'M YOUR LAST SEAT MATE
[inaudible]
AS WELL [inaudible]
AND YOU BEEN A FANTASTIC SEE MAY
JUST THIS SHORT PERIOD TIME THAT
WE'VE HAD TOGETHER.
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT WE SHARE
THIS TIME TOGETHER THE SEAT MATE.
EXPERIENCE IS IT IS A REALLY --
IT'S UNIQUE --
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY REALLY TO
GET TO KNOW SOMEONE WELL. FOR ME
AN OPPORTUNITY GET A WINDOW TO
THE DISTRICT ACROSS THE BAY FROM
ME WE'RE SO CLOSE.
BUT YET ACROSS THAT WATER
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT LARA
AND KEVIN IN IN THAT EVERYONE
DECIDES THINGS ARE SO TRUE ABOUT
YOU.
AND YOU COME TO YOUR WORK WITH
VERY DEEP PASSION.
IN VERY DEEP CONVICTION.
THAT'S VISCERAL THAT THOSE
AROUND YOU CAN FEEL THAT WE KNOW
IS.
TRUE TO YOUR HEART IS DEEP IN
YOUR BONES.
THAT AUTHENTICITY --
IS INSPIRING.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
PURSE SHARING THIS DESK WITH ME.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO PAUSE THE TRIBUTE
TO MR HARMON FOR ONE MOMENT I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MISTER SPEAKER.
BUT IN A TREMENDOUS HONOR FOR
ALL OF US.
TO HAVE SERVED. FOR VARYING
AMOUNTS OF TIME.
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS QUITE
LITERALLY A LEGEND --
SOMEONE WHO SERVED AS GOVERNOR
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS WHO HAS BEEN --
HER WROTE IT IS EFFORTS AT
BATTLE THE CLIMATE CHANGE
SOMEONE WHO MOST RECENTLY.
HAS BEEN --
MAKING SURE THAT A LOT OF WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH RESPECT TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN THE PAST WAS
UNDONE.
AND THAT --
THE PATH TOWARDS JUSTICE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE AS A STATE --
HAVE -- HAVE
TRAVEL DOWN [inaudible]
QUICK QUICKLY.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS I
WHEN WE WALKING UP THE STAIRS
RIGHT NOW I I'D SAID OF THE
GOVERNOR SIXTEEN YEARS AS
GOVERNOR THAT'S A LONG TIME HE
SAID YEAH PROVES THE TERM LIMITS
ARE BULLSHIT [inaudible]
YEAH -- AND
I ADDED.
ANYONE WHO'S SPENT ANY AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH HIM WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED BY THAT COMMENT.
WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED BY IS
WHAT WE'VE ALL BEEN HONOR TO
SERVE WITH THEM --
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SAYING GOODBYE
TO GOVERNOR BROWN
. OH OKAY
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED.
WITH SOME OF THE MEMBER TRIBUTES
FOR OUR GOOD FRIEND [inaudible]
THURMOND.
MISTER MR MAIENSCHEIN.
IF YOU WELL.
NO SO COURT GOVERNOR BROWN JUST
HE'S TOOK A NAY SAYER.
AN INTERLUDE I THOUGHT THERE WAS
ANY LONGER --
FORGOT THE SINGLE THAT CAUCUS
AND MR MEDINA WHICH I TONY AND I
AYE MY QUICK FOR ABOUT TWENTY
FIRST OFF THANKS FOR ALL THAT
YOU'VE DONE FOR THIS BODY YOUR
PASSION ON EDUCATION AND REALLY --
ALL THE TREMENDOUS SOCIAL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON SOCIAL
ISSUES YOUR BACKGROUND YOUR
SOCIAL WORK BACKGROUND ALL THAT
YOU BROUGHT TO OUR COMMITTEES IN
THE DISCUSSIONS THERE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT --
IT MADE THIS BODY A BETTER PLACE
IT IT IT MADE A BETTER TO SERVE
HERE SO --
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THAT BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU AND I I THINK
BECAME BECAUSE BECAUSE EVERY
TIME WE CAME IN HERE WE START
TALKING ABOUT OUR DAUGHTERS.
AND OUR DAUGHTERS HAPPEN TO BE
THE SAME AGES AND WE ARE SO
EXCITED TALK ABOUT WHAT WE DID
OVER THE WEEKEND AND WHAT THEY
WERE DOING AND HOW THEY WERE
GROWN UP AND I REMEMBER WHEN YOU
CAME TO SAN DIEGO.
I IN YOU BROUGHT YOUR DAUGHTERS
AND WE ARE GOING TO GET AND
TOGETHER WE ARE SO EXCITED WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IT.
THEY WERE GOING TO BE GREAT
FRIENDS AND THEN WE SAT DOWN TO
DINNER WITHOUT THE FOR THEM DOWN
AND THEY JUST LOOKED AT EACH
OTHER.
AND SAY ANYTHING THEY JUST SAT
THERE AND WAS.
WILL AWKWARD. FOR YOU AND ME
START TALKING --
AND THEN MY AND JADEN AND TARA
BROWN IT BECAME REALLY CLOSE YOU
KNOW THEY GOT WHAT THEY GOT
TALKING AND I THINK YOU AND I
GOT TOO MANY.
OUT WORDS IN EDGEWISE AND AND
THAT IS WHY I WILL TAKE --
AS MY MEMORY OF YOU IS THAT
MOMENT OF OF US BEING ABLE TO
SHARE TIME WITH OUR DAUGHTERS
AND AND THE PRIDE AND JOY THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN THEM AND HOW YOU
PHRASE AND THEN TAP.
FIND STRONG YOUNG WOMEN --
AND OUT OF ALL THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HERE AND THERE
MANY YOU'RE GONNA GO ON TO DO
GREAT THINGS THOSE TWO REALLY
ARE -- YOUR
BAT IN MY VIEW YOUR GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT SO
CONGRATULATIONS I LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE.
TO WORK WITH YOU AS YOU MOVE ON
MISTER CALDERON --
MEMBERS.
LOT OF MICROPHONES STILL UP.
WE DEFINITELY WANT TO MAKE SURE
OUR MEMBERS THAT ARE LEAVING
FEEL LOVED.
I THINK THEY FEEL THE LOVE.
UNLESS IT ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE
SAID ON THE FLOOR I'D IT
ENCOURAGE YOU TO APPROACH HIM
DIRECTLY AND TELL THEM HOW MUCH.
ELEVEN BECAUSE IT'S GETTING LATE.
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER WE
STILL NEED A LOT TO DO A TRIBUTE
TO USE UNLESS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY WOULD REALLY.
WOULD LIKE.
TO TRY TO MOVE THINGS ALONG HERE
AND AND GET THE HOGS IN
PERSONALLY THANK YOU.
I DON'T SEE MY PHONE'S GOING
DOWN.
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY MISTER
THURMAN WE LOVE YOU.
LET ME CALL ON MISTER.
GIBSON.
AND MISTER KALRA.
IT'S YOUR GIPSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER LET ME JUST
BE BRIEF --
WANT ONE I THINK --
IS DETERMINED FOR ONE HIS
FRIENDSHIP --
HE NUYS ART CAME AT THE SAME
TIME IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
BUT ALSO --
YOUR INCREDIBLE --
LEADERSHIP IN TERMS OF BEING A
FATHER --
BECAUSE EVERY TIME I SAW YOU YOU
HAD YOUR DAUGHTERS WITH YOU KNOW
THAT'S BEEN SAID BEFORE.
BUT ALSO WALKING UP AND DOWN THE
STREETS WITH A SUITCASE --
GOING TO THE TRAIN STATION
UNDERSCORE --
AND BELIEVING THAT THE NEXT
CHAPTER THAT YOU GOING TO WRITE --
AS SUPERINTENDENT I'M IS GOING
TO BE ONE THAT I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE.
IN.
YOU KNOW MY TIME IS CALDERON
OUTCOME.
ANYWAY AS I WAS SAYING --
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THE BEST IS
YET TO COME --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ONE
ACCEPTED MY KNOW WHEN I CAN
SUPPORT.
OF A PARTICULAR ITEM OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT YOU'VE
ALWAYS LEFT WITH A GREAT --
ELEGANCE ABOUT YOURSELF --
YOU HAVE TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP
AND I THINK IT EXUDES --
IN THIS BUILDING AND I'M HAPPY
TO CALL YOU FRIEND OUTLOOK FOR
TWO A YOU MOVING UP --
IN YOUR NEXT --
IN THE NEXT DIMENSION IN YOUR
LIFE AS OUR NEW SUPERINTENDENT
[inaudible]
KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND THE TONY T..
WE GO BACK A LONG TIME I DON'T A
DECADE OR MORE --
AND IF YOU KNOW YOU HAVE BECOME
LIKE A BROTHER TO ME A GUIDE.
A NORTH STAR.
WHEN I WALK ON TO THIS FLOOR AND
HAVE A FUN COMING OUT ON HOME TO
A VOTE? FOR THE FIRST THINGS I
DO IS LOOK AT SEE WESTERMAN DUNE.
FALCON HELPS THAT STONE AND TING
EARLIER IN TWO SECOND BECAUSE IT
IT HAS TROUBLE AHEAD.
BUT BUT I ALWAYS WANT TO KNOW --
BUT TONY'S THINKING ABOUT
SOMETHING WORRIES GOING WHAT
HE'S FEELING ABOUT IT. TO THE
MATTERS THAT MUCH.
YOU ARE THE EPITOME OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
YOU'RE THE HOPE OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
ARE [inaudible]
KIND.
YOU'RE A GENTLEMAN.
THEIR COLLABORATIVE YOU'RE ALL
THE THINGS THAT A PUBLIC SERVANT
SHOULD BE.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'VE BEEN MY
ROLE MODEL IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
SO WHEN I RENDON --
TWENTY SIXTEEN AFTER THE PRIMARY.
WE CAME IN SECOND AND BUT YOU
ARE DOWN LIKE 15%.
AND HOW THE FIND A WAY TO
CONVINCE NOT ONLY MY TEMA MYSELF.
THAT WE HAD A SHOT.
IN THE FIRST THING I SAID WAS
TONY THURMOND [inaudible]
TONY THURMAN.
FROM JUNE TO NOVEMBER.
SWITCHED AT FIFTEEN POINT 3%.
I DON'T KNOW IF I BELIEVED AT
THE TIME BUT I HAVE TRIED TO
FIND A WAY TO GET OTHER PEOPLE
TO BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN DO IT.
I HAD TO TRY MY BEST TO EMULATE
TONY THURMOND AND TO INSPIRE
PEOPLE THE WAY.
THAT TONY ALWAYS HAS.
YOU ARE MY INSPIRATION THEN.
EVERY TIME I WALK ON TO THE
GREEN CARPET YOU'RE MY
INSPIRATION.
AND WILL BE MY INSPIRATION THE
FUTURE TO EVERY SINGLE DAY AS I
TRIED EMILY.
YOU IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
LOVE YOUR BROTHER.
THANK YOU MISS KALRA MISTER
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
THUNDERING THURMAN [inaudible]
MR T..
I PROMISE I KEEP SHORT NOW MY
GOOD.
BUT I SAY.
YOU'RE ARE ROCK SOLID MODERN DAY.
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER.
AND JUST AN AWESOME DAD.
I'M PROUD TO CALL YOU FRIEND.
I LOVE YOU.
KEEP DOING THE WORK [inaudible]
MISTER CHIU.
TONY ONLY EFFORT TWO THINGS I
WANNA SAY FIRST I JUST WANT TO
SHARE.
MY VERY FIRST IMPRESSION OF U.
S. THE LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUE IT
WAS DURING FRESHMAN ORIENTATION.
WE WERE GOING AROUND THE ROOM
INTRODUCING OUR NAMES.
AND OUR GOOD FRIEND ARE
DEPARTING COLLEAGUES SAID HELLO.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL JORDAN.
AND MICHAEL JORDAN TONY THURMOND.
YOU HAVE NOT JUST ONLY.
ENTERTAIN US WITH YOUR HUMOR AND
YOUR QUICKNESS BUT YOU HAVE BEEN
A TRUE CHAMPION.
A CHAMPION FOR EDUCATION AND
THAT FOR FOSTER CARE. FOR
EDUCATION BUT OF COURSE
[inaudible] FOR KIDS.
KIDS WHO DESERVE A SECOND SHOT.
AND OUT LET ME JUST SAY ONE
DISAPPOINTMENT I'VE HAD IS YOU
HAVE JOIN VIRTUALLY EVERY CAUCUS.
JEWISH CAUCUS THE PANAMANIAN
CAUCUS THE LATINO CAUCUS THE
BLACK CAUCUS.
I JUST A LITTLE FRIEND WHO NEVER
CAME OUT AS A BROTHER.
IN THE API CAUCUS.
THERE'S STILL TIME FOR THAT BUT
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY SAYING.
WITHOUT WE'RE GONNA GET TWELVE
YEARS TOGETHER WE ONLY GOT FOUR
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO SERVING
WITH YOU.
HOPEFULLY YOUR NEW CAPACITY
GODSPEED BROTHER.
AND MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES.
BROTHER THURMAN TONY T..
THAT WE HAVE MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS TOGETHER ON THIS FLOOR.
BUT I REALLY ENJOY THOSE FOUR
YEARS I KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO WORK TOGETHER IN MANY WAYS.
GOING AND GOING FOR I WANT TO
SHARE A COUPLE STORIES.
YOU KNOW WHEN THINGS ABOUT TONY
NUYS -- WERE
WERE BOTH FORMER ATHLETES AND I
SAY I STRESS THE FORMER.
IF ANY OF YOU EVER BEEN TO THAT
SACRAMENTO AMTRAK STATION
SOMETIMES WE GET THEIR LITTLE
BIT LATE WE HAVE TO RUN ON DOWN.
AND WE DID THAT RECENTLY THAT A
COUPLE TIMES TOGETHER.
WE'RE FEELING GOOD ABOUT
OURSELVES WHERE WHERE.
YOU KNOW AS WE GET CLOSER
GETTING SLOWER AND THEN.
WHEN WE FINALLY ON THE TRAIN WE
GET WE'RE PRETTY HAPPY WITH
OURSELVES BUT WE CAN'T TALK TO
EACH OTHER FOR THE NEXT FIVE
MINUTES?
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO CATCH
OUR BREATH.
SO WE SAT THERE PANTING.
AND THAT IT POINTING AT EACH
OTHER CHINESE HAND SIGNS --
ENEMY COMPARED NOTES ABOUT HOW
SORE WE ARE THE NEXT DAY WHO
STORE -- IN
OUR LEGS --
ONE I THINK I WAS LUCKY I'VE HAD
SOME TOUGH BILLS AND I SOMETIMES
I WORK WEEKENDS AND NIGHTS AND
TRY TO MAKE CALLS AND GET
SUPPORT.
WHATEVER I'VE A CALL.
TONY.
SOMETIMES IT SAY MY STAFF HAS A
BRIEF ME SOMETIMES TO SAY HAVE A
CHANCE TO READ IT AND FOR SOME
BUDGET SAY IT'S NOT ON MY RADAR.
BUT THEN HE'D ASK.
IS IT A BONTA BILL.
AND I'D SAY YES HE SAY THAT I'M
AND I AND I APPRECIATE THAT
SUPPORT YOUR BELIEF IN ME --
I INVITE ANYONE AFTER TWENTY
LEAVES TO TAKE ON THAT ROLE.
FROM MY BILLS IF THEY WANNA BE
AN UNCONDITIONAL I BE VERY
APPRECIATIVE --
I WILL SAY THIS OF ALL THE GREAT
THINGS THAT BEEN SAID I BELIEVE.
A 100% MORE.
AB BUT THERE IS ONE PLACE WHERE
YOU NEED IMPROVEMENT --
YOU GOTTA GET YOUR BOWLING GAME
UP MAN.
WE WE DO S..
WE DO A EAST BAY BOWLING
CHALLENGE A FUNDRAISER FOR SOME
BY YOUNG LEADERS --
IT'S BILLED AS TONY TEN PINS
THURMOND AGAINST ROB KINGPIN
BONTA.
AND HE IS --
HE'S ON A STREAK OF LOSING.
BOTH TIMES BY WAS THAT YOU LOOK
GOOD WHEN YOU PLAY.
YOU GOT THAT FOLLOW THROUGH ITS
MOVE IT'S JUST THAT THAT THE
BALL DOESN'T HIT THAT PINS THAT
OFTEN WHEN YOU WHEN YOU DO THAT --
DON'T PUT IT IN WITH THIS TONY --
WE SPELL OUT TIME OF THE TRAIN
HAS BEEN A LONG TIME TO
DISTRICTS I'M PROUD THAT WE
REPRESENT OAKLAND TOGETHER --
THOUGH WE'VE GROWN OUR
FRIENDSHIP.
OVER THE TIME IN [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I RECOGNIZING YOU EVERYONE I
THINK [inaudible]
SEES THAT.
ADAM YOUR HARDWIRED TO TO WANT
TO HELP PEOPLE.
THAT YOU HAVE A A GOOD HEART AND
A PURE HEART THAT.
WHEN?
YOU SEE SOMETHING WRONG YOU WANT
TO WRITE IT YOU WANNA YOU WANNA
EASE PAIN YOU WANNA AND
SUFFERING.
AND YOU BELIEVE IN PEOPLE YOU
BELIEVE IN THE GOOD IN PEOPLE.
AND YOU [inaudible]
SEPARATELY BELIEVE.
CHILDREN AND KIDS [inaudible]
AND POTENTIAL OF EVERY CHILD IN
THE YOU BELIEVE THAT EVERY CHILD
WITH THE RIGHT RESOURCES IN THE
RIGHT SUPPORT CAN.
REALIZE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL AND
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS AND SHOW
THAT EVERY DAY.
SO NEW YOUR MORAL CLARITY YOU
MORAL COMPASS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT LOST ON ANY OF US ITS
INFLUENCE MANY OF US INCLUDING
ME.
EVEN SO YOU'RE ABLE TO INSPIRE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT SUPPORT YOU BUT YOU'RE ABLE
TO INSPIRE US TO EVEN SPIRED ME.
TO BE BETTER TO BE MORE
PASSIONATE TO BE STRONGER TO BE
A FIERCE A FIGHTER TO BE MORE
CHAMPION WARRIOR.
SO YOU WILL BE MESSED --
BY ME YOU BE MISSED BY ALL OF US
ON THIS FLOOR YOU'LL BE MISSED
BY ME ON THE TRAIN --
AND I HOPE THAT MAYBE THIS TIME
NEXT YEAR I'LL BE STANDING UP
HERE --
OFFERING A BILL SPONSORED BY YOU.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONTINUED INSPIRATION AND YOU
CONTINUE LEADERSHIP AND MUCH
SUCCESS TO YOU AND MUCH LOVE
BROTHER.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
MR THURMAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES ARE ON I THANK YOU TO
ALL OF YOU.
AND ONE I THINK THE SPEAKER --
WE THE SPEAKING I HAVE A JOKE --
THAT ALL HE DOES IS WHEN AND AND
THE TIME THAT I HAVE TO SERVE
WITH THE SPEAKER AND AND THOSE
OF YOU HAVE BEEN HERE. FOR FOUR
YEARS SIX YEARS.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST PIECES OF
LEGISLATION HAVE HAPPENED.
IN THOSE YEARS SUGGESTS WATER TO
ADDRESS HOUSING --
TO ADDRESS THE QUALITY OF LIFE
ISSUES FOR STATE AND I'M VERY
PROUD OF THAT WORK YOU KNOW
WE'VE DONE MORE TOGETHER. TO
ADDRESS FOSTER YOUTH NEEDS OF
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND MONEY FOR
SCHOOLS.
AND AND I AM THANKFUL TO BE HERE
ANY TIME OF THE STATE HAS MONEY
AND AND WHAT I WOULD ALWAYS SAY.
TO LANA IS YOU KNOW.
WHY WOULD WE SPEND THE PEOPLE'S
MONEY ON THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT
THE MOST?
I'VE NEVER UNDERSTOOD THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I NEVER
WILL NOW NEVER ACCEPTED.
WE TELL OURSELVES NO.
EVEN WE HAVE THE DOLLARS TO DO
IT AND I UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
BE INTERNAL CONTROLS.
BUT WHEN I GOT HERE THEY SAID.
AS A FRESHMAN THEY SAID TO ME
DON'T EVER ASK FOR ANY MONEY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE CRAZIEST
THING I EVER HEARD MAYBE THAT'S
WHY THEY PUT ME IN MISS BURKE'S
OFFICE WHICH IS NOW.
515-0 AND I THOUGHT WELL I'M
GONNA ASK FOR MONEY.
BECAUSE I GREW UP WATCHING IN
THE STATE EVERYTHING THAT I
CARED ABOUT THE CAT [inaudible]
EDUCATION.
HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS FOR SENIORS
AND SO.
I'M HONORED TO BE ABLE TO BE
HERE TIME WE ACTUALLY HAVE
RESOURCES. TO HELP THOSE WHO
NEED HELP THE MOST I'M THANKFUL
TO SERVE THESE GREAT COLLEAGUES --
I FEEL AS THOUGH I'M CERTAIN
SOME OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE
HARDEST WORKING PEOPLE I LEARN
SOMETHING EVERY DAY EVERY TIME
YOU PICK UP YOUR MIKES.
I LEARNED SOMETHING ELSE IT WILL
I DO NIGHTLINE AND I KNOW THAT
ONE AND I I WISH I SAID THAT I
LEARNED SOMETHING.
THAT HELPS ME TO BE A BETTER
PERSON.
AND I HOPE A BETTER LEADER AND A
BETTER SERVICE --
EVEN THOUGH WE DISAGREE YOU KNOW
I TELL PEOPLE ALL THE TIME THAT
YEAH I GENERALLY HAVE A SENSE OF
HOW I WANT TO GO.
I TRIED TO MAKE MY REPUTATION
HERE IN ALL THE THIRD HOUSE
PEOPLE WERE HANGING OUT THERE.
IN THAT.
NOW THE WAY WHATEVER YOU WANNA
CALL IT.
I'VE ALWAYS TOLD THEM WHAT WAS
GOING TO SUPPORT SOMETHING I
TELL NOT UP FRONT.
BUT I'M WILLING TO LISTEN AND BE
CONVINCED IF YOU CAN HELP ME SEE
SOMETHING.
THAT I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THAT ONCE KEEP
AN OPEN DOOR POLICY UP HERE.
BE WILLING TO MEET WITH PEOPLE
TAKE MEETINGS WITH PEOPLE WITH
WHOM YOU DON'T AGREE.
AND YOU NEVER KNOW --
IN A MUCH A LOBBYIST WILL SAY TO
ME WELL WE MIGHT NOT GET MORE
THAN.
5% OF OUR VOTES FROM YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
HAVE AN OPEN DOOR POLICY.
AND YOU KNOW I TAKE THAT AS A
BADGE OF OF A BEING WILLING TO
TO WORK WITH PEOPLE.
I WANNA THANK --
ALL OF MY CAUCUS MAKES.
AND IT'S BEEN AN HONOR --
I THINK I THINK A DOCTOR EGGMAN
AND I SHARE RECORD FOR BELONGING
TO THE MOST CAUCUSES --
SHE NIGHT.
BELONG TO THE SOCIAL WORKER
CAUCUS ONLY SOCIAL WORKERS HERE --
I'M GONNA THINK THE BLACK CAUCUS
THE LATINO CAUCUS THE JEWISH
CAUCUS --
THE BAY AREA CAUCUS --
AND ALL MY VERY CAUCUS MATES IN
THE LEADER THE BAY AREA CAUCUS
WILL TEAM WHO'S THE FIRST PERSON
TO SPEAK UP FOR ME.
WHEN I WAS ONE OF FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AND HE DOUBTS REMAIN?
AND WHEN YOU'RE.
WHEN YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
HAVE MONEY OR POLITICAL
CONNECTIONS AND YOU JUST HAVE A
DREAM THAT YOU WANT SIR UNIQUE
PEOPLE ABOUT FOR YOU?
YOU NEED PEOPLE TO SAY GIVE THIS
PERSON A LOOK SEE.
FILLED THE DATA RIGHT I CAME TO
MY DISTRICT AND MAKE PHONE CALLS
AND TALK TO PEOPLE CHECK OUT
YOUR FOR ME.
YOU KNOW BARELY KNOWN ME BUT YOU
KNOW THOSE THINGS MATTER.
AND I APPRECIATE MY CAUCUS MAYES
I WANT TO THANK MY STAFF I'VE
HAD.
INCREDIBLE STAFF IN MANY OF THEM
ARE HERE --
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO GIVE THEM
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
THANK GOD [inaudible]
ALTOGETHER.
MY CAPITOL STAFFERS HERE MY
DISTRICT STAFF IS HERE --
I LIKE TO THINK THE BUDGET STAFF
ONE I THINK THE PRO TEM WHO WAS
AT THE TIME SPEAKER WHO GAVE ME
A CHANCE. TO CHAIR BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
A FRESHMAN AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON PROGRAMS
AND MATTER SHE TOLD ME THAT I
ASK FOR COMMITTEES.
THAT NOBODY EVER ASKED FOR AND
THAT NO ONE EVER WANTED.
AND I SAY WELL THAT'LL BE ENOUGH
IT'S REALLY FOR ME TO CONTRIBUTE
AND IT REALLY DID OPEN DOORS FOR
A DISTRICT LIKE MINE.
THAT NEEDED HELP THEY NEED HELP
FOR HEALTH CARE HOSPITALS CLOSE
THEY NEEDED HELP IN OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS IN HAVE DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY POLICING.
THAT NEEDED HELP FOR OUR SCHOOLS
AND I CAME UP HERE TO WORK AND
I'M SO THANKFUL THAT I WAS GIVEN
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES I THINK THE
BUDGET STAFF.
I THINK LEADERSHIP --
I DIDN'T GET THE INVITATION TO
THE API CAUCUS I GUESS I'LL HAVE
TO DO OF SPIT TEST TO SEE IF I
HAVE ANY LEGITIMATE.
RIGHT TO EARN BUT I WAS VERY
PROUD TO WORK OF THE FBI CAUCUS
IN THE LGBT CAUCUS --
IN THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND SO
MANY GREAT GROUPS THAT ARE HERE --
I GUESS ALL I WOULD SAY IS THANK
YOU TO ALL OF YOU COLLEAGUES I
SAY THANK YOU TO THE PEOPLE OF
THIS DISTRICT.
I'M I NEVER [inaudible]
IN VISION.
BEING ON GREEN CARPET.
YOU ALL KNOW MY STORY --
MY GRANDPARENTS WERE IMMIGRANTS.
AND MY GREAT GREAT GRANDPARENTS
WERE SLAVES [inaudible]
MY GRANDMOTHER [inaudible]
CLEAN HOUSES.
MY AUNT AND MY COUSIN WHO RAISED
ME.
WAS A NURSING ASSISTANT.
AND WE STRUGGLE --
I WAS ON EVERY FORM OF PUBLIC
ASSIST [inaudible]
THINK OF FREE LUNCH [inaudible]
FOOD STAMPS.
YOU HEARD WE SAY THE JOKE A SO
MUCH GOVERNMENT SHE'S AT THAT
THE USDA WAS A BRAND NAME.
I LOST MY MOTHER TO CANCER WHEN
I WAS SIX YEARS OLD.
MY FATHER WAS A VIETNAM VET WHO
I FOUND ON THE INTERNET AFTER
THIRTY YEARS OF NOT KNOWING HIM
ALSO DIE FROM CANCER.
AND I WAS RAISED BY COUSIN WHO I
NEVER MET UNTIL I SHOWED UP ON
HER DOORSTEP.
YOU SAY MY LIFE.
SHE MAKES RIGHT AND EDUCATION.
TO GET ME OFF THE STREETS IT YOU
ROLE MODEL FOR ME.
THAT MY LIFE COULD BE DIFFERENT
IN EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
[inaudible]
SOMEONE.
VOLUNTEER TO MENTOR.
OR INVESTED IN NEED POURED INTO
ME AS THEY SAY PEOPLE MY FAITH
GROUP.
PEOPLE IN HIGH SCHOOLS.
THEY ALWAYS SAID THAT LIFE WOULD
BE DIFFERENT.
THAT IT STARTED SO THE REASON I
SAID MICHAEL JORDAN.
BECAUSE I HEARD HIM SAY ONCE
THAT IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOU
START.
IN MATTERS LIKE [inaudible]
AND BEING HERE TO ME IT'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUS HONOR AND I NEVER
THOUGHT.
THAT I WOULD.
COME THAT CANDIDATE FOR THIS
OTHER JOB.
BUT ONE DAY IT HIT ME
[inaudible]
THAT.
I COULD HAVE I ASK MYSELF WHAT'S
THE LEGACY.
BUT I WANT TO LEAD.
AND WHEN I DISCOVERED THAT THERE
MIGHT BE AN OPENING DISSERVICE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION I THOUGHT.
IT IS THE PERFECT LAYERING OF MY
INTEREST IN POLITICS IN MY
DESIRE TO HELP KIDS.
IN EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU HAS
ASKED ME WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO
GO. TO AN OFFICE THAT NO ONE
WANTS OR UNDERSTANDS
[inaudible]
AND RISK.
THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS THAT I
COULD SERVE HERE AND I THOUGHT.
KIDS OF CALIFORNIA ARE RISKING
EVERYTHING.
SO I'M RISKING SOMETHING TOO A
MOMENT FOR OUR KIDS AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT I'LL SPEND.
THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS SERVING
THEM IN THAT CAPACITY AND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH YOU.
CONTINUING EQUIPPED WORK CLOSELY
WITH YOU.
SO.
CAN I LEAVE YOU AND I SAY.
SEE YOU LATER --
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE WORK
THAT WILL DO TOGETHER.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WILL CARRY
ON THE GREAT WORK.
AT THIS PLACE WHICH HAS BEEN THE
GREATEST JOB MIGHT I THANK YOU
GOD BLESS YOU GOD.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE
.
MEMBERS WE MAY ENTERTAIN VOTE
CHANGES FROM YOUR GAS
[inaudible]
MS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU A VIOLATED IN TO
FOURTEEN NOTE TO AYE
[inaudible]
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MELENDEZ ASSIGNABLE TWENTY SIX
SIXTY FOUR NOTES I IS WATER.
S. B. THREE TO A I TO NOT NOT
VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON SENATE
BILL THREE TWO EIGHT AYE NOT
VOTING [inaudible]
THIS FRIEDMAN.
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE I TO
NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SAID
MULTIPLE SEVENTY NINE I IT'S NOT
VOTING [inaudible]
SHALL.
AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT FROM HIGH
TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD.
AS A LABEL SEVEN FORTY EIGHT AYE
IT'S NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MISTER DALLI [inaudible]
MR GALLI.
FILE FORTY A. S. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY TWO NO TO AYE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO YOU KNOW TO
AYE [inaudible]
MISTER STEINORTH.
AB TWO THREE THREE FOUR NO TWO
WHY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEINORTH
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR NOTE TO AYE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS TO
PRINT A LETTER IN THE JOURNAL
FOR THE FOLLOWING BILLS.
THESE HAVE A SUPPORT SUPPORT
POSITION ON BOTH SIDES.
MOTION SECONDED BY MISTER BONTA
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SUPPORT
SUPPORT LAST.
OF BILLS AND AUTHORS.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY SIX
EGGMAN EXCITABLE THREE FIFTEEN
WOULD.
ASSEMBLY BEFORE A SIX MCCARTY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
SEEING.
AS A LABEL EIGHT TWENTY NINE
DAVID CHIU.
ASSIGNABLE TWELVE FOURTEEN STONE
ASSIGNABLE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BONTA.
AS NUMBER EIGHTEEN SEVENTY REYES
AS LABEL NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
EDUARDO GARCIA.
AS UNABLE TWENTY SIXTY ONE
FRAZIER SAMPLE TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN REYES ASSEMBLE TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN FRIEDMAN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED [inaudible]
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
ENTERTAIN.
SOME TRIBUTES FOR MS COPY GYRO
I'M GOING TO BEGIN WITH DR
EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
IT'S DOES.
IT'S INTERESTING FOLLOWING.
MR MY FRIEND MR THURMAN'S A
TRIBUTE WITH MY FRIEND MISS
CABALLERO DISTRIBUTE.
BECAUSE I THINK IT GOES TO SHOW
THE GREAT DIVERSITY THAT IS
CALIFORNIA --
THURMAN REPRESENTS A VERY
[inaudible]
URBAN.
COASTAL PART OF CALIFORNIA.
AND MISS CARILLO REPRESENTS A
VERY.
RULE PART OF CALIFORNIA.
AND YET THEY'RE BOTH DEMOCRATS.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THE BEAUTIFUL THINGS ABOUT THE
STATE THAT IS SO BIG AND SO
DIVERSE.
AND THAT THERE'S ROOM FOR ALL OF
US TO COME WITH ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES.
SO YOU HAVE ON CABALLERO WHO
SERVED THE LIFE OF A PUBLIC
SERVICE.
I'M IN AN AREA THAT IS NOT NOT
ALWAYS BEEN HARD TO REPRESENT.
A CHILD OF COPPER MINERS.
MOVE TO CALIFORNIA.
SHE IS A MOTHER.
CHOOSE A WIFE.
SHE THE DAUGHTER CAREGIVER OF A
MOTHER WITH A LONG TERM ILLNESS
THAT.
THAT MANY OF US CONTINUED TO
STRUGGLE WITH.
DISEASE OF ALZHEIMER'S.
I I KNOW THE PAIN THAT COMES
FROM THAT.
SHE WAS AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RULE LISTED RULE
LEGAL ASSISTANCE.
STOOD SIDE BY SIDE WITH
FARMWORKERS.
YOU START NONPROFITS.
AND THEN LIKE MANY OF US AFTER
WORKING.
ON THE FRONT LINES AND DOING
ADVOCACY AND WORKING ON BEHALF
OF PEOPLE SIDE BY SIDE.
THINK YOU KNOW I HAVE TO DO A
PART OF BEING PART OF OF OF
GOVERNMENTS TO AND THEN WAS ON
THE PLANNING COMMISSION AND THEN.
BECAME THE MAYOR OF SILLINESS.
AND OF THOSE OF US WHO KNOW YOU
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CHANGES YOU FOR EVER IN HOW YOU
SEE THE WORLD AND HOW YOU SEE
YOUR ROLE.
AND THEN FROM THERE CAME SERVED
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY I REMEMBER
THE FIRST TIME I MET ON I WAS AT
ONE OF OUR STONE WALL MEETINGS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND WHILE THE SPEECH WAS RUNNING
FOR WASN'T EXACTLY WHERE WE
LIVED SHE WAS IN THAT CAR AND
AND WELL THEY TALK ABOUT THE
TRAIN CAUCUS.
WHERE WE LIVE THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF TRAINS GOING THROUGH A LOT OF
TIME SPENT IN CARS UP AND DOWN
THE NINETY NINE AND UP AND DOWN
THE FIVE AND UP AND DOWN?
ROADS WHERE THERE'S NO SELF
SERVICE A LOT OF PLACES IN --
BUT SHE AND ONE WOULD COME UP
AND DOWN AND TALK WITH PEOPLE
AND MEET WITH PEOPLE IN.
A MINUTE THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE ALWAYS ADMIRED
AND RESPECTED ABOUT HER IS HER
TENACITY HER HARD WORK --
HER SPEAKING OUT FOR RULE
CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THE UNIQUE ISSUES THAT
PEOPLE FACE WHEN THEY LIVE
WITHOUT RESOURCES AND THEY LIVE
WITHOUT CLEAN AIR AND THEY LIVE
WITHOUT CLEAN ATER.
AND THEY LIVE WITHOUT GOOD
QUALITY SCHOOLS AND THEY STILL
WANT REPRESENTATIONS ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT EVERYBODY ELSE WANTS.
AND YET THEY'RE NOT A SIMPLE TO
GET.
WHEN YOU LIVE IN AREAS THAT ARE
OFTEN OVERLOOKED AND SO IT IS SO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
STRONG ARTICULATE VOICES? TO
SPEAK ON YOUR BEHALF AND TO BE
ABLE THE HOUSE PASSED
LEGISLATION ON YOUR BEHALF AND
TO BE ABLE.
TO HELP OTHER MEMBERS UNDERSTAND
THAT CALIFORNIA'S MORE THAN.
THEN THE AND THEN JUST THE COAST
THAT IT IT IT IS IT IS IT IS
FARMS IT IS FARMWORKERS AND IT
IS.
THE FABRIC OF THOSE PEOPLE'S
LIVES TO HELP MAKE UP OUR STORY
IN OUR REALITY.
AFTER SHE LEFT THE ASSEMBLY SHE
WAS A SECRETARY FOR JOBS AND AND
NOT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEY CAME BACK INTO THIS
CHAMBER STILL NOT STILL NOT DONE
SERVING.
AND AS A CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I COULD SAY IT IS BEEN AN
HONOR TO SERVE WITH ON A
CABALLERO WHEN SHE GAVE YOU HER
WORD SHE KEEPS IT.
AND SHE SAYS SHE'S GOING TO DO
SOMETHING SHE DOESN'T.
AND WHEN SHE TOLD YOU SHE CAN'T
DO SOMETHING IT SHOULD SAY THAT
LOT MEMBERS LED MEMBERS THE
SESSION WHEN BOTH A LOT OF MY
BILLS.
NOW.
IF SHE WAS HONEST AND SHE WAS
UPRIGHT AND SHE NEVER DODGE THAT
AND SHE WOULD EXPLAIN TO YOU
PERHAPS LONGER THAN YOU WANT TO
HEAR.
WHY SHE COULDN'T OR WHY SHE
WOULDN'T?
BUT ALWAYS WITH THE WELL
REASONED.
WAY TO PRESENT THAT.
IN A WAY THAT SHE FELT WAS BEST
REPRESENTATIVE OF HER COMMUNITY.
AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY CAN
ASK ANY MORE THAN A POPE FROM A
PUBLIC SERVANT IS TO SERVE WITH
HEART. TO WORK HARD TO SERVE
WITH INTEGRITY AND PASSION AND
NOT BE DONE [inaudible]
I HOPE.
AND I WILL DO MY ALL I CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
SHE IS ONE OF THE LATINOS ARE
GOING TO BE OVER THEY'RE SERVING
US IN THE SENATE.
ANOTHER WORK DONE IS NOT DONE
BUT I CAN SAY THAT EVEN IF SHE
WENT HOME TOMORROW.
AND THIS WAS IT.
HE'S BEEN A WELL LIVED LIFE OF
PUBLIC SERVICE THAT HAS NEVER
STOPPED AND HAS NEVER WAVERED.
FROM THE HARD WORK AND THE
DEDICATION.
AND I'VE NEVER FORGOTTEN.
S. PEOPLE WHO LOOK TO HER. FOR
HOPE.
AND FOR SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING TO
FIGHT FOR THEM.
AND FOR THAT FIGHTING SPIRIT AND
THAT SENSE OF INTEGRITY AND THAT
BRINGING ATTENTION TO RULE
CALIFORNIA.
A TRIBUTE A PREACHER BTO AND I
WILL MISS YOU BUT I WILL FOR
EVER CALL YOU MY FRIEND. EIGHT
ACCURATE WHEN MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
WELL THERE WERE I CAN BARELY SEE
OR YOU HIDING OUT OVER THERE.
YOU KNOW --
YEARS AGO I LIVED IN SANTA CRUZ
AND I DIDN'T I KEPT HEARING IN
READING THE NEWSPAPER ABOUT THIS
REALLY VIBRANT.
HARD WORKING WOMAN WHO'S WORKING
OUT A SALINAS AS A COUNCIL WOMAN
AND AS A MAYOR.
AND I WATCHED YOU FROM AFAR AND
AREAS THOUGHT WHO IS THIS GUY
ALL IN BECAUSE IT WASN'T GRANTED
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A LOT OF
WOMEN IN --
ELECTED POSITION AT THE TIME.
AND I WAS SO EXCITED WHEN I
SHOWED UP HERE ON THIS FLOOR AND
FOUND OUT THAT ON A KALRA HERO
WAS GOING TO BE SERVING AT THE
SAME TIME I WAS AND THAT.
YOU WOULD HELP ME --
LEAD ME DOWN THE WAY OF HOW TO
WORK IN THIS BUILDING.
AND I WANNA THANK YOU
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE OF
ACCORDING TO RURAL COMMUNITIES.
I FEEL LIKE MANY TIMES YOU AND I
ARE TRYING.
TO PUT A LOT OF HEAVY LOAD ON US
TRYING TO HELP OUR AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY.
AND SO I'M GONNA MISS YOU NEXT
YEAR I'M GONNA TRY TO FIND
SOMEONE ELSE TO HELP.
A WORKOUT WITH OUR AGRICULTURAL
AGRICULTURE PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW
I WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL YOU'VE DONE.
ANNA I MEANT FOR UNFORTUNATELY
WOULD BE OVER ON A RED CARPET
RATHER THAN GREEN CARPET --
BUT WE DID WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
OUR DINNERS TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT ALL THE WONDERFUL THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING FOR A
COMMUNITIES KEEP UP THE GOOD
WORK OF FRIENDS.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
MUCH HAS BEEN SAID BY MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ABOUT ON AND I
JUST WANT TO ADD A FEW OTHER
THINGS ANA A I GOT TO KNOW HER
THROUGH A DRIVE GOING UP TO
RETRIEVE AND WHAT I SAW THERE.
OF BETWEEN HER AND HER HUSBAND
WHO IS SO DEVOTED TO HER WHO HAS
SPENT SO MANY OF HIS HOURS
TAKING HER FROM EVENT TO EVENT
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES IN HER.
AND TO REALLY LEARN OF THE WORK
THAT SHE'S DONE OVER MANY MANY
DECADES NOT JUST IN THE LAST
DECADE BUT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
A IT IT'S VERY INSPIRING TO
WOMEN LIKE ME --
WHAT I SEE AS MUCH AND ANA WHICH
IS THAT WE HAVE TOUGH DISTRICTS
AND SOMETIMES WHEN YOU VOTE YOUR
DISTRICT IT DOESN'T ALWAYS MAKE
PEOPLE HAPPY BUT SHE HAS?
A COMPASS SHE KNOWS WHERE SHE'S
GOING SHE IS THE EPITOME OF
BEING PROFESSIONAL AND SHE
SOMEONE THAT I TRULY ADMIRE I
ALSO MET HER ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE TABLE AS I WAS THE CHAIR
OF THE VETERANS COMMITTEE.
A FEW YEARS BACK AND SHE CAME TO
THE COMMITTEE AND I REMEMBER --
NOT KNOWING A LOT ABOUT HER AT
THAT TIME IN JUST BY HER
PRESENTATION AND SO FORTH
THINKING I WANT TO GET TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT HER SO IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO SERVE WITH YOU.
AND I WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK
[inaudible]
MS RACE [inaudible]
Q. ANA.
YOU TO SUCH A CLASS ACT.
EVERYTHING ABOUT TO SPUR YOUR
PROFESSIONAL IT'S ALREADY BEEN
SAID.
YOU'RE YOU'RE SOMEBODY THAT
WOULD LOOK UP.
TO OR WE LOOK DOWN [inaudible]
TO YOU'RE JUST.
BECAUSE YOU'RE SO SHORT YOU GUYS.
SHE WEARS A LITTLE HEELS
[inaudible]
YOU'RE IN BUT ON I JUST LOVE
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE DONE HERE
I I I REALLY ENJOYED WHEN I
WOULD SIT WITH YOU.
AND THE INSIGHT THAT YOU WOULD
GIVE.
NOT ONLY ON RURAL AMERICA
BECAUSE YOU FEEL USED YOU JUST
ABSOLUTELY FIGHT FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY.
LIKE NOBODY ELSE Y. SUPPOSE LIKE
CECILIA LITTLE BIT.
BUT NOBODY FIGHTS LIKE YOU.
WHENEVER I WANTED TO KNOW.
HOW YOUR COMMUNITY WOULD RESPOND
I KNEW THE CHIU YOU HAVE THE
PULSE OF YOUR COMMUNITY?
AND YOU WERE ALWAYS WILLING TO
SHARE WITH THE REST OF US.
AND YOUR INSIGHT ON THE GOVERNOR.
AS BEEN PRICELESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
THAT THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
YOU'VE DONE IT AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU AND
HEARING ABOUT ALL THE GREAT
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE DOING.
ON THE RED CARPET.
CONGRATULATIONS BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'LL BE THERE.
MR LOW.
IRAN HAS.
I'M I WAS ABOUT SUB PROXIMALLY --
A YEAR AGO --
IN WHICH WE ADJOURNED OF OUR
LAST SESSION.
AND I THEN.
AT ABOUT ELEVEN O'CLOCK I NEEDED
TO BE IN LOS ANGELES TO ADDRESS --
THE ABOARD OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN THE ROLE OF CHAIR
OF THE LDP LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
WAS COMPLAINING BECAUSE WE HAD A
LATE NIGHT AND WE TO FLY ALL THE
WAY TO LOS ANGELES.
AND WHEN I ARRIVED.
I SAW YOU THERE.
BEFORE I ARRIVED.
AND I THOUGHT TO MYSELF.
WELL CRAP.
WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
LGBT CAUCUS THAT IT IN NO ABOUT.
THIS IS HISTORY OF NINE MEMBERS.
WHEN IN FACT YOU WERE?
THERE BRIGHT AND EARLY SHIP A
SMILING SAYING YOU.
ARE ACTUALLY SERVING ON THE
BOARD AS A STRAIGHT ALLY.
AND WE CAN ALWAYS BE VERY
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN CONVERT OR
MAYBE NOT A CONVERT. TOO SOON
OKAY SIDE WITH THE GLORIA.
BUT WE IT IS GOOD TO SHOW YOUR
CHARACTER THAT YOU AS A STRAIGHT
ALLY WOULD SERVE FOR THOSE IN A
COMMUNITY THAT IS DISADVANTAGED.
AND YOU DID SO --
WITH DISTINCTION EVEN WHEN YOU
DON'T NEED TO AND SO AFRAID THAT
WE ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND WE LOOK FOR TO YOUR
CONTINUED SERVICE.
AND THE OTHER HOUSE.
FAMOUS LOW MISTER COOLEY.
AND I JUST WANNA RISE AND
CONGRATULATE.
TO I GOT TO KNOW YOU AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND TEN WHEN I WAS
DOING COMMITTEE WORK IN THAT.
IN THE HOUSE YOU'RE HEADED --
TO AND ALSO THEN FOLLOWED YOU
ISSUE WHEN IN THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION TOOK ON THOSE
RESPONSES.
I AM RESPONSIBILITIES --
YOU YOUR YOU'RE SORT OF AN
ARTIFACT IN THE SINCE YOU UNDER
THE OLD SYSTEM OF TERM LIMITS.
WHICH MEANS YOU HAVE THE
PROSPECT OF EIGHT YEARS OF
SERVICE.
IN THE NEXT HOUSE --
ADDICTS EXECUTIVE BRANCH
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU [inaudible]
EMBODY.
IS IN SHORT SUPPLY HEARING IN
THE BUILDING.
A GREAT ASSET I THINK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE SOME WITH YOUR
BACKGROUND [inaudible]
I APPRECIATE.
AS AN ATTORNEY I APPRECIATE
SERVE WITH AN ATTORNEY.
WHO UNPACKS ISSUES NGUYEN
ATTORNEY DOES?
AND P. JUST KNOW YOU HAVE MUCH
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
I'VE OFTEN SPOKEN ON THE ISSUE
OF ALZHEIMER'S AND MY MOM WAS IN.
YOUR CITY GETTING CARE IN HER
FINAL YEARS --
GREAT CITY --
I KNOW OF YOUR INTEREST IN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND I GO
BACK TO THE DAYS WHEN.
SPRECKELS WAS BIG ON THE SOUTH
SIDE OF SALINAS.
SO THERE'S JUST A LOT OF A LOT A
NEEDS IN IRAQ OR CULTURAL AREAS
YOU COME VERY SPECIAL.
PART OF CALIFORNIA.
IN I THINK YOU FOR THE LONG HAUL.
A YOU MAKE GETTING HERE ON A
WEEKLY BASIS [inaudible]
SERVE [inaudible]
MR.
THANK IS SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
WANTED TO JUST RISE IN.
TECHNOLOGY HONOR AND I'M GLAD TO
BE SHARING TRIBUTE NIGHT WITH
YOU AND WITH OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
ACROSS THE AISLE AFFILIATE WE
THAT WE JUST IT'S GRADUATION
NIGHT AIR SOMETHING THAT FACT
THAT.
I'VE REALLY ENJOYED SERVING WITH
YOU AND I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE ONCE
AND I THINK THAT YOU HAVE SO
MANY GIFTS.
AND LEADERSHIP AND A GREAT
VISION TO SHARE AND I THINK THAT
YOU ARE PERFECT COMBINATION.
OF HARD DRIVING LIKE A
PASSIONATE AND THOUGHTFUL AND I
THINK THAT'S NEEDED AND I THINK
WE NEED TO SHAKE THINGS UP.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GET PAST THE
STATUS QUO AND I REALLY SEE YOU
DOING THAT I'VE WATCHED HOW YOU
WORK AND I'VE LEARNED A LOT FROM
HOW YOU WORK.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW
CONVERSATION WITH THE CALI.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE TOUGH
ON THE KILEY.
WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER ON MANY
MANY TOUGH BILLS AND WE'VE HAD
MANY.
HEY CAN YOU STEP INTO MY OFFICE
OVER HERE.
AND HAVE A ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATION ABOUT TOUGH BILL
AND WE FOUND A WAY TO GET
THROUGH IT IN NEED OF WE AGREE
WE STILL FOUND A WAY TO MAINTAIN.
A RELATIONSHIP IS COLLEAGUES AND
TO WORK TOGETHER IT TO LOOK FOR
A WAY TO WORK TOGETHER ON THAT
NEXT ISSUE AND I I THINK THAT'S
AN ART THAT'S OFTEN LOS.
I THINK PEOPLE BURN BRIDGES.
THEY DON'T COMMUNICATE HONESTLY
THEY DON'T SAY HEY I'M SORRY I
CAN'T BE THERE WITH YOU.
YOU'RE STRAIGHT UP AND YOU JUST
LOOK A PERSON IN THE EYE AND SAY
WELL THAT'S A DUMB IDEA NOW
YOU'VE NEVER SAID THAT.
BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE VERY GENUINE
AND STRAIGHT UP ABOUT WHAT YOU
ARE THINKING BUT THAT YOU WERE
OPEN.
IT WILLING TO HAVE CONVERSATION
TO NEGOTIATE TO MEDIATE AND TO
LOOK AT WHAT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THOSE THAT WE SERVE
UNIT CREDIBLE LEADER YOU SERVICE
SO MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS --
YOU KNOW IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND I THINK THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LUCKY TO HAVE YOU.
AND I I I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW I
BOTH HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER AYE BUT
I'M EXCITED FOR YOU AND WORKING
WITH YOU.
AND THAT CONGRATULATIONS ND
THANK YOU FOR THE ABILITY TO
SERVE.
SCOTT DR ARAMBULA.
THE MAKE ONE CAN ON THIS.
YOU DAVID ECHO MALL HARRIS
[inaudible]
TELL ME.
WHO YOU WALK WITH?
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHO YOU ARE.
FOR A LONG TIME AND I'VE WATCHED
AS YOU'VE WALKED WITH MY PARENTS.
FROM THE DAYS OF STARTING WITH
CRLA TO THE DAYS ON THIS GREEN
CARPET WITH MY FATHER.
IT IS A PROUD MOMENT TO KNOW
THAT THIS PAST SESSION I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO SERVE WITH YOU AS
WELL. TO LEARN FROM SOMEONE WHO
IS A TRUE STATES WOMAN FOR OUR
STATE.
PROUD TO SAY THAT YOU ARE A
GREAT REPRESENTATIVE FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND I CAN'T WAIT TILL
THE DAY.
THAT I GET TO CALL YOU MY CENTER.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THESE NEXT FEW
MONTHS HELPING TO CONVINCE THOSE
PEOPLE FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT WE NEED A TRUE CHAMPION IN
THE SENATE SOMEONE JUST LIKE YOU
TO FIGHT FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR WALKING AND
SERVING OUR COMMUNITIES IT IS AN
HONOR TO GIVE YOU THIS TRIBUTE
[inaudible]
MISTER GALLAGHER.
ON I JUST WANTED TO TAKE IT.
A BRIEF MOMENT AT JUST TO SAY
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO SERVE
WITH YOU --
AND ONE THIS.
HAVING SOMEONE THAT ALREADY HAS
A BREADTH OF KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE --
AND BEING ABLE TO COME AND TALK
TO YOU ABOUT DIFFERENT ISSUES
ESPECIALLY ON AGAN WATER ISSUES --
YOU'VE BEEN A GREAT ALLY AND
SOME OF THE I I FEEL LIKE I CAN
TRUST AND WORK WITH ON THOSE
ISSUES.
AND IN THIS SPECIAL I THINK
MAYBE WE MORE MOST ESPECIALLY
BONDED.
AND I WORKING ON THE WATER
CONSERVATION --
LEGISLATION.
AND THEN TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
THAT THAT REALLY IT DID ADDRESS --
THE NEEDS OF OF INLAND
CALIFORNIA OF AGRICULTURE AREA
OF RURAL AREAS --
RECYCLED WATER.
BUT IF YOU WENT BACK AND FORTH
ON THAT MANY TIMES BUT YOU KNOW
JUST HAVE HAVING SOMEONE.
ACROSS CHAU THAT I FELT LIKE WE
YOU KNOW.
WATER IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
KNOW WAS A BIPARTISANISSUE --
AND I THINK WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS TOGETHER I THINK WE'VE
MADE SOME GREAT STRIDES.
ON MANY ISSUES --
AND SO.
I I JUST WANT TO SAY IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU AND TO
HAVE SOMEONE THAT I CAN.
YOU KNOW.
NOW A RELY ON FOR GOOD
INFORMATION BACKGROUND HIS.
WHO'S BEEN THROUGH MANY
DIFFERENT BATTLES OVER THE YEARS --
BUT ALSO JUST TO WORK ON GOOD
POLICY TOGETHER AND SO.
BUT I WISH WISH YOU THE BEST OF
LUCK AND I IN YOUR IN YOUR
FUTURE.
I'M SURE WE'LL BE WORKING
TOGETHER AND IN.
MANY DIFFERENT ASPECTS THINKING.
AND FINALLY YOUR SEAT MATE
[inaudible]
MISTER STEINHAUER.
WELL I HAVE TO SAY IT'S
ABSOLUTELY BEEN A DELIGHT BEING
YOUR SEAT MATE THESE LAST FEW
MONTHS YOU'VE TAUGHT ME A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT.
BUT SOME THINGS I'D LIKE TO
SHARE WITH EVERYONE ELSE'S.
HE YOU YOU'VE TAUGHT ME THROUGH
YOUR OWN EXPERIENCE AND YOU DO
WITH ACTIONS WHILE SO MANY OF US
SPEAK THEORETICALLY.
AND A LOT OF WHAT YOU AND I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SHARES WE'VE
WATCHES PEOPLE WHO VOTED IN
WE'RE SITTING HERE COMMITTING
OURSELVES AND YOU KNOW I JUST
HAVE TO SAY YOU'RE PROBABLY ONE
OF THE CLASSIEST PEOPLE I'VE
EVER MET.
AND IT'S JUST IT'S BEEN A A TRUE
PRIVILEGE GETTING TO KNOW YOU
AND WE HAVE SO MUCH IN COMMON WE
LOVE TAX PORTABILITY WE LOVE
BEING BIPARTISAN ALL OF THOSE
THINGS BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY.
WE HAVE A TRUE PASSION FOR
ADOPTION.
AND I JUST I WANNA JUST SAY HOW
HOW GRATEFUL I AM FOR YOU AND
FOR YOUR CHILDREN YOUR FOR YOUR
HUSBAND AND FOR THE WAY THAT YOU
HAVE STRUCTURE TO RAISE YOUR
FAMILY YOU ARE AN EXAMPLE FOR
ALL OF US.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU ARE
SUCCESSFUL AND EVERYTHING ELSE
YOU ACHIEVING MY GOD BLESS YOU.
THANK YOU MISS STEINORTH SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO MISS
CABALLERO.
WELL LOOK WHAT TIME IT IS.
I WANNA THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR SOME
REALLY WONDERFUL WORDS I HAVE
WELL LET ME START OFF BY MY
THINKING --
LEADERSHIP --
FOR STEPPING UP --
SPEAKER RENDON.
YOU DOLLY --
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK.
THIS THIS IS NOT EASY TO DO AND
WITHOUT YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
ATTENTION TO DETAIL IT WOULDN'T
IT WOULDN'T HAPPEN SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR FOR ALL OF THAT
LEADERSHIP ALSO --
ONE ED.
ECHO WHAT MY SEAT MATE SAID IS
THAT THERE ARE SOME INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE --
CHIEF AMONG THEM IS --
OUR CHIEF CLERK DODSON IN HIS
STAFF.
WHO ALWAYS ARE THERE FOR US AND
MAKE US LOOK GOOD THEY MAKE THIS
PLACE RUN AND SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR FOR YOUR SERVICE --
AS WELL AS ALL OF THE SECURITY
STAFF EVERYONE THAT THAT REALLY
MAKES IT POSSIBLE AND I REALLY
WANT TO SALUTE MY AND MY STAFF
IT'S IN.
IT'S IN THE OFFICE --
BECAUSE I I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GET ANY OF MY BILLS DONE
WITHOUT THEM AND DOT TODAY WAS A
CRAZY DAY.
WITH ALL OF THE HEARINGS THAT WE
HAD OFF THE FLOOR AND THAT IT
WAS STAFF WORK THAT.
HAD THOSE REPORTS READY THAT HAD
OUR BILLS READY HAD IS WITH THE
RIGHT FOLDER.
AND WITH THE RIGHT BILL AT THAT
YOU KNOW RIGHT TIME AND SO --
THANK YOU TO ALL THE STAFF THAT
THAT REALLY MAKE US --
LOOK GOOD IN THAT MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR US TO BE HERE.
AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT I DOWN
THIS IS THIS IS THAT I WHEN I
CAME BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY I SAID
I WAS A RETREAD.
RIGHT SO I BUT IT IF I REALLY
HAD IT IS BEEN AN HONOR AND A
PRIVILEGE. TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
IN THIS GREAT STATE.
AND I FELT HONORED EVERY TIME I
WALK IN THIS BUILDING AND I GET
THE CHILLS EVERY TIME THE LIGHTS
GO OUT IN THIS.
ROOM AND WHEN THEY STUDENTS
COMING THEY THEY LOOK AND AT OUR
NAME PLATES AND THEY SEE THE
MICROPHONES AND WHERE WE DO
BUSINESS --
IT'S JUST SUCH A IT'S A MAKES ME
FEEL VERY VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO BE PART OF THAT.
EXPERIENCE AND TO BE ABLE.
TO EDUCATE AND GET THEM EXCITED
ABOUT GOVERNMENT AND SO --
I'VE REALLY BEEN.
HONORED TO CHOOSE TO SERVE WITH
EVERYONE OF YOU --
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
THAT.
I WILL REMEMBER YOUR SERVICE AND
YOUR PARTICIPATION --
WITH GREAT FONDNESS BECAUSE IT
ISN'T EASY TO GOVERN A STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA.
IT IS COMPLICATED.
AND WE ARE FACING INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES WORLDWIDE.
THAT WE NEED THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
AND IF WE DON'T DO IT WELL.
THEN WE END UP IN SITUATIONS
WHERE WE I WAS HERE WHEN THERE
WAS NO MONEY.
AND EVERY SINGLE THING THAT I
THOUGHT THAT WAS IMPORTANT I HAD
TO VOTE CUT.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE US DO
THAT AGAIN.
SO WE HAVE THIS TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE OUR
ECONOMY IS RUNNING RUNNING THAT.
THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND WHAT HAS BEEN GREAT IT'S
BEEN ABLE TO SEE YOU ADVOCATE.
FOR WHAT YOU THINK IS IMPORTANT.
BUT TO DO IT TOGETHER AND IT'S
MY EXPERIENCE THAT.
THAT IF YOU GET PEOPLE IN A ROOM
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
COMMON VALUES ARE.
AT YOU USUALLY CAN GET TO A
RESOLUTION AT THE END.
AND SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN GET
IN A ROOM AND TALK ABOUT OUR
VALUES TALK ABOUT.
RAISING CHILDREN TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOSTER.
FOSTER CHILDREN AND SUPPORTING
THEM THE IMPORTANCE OF A GOOD
pGOOD JOB.
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN LIVE WITH
DIGNITY.
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GET
AROUND WITHOUT HAVING TO DRIVE A
VEHICLE ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
ARE ISSUES THAT.
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON AND WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
THIS JOB IS THAT I GET TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT I REALLY LOVE.
AND I WAS NOT RAISED IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA I WAS RAISED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
THERE'S NOTHING ROTH THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT GIRL IN SPANISH
CALIFORNIA BUT THERE'S NOT A
WHOLE HECK OF A LOT.
ACTUALLY FIGHT WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP THERE WERE A LOT
ORANGE TREES ALL THAT'S GONE --
AND THAT'S PROBABLY IT A STORY
FOR ANOTHER DAY TO TALK ABOUT IF
WE'RE NOT WISE STEWARDS THIS IS
WHY LIBERAL CALIFORNIA IS THAT
WHAT I WHAT I LEARNED MOVING TO
RURAL CALIFORNIA IS THAT HARD
WORKING PEOPLE MAKE IT HAPPEN.
AND THEIR DEDICATION TO TAKING
CARE OF THE EARTH BECAUSE
OTHERWISE IT DOESN'T GIVE YOU A
GOOD CROP IS REALLY COMPLETE AND
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT GET UP AT
THREE O'CLOCK EVERY DAY AND GO
OUT TO THE FIELDS AND WORK.
AND AND THEY'RE JUST LOOKING FOR
A GOOD SALARY A THE ABILITY TO
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN IN THEIR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE MOST OF
THEM -- CAME
HERE LOOKING FOR A BETTER LIFE.
AND WHAT I LEARNED OUT OF ALL OF
THAT IS THAT THERE IS TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE. TO CHANGE
THE COMMUNITY AND TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO TO DO GOOD THINGS SO
THAT THOSE KIDS DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A CHANCE IN
THE GET A GOOD EDUCATION AND GET
A GOOD JOB.
BUT IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL.
ON THEN WE'RE GONNA LOSE
AGRICULTURE AND THAT'S WHAT
WORRIES ME.
AND SO I AM AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE PEOPLE.
I LOVE THE HARD WORK I LOVE THIS
SOIL I LOVE THE THE FEELING OF
BEING OUT IN.
OPEN OPEN FIELDS --
AND THAT IS SO IMPORTANT TO TO
EVERYTHING WE KNOW ABOUT
CALIFORNIA AND IF WE'RE NOT
CAREFUL LOSING --
SO THAT'S WHY I KIND OF FEEL
LIKE I'VE GOT TO BE HERE.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT I
KEEP COMING BACK ALL THE TIME
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT --
THAT I AM SO DEDICATED TO MAKING
SURE THAT.
THAT THAT THAT DOOR STAYS OPEN
THAT WE REALLY DO LOOK AT WAYS
TO BE ABLE --
TO CONTINUE TO GROW THE BEST PRO
PRODUCE IN THE WORLD.
AND TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE.
AND THAT PROVIDES A LIVING A
GOOD LIVING FOR THE FAMILIES
THAT HAVE DECIDED THAT THAT'S
WITH THE THEY WANT TO WORK THEY
WANT TO WORK ON FARMS THEY THEY
THEY LOVE THE LAND AND THEY WANT
TO CONTINUE --
TO FARM BOTH WORKERS AS WELL AS
AS FARMERS.
SO -- I'M
HOPING TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK
AND I AM GOING TO WORK HARD FOR
IT.
BUT TONIGHT WHEN I WANNA TELL
YOU IS THAT --
I REALLY APPRECIATED YOUR
FRIENDSHIPS --
SOME MORE THAN OTHERS --
BECAUSE I KNOW I'VE I'VE I'VE
BUT I'VE MADE SOME PEOPLE NOT
TOO HAPPY WITH THAT --
WITH POSITIONS THAT I'VE TAKEN
BUT NO THAT --
THERE I REALLY THINK THINGS
THROUGH AND I THINK THINGS
THROUGH TO BE ABLE TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION AND I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF A PEROT CALIFORNIAN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND AND MANY OF YOU
HAVE SUPPORTED ME IN THAT.
EVEN THOUGH YOU DON'T YOU'RE NOT
FROM RURAL CALIFORNIA EVEN
THOUGH YOU'RE NOT --
YOU'RE NOT THERE YET IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THAT I WANT
TO THANK YOU BECAUSE IT SHOWS
YOUR TRUST AND YOUR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THAT.
WERE AT THE TABLE AND THAT --
WHAT WE SEE IS IMPORTANT --
SO I'LL CONCLUDE BY BY SAYING
THIS -- WE
HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU WHETHER IT'S IN
ITS ON THE RED CARPET.
OR WHETHER --
THERE'S AND THERE'S ANOTHER --
PACKED YOU KNOW WHEN ONE DOOR
OPENS WONDER CLOSES --
I WILL WORK HARD TO TRY TO EARN
THAT BAD IF I IF I DON'T THEN
THEN I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO.
AND TONIGHT I HEARD A LOT OF A
LOT OF TIMES I HEARD WE GOTTA
COME BACK AND FIXES NEXT YEAR.
AND SO I WANT TO I WANT TO BE
THERE WITH YOU WHEN WE DO THAT --
SO THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
FRIENDSHIP UP FOR YOUR REALLY
WISE WORDS.
AND FOR THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO SERVE WITH YOU IT'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUS HONOR
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
PLEASE.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THANKS VERY IMPORTANT
INDIVIDUALS BEFORE WE INSURANCE
TONIGHT.
WE WILL ALSO HEAR BRIEFLY FROM
OUR MAJORITY LEADER --
MINORITY LEADER AS WELL AS OUR
SPEAKER. FOR SOME WRAP UP
REMARKS VERY BRIEFLY.
A MAJOR THANK YOU TO OUR CHIEF
CLERK DOTSON WILSON
.
AS WELL AS DOORS ALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CLERKS OFFICE
DOTSON IS TEAM HERE THE ASSEMBLY
GAS HAVE TIRELESSLY.
PROCESS ALL THE BUSINESS WE HAVE
CONDUCTED ON THE FLOOR THIS PAST
WEEK.
AS WELL AS FOR THE ENTIRETY OF
THIS TWO YEAR SESSION THEY SET
THE NATIONAL STANDARD. FOR
CLERKS OFFICES AMONG ALL THE
STATE'S IN THE COUNTRY.
WE DON'T YES LET'S GIVE THEM ALL
AROUND THE WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK OUR CHIEF SERGEANT MISTER
FRANK US OF SIN AS WELL AS HE
ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS. FOR THEIR
WORK DURING THE LONG HOURS
BECAUSE THIS WEEK LAKE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS MORE [inaudible]
MEMBERS PLEASE.
JOIN ME IN THANKING OR CLERKS
ARE SERGEANTS THEIR SERVICE IS
AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE WORK WE
DO HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
ONE FIVE LOS.
AND MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEY DO YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS -- I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
THERE'S A LOT THAT GOES INTO
RUNNING THE FLOOR.
A LOT THAT NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
SEE IN A LOT OF PEOPLE BEHIND
THE SCENES THAT DO A LOT OF WORK
FOR US. TO MAKE SURE THAT.
I NOT ONLY THAT WE LOOK GOOD AND
NOW WE LOOK LIKE WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING --
BUT THEY PUT ALL THE PIECES
TOGETHER SO THAT BY THE TIME IT
HITS ARE DESTINED BY THE TIME
IT'S READY FOR US TO DO
SOMETHING.
WE WE WE KNOW OR WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE OUT A
COUPLE A COUPLE OF THE PEOPLE --
THAT REALLY PUT IN A LOT OF TIME
AND EFFORT --
TED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SESSIONS WHAT RUN REALLY
SMOOTHLY I WON I THINK --
BRIAN EVER WHO'S IN THE BACK.
I ALSO WANT TO PAY. ONE THORESEN
WHO WHO TRIES TO KEEP US IN LINE.
WE ALSO HAVE MYRA AND TOWN BUT
THE IN THE BACK OF TOGETHER ALL
OUR DOCUMENTS MAKE SURE WE GET
EVERYTHING GOING.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK --
FROM MY STAFF MY CHIEF OF STAFF
TOM WHITE WHO DOES QUITE A LOT
IN THIS BUILDING.
AS WELL AS ALL OF MY STAFF
DEALING.
CELEBRITY OF YOUR BODY SHE HELPS
US MANAGE ALL OUR JOURNEY
MEMORIES AND ALL THE STATE
[inaudible]
MY OFFICE.
IF THEM AROUND LIKE THEY DO A
LOT -- AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU. FOR
PUTTING UP WITH SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND AT THE TIME --
BUT YOU INDULGE ME IN MY
CRAZINESS WHAT I'M SAYING CAN
YOU PLEASE PUT YOUR MIKE DOWN TO
KEEP YOUR CONVERSATIONS TO A
MINIMUM I APPRECIATE THAT REALLY
HELPS US.
GO AND MOVE THINGS ALONG
SMOOTHLY --
BUT LASTLY I WANT TO TAKE THE
TIME TO THINK.
OUR LEADERSHIP FLOOR TEAM WHO
ARE CHAMPIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
MAKING SURE THINGS RUN SMOOTHLY
I WANT TO START BY THINKING OF
MY ASSISTANT MAJORITY LEADER
MISTER ROB BONTA.
MISTER TODD GLORIA ARE MAJORITY
WHIP IN OUR PRO TEM STAND IN.
AS WELL AND OR MAJORITY WHIP'S
ELOISE REYES AND JESSE IT WILL.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SYSTEM PRO
AND DONE AN AMAZING JOB.
AS LAURA FRIEDMAN.
AND LAST AND CERTAINLY NOT LEAST
I WANT TO THANK.
THE BEST IN THE BUSINESS.
PRO TEM KEVIN MULLIN
.
NEWMAN BEEN SIMPLY THINKING.
THE LEADERSHIP THIS BRIAN DOLLY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING SUCH
A GREAT PARTNER MARIE WALDRON I
COULD NOT DO MY JOB WITHOUT YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PLEASE GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE GOT.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
LEADER.
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE IN THIS POSITION
[inaudible]
YOU'RE. FOR BEING YOU.
AND MISTER DALLI YOU ARE RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I WANT -- TO
I WANT TO FIRST THANK MY CAUCUS
FOR HAVING THE CONFIDENCE IN ME.
TO LEAD THIS SLASH [inaudible]
YEAR.
I WANT -- TO
THANK THE SPEAKER.
AND THE THE STAFF THIS BEHIND
THE SCENES DOES IT YELLOW BE.
THOSE WHO THAT THE THAT WOULD
WORK EVERY DAY TO MAKE US ALL.
I DO THE JOB THAT WE NEED TO DO
HERE -- IT'S
AMAZING HOW.
STOPS ALONG I I I COULD NOT ASK
FOR A BETTER LEADER IS OUR
SPEAKER.
YOU CALDERON AND MARIE I LOVE
YOU YOU'RE AWESOME AND THE WAY
YOU GUYS GET ALONG --
THAT'S AMAZING I WANT TO THANK
MY WHIP TEAM [inaudible]
HE THIS JAMES ALL YOU GUYS FOR
DOING WHAT YOU DO AGAIN --
YEAH AND LEADERSHIP SO AGAIN.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT RUN FOR ME FOR
THE SHORT TIME I'VE BEEN HERE
DOING THIS AND I I JUST WANNA
SAY ACTS.
IT REALLY MAKES --
GOVERNMENT WORK WELL WHEN WOULD
PEOPLE GET ALONG AND AND OVER
THE LAST --
FORTY EIGHT HOURS IS THAT A LOT
OF RAIN THESE GOING ON BETWEEN
THE HOUSES AND I WILL SAY.
I THINK THIS HOUSE WORKS REALLY
GREAT IN ITS USE TO YOUR CREDIT
AND TO THE LEADERSHIP THAT YOU
DID YOU GIVE IN.
AND THE STAFF BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER SO I THINK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO COMING BACK HERE IN
JANUARY START ALL OVER AGAIN.
FINALLY MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I HAVE SHORT COMMENTS ABOUT AN
HOUR AND A HALF OR SO --
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
ANOTHER PRODUCTIVE AND
PROGRESSIVE YEAR IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY THIS SESSION.
WE HAVE PROVIDED RECORD FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION.
AND WE HAVE BUILT A RESERVE --
AS A RESERVE SYSTEM IN THIS
STATE THAT IS LARGER.
LARGER THAN THE BUDGETS OF
THIRTY THREE STATES IN THIS.
I WAS A REMARKABLE.
WE HAVE ALSO PROTECTED THE INTO
THE INTERESTS OF OF INTERNET
CONSUMERS WILDFIRE VICTIMS AND
FAMILIES WORKING TO RISE OUT OF
POVERTY.
AND WE A BET THE ARE CLOSER TO
ECONOMIC.
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
BEFORE I LEAVE I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE HELPED TO
MAKE THIS YEAR SUCCESS AND THE
SPEAKER PRO TEM SO SOME MY
THUNDER --
SO I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
REDUNDANT --
BUT I WON I THINK I WANT TO
START BY THINKING OUR LEADER
BRIAN DOLLY.
OUR MINORITY LEADER BRIAN DAHLE
YEAH I WAS IN A LONG TERM
ROMANCE --
THAT ENDED ABOUT A YEAR AGO --
BUT I'M OVER HIM NOW.
GOT A BETTER GUY NOW --
GOOD BRIAN THE TRANSITION HAS
BEEN SEAMLESS YOU'VE BEEN
FANTASTIC FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
DON'T KNOW.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO WE HAD A
OF THOSE FEW OF OUR MEMBERS.
TO I FROM THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS --
WHO WERE DANGEROUSLY CLOSE TO
THE WILDFIRE?
AND NEEDED A PLACE TO TO SPEND
THE NIGHT AND THEY ENDED UP.
AT THE DOLLY RANCH AND THE DOW
WE STICK THEM IN.
THAT SAYS A LOT ABOUT BRIAN SAYS
A LOT ABOUT HIS FAMILY.
LEAD YOU THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU
DO BRIAN I APPRECIATE
.
I'D I TWO ONE I THINK THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE THIS FLOOR
RUN SO SMOOTHLY FIRST OF ALL HE
IS ABSOLUTELY THE BEST.
SPEAKER PRO TEM KEVIN MULLIN
THINK.
OUR MAJORITY LEADER PEOPLE OFTEN
SAY WE'RE TWINS BECAUSE WE LOOK
SO MUCH ALIKE IAN CALDERON.
OUR SYSTEM SPEAKER PRO TEM LAURA
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU ARE.
AND A REPUBLICAN FLOOR LEADER
MARIE WALDRON THANK YOU LORD.
I WON I ALSO WANT TO THINK THE
FLOOR STAFF TO DO A GREAT JOB
ALL YEAR ROUND.
ACTUALLY --
HERE AT THE END OF SAN.
THANKS TO THE TO THE FLOOR STAFF
AND AND FOR PUTTING UP WITH US.
I WE ALL OUR THANKS I WAS
TALKING TO THE THE FOUR FRESHMEN
WHO GOT ELECTED IN --
IN SPECIAL ELECTIONS THIS YEAR
AND I TOLD THEMTO IF THEY WERE
TO SIT DOWN WITH ONE PERSON.
I TOLD THEM TO SIT DOWN WITH
DOTSON WILSON.
AND IT WAS DAMN GOOD ADVICE ON
MY PART.
THINKING DOTSON FOR ALL THAT YOU
DO.
WHY KNOW SOMEONE PAID --
DEBRA GRAVERT IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
I WANT TO THANK A LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL DIANNE BOYER BY AND
HURTS.
I WANT A THINK AT CHIEF
GUSTAFSON AND ALL THE SERGEANTS
TO SECURITY PERSONNEL WHO KEEP
ALL OF US SAFE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR THANK YOU.
I ONE THINK ALL THE D. G. S.
PERSONNEL WHO MAKE THIS
WONDERFUL BUILDINGS A GREAT
PLACE WORK THANK YOU ALSO.
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAFF ARE DISTRICT STAFFS ARE
CAPITAL STAFF WHO MAKE KEEP
DISPLACE RUNNING WHO.
WORK ON OUR BILLS WORK ON OUR
COMMITTEES WERE.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR STAFF.
I WANNA THINK --
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI
ATKINS THANK YOU TONY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TEAM WORK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EAGLE THIS
APPROACH THANK YOU FOR USING
WORDS THAT ACTUALLY EXIST.
I IT HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH TONI
ATKINS THANK YOU TELL.
THE OTHER GUYS TO GIVE HIS
GOODBYE SPEECH FROM LAST YEAR --
I ALSO --
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY SAYING GOODBYE
TO A A FEW OF OUR A FEW OF OUR
COLLEAGUES --
GOODBYE TRAVIS ALLEN.
WE WERE THIS CLOSE TO YOU PERSON
WHO CLUB --
TO TO FIFTH PLACE ON MONICA
BUREAU GOOD LUCK IN THE SENATE
THANK YOU ON A FOR EVERYTHING.
I REMEMBER MY FRESHMAN YEAR THE
FIRST TIME.
THE FIRST TWO TIMES I HEARD
ROCKY CHAVEZ GETS CHOOSE
[inaudible]
WERE --
WONDERFUL SPEECHES ABOUT LGBT
RIGHTS IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION THANK YOU ROCKY
HOMELESS YOU --
MARK STONE WORTH PLAYED A REALLY
DIRTY TRICK ON ALL OF ALL THE
DEBTS THAT WE'VE WALKED
PRECINCTS WEEK REYES MONEY AND
THEN HE QUIT.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
MISS YOU AND WE'RE NOT THE
WALKING REST OF CUCAMONGA
ANYMORE.
LOW MISTER MARK THANK YOU.
AND FINALLY TONY --
YOUR SERVING WITH YOU IS NOT A
LOT.
BUT YOUR FRIENDSHIP HAS MEANT
MORE I LOVE THE REALLY RICKY
OVER THE BECAUSE THE BUDGETS ARE
SAID MAKE SICKER.
THAN ASK FOR MORE MONEY --
SO I JUST A FINAL POINT I'D LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT TO THE CLASS
OF TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THOSE OF
US WHO CAME IN.
WHO CAME IN WITH US?
SURELY AND RICHARD AND TOM AND
ALL OF US.
I THINK IT IT DUH.
WE SHOULD REMEMBER THAT.
IF WE HADN'T EXTRA IF IT HADN'T
BEEN FOR THE EXTENSION OF TERM
LIMITS.
TONIGHT WOULD BE OUR LAST NIGHT.
SO WE OWE IT TO THE STATE TO TO
USE THE EXPERTISE THAT WE'VE
GAINED.
IN THE LAST SIX YEARS TO MAKE
THE LAST SIX REALLY COUNT.
I KNOW THAT ALL OF YOUR
COMMITTED TO THAT.
AND I KNOW THAT ALL OF YOUR
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
COME HOME NEXT YEAR.
THAT WE COME BACK HERE NEXT YEAR.
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THE MASSIVE WORK A CHANGE IN THE
WAY THE CULTURE IN THIS CAPITAL --
TO ENSURE THAT IS A SAFE.
AND RESPECTFUL PLACE FOR
EVERYONE [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU GOODNIGHT BE SAFE
.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TANE.
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE.
MISTER CALDERON.
MISTER SPEAKER IT BRINGS ME
GREAT PLEASURE.
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE.
FIFTY ONE I MOVE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED FOR THE FINAL
RECESS TO BE FOLLOWED BY
ADJOURNMENT SINE DIE ON NOVEMBER
THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
PURSUANT TO ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
THREE A OF THE CONSTITUTION.
SEEING AND HEARING NO OBJECTION
MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MISTER DALLI SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
AND WILL CONVENE FOR THE
ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION ON MONDAY.
DECEMBER THIRD TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE ARE ADJOURNED IN THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO DO
VOTE CHANGES PLEASE APPROACH THE
ROSTRUM
.
BUT JAMES CERVANTES S. B..
ONE FIVE TWO I TO KNOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY TWO I KNOW.
WELL CHANGE ACOSTA AB SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN NO TWO WHY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA ASSEMBLY
WILL SEVEN FORTY SEVEN NOTES I
IRWIN VOTE CHANGE AB TWO NINE
SEVEN THREE NOTES YES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AS UNABLE
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY THREE NOTES
I AND TO A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN NOTES ARE NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN HAS ON
BOTH FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN NOTES
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
REYES.
SENATE BILL.
FOUR SIX FIVE AYE TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES SENATE BILL
FLOOR SIXTY FIVE I IT'S NOT
VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EARLY MONA.
S. B. SEVEN ONE FIVE AYE IT'S
NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MOAN SENATE
BILL SEVEN ONE FIVE AYE IT'S NOT
VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA VOTE
CHAINS S. B. THREE TWENTY EIGHT
AYE TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY EIGHT I IT'S
NOT VOTING.
IT'S ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT CORRECTION
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY A I
IT'S NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALAN ITEM THROUGH
NINE EIGHTY TWO OH FIVE I DO NOT
VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALLEN MISLABELLED
TWELVE OH FIVE I IT'S NOT VOTING
THANKS YES.
THAT'S IT JUST LIKE THAT.
IN THIS AREA IN AB SEVEN THREE
FOUR CHANGE.
I TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN
ASSIGNABLE SEVEN THIRTY FOUR AYE
IT'S NOT VOTING